what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the worst day of our lives
[Laughter]
unfortunately i have a habit of
promising things i don't want to do i
don't know why
when people want something i get hyped
up they'll be like when's the next
24-hour livestream and i'll answer i'll
be like
oh it's 250k me thinking oh that's 150k
away
but y'all killed that [__] what did we
do it in june our last one it's like a
month and a half two months
yo yeah like this is like two months ago
so don't don't even ask me when the next
one is because i will promise something
i don't want to do so don't even ask me
i feel like the next one stop it stop it
it's far away
what if we hit in like
if we get three live streams done
i mean three 24-hour live streams in six
months that'd be crazy
what if we got four hit a million
anyways subscribe or don't because
we're not trying to do this it's up to
you whatever you wanna do
um so today we are red pilling jess for
24 hours
i know we've been a little low on the
reactions for the month together so
we're just making up for it today yeah
uh before we start a couple
announcements we have eclipse channel
we've been killing it yeah they're at
15. 15k
i think i think it might even be more
yeah
i like the class nice work
i just feel like the claps make
everything more exciting it does because
if you're just like yay
just like
i feel like yeah
i wish i wish i could have someone
follow me around and like clap for the
things i do during the day
you woke up this morning yeah you woke
up before 12. yes
i went to bed before midnight yeah yeah
i did it i never thought i went to
training yesterday
i went for a run yay
i just you didn't drink coffee yay
okay it's an exception for today i want
a week without it
[Laughter]
so
anyways um if anyone wants to do that
feel free to dm my instagram just follow
me around and clap for a day job
application
yeah job application
um okay but yeah go subscribe to the
clips channel
um we want to get to 50k on the clips
channel that's our new goal you guys
keep passing the goals that i set that
are 5k away so i'm trying to do it like
a higher goal so we have something to
work towards um
memberships we have four tiers of
membership so first here means you can
be a part of the live chat right now i'm
pretty sure it's open to everyone yeah
yeah it's open to everyone this is this
is a thank you stream so we're we're
letting everyone in the chat today um
i mean we might
no no no
it looks like it's members only oh
okay i don't know
um
so that's the first here second tier you
get the discord and vlogs
if you want to see me rapping yo there's
one coming out soon you send him the
footage yet i did yeah so it's coming we
can see us freestyle
is she even saying a little bit yeah
he was doing some toxic boy wraps yup
yeah what is yeah what have you been on
ish
what have i been on yeah yeah what have
you been on i don't know if they can
hear me they can't hear you
well we'll find out is your mic now
plugged in it is plugged in but it's on
talkback so
we'll hear like if they if they say they
can hear me can you guys hear ish hey
can you let me know in the chat if you
can hear
he said he basically said though you
can't hear him that he's just on this
toxic portion and he just he's the
player he's got to play he's got a guy
he's that guy if there's any females out
there that want that guy if you don't
want to if you want if you don't want a
stable man you want to be emotionally
insecure
you're gonna be alpha witted
you want to be alpha widowed
ish is your guy come waste your best
years on it
yeah yo they can hear me to check and
hear me my people them come on
yeah he said that word for anyway he
said waste your best years on it
on iss yeah cause he ain't marrying you
hey hey hey
for any potential candidates
don't listen to him
she said
waste your best [__]
okay it's gonna be a fun 24 hours yeah
third third tier you get to connect with
us on social media look at um fourth
tier one-on-one call with me once a
month
if you if you special request it i can i
can even get jess on the call maybe even
ish maybe we could do a three look at i
won't promise that you know they got
busy they got to do things for me you
know they got to work
but if you special requests i can get us
all on anyways
instagram jess has a new username i do
i do everybody she doesn't know it yet i
don't it's your girl jess lee oh there
you go there you go now i need to
there was someone that gave me a name
and i meant to shout them out last time
i was on this did they think of it yeah
they did his name is cc for life or c
underscore mo one underscore he gave me
a name a while ago it's i'm just your
girl
oh that was one that he gave me why
don't you go with that
i don't know i just like your girl jess
i think it sounds like jesse with just
lee so it's kind of a play on words yeah
why didn't have you ever gone by jesse
no no okay no
my grandmother calls me jessie
and they my family makes fun of me for
it not fun of me but the way she says it
she's like an old southern lady shows
jesse and so it sounds like that
i feel like does your does your grandma
cook well
when she was able to oh she threw down
like i feel like southern grandmas oh
yeah oh yeah thanksgiving christmas oh
bless the lord okay i don't know about
you but my
grandma would always like i feel like
back then they didn't know if they'd
have food all the time you know
my grandma will give us expired food oh
yeah she's like why
and when you're like grandma this is
three months expired she's like so it
was in the freezer you just defrosted
you just defrosted cookies i'm like
grandma you cooked this a year ago like
it's still good it was in the freezer
it's melted get the different stuff
you're fine
yo yes
yes anyways that's true three um
my my instagram is just dot pearly
things we just hit 25k on my instagram
yeah
i do shorts every day i got banned off a
tick tock
right before a million which is really
sad i was at 930k so now i post the tick
tocks on shorts so if you want to see
those maybe i'll get you a mil on
instagram instead um
we might have found a studio
but we found a place and we put in a bid
for it in the uk it's not like you can
just take it you give them an offer
and so i don't know hopefully today
we'll get a call saying we got it we'll
see
prayers up people it's nice though you
guys
oh
mtv cribs yeah
yeah
that i mean if you're second-tier
memberships you'll see what it is but
oh yeah because we'll do a move-in vlog
yep but if you're not sorry
okay um yeah and that's only 10 bucks a
month you can see you can see the whole
new studio
um and the cool thing is we're going to
start like other channels on it there's
going to be smasher pass dating shows
which i know some of you guys are like
why would you do that
guys
fun
yeah i want to create all this stuff on
youtube i watched growing up but i just
i love those videos and now she's able
to do it yeah yeah so and we'll also do
like red pill stuff like you could do a
like
we're going to do wife school yeah
school yeah where we learn how to do
wifey things we're trying to get wife
out yeah we're trying to
we're gonna put in the work we're gonna
get a personal trainer no one wants to
wife tomboys yeah nobody yeah we we
spent most of our life trying to be
dudes
we grew up we grew up with brothers as
boys yep
we were the female male yeah yeah
so we're trying to undo that in wife's
school so
yes
so everyone fingers crossed
hope hope we can get the studio because
it's really nice um
talk about our member of the week i
remember the week is zentius
and so um for member of the week we go
off of all the members that we have
um
it's just at random selection
everybody's name gets put in a pot and
we randomly select or if we see that
there's been one from the following week
that's just been
super active in the chat super um
active and donating to the channel we
will
pick that one out of the pot instead of
randomly selecting so yes
zen hands was a g like early on he was
you remember you were on those shows it
was my first 250 dollar super chat and i
was like
250. i said yes
i was like
because at that point i i just lost so
much money and i got equipment and [__]
i was like oh my god i can make my money
back
i was like i'm so poor
[Laughter]
sentience oh gee okay can i i can't see
the oh here it is okay
i can't see the chat on my computer
where's the live right there
no that was the old one
i don't think i don't think this is us
that was the first i can see the chat
okay i was just wondering i'm pulling it
up on my laptop
so today the first thing we're doing is
we're actually going to be showing jess
the red pill dot oh here it is
uh
oh he clicked the wrong one that's why
yeah yeah take the pre-game you wanna go
you're gonna go fix it yeah okay okay
because you can edit it on stream hey
guys yeah
episode one
yeah i know i could i could see it cause
i was like it's not coming up i don't
see it
but it's it's cool jess is gonna go fix
it
um
now with the discord
i think the discord links works now i
think we fixed it
yeah no um if it doesn't let dm me on
instagram we'll see if we can figure it
out
um
okay
finishing school i know i want to go to
finishing school all the finishing
schools have rejected me so far but
that's the plan but today i'm showing
jess it's called
the it's a red pill documentary um it's
by cassie something what is it you know
the name cassie j cassie j yeah and so
we can't actually show it on the screen
because of copyright but what we're
going to do is there is a link in the
description so you guys can watch it
there and we're going to tell you time
stamps of where we watch so if you guys
want to watch it with us get ready you
know and then we're going to tell you
we're going to tell you when we stop
um
let's see oh my god am i sunburned from
yesterday look at that
man that's like a normal day for me i'm
not too
especially in london
it's a bit rare in london yeah okay um
also if you want to get on the show dm
eddie um the link is in the description
we
we're about to ramp up the guests after
we move there's a oh my gosh i just know
this show is about to hit like new highs
as soon as we move because we have
we have a lot of different topics you
changed the thumbnail too
yeah let me just let me check it
sometimes you gotta
perfect yeah yeah perfect
and then the is the video in the
description
yep okay amazing
um
but are you sure i don't see
it um
yeah i don't see it is there
and make sure and we have the pen comma
oh thank you for the super chat
i let's you guys in stratford yesterday
having a good time yeah guys we have a
video coming out that's going to be so
funny we were raiding people on the
street to their faces
it was so funny oh my god
why would finishing school reject you
well
i don't know why actually i mean i think
they were busy from the time of the year
or maybe that was an excuse i don't know
i think it's sometimes like people don't
want to be involved in the channel
because it's a little bit controversial
but i'm gonna that's like one of my
goals for the next couple months is to
find a finishing school to work with
um
so if you know any let me know feel free
to dm them like ones in london
red pill this is going to be interesting
okay jess is coming back
it's been wait no it's been so hot in
london
okay
you ready for this
so we're about to start the documentary
and we're going to put it in between us
and we're gonna do time stamps
and so it's a two hour video
um
so i'm gonna give you guys like five
minutes to pull it up if you wanna do it
so give you guys a second
um and you can put it on the screen the
yeah okay
should we do a workout on camera later
tonight
what if we have somebody
write a workout for us and we did it
it has to be at night it's going to be
too hot during oh yeah at night for sure
wait we should get there's been some
trainers that came on the show see if
they want to like come work us out
what trainer could we get
was it mike is it micah trainer yeah i
think he is
see what he's doing
oh wait
um okay
i'll ask him later today yeah
all right guys so are you sure the
link's in the description i don't see it
here
what is it yeah so go go put the link in
i changed it maybe you didn't press save
i don't know sometimes
we've been struggle busting today don't
worry we have 24 hours to figure it out
oh auntie jenny's coming in four hours
yeah onto jen in the chat yay wait clap
clap yay
we see you onto jenny let's see
let me refresh it
um
no why do you put it that i'm so tired
why do they keep putting ninja watchers
in the chat they're like ninja watching
here no i don't like you people
don't let them get to you paul they do
get to me i'm putting on a fire ass show
i'm live streaming for 24 hours straight
and you'll have the audacity to not
subscribe or even like the video they
probably dislike in the video oh
they're disliking the video
could you imagine gasps
i'll tell you what though
dislike goes towards the algorithm
they're engaging in your content
they're here
they they
are doing something
no but then they'll put in the chat
ninja watcher here what do you mean
ninja watcher
you're not a ninja watcher if you're
commenting
true
true i'll get this on instagram like
people will dm me ninja watcher ninja
watcher i'm like
oh my gosh anyways
okay let's see let's see if the chat is
there look at them they're posting in
their numbers now
there
um
oh yeah yeah we got it we got it
is that it so is that a youtube video oh
it's for buy or run i see okay yeah
because we can't put it on the stream
guys let me know in the chat if we put
the audio on on loud on my laptop would
youtube copyright it
because that's one way we could do it
but i'm a little nervous that youtube's
gonna end the stream
i'll let you guys pick in the chat
i mean i guess if this stream ends we
could just do another it's not the
end-all be-all
um
i now see what
you wanted the that the middle mic for
so you could put the microphone next to
the laptop
oh i didn't even think of that
um
we found her trigger
oh dude oh they want me to do a quick
wrap i'll do a quick wrap for you guys
i'll do a quick wrap i'll do a quick
grab but no screen recording this had no
clipping me
don't do it
do not i will have beef with you
real beef
okay hold on let me um
yeah he's setting up because i think
we're going to put the audio one mic by
the laptop okay so we can pick up the
audio but not i think
couldn't you just have the mic
uh okay
about whales that's what they said they
want to freestyle about whales
chat with us today
why would i open i keep trying to
hmm
[Laughter]
get it
i'm in the street and i'm well citing
sailing through the g's
wait hold on i gotta try again hold on i
got nervous
let me try again
correct
whales
[Music]
i'm a bail for the whale smooth sailing
and i know that they're leaning over the
railing rails they're so big they're so
fat all the rolls like that
rolls rolls rolls
and they say they want a high value man
i say girl you can chase him if you can
but you can't run that far you're a
freaking whale
get on a boat but it probably won't sail
yeah yeah get on a boat probably won't
say it
because this is what they try to do
i say girl get on the treadmill but
you're so freaking loud it's like a
windmill
[Laughter]
time to fix
that's all i'm here for
wait wait you could say
all right just thought of something
funny
okay
take the whale out to dinner like that
you'll probably get a big ass bill and a
heart attack
[Laughter]
go you want to try no i know i've
already told you nope i can't yeah you
could do it i feel like you could do it
i'm a hype woman i'm a woman
you think if we
close the blinds
it would be less hot since the sun's not
beaming in yeah oh good idea look at it
look at it
oh just do it a little lower then just
so you don't have to
okay okay
it's whale hunting season that's what i
said you can get a big ass whale and get
her into bed
she'll be easy yeah cause she's got low
self-esteem i'm just spitting facts you
might say that i'm mean
yo yo yo yo get up earl get in pearl
yo
and then they'll come crying every day
it's a whale attack every single day
that i play i'm not trying to be mean i
just say how it is
and you know that you don't want to have
kids no girl that can't put the freaking
fork down
becky come on
turn this [__] around turn around turn
around baby put the fork on the ground
maybe try a salad soup
and get a round
turn that frown upside down period
what's the chat saying oh i don't want
to know
okay okay
change up the beat
yeah what should i do what should i rap
about
[Music]
modern women
moderate moderate
reload the beat reload the beat
okay okay okay
all right
modern
[Music]
she's in everybody's sheets
let's know she's got the meat
of everybody around town and sweet
you might think i'm a little harsh harsh
you might think i'm a little mean mean
you might think there's some in between
but modern women that's what they be b
they're in instagram they're in every
freaking rapper's dm's and they want a
high value man six figures
six inches my friend
and i asked what do you have to offer
well i asked what do you have to say
are you a good wife and mother
she said [__] not today
period
ah i like that one
just party things
album dropping january 1st what else do
modern women do let me think let me
think so what do they say they sleep
around they go around town nothing's
ever their fault shame insult need to be
right and they always want to fight
every day
and i'm like [__] what do you say men
have it hard you don't even know girls
have it easy in the world they don't
even know they think they're so
oppressed they can't even get dressed
they think that it's so hard but it's
really freaking easy i mean you're like
wait
let's go
around
you're a pretty white girl and you're
from the suburbs
and you got a lot of brothers
and you think that you have it so hard
you think that you're oppressed when you
go the whole 90 yards how are you
oppressed when you don't have to fight
you don't have to
be out at night you can be really easy
i can't think of one wait
what else do they do
let's go into round two what do they do
jess
a lot a lot a lot it's like
not a rumble they sleep around
double standards
okay okay i gotta go
they don't take accountability
i'm a modern woman it's about me
i'm a modern woman only i see i'm a
modern woman it's about me
me me not my family i could have two
kids but i'm gonna leave
i want to go in a time machine because i
could have did better than my baby daddy
all right i'm done let's go i'm done
just party things i'm done on the mic
i'm done
dropping january
january
oh this is funny whale will attack
trying to get on that heart attack come
at me i'll remind you of that pasta
snack
there's another super chat earlier i
don't know if it was a wrap
yeah you should try it's fun you know
race transformers are the key to showing
how wild gender ideology is you can use
the shaming language to defend it you're
being a race transformer phobic you're
anti-switching your pod made me think of
this
and thank you for joe seen all the super
chats
the green one where did i miss it
here's a tip for all of you to beat the
heat grab an ice cube and hit the bottom
of your wrist for 10 seconds each oh
thank you
okay let's so we're going to start the
red pill documentary yes yeah sorry
carry on
okay i have it pulled up here okay so if
you guys want to follow along with us
i'll tell you guys time stamps of when
we start
uh could you just test that mic in front
of you for me with your um
with your voice
in testing one two three perfect we're
gonna put it and we're gonna put the
audio on the screen i think yeah i'm
gonna put it here
[Music]
i wish i could put it like
all right i'm gonna go back
okay
we're getting it together guys make sure
justin we got 24 hours i know
okay amazing
yeah and if you guys want to watch it
with us you can buy it the link is in
the description
um unfortunately youtube's gonna
copyright me i'm a little nervous about
the audio we'll see if it starts to get
picked up on copyright then
can you see before it gets picked up on
copyright no it'll just send this if it
does we can just restart another one
what do you mean for the website no no
you have to that's yeah um
but yeah i've seen other people do it
um
okay let's see
this patch on my arm looks so bad looks
like i'm a
burn survivor
i'm a survivor
[Music]
this
is that journey for me
oh you know what i should do
it's buffering
you never buffer here
no
i got
like
what's going on you know i'll download
it so it's actually we actually have the
file so it won't
give me a second
how's everyone's day
or night
where is everyone tuning in from i'm
wondering
what
i think i downloaded it a couple months
ago though so as long as i didn't wipe
my computer
[Music]
let me see i can't see
what the people ask oh yeah you know i
have it i have it here okay we're good
okay we found it
you want me to look at the chat yeah i
want to just pull that but it's feeling
weird
have you ever been to something
and you don't sound from earlier what
just happened
but you know it was important to go
through
this
is that journey for me
[Music]
a toxic distillation of the worst
aspects of american sexism
it's a universe of message board where
men get together to express their hatred
towards women
i i thought men's have all the
advantages in the world these days
that's utter nonsense men are routinely
ground up in a family court system that
is misinterested and biased against them
they are the majority of the homeless
they are the majority of suicides they
are the majority of the drug addicted
they are the majority of the unemployed
they are the majority of school dropouts
there are majority of those in prison
how do we know that they're not the
cause of these problems
but when you when you say all the
women's problems it's men's problems
what if what if they said like women are
the majority of the sexual assault
victims what if the women are the cause
of that problem yeah the time stamp is
138 that we paused that
oh [__] thank you for now you're good
um she said
yo yeah
that's
my goodness she said what how do we know
that they're not the cause of the
problem what about
that that's
ah
that's the first minute we're in for a
ride folks
mark let me tell you it is because we
are stronger and we are happier at the
end of the day than most men and that is
factual and you know it when men are
married to women who scream like you
they just want to die sooner
first of all how is that factual
and second of all married to women like
you they want to die sooner or just
leave them
yo
oh my god how was that factual
how
show me the fact show me the carfax
susie
show me the carfax
time stop oh
sorry it was 150 151
151 okay now we're at 152.
a voice
an online hub
for men's rights activists and they were
founded by a man named paul ellen
it's a website called a voice for men
that's run by a man named paul elam
which is male spelled backwards but it
is his real name apparently
it's a gathering of women haters the
southern poverty law center has
classified that group and men's rights
groups as hatred
he
wrote a piece
declaring the month of october to be
bash a violent [__] month
i mean literally to grab them by the
hair and smack their face against the
wall here
uh 246 time stamp um i mean i wouldn't
condone violence
for them to say that
this
is a hate group and
um
pretty much a hate group and a
violent group
what about
the context of
feminism or a feminist and what their
original outlook was to do why
can't we if we're gonna categorize one
we might as well categorize the other
one because it's just the same thing
it's just
they're one's male one's female i just
feel like the men's rights group have an
actual point where women are just
spoiled
you ever think about how men built the
world for us to hate them
yeah because think about it like
in the old days we would just be like
stolen
yeah they would think that's what you do
you kill the dad you you take the kids
and so they basically made a safe ass
world where we can walk alone like
roughly alone like people will say they
can't walk alone at night but i do it
all the time i'm fine same yeah and
and they we built they built this world
for us
yeah like because they did all the hard
[__] they fought in the wars like we
couldn't even have sovereign states
without men
we like they tamed the world like the
world was a harsh place they tamed it
for us to go back complain and hate them
and then leave them like did you know in
the u.s they literally kidnapped
guys and like sent them to the u.s or
sent them to england to like start start
the united states they were literally
kidnapped and taken like just sat there
and most of them died
wow
that's interesting yeah and they tried
to do it with women and then they think
christopher columbus a kidnapper
i don't think it was no i don't think it
was him i don't i don't know i just know
that's how it originally like started
wow
do you okay so
you said that um
talk about how women can walk alone at
night and you said that you do i do the
same thing
do it
you think that
men get not offended but men get
what's the word that i'm looking for
because
okay better question do you ever have
dude say like no like i'll walk you i'll
walk you to your car i'll walk you home
and you're like no i'm fine
like do you ever have dudes like do that
and they'll be like no like let me walk
you like you can't walk out here so hot
they're like no
you're like okay please i can't
like i'm so i'm so helpless
then you pull the car oh i i can't walk
alone that night you have so quick
question doesn't it depend on the guy
yeah
i mean i think it's sweet either way no
but i've had guys i'm not attracted to
like if i'm friends with him no so like
so my question is more so like if a guy
says i'll walk you home and like you're
not attracted to him and he's like no no
i will walk you home
doesn't that
oh if i it depends if i don't know
yeah if he's creepy then i'm creeped out
that's true but then they always say
that
you know it depends how it like creeps
how attracted you are to him so for me
i just end up saying okay because
i know i can walk myself home and
usually it's not a far walk not just
like yeah no i'm fine and sometimes i
like walking by myself but they're like
no like you can't you're a woman you
can't i'm like
okay and you can walk me all right
i don't know if it's if it's a guy i
like i'm like
i get to spend my time with you
you're right yeah i'm just so helpless i
don't
i'm a woman i can't do nothing can you
actually hear me
oh my feet oh i actually can't use my
legs
oh there's a two super chats oh super
chat um just an fy for the boogies the
movie is on amazon and can be watched
for free with ads
oh there you go
uh
a monkey
you sob he always sends stuff like that
and i really don't want to read it i
know i saw the last one
i'm happy that we can support you in
that way in life um
but please don't tell us yeah we don't
want to know now now we know
oh you can't now we know
like i said if we're happy we can
support you in that and like take that
at you as you will
and that's fine that's fine
but the house of has says the stock led
to me meeting so many men in the u.s i
wanted to self-deliver but who wanted to
self-delete leap because they couldn't
see their kids it truly hurt my soul no
to marriage and the us is too risky
american women are too risky
not as american yeah no we're in the uk
so
we we switched over
yeah we're different
we're special
we're the exception the exception
so many exceptions
was that 236
uh we're at so we're at 307 right now
yeah that last one was yeah that was
yeah that was 256.
oh paul elm is he said it was male's bed
but it spelled backwards
okay oh my god the audacity someone in
the chat said she'll only pay attention
to those who throw money at her
excuse me um pay attention if you're hot
too
exactly yeah get your priorities
straight
and that's three three or seven yeah
three three three sixteen no
audacity
money and good luck yeah only money
you may be wondering why i'm sitting in
a car with notorious men's rights
activist paul elam
that's a valid question
and to answer it
i need to start at the beginning
the beginning of how i became a feminist
i was a quiet kid preferring to observe
from afar my mom put me in theater
classes when i was eight years old to
break me out of my shell and i loved it
so much to the point that i decided to
move to hollywood when i was 18 years
old to become an actress what i wasn't
prepared for was to be pigeonholed as
the blonde who always died billy
she was that blonde and scary movie i
had a good scream
but the characters i played weren't
alone and feeling objectified i was
commonly harassed on the streets hit on
by married producers told by
photographers to come back when i lost
15 pounds and got a boob job and a
plethora of other uncomfortable
experiences
all while still being a teenager
i started to realize my role in the
world seemed a little too similar to the
unfortunate roles i was auditioning for
and it was not how i saw myself or the
person that i wanted to be
so
i quit acting and bought a video camera
to tell the stories i wanted to tell
and now i've been making documentary
films since 2008 when i was 21 years old
most of my work has been about women's
issues and sexuality
i've covered a range of topics from the
phenomenon of purity balls to
reproductive rights single motherhood
and lgbt rights
after releasing my film in 2012 about
marriage equality
i was at a loss of what topic to explore
next
and that's when two horrific stories
broke the news
two-star high school football players in
steubenville ohio have been found guilty
of raping a west virginia teenager
the video shows the former steubenville
student callously joking about the
incidents
[Music]
outrage across india as a 23 year old
woman the victim of one of the most
horrific rapes india has ever heard of
a 90-minute horror for a 20 okay we're
at uh 5 52. i stopped it but
huh
justin you take notes of the timestamps
as well
um
no just to hear that in india because
you don't hear much about stuff like
this
there so that like yeah maybe a little
bit i don't yeah
that's really sad yeah give me one
second
what's wrong
oh you want a lip balm
not trying to look like a crackhead on
screen guys
where what is he doing with the time
stamps
um i think he's he's put in the chat or
something yeah okay we're at 5 52.
three-year-old medicine student on this
bus
gang raped and beaten her friend
assaulted and thrown out of the bus
every day every woman is facing violence
on the street
i started to research this rape culture
a website called a voice for men popped
up
paul elam wrote about how women longed
to live out their rape fantasies to be
taken by a man she's never spoken to
yeah
yeah that's what the sorry uh 625
um that's what the guy from only family
said he said that's his most requested
but then i see i don't understand that
women have fantasies about it and they
behind closed doors don't want it
happening to them
but
we'll be out in the street
men do this and then do that you know
what i think it is i think i wonder if
there's some biology behind it because
historically the best man won
so it was almost like if if someone
stole you um
i know
what do they do they kill they kill the
husband and kill the cubs
and then they take you and they claim
you and then they have more kids with
you
you know what i'm saying and so i think
that's why women are so hypergamous is
because throughout history if you
weren't like your dude would die and
they'd take him and they would take you
and that's why they say like girls can
get over men so fast
is because like before like they had to
because they were now the property of
the strongest man that is true and so
like in this i wonder if that there's
somebody i don't know but i'm wondering
if there's some biological like reason
that girls have those type of fantasies
because
biologically like you were that would
you were graped if
you would say like yeah and you and you
had to like stockholm syndrome you know
what that is i've heard of it but it's
it's when so if you were to get
kidnapped
and you would fall in love with the guy
that kidnapped you
that only happens to women it doesn't
happen to men
where like they'll try to get the girl
and she'll be like nah i'm staying
okay yeah because that's like the
strongest i mean if he's hot come on
shut up
i'm playing i'm playing don't nobody
come knocking on my door
or busting out my nose please
i don't know if that's true but i was
just that's interesting okay 6 25 we're
gonna keep playing
let alone given consent to
as i read i was asking myself
is this the rape apologist that i've
been hearing about great cassie
i continue to read voice for men's
website
often stopping around the halfway mark
in every article because i could only
read so many [__] [__] feminazi and
rape tart words per minute
but even still
i kept reading
and thinking when is it
the title of that that um
703 go ahead um
he said when is it okay to
punch your wife
like
um
um i don't know but someone was actually
searching that that's funny when is it
okay to punch your wife chad when do you
think it's okay to punch your wife do
you think do you think it's ever okay to
hit a woman if not like if she's being
super mouthy or something like okay
imagine this so that's thinking like
you've seen girls be super mouthy with
their boyfriend mm-hmm
what if he slapped her is he wrong
um
i don't i don't have an answer i was
thinking
it's hard
cause like if a dude gets mouthy with a
woman she'll she won't hesitate to hit
him
yeah
but a man will hesitate because he knows
like
he doesn't want to go you know he's like
he's not going to jail over this yeah yo
if i well we're going to talk about this
later but if i was homeboy in that
elevator i was a molly whopped home girl
so quick
hold on my hair
we're going to talk about it later oh
god
okay 70703 we're playing i understand
how these what i perceived to be women
haters could have so many followers
[Music]
so
i decided to meet these mras
the ones leading the movement
and some of their followers too
and this
begins my journey
down the rabbit hole
this ladies and gentlemen is an historic
[Music]
moment still gone
what you'll hear
is that we hate women
you'll hear that it's a backlash against
women's rights you'll hear that we're
regressives that want women back in the
kitchen and making sandwiches and and
barefoot and pregnant you're just bitter
you're a loser you're a whiner you're
ugly you're undesirable you're lazy
you're scary you must be a racist you
must be a misogynist when we do speak
out
uh women often don't want to hear what
we have to say
[Music]
and so then we're called names
we're called whiners
and this is the way people who don't
want men to talk about issues try to
shut us out
you know the fun thing is
if they called
if it was the roles were reversed and
they said
women were whiners they complained they
don't like men oh my god yeah
they would be pissed
even though i kind of do say that
and the women hate me
and they're still pissed but if it was
on like a large scale like that
where yeah people are trying to
create
rights that they
essentially don't have
um
they
they would be
upset yeah but now they're just supposed
to take it like no
it's okay
take it
um
9 10.
beta
[Music]
and don't confuse selfridge with
oppression everyone suffers it's
universal
i am a man and i need feminism
and it is crystal clear
that the problems for men and boys
are real
i would like to turn the microphone to
uh
[Music]
for
what is the mra actually like men's
rights activists i know i know what it
stands for what do they what do they
stand for
it's like things like it's kind of like
a lot of the issues that we talk about
our channel like child custody
okay like there are men that commit
suicide over trying to get custody of
their children and you know what's crazy
when you talk to feminists about it
they always say things like women have
to have the kids
when i talk about child support when
they're like oh they have to raise them
i'm like what about they get to
yeah like
have to you don't you don't want to be
around your children
yeah exactly but i think it goes okay i
think some women hate their kids
oh i believe it i think it's because
they they reproduced with a guy they
wish they didn't reproduce with
and especially when they leave they
think they could have did better and
they low-key hate that kid yeah because
that's the
yeah there's a lot there's a lot of
stories that i've heard where
the mother will hate their kids because
of the envy that
she has towards the dad and it's like
why are you blaming the kid for with
someone else and they'll take everything
out on that kid or moms that are still
single so they compete with their
daughters looks wise yep i've heard that
but it's always single moms it's not
because if you're married what do you
care
exactly yeah but
yeah
or even if they're
there i've heard stories where the
the mom is still in the relationship
with the dad and the daughter is getting
all this attention from
the dad
and then the mom will envy the daughter
because she's like i want that attention
that should be my intention and she
treats her like i never i never thought
of that yeah
um 10 15. women hate their kids because
the kid becomes number one in the family
not her
that's true because modern women are so
self-centered and selfish that like when
it's not about her anymore they're
pissed
oh my gosh that's terrible like
you made the decision
to get pregnant to have a child
and then you're going to bring this
child into the world
and envy it because of the attention
that it gets from someone that
you
love i'm talk speaking that they're
married and whatnot someone that you
loved and consensually decided to have a
child with you're going to envy that
that child that had
literally
nothing to do with anything
and make its life miserable you know
i have a question i just thought of this
yeah would you rather have three hundred
thousand dollars in your bank account
and be 35
or would you rather be
21 with zero dollars in your bank
account
in context of what i'd probably be
21 with zero dollars in my bank account
is that interesting how valuable youth
is
yeah
and
because
the reason i asked in terms of what uh
like what context if um
are they still gonna be able to hear the
sound
could they hear it at all yeah yeah okay
cool
um
see if i was uh
what if you're 35 and married would it
change because i almost might pick 30
days yeah if i would see if i was 35 and
married and had that in my bank oh yeah
it would change but if i was 21 it had
zero dollars
and i was able to know what i know now
yeah then i would essentially
be able to make that much money yeah in
a short amount no that's what i think
that
like skills are more important than
than money
like knowing what i know now i could
even if i went to zero i could build it
again that is true different way that is
true oh we have a don't
we're getting it together
the entire platform of the men's rights
movement
is kind of like trying to understand the
snow
one snowflake at a time
it's a very very complicated matter
just consider this that
of workplace fatalities are men four of
five suicides
are men
men are dropping out of higher education
at very alarming rates we're down to 38
now
of college students are men
and it's dropping rapidly male suicide
male abuse male unemployment male
homelessness male failure and education
male health issues we've got the
paternity fraud issue
and the wrongful fraternity issue
not false
[Music]
they're less likely to have health
insurance the family court system truly
admires against men i mean there's just
no question about it this is really the
process for women only
because men
they're denying men any kind of choice
once a child is conceived her body or
her choice right
think about men
this body his choice
not so much okay
okay we're at we're at 11 54.
you know what's crazy
um
when they say my body my choice
they never talk about like men don't
have the choice if they get drafted they
call it selective service now it's like
if there's a state of emergency men have
to basically go to war but like nobody
cares when it's
that
that is true
and
and then even with the my body my choice
argument you know what they said so i
was saying you could grab one of the
stinky okay
um
like
what if someone aborted babies based on
skin color would that be okay because
it's her body her choice yo
like based on and i said there
apparently there's reddit threads of
girls getting pregnant by a certain race
and then aborting it because it like wow
[Laughter]
yo we'll have to tell you about the chat
we had before this stream about short
kings
um someone asked in the chat what we're
listening to so the
the
thing is on the screen it's the red pill
by cassie jade
so you guys can youtube or you can um
the link to it is in the description so
if you want to buy it you can follow
along we're giving time stamps
[Music]
okay okay so 11 54.
he does not want to send you to die if
you'd rather send me
[Music]
young men that are begging to launch
they're staying in their homes of origin
far past
[Music]
of young boys with drugs like redline to
manage their behavior almost all victims
of autism spectrum disorders are boys
boys are most likely to be homeless most
likely to get cancer most likely to die
young and of every major problem most
likely to be arrested prosecuted
and even executed
it doesn't matter what their ethnicity
is it doesn't matter what their
religious or non-religious views are it
doesn't matter if they're gay or
straight
men and boys are in crisis and they need
your help and they need your support
because they are human beings too and
you will not shame me or anybody here
it's the silence about it anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
so if
but if you start to talk
13-1307
so if
if men don't support this movement what
does that say about them
betas
like i just think that we're brainwashed
we're like i just think we're
brainwashed from a young age like even
terms we use in our society knocked up
it sounds like he did it
he got her pregnant
like even like yeah there's like phrases
in society that we and i i've used them
too and it's still even today like
i'll say something and then i'll think
about it i'm like why do we say it like
that
i feel you
that's interesting like it's always the
accountabilities on men
and i think men are just told they're
[__] from like a young age
yo how do you even how could you live
life does people always being
against you how how is that ish knowing
that
you have to kind of
walk around
on
egg shells
throughout life like have you ever felt
where you can just be like
be you
or you always have to be like oh i'm a
man and essentially like i'm a black man
so
so i think
um it's an interesting question because
more so than anything you you learn as a
man that's aware of surroundings
especially within the red pill that um
[Music]
it's important to know how to code
switch
and just understand your environment and
surroundings and yes you can act how you
want if you wanted to
but understand there are consequences
for you not acting in
an according way
and so
i wouldn't necessarily say it's acting
but i would say it's being the best
version yourself of yourself in that
environment
so
um what allows you to get the most out
of an environment is it the way you talk
is it the way you communicate with
people either verbally or
um
what's visually
um and just understanding your
environment really yeah
i know there's a lot of nothing but
it makes sense
so did because you weren't always red
pill did you ever had a red pill moment
when you were younger like then maybe
looking back you didn't think anything
of or like like at the time you didn't
think of anything of but looking back
you're like that that was a moment so
many so many um especially like in the
dating market
um
i
would talk to a certain type of girl and
not really understand that
within the hierarchy of real market
value within the dating society
certain people have advantage or
they can have leverage
um just based on their market value i
didn't understand that so when i would
talk to girls that i would considerably
say were at a certain level
i didn't understand that
they could be looking elsewhere and i i
it was just mind-boggling to me you
didn't realize how many girls guys she
was talking to yeah like you were just
one of many yes and yeah
i've seen guys like face yeah like
change
yeah when or or like we'll know cause
we're girls right and so we kind of know
a little bit more than you guys just
behind the scenes like talking where
like dude doesn't know that she's
talking like to everybody
and so he'll like his ego like he'll
he'll be excited about her
and then just find out oh she's
yeah on the streets for the gang
okay we're at 1307.
i see anything about those issues and
address them in terms of how they affect
men and boys as a group
people get hostile
about it
the idea is that
men have all the rights they've always
had the power
but if that's true
why can't men talk about their problems
and that's what really got me interested
in this to begin with
shortly after i began filming men's
rights activists
i realized my own views were being
challenged
i kept a video diary throughout filming
and i've decided to share some of those
diaries with you
i really do feel like learning about the
men's movement and their specific issues
the issues that they have issue with
it's hard for me to completely
understand them and
just automatically feel welcome in that
space of talking about these issues
because at least with feminism whenever
i heard about the issues that feminists
were fighting against i always felt like
i had something to draw from and
experience to be on board with that
that's always been
why i've been drawn to the feminist
movement is because a lot of what they
spoke about i had personal experiences
with and with the men's movement i have
very little
personal experiences with the issues
that they talk about
a cab driver uh who was work driving a
cab 70 hours a week was not saying i am
earning this money to have power over my
wife he's he was earning this money even
though it took power away from his life
he was doing that so his child wouldn't
have to drive that can
the garbage collector does not get up at
three or four in the morning and rain
and sleet and snow and and get out to
do the garbage so we can have more power
over his wife that's power he's losing
over his life in order to make his
contribution his sacrifice his way of
loving and this has been
translated into the culture of you make
more money than women do you must
therefore have more power
meet warren farrell
uh 1538.
that's interesting
because so do you think women associate
money with power
people i think you get i think you get
more power the more money you have even
even okay i grew up in a one percent
family people think before effing with
you more mm-hmm because like we will sue
you yeah we will
let it be nice like
no and they call it like they call it
[__] you money for a reason
yeah because [__] you like you
like that is true if you're broke what
are you doing nothing
yeah so did you mess with the rich
person there was there was um a time
when i was in high school um and my my
family just let us miss school whenever
so like am i the way my mom looked at
parenting is like you have to let kids
make their own decisions because you
don't want to raise overgrown children
so if you make all the decisions for
your kid then they're going to hit 18
they've never made a decision in their
life that is true and they don't know
how to make decisions so that's why you
have all these like boys that are like
they're like kids you know what i'm
saying yeah and it's the same thing with
women too
because you know a lot of red pill guys
will be like oh i'll protect my daughter
and you know but at the end of the day
like girls are going to do what they're
going to do and we all know that like
some of the girls with the strictest
parents are the why are the wildest
because my dad would always teach me
that like people will resent you for not
letting them make decisions and that's
why even when like i
like you guys work here like i give
people a lot of creative freedom because
i want people to but back to school so
so my mom would basically like if you
get anything below a c where you're
going to have problems but if you can
figure out your school and you don't go
as i don't care my mom would just call
us in i know that's like unheard of in
the uk
and i didn't i always had like good i
never i never was like an a student but
i always had good grades yeah except
this year
it's okay
you've got good grades on youtube yeah i
got good youtube yep
straight a's
but um so back to
the there was a teacher that didn't like
that i'd always miss her class it was
english and i'm i'm good at english
mm-hmm like
talking you know yeah i'm just naturally
good at it so i didn't have to go that
much and i still would do fine and my
mom would just call me and say i was
sick whatever because our mentality was
you can do
like these are my kids why do you get to
tell me what i get to do with my kids
you're the school like if i want my kid
to not be in school and she's passing
why is that your business what i do
like it's not it's not your business
like you're not the parent i'm the
parent like who is more who has more of
a best self interest in the kid turning
out good than parents
like what you're a stranger what do you
get to say so
we went on vacation to florida for two
weeks
and i just missed school for two weeks
yeah we just went me and my family went
to florida we were and i came back and i
didn't know my mom called me in sick
oh so she called so so i was in back i
was showing pictures from vacation in
english class i didn't like i didn't
know how my mom but my mom was just like
screw you guys and this teacher tried to
give me zeros for everything i missed oh
wow because
yeah she tried to give me zeros and so i
would have went i went from like a high
b and catholic schools have different
grading systems so a b is a 92.
oh b plus is a 92 yeah it's like those
grading scales 93 to 100 is an a 86 i
remember i got to college i was like
this [__] is so easy because 86 to 92 is
a b yeah 76 to 85 is a c how the freak
do you get at a in catholic school if
it's
that gap is like this big
it's hard it's very competitive yeah and
there's plus and minuses too yeah
we had this i remember i remember the
best day of my life was only i could get
an 80 and this [__] is a b i was so
excited yeah because in catholic school
you would get a 80 a c it's a c it's not
even a high c it's not even a c plus
that's a low seed
so i would always get mad because my gpa
would be lower than the guys for public
school but i'm like y'all have this [__]
on easy mode
literally
but um
i pat like in that class i had like a 90
ish and so um
that teacher wanted to give me zeroes
and basically we had to take it up and
take it up and basically they were going
to do [__] because we were like we will
sue yeah
one you can't prove it i mean we might
look to my facebook picture i could have
taken them at any time exactly
this was before lives
this is before
stories this is before this is when you
just post the picture on facebook
back in the day back in the day and so
and so but like if we didn't have fu
money what would they have done they
probably wouldn't have i probably would
have had to retake that i was a senior
too oh you would have ever had to reach
out to i probably would have graduated
so it's like buddy is power to some
extent yeah
cause that like what are you gonna do
that is true and so when they have more
power but it comes with more
responsibility
like even building this like i have more
responsibility because i have to think
of all the expenses i have to think of
like this this like problems you don't
have if you're like
feared in the background yeah yeah so in
terms of relationships do you think
that's where like the imbalance comes
from if a woman makes
more than a man then essentially she
sees herself as having more power yeah
but we don't factor into like they're
protecting us like that's a pal like
that's that's a power that they have
like
and that comes with responsibility and
so to them it's like if they're offering
protection and provision even if it's
not income
because like yeah okay i'm really great
at making a youtube channel but if
someone's breaking into my apartment
who's going yeah he is
yeah exactly and so it's like that power
used to come with responsibility and it
used to be like i mean most women don't
didn't don't did not earn men but like
it used to be like
if you did
you still submit to him because he's a
man and there's value in being a man but
now we've just marketed since the 70s
that there's no value in having a man
you don't you don't need a man yeah
and so it's like we have like women that
genuinely think they don't need a man
even if you make a lot of money and you
don't need a man you still do because
you need men to protect you
and so you're disrespecting like the
firemen the cops the garbagemen
everything that makes society run like
the the worst hardest jobs are men
yeah and
women don't appreciate them anymore
because we're just we've become to a
point where they tamed the world for us
and made it so easy that we are now
entitled
and we we feel like we are better than
the very men that protect us
just because okay yeah we make like i
make money on youtube that's yeah it's
not
like yeah okay maybe maybe i make money
on youtube but what's a harder job that
or being a garbage man
car but your man yeah
yeah if i would have known that i
probably i'd probably be a garbage woman
i
would you stop the cat
stop the cap if i know how much they
make
oh my i might get a little dirty on a
job get a little
sweaty but
i
i think some women
have
forgotten that men also offer all the
other things you're talking about
because they dismiss them when they
don't earn xyz and it's like oh i earn
more than you i've already have that
power you have nothing else to offer and
they don't realize that they offer so
much more than we could ever offer
ourselves but
because of the money's not there then
it's like cancel them you don't say hear
men even when they make a lot of money
saying we don't need women like oh i can
hire someone to nurture like you know
like we're more nurturing like you don't
go into uh
you don't see men going into
a freaking what do you call it um
a child care center and say and saying
oh we don't need women we can do this
job better than them like that would be
so weird be right or like they're going
into the teaching profession
be like
but women go into male dominance and say
oh i can do it just like the men do that
i'm a strong independent woman i don't
need no man all right say that years
later when you're sitting there by
yourself here's a question for you yeah
so do you think the gynocentric society
has made women believe that with the
society that men built and the fact that
women are more safe than ever
give or take what
other groups may say yes um do you think
that women are under the false illusion
that they don't need provision from the
men
that
they are intimate with on the basis that
if he touches me
i i've got all the power i hold all
everything and that way it's like that
provision aspect has now been removed
from what he has as what he brings to
the table
yeah it's almost like
yeah yeah because i think they forget
it's still men providing that to them
it's just not men they're intimate with
so i think i think they just like forget
that men i think hard times breed
families like world like wars
that's when marriage rates go up because
the war is coming girls are like oh [__]
friend zone friend zone i'm here
dang that's what kevin samuels would say
like like let one war break out and
women will have a man so fast
so fast
that is true
yo yeah so fast because when the world's
a shitty place you can't you can't be a
woman
like you you need a man you can't be a
woman like if society started to crumble
like
families would return
that is true
and that's why i think the marriage rate
increased after like world war ii or
something world war one i don't know
what it was bring back the families
crumble society
complain okay we're at
15 38. yeah
and self-styled
[Music]
i asked my girlfriend at the time to buy
me
as a gift i think for christmas for my
birthday warren farrell's book the myth
of male power which she did and it just
changed my whole life and his premise
was while women are often seen as sex
objects
men are often seen as success objects
and this resonated with me he wrote this
book that that questioned our notions of
power of who had power and where it was
and it questioned
the roles of men
but not the way feminists had always
questioned gender roles
every society that survived survived
based on its ability to train its sons
to be disposable
disposable in war as warriors disposable
and work as firefighters as workers on
oil rigs and so on coal miners
yeah
indirectly
[Music]
that is so
true if you think about
the dangerous jobs that men do
the potential in there is death like you
could potentially die from this job that
you're doing
that that is that is a potential side
effect and
you know i i
men are willing to do it like even they
were talking about they're like men are
willing to do this so their wife won't
have to so their kids won't have to
that's a common theme i always hear from
like older dads where they're like even
my dad okay he talked about
he his whole goal was just to pay all of
our college funds wow because he had
like a [__] ton of debt after college
and he's like i don't want my kids to
live like i did
and
but you don't hear women talk like that
like they're they're the ones stealing
child support
i talk like that
but no i i i in general yeah yeah yeah
like women it's they're the ones like
the child supporting going to the kids
like women are me me me me me where i
think i think men are more generous than
women in general oh
for sure
that
i it literally just clicked
man yeah men are men are seen as
expendable even how the u.s started they
kidnapped a bunch of men threw them on
the east coast and said build
build
build build society build it christopher
columbus
like he he went into the freaking open
ocean and said what's out there
if we if we elon musk is talking about
going to mars women aren't going to go
there to start it
that's for sure
i'm not going
but i bet you men will volunteer
yeah for sure
man
that's
my my brain is like huh
[Music]
were male
what happens
in men's life when they're raised
that they're worthless unless they're
but then they want to talk about the pay
gap the pay gap the pay gap
are you you want to go do these jobs go
do the job make the money
make the money go be a windshield uh a
window washer go be construction worker
up in the sky go cut down trees go fire
fire
go be on the front line go ahead if you
want to make the money since there's a
pay gap work these jobs time's up oh 17
17 10. yeah 17 10. go do that if there's
a pay gap like
my goodness there's
like the window washers i've always
looked at better like oh that's so cool
would i do it no
probably not
maybe it was like maybe three five feet
off the ground i'd be like
so let me guess right
you'd be a garbage disposal woman but
you wouldn't be a window cleaner the
height is the height okay it's not the
not like the job yeah being a garbage
being garbage woman
it would be it would be fun for a while
and then i'd be like i'm tired of this
garbage
let me move on would you be okay with
the smell
cat just you're not doing any of these
jobs
it could be like you're listening you're
not just you're not being a garbage man
i'm sorry i know just new jobs new uh
new channel idea i have a new channel
where i go out and try all these jobs
for a day it's a great that is a great
idea we should do that when we go out
and try all day like i just want to be a
garbage man for a day work experience
for a day yeah oh my god but let's see
let's just be real let's just be real i
would do it for that for no before
come on look at it look at jess jess
you didn't like recruiting
garbage garbage man and recruiting are
two different things okay ish let's just
if i had no
if i had the mindset of uh back in high
school and i was like railroad tomboyish
i probably would have done it
ish would you rather be a garbage man or
recruit for a podcast i'll recruit for a
podcast
it's a
it's different okay
just you have many go ahead you're
you're very recruiting i will take that
recruiting is not one of them
i would take that jess you know damn
well if you had to be a garbage man for
a month and you had to recruit for a
month you would pick recruiting
st stop kids
no i'm being serious
i
i probably do garbage
i'd probably be a lesbian by the end of
it i'd be
bolo but you know
you got you something to say yes
what say it i forgot like
oh no oh no i i'm just like would you
really
okay to be honest i was saying i know
recruiting is hard mm-hmm like i
remember oh it's a hard job it's almost
stressful that's why i was like oh don't
give up it takes a different mindset
it really does and i said i'm not ready
for look it i i just like i i didn't
think you'd like it i was like i'll let
her try it i didn't think you'd like
yeah i tried it but not my cup but
i would still do that over a freaking
garbage man
nah you were good at it though
what a recruiting
yeah i know i'm
that's that saleswoman yeah i mean
yeah but i still hated it homer i'm so
glad shout out eddie eddie shout out
she's
[Music]
that is very very powerful stuff see
feminism
did see accurately that we value male
work more than we value female work
but
there's also
the issue that we value female life more
than we value male life
[Music]
wow
oh wow
with these we're at 1758 yeah with
they can't see the screen but tell them
what's on the screen uh on the screen it
says total u.s military war death korean
war two females um
36 572 males 99 male
vietnam war eight female five fifty
eight thousand two hundred and seventeen
male 99 male persian gulf war 15 female
280 male 95 male
operation enduring freedom oef 51 female
2 301 males 98 and operation
iraqi freedom oif 110 female 4 302 male
98 male
so um
people would see this and be like but
they didn't let women in the war they
let women fight they did
there just wasn't
women wanting to there was two females
in the korean war and 36 thousand males
though died
two females
that's crazy
and then i on a podcast and i'm like do
you want to fight morrison's like yeah i
would fight
that's one job i would not do right you
would not i would not the front lines
you wanna you wanna run into fire
yeah no people dying next to you
dropping you you're trying to do that
yeah i know whenever i watch like war
movies or like
um not war movies but asian ancient
greek movies i would be always telling
my mom like oh i'll be in the back as
soon as i see them charging towards me
you'll hear a little voice in the back
running away just see a little dot
running away that is me i no
garbage woman all day
even when that plane went down new york
city a few years ago and that you know
the pilot was a hero for the way he
landed it and saved everybody word
arrived over the city-wide fire
frequency that a commercial jetliner was
in the water with 155 people on board
then over the next few minutes the doors
opened life vests were inflated and
women and children first everyone got
off that plane they saved all the women
first that's still when i went on a
cruise you know there's still women
into the life
votes for you know because you're not
because you're a man so you should be
able to swim up halfway across the ocean
but because you're a man you're
expandable
we have to look at not just the glass
ceilings but also the glass cellars
and paul i think as you are saying we
have to look at men just not only as
human doings but also human beings when
you survive because somebody else is
willing to die like in war
then that you are immune to the pain of
the people who are dying because you
have an investment in there with being
willing to die you say i will build a
statue i will remember you in a history
book but if you look at that from
another perspective that building of the
statue or remembering you in history
book is a bribe
to be a willing to die so that i can
live
but both sexes in the area where they
are rejected
tend to turn what rejects them into an
object
so the area where men
i'm watching this um
lecture that warren farrell is giving in
the 90s i see some women in a crowd and
a lot of them have their hands folded
and
there is a little bit of
uncomfortableness
by being a woman
in a crowd of people while the speaker's
talking about how
men are oppressed
and
women have it so great
it kind of puts you on the defensive
as a woman
and understanding that i feel that way
makes me wonder
are men
having their arms crossed
listening to a feminist speaker talk
about how men have all the power and
women are oppressed
are men feeling like
what are you talking about
i don't have power and
we have it pretty shitty on this side of
the grass too
what do you think
uh
2049.
when i say men have it hard when i
because i i'll have like little rants
where i'm like men have it hard
it's always followed i won't say always
but a lot of the time if i have a
feminist thought it's always but women
but women
i say or they'll flip it and turn it on
the man if i say paternity fraud
well you picked the
woman or i'll be like well but child
support well they shouldn't have got her
pregnant
technically you have access to sex so
you pick the man to impregnate you yeah
so
it's your fault
but i don't i don't think men
think that i think men just listen
and
men ish correct me if i'm wrong they
just listen and they know they know that
whoever's talking is full of it so like
this dumb broad or she doesn't know what
she's talking about and they'll
go about their day they won't blame
blame blame blame blame point point
point they'll just they'll listen
my father once said
don't argue with the form
because they'll bring you down to their
level and beat you on experience don't
argue with a what a fool
a four a fool as in a fool for four
back sound was getting away because
they'll bring you down to their level
and beat you in experience
ah
i'm here that's sometimes when the girls
are like saying nonsense on the show and
i'm just like what did you do
you have to see your facial look at them
be like yeah
what and you'll be like so
you're saying this is like no no no no
no like can you tell someone to start
saying can you talk like a normal person
you're like i'm just trying to
understand
what it is that you're saying explain it
to a five-year-old i'm not that smart
like let's just
no you are smart no but that's no that's
the like the point is
the people that try to over like go over
your head it's because they're saying
nothing
they're talking in circles explain it
explain it in layman's terms yeah
because if you're if you actually
understand something you should be able
to explain it like that's the best
teachers they're not the ones that
confuse you
they're the ones that like say it easy
and you get it
that's true
fish you tell me my sandwich
[Music]
farrell was speaking on behalf of men's
issues at the university of toronto in
canada
a feminist group protested the event
[Music]
yeah but if a man if a man did that
s-a-s-a-s-a
if a man like
that's women get away i was doing
interviews like a week ago um
and this girl came up to me was acting
so [__] and i was like you get away
with this because you're pretty and
you're a woman
that's true you literally get away with
this because you're pretty and you're a
woman
wow
because if if a man was all up in a
woman's face like you can't do that
because you're a man but a woman can do
that if he hauled off and backhand her
real quick
then
she would claim oh he assaulted me right
blah blah blah and it's like but you you
provoked him to do that
but the other way if it was other way
around and you hauled off and slapped
him
it would be okay
because
he approached you and got up in your
face it's the same thing
yeah and that's the thing men always
have the
the consequence of i might get punched
if i act a certain way but women don't
have that they used to
before like we got rights
return our rights 21.50 send us back to
the kitchen
52 21.52
you know what though why would you pay
money for [__] support of [__]
great apologies if you weren't [__]
once
well it's [__] strong
[Applause]
is
she said get a real job
ma'am i'm pretty sure you wouldn't be
the police what do you do for work
she said get a real job
oh my god that's the crazy thing is like
even when all the
um like women people were really hard on
criticizing the police a couple years
ago i'm like that's easy to do and
you're not the one doing it you you go
into these like you go into these
low-income areas these dangerous areas
and
try to
let me go let me know how it works for
you let me like it's really easy to
criticize like a job you're not doing i
i my mind switched on police not not
that i was ever against it but it gave
me a different perspective when i had to
do one of their
i sold copiers to this like training
academy it's like virtual so you
literally have the gun and they put you
in simulations where you have to pick
what to do and i got shot like every
single time because if they reach like
you have like a second oh wow so when
they're like oh he was unarmed
but it's like if they if they put their
hand down
they could get a gun and shoot you in a
sight like in a millisecond
and it's the same thing with traffic
stops like most police that die like it
comes from traffic stops so that's why
like when i was a kid they'd always
teach me to put your hands on the wheel
so they're like not threatened
because they don't know what they're
walking into because someone could have
like a warrant out for their arrest
yeah so if you get the wrong person they
might
yeah so but like a lot of times women
don't empathize with men because again
they're seen as expendable
yeah
it's i think women should be allowed in
the police force sometimes i'm like i
don't want a woman protecting me
um
i i don't know it's
i think
i think they're needed
it's just in different areas possibly
like possibly more like
home calls to where
okay
but if it goes south
not like abuse home calls
but
it's hard to explain i
i would say they're needed
just in areas where they can't excel
i can't think of any in police
like i can't think of one thing that a
girl could do better than a guy at
police
um ticketing
yeah but you know like but if you pick
what yeah admin but you might as well
just get an admin assistant like like
ticketing on like paying tickets on
cards like a ticket monitor
i think they would do that the same
i don't think women would do ticket like
parking tickets better than men
oh yeah would be like
they've only been here for five minutes
if anything they'd let people go yeah
yeah i'll give them five minutes like
because even just traffic stops like
again most police shootings are at a
trap like a traffic stop
i
think i think they
would be
they're needed for
to be
another
like person there
for if they do i know you can't like
gear off whoa when are we gonna do
women's stops when they're gonna do mail
stop so we need two male cops here we
need a male and uh nah kick him out of
the force
kick him out
that's not me saying that
is what 22-27 rights look like
men's rights look like this is what men
tried to look like this is what men's
rights look like
right
what do they mean
[Music]
but pharaoh wasn't always so attentive
to men
in fact for years he focused almost
exclusively on women's issues rubbing
shoulders with feminist leaders like
gloria steinem and he's still a
card-carrying member of the national
organization for women
i believe that women cannot hear what
men do not say and he's got a lot to say
to both men and women in his provocative
new book the myth of male power
i was making a very significant amount
of money speaking around the world on
behalf of women's issues alone
i went through a period of forming men's
groups and then when i listened to them
i thought well gee this will be really
helpful to present to audiences so that
they can understand not only women's
side but men's side too because i was
released totally in the feminist camp
and immediately i saw my standing
ovations dropped i started hearing that
there was people saying don't invite him
there you know and to speak with us and
pretty soon i had you know very few
college and university speaking
engagements how did you originally get
involved with feminism
where did that all begin i was doing my
doctorate in political science at nyu in
the
late 60s and the women's women's service
[Music]
i wonder when
it started or like when women
thought they were unequal to men or when
when was that like
switch or whatever like oh we are
unequal to men we need rights like when
i think it was in seneca falls new york
i think
i mean essentially we are unequal to men
because they're man well bio
biologically yeah if
a dude hits you you might die
yeah
granted so it's sort of mad but it's
just not the i think you you
i've never seen rece i just my my gut's
telling me that if i get hit by a dude
i'm more likely to die than if a dude
gets hit by a dude i don't know why
yeah no that is true
aren't our bones yes it's smaller yeah i
think it's like bone density like men
have thicker bones or something
whatever the first trans person existed
i wonder
did i ever tell you i played basketball
against one
i'd be so irritated
what happened
she decked somebody no it was just like
we were walking into was when i played
uh at my first college in california we
were going to a weekend um
scrimmage uh tournament
and i walked in and they did like an
article and a video on her and
everything i walk and i see this
six foot like
five
woman older and i'm like
yo i looked at my teammates and i was
like
how many how many points she dropped
she wasn't that trippy
no see i think i think it's a cheat code
for men that aren't the men that aren't
that great at a sport they can become
trans and be
still not great but seem like they're
like
excellent as a woman because they're in
women's sports oh so it allows them to
elevate from whatever level they're at
so let's say their mediocre at the men's
level they're now
in the top percentile in the female
they're not amazing yeah but they're
they are
they're better than if they were a man
so it was interesting playing against
her i was like you are
you are
were born a man but now you're playing
and i was probably like
bro 19. yeah i was probably like 19.
yeah 19 19 20. i said in the chat how
many times this girl got red pill
every day
i i'm around pearl every day so
i'm her shadow literally i literally
can't oh my god i would protest
if someone made me play against dudes oh
i'll play against some dudes in the in
the park you know
yeah but i know i know i can see their
skill you know when you go to the park
to play basketball there's some games
you bow out of oh yeah you ain't you
ain't play like you see a certain when
it gets to a certain level you're like
yeah you're like
yeah
or the ones that think they're at that
level and they're not you know you get
injured you're like yeah i know
yeah i'm i'm not i'm not about to put
myself in harm's way but it's like as a
woman now they're entering the sector so
it's like
you the skill might may not be there and
you may be like okay i can take them
skill wise yeah but then it's like
physically i can't because if i stand up
against them i'm going to get hurt
either way because they're just
physically stronger than me it's like
how
no
i'm okay no
okay we're at 2502. 250. this is the
most effective thing i've ever heard
because i heard civil rights gay rights
but suddenly being open the door is
and so it's like why shouldn't women be
encouraged to do everything they
possibly can do and if they hope when
the window is in the bathroom just make
sure it's open married
please make sure that
[Music]
how depressed that must make a woman and
it's not going to be good for a man
either he never knows whether he's loved
for who he is or love for what he has
and he's afraid to give up producing
because he's afraid to lose love and so
women who were successful to me appeared
to be women who would free men from
having to be all you know wrapped up in
just being the only breadwinner
and supporting one two three four five
people which you know it's one thing to
support yourself when you're supporting
five people you don't have the freedom
to question your boss
because you're supporting five people
the first issue of feminism
was to say just because i'm a woman
maybe i don't want to spend my life
raising children you know don't don't
force me into that role against my will
so they looked at men and said well
you're not forced to raise children you
don't have any issues
but for men the traditional sex oil was
not raising children for us the
traditional sex role is to be a provider
a protector and to initiate relationship
how is someone forcing someone to have
children
to raise the kids just basically saying
that's a feminist say
like oh he gets to go to work or i have
to raise the kid it's like it's weird
they like hate kids
i just don't understand how they're
forced to have if you don't if you don't
want to raise kids you don't want to
have kids
cool they feel like society is making
them do it even though it's not society
it's personal choice but they feel like
like society's making that's the only
like if you talk to feminists they'll
say things like oh society's pushing
these gender roles on us
and when i'm like what about women's
empowerment like i've been told i could
do anything from the time i was like a
child yeah
dang in all the movies it's always like
a girl doing a guy's job
she's the man
remember that movie i love she's the man
why it's because of girls in a man's
world and doing it better than them it's
funny i know it's a fight
that's one of my favorite movies the
point is like after we see those
storylines all the time yeah even in the
freaking superhero movies now i'm like
scarlett johansson pipe down you know
damn well you are not leading the
freaking chart like this is just
unrealistic at this point like if you're
gonna do it give me brittany
sorry brittany griner like i know you
can't right now
but i'm like give me give me a [__]
like that in there if you're gonna have
someone leading don't give me scarlett
johansson how tall is she she ain't
doing [__]
yeah get get me in there that'll at
least be a little more realistic or one
of those bodybuilding [__]
that tr that's your helga from um the
titans yeah yeah like you're getting yo
led the chart i'm like i'm behind okay
let's go you hear me scarlett johansson
what is she gonna do
i'm like i'll probably
i'll probably live longer than her and
she's leaving the charge
um 26 31.
[Music]
each of us has traditional sex roles
don't force us to carry out those
traditional sex roles
we have the same rules set up for men
that they've always lived by that you
need to protect and provide at any cost
but we've changed everything where it
concerns women they now have access to
everything men have always had access to
to education to work to whatever they
want to do
that's my books are not the ones driving
the seminars
and they're not the ones in the coal
mines
you don't hear the national organization
for women complaining that there is just
not enough female ditch figures
it is still men carrying the lion's
share for what it takes to to operate
and maintain this society
and it is still the expectation that if
somebody's going to go down with the
ship it's going to be men
yeah 27 41. no act of fool it's live
ellie ain't nothing in this box you want
to see it
she can smell it ain't nothing go
through it no go throw it away
so she does it yeah
yeah
let the people know you acting a fool
right now
ellie chill out
thank you for the super chats guys
um
it's helping us because we're about to
buy this new studio i'm a little nervous
we'll see hi jess ish and pearl i
watched this documentary in 2017. it
changed my view of the world and my
place with
am i
placing it down with feminism
domestic disputes are a highly fatal
police call someone says
um oh michael holman your upgraded
membership to pre pregame plus hey
yes sir
thank you sir michael holman also 29
dollar super chat alistar horton that's
why men are just
or just just have the popcorn ready
there's more earlier but they didn't all
pull up at the same time
okay press
i want to get one of those too actually
[Music]
my knees getting stiff
my goodness
today's saturday
it is a sad day in it
no we're like two hours in
no we started at 12 or we're two hours
we started like 12 10.
close to 12. what time is it oh it's 1
58. yeah we're almost 2 hours in
chill out we've been here for long in an
hour
22 hours left
i think i'm gonna die around
4am i think that's when i placed myself
i think i think we'll be better this
time because we're starting it now yeah
instead of going throughout a whole day
a show
and then keeping it going
i caught i can't lie you're taking into
consideration that we had good sleep
i mean i had good sleep oh by you paul
so it looks like i'll be up for 24 hours
i mean if you ain't got no room to talk
you're leaving
from yesterday
or am i just tan
you could say you got a little timed
little tanned
little mixture of both you doing well
you didn't burn badly
no i got a little tan this summer
actually i have burned so many times we
love that fish
um
no but i i've still got to do a couple
things so i'll be here
for a while
but you you won't have to be on that
that's true that is true
remember fell asleep on the toilet last
time hey oh did he they no no nobody
knows about that i was like where did
ish go they do now i was like where's
ishgo and i was trying to get the
bathroom and then like he opened sorry i
was like it was locked and then i
knocked and then age comes out he just
looks like a zombie i didn't know that
hey you you don't say that's on the
stream
we got that [__] on camera i could not
mine
are you sitting down
yeah
i was out i said i thought you were
one second i thought you fell asleep
standing up i was like could you imagine
yeah no real good
can you guys see how it's the audio in
the chat i'm just wondering can you hear
it on your end the audio yeah okay now
you guys are good um i'm at like the
actual screen i just was wondering how
clear it is it's decent it's clear
enough for everyone to hear the words
that are being said
it's not
it's not like if i was watching that on
tv i wouldn't be okay with it but like
yeah i think everyone understands that
if they have amazon they can watch it
side by side so yeah i was just
wondering okay we're at 27.41
should be all headed um any men's rights
activists that i would support would
support portions of the women's movement
that is
encouraging women to have more
flexibility in roles
so where do the men's movement and
feminism disagree
well only on the fundamental belief that
the
women's movement says men are the
oppressors that they
are we are involved in a patriarchal
world
in which men
um invented the rules
to benefit men
at the expense of women
don't we live in
28 21.
so essentially
there what he's saying the men's rights
uh
movement
supports
feminists
or the feminist movement and the things
that are
helpful
to
feminists but don't support the things
that are degrading towards
men
yeah i mean i think he's like i think
most male like
men's rights activists are cool with
birth control they're cool with girls
being able to vote
but they're just not cool with the fact
that feminists
think men are oppressing women because
that's not the dynamic
men are doing jobs so we don't have to
even like elon musk who the [__] wants
to run tesla
who the
like it sounds nice
i'll have elon russ
elon musk run it if i get all the
benefits
i'm playing i'm playing typical
you could be baby mama number four
for elon
number four that's he's got he's got
three baby mamas that's a father
shout out to my girl does he really yeah
you didn't know that i i know i knew
what his dad did
he impregnated some girl at his company
and then
i think there's a girl before all this
too maybe
i know what his dad did just like his
daddy
um not just like his dad
do you know the story about no
yo story time story story time people so
the story about elon musk's father
is that
did he is he dating her now or
huh wait who's her
his so
he
married a woman that has a
daughter and she they've been he's been
in her life since she was
young and now i don't know if he's
dating her but he got her pregnant
ah
he's been there for pretty much most of
her life
she's a young one too
what guy
that's a bit wild still it's a bit wild
like here's your
here's your father grandfather
father not father that's that's
different father that's your that's your
father and your grandfather at the same
time i would literally never talk to my
dad again if he ever did that
we've had so many people live with us
over the years we had nannies i'm like
i would i would ha i would never talk to
him again
oh that man is wildin oh someone has a
crush on you man of understanding
he would understand you jess thank you
oh if you ran like a company i got all
the benefits thanks
make it happen um we are at 28 21.
28 21 thank you oh yeah
okay
patriarchy
when most of the world's nations still
have never had a female leader
[Music]
and less than five percent of ceos of
fortune 500 companies are women
you have to look at this in a larger
perspective
patriarchy is the result of gender roles
and not not the vice versa
traditionally women's power and
responsibility has been in the
reproductive sphere while men's power
and responsibility was in the productive
sphere
you know you have to reproduce to
continue the species and you have to
produce to feed people so that they can
reproduce so you know it's like they
work together
that was early breathing
[Music]
and most cultures divvied up roles
because women were responsible for
childbirth they were more likely to
breastfeed
they're not more likely to
they did the breastfeeding they tended
to be involved in the role of raising
children
men tend to be involved in the role of
raising money
or making a killing of the animals or
making a killing in wall street but
those were our obligations
so that's why industry was male
dominated and government was male
because that that was our job and so
what we call patriarchy is men
giving in to the expected roles that
they're supposed to give into and many
of those roles are very harmful working
exceptionally long hours difficult hours
dangerous jobs getting killed on the job
even politics a lot of people described
as masochism
[Music]
imagine what it takes to be a successful
politician
imagine how much of your personal life
that you give up how much you work
how much privacy that you sacrifice how
much freedom in your day-to-day life
that goes out the window there are more
men willing to do those things than
there are women
and you know what's one thing they don't
talk about when they say like throughout
history mostly men like were in power
when you were in power you also could
get killed
yeah you know i literally just thought
about that yeah when you're a president
or a politician you have the biggest
target on your back
i mean how many throughout history most
powerful leaders got murdered at some
point usually by their friends
yeah like like what's his face the dude
that got stabbed like a million times i
can't remember
you you don't talk about it it was a
famous someone in the chat it was a
famous it was like all of his stop
licking my feet ellie
it was like a famous
stabbing it was like all of his friends
like greece or something somewhere
i don't know
let us know chat yeah let us know
ellie
ellie about to get put in the cage girl
[Laughter]
julius caesar
oh
yeah that's who was i've heard that how
bad is ellie's breathing should i should
i put ellie in the away guys should i
put her in the crate
one for yes two for now
we're gonna wait let's flip the chat
let's let the chat decide decide your
fate ellie she can't shut up
yeah that's gonna they can't hear it
properly now
uh we're gonna put her in the hallway
yeah look at the hallway the hallway
cage um
we are at 30 42.
so show us the puppy can you show this
chat could you put her show the puppy on
your camera you want me to pick her up
really
[Music]
you've been you've been asking for
attention now you're running away child
oh she knows she means she's gone she
thinks she's gone
[Music]
ellie come back
[Laughter]
say hi hi folks on the screen
oh
he's like put me down
yeah put her in the hallway just make
sure the gate is closed in case she goes
outside sometimes she likes to lay in
the sun
oh but then the airflow gets bad
[Music]
now that she's gonna start barking
oh the good thing is in the new place we
can put her way further back
if we get it i haven't heard from them
it's probably not a good sign
but dude i think is on vacation yeah so
we'll see we'll see
you take her outside no oh sorry
oh you closed the gate
makes sense
okay
the one for instance writing the laws
in general doesn't mean that the laws
are protecting men
let her out you hear about that director
right although evil is the world from
patriarchy but we're the ones dying
and we die for you guys you know protect
our families our friends
in every society that's there y'all can
watch her if we let her out
have that privilege and protection that
men did not
for example we never hear about how
men were excluded from the forced labor
convention of 1930 for years the forced
labor convention was an international
treaty that banned slavery for servitude
but it made an exception for able-bodied
males ages 18 to 45.
wait what eventually they got rid of
that
but there was still an exemption for
prisoners
and military which is 90
mail
stop pretending that
oppressed and men are your oppressors
it's a lie and it's a hurtful lie
and it's a hateful lie and it's wrong
[Music]
you talk a lot about the red pill in a
voice for men what is the red pill
oh it's sort of a cultural slogan it
comes from the movie the matrix where
the character neo
is given the choice between a red pill
and a blue pill
you take the red pill
you stay in wonderland
and i show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes
and if she
swallows the red pill
the scales
he will see everything that he hasn't
been able to see
and if he takes the blue pill he'll just
go back to sleep
and live in his sort of unaware
semi-comatose state
someone said ellie on strike
sorry
no
okay now i'm glad he explained that
because
i always thought that
i always thought that the red pill
blue pill was associated with the matrix
and everything i was just like maybe
it's something different
but now okay i feel i feel more complete
now that he explained that now i
understand it a little bit
more
okay
and that's that what he explained what
the red pill does to you
it does i haven't i don't think i fully
have swallowed the red pill i think it's
still in my esophagus i think it's just
sitting there but i have a scientific
side effects of the
the red pill someone said historically
during transitions of power
traditionally opposing country men were
executed while women were likely to be
spared
wow that's what they would do they would
kill them out and keep the women
wow
because women are born with value maybe
the old woman they'd probably kill
i think they're like what can they do
look here look here look here you're not
35. that's not
someone said donate to free ellie
five hundred dollars
500 bucks in the chat will free her yep
that's the only price will free her
she's locked up i'm locked up they won't
let me out that's what ellie's singing
right now
32-56 forever and probably be a lot
happier who turned on subscribers only
mode
that is kobe hi kobe hi kobe the blue
pill is the paradigm that most people
live by
men have all the power that they've
always had all the power that domestic
violence is a
problem that's committed by men against
women only that sexual assaults are only
committed by men against women
the women don't make the same money for
the same work as men
teach men not to write only men can stop
right men commit domestic violence
that's the
i hate that argument
well why i hate that argument why don't
you guys just teach men not to great
instead of instead of saying to women to
be careful i'm like yeah go up to go up
to ted bundy say stop murdering let me
know how that works for you no the men
that are going to grape you are going to
do it anyway
you could say i think it's pretty known
in society you shouldn't grape women
yeah i think that's pretty agreed upon
that's how you shouldn't murder people
yeah you're gonna tell criminals to not
commit crime that's what they do they're
criminals
it's like telling women not to want
attention
stop being attention [__] no not look
at it look at it
that's sexist
and so
yeah so 33 31
33 31 for ellie
feed my girl ellie
my dad's calling me
i should
hey dad
why was i funny
i called you at 4 49 in the morning oh
my bad sorry i forgot about the time
change
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm on a stream right now i'm streaming
for 24 hours straight
hello mr davis
what
oh no i wouldn't do that
i i offered on the one with the big
balcony i decided um i because i showed
what
the documentary is in the chat yeah it
was the the reason was the living room
was too small the really nice building
like i just it's caught the rest
of the most important things the living
room and i think i think we'd actually
get to go to a smaller living room it's
called the um red pill documentary it's
in the chat the link is there someone
said you can find it on
amazon for free if you want to watch it
with us we are at 33 35 right now five
does that help you out um watch the
screen tv
but and and um i said we can move in in
a week
so that was the main thing as i said
um the only thing is for the buyout um
you'd have to like here it's kind of
hard to get the two month thing but the
way it works is you pay the realtors to
find somebody and housing is pretty easy
to like
swap does that make sense so you pay
them like
instead of like because they don't have
you can't do it here it's weird you can
move out
like immediately like they don't do the
three i thought it was like you give
them three months from front and you
could go but they don't do that here
like like like because the only way you
can do a buyout is if you can leave like
right now there's some housing law or
something it's
like when they said that i was very
confused
um but yeah so
but the the way it works is you just get
you paid a realtor and it's usually
pretty easy to fill
yeah if i wanted to do that so i wasn't
too pressed about like not having that
so i yeah that's what i looked at
so we'll see i'm supposed to hear back
from them today
okay good watch the stream tv i'm just
going through all your
comments right now seeing if there's any
other ones that we need anybody needs
helps with um
super chat i'll read a super chat
well yeah because it's um
here's some bail money for ellie thank
you
the pot is growing
um ish one of the subscribers said it's
marriage cause it causes divorce
um this week uk announced for the first
time ever since 1845 most babies were
born from unmarried couples and this is
part of a long-term trend any thoughts
this seems like a w for women
or for men sorry w for men
so say that again for me please so
uh this week uk announced for the first
time ever since 1845 most babies were
born from unmarried couples and this is
part of a long-term trend any thoughts
this seems like a w for men
um
yeah but
back in the day wasn't it that people
were having gone is it gone
shotgun marriages
yeah shotgun marriages so was that a
thing here in the uk yeah as well um
[Music]
i don't
i i need clarity but i think my parents
did something like that
and i'm probably not in the sense of
like an actual shot yeah not sure but
like a quick wedding oh yeah like they
did like a register and i only know this
because i've seen pictures
of me at their registrar oh yeah so wait
someone said grape hill here fair use
will cover you playing it on the screen
you just have to have comments or
criticism
yeah that's what someone said in the
chat yeah grey pilled he said that um
you willing to risk it
and the only reason why i'm like worried
about it is purely because it's on a
paid subscription site
someone said you can watch it on youtube
for free oh
what's the link if you can watch it on
youtube for free okay somebody could
switch it oh you say no bs what is the
[Music]
um
what is it link
uh
pissed one or sorry not piss one oh it
is pissed that's how
p155 3d oh wow
it is on youtube for free okay
yeah let's put it on the screen then run
it yeah okay
okay i'm gonna send you the do you have
the link or no it's on youtube for free
folks we're gonna put the
link in the chat
i'm gonna put in the google doc
thank you
uh piss said 24 hour stream let's go
when did it start
when does it end congratulations on the
wonderful achievement of 250 yeah we
didn't even say thank you for 250 yeah
yeah yeah this is huge i my goal for
2022 i had a list of goals for the year
my goal was 1 million on tick tock i had
800k and it was 100 000 subscribers on
youtube crushed it crushed it crushed
the rest of his uh super chat says i've
been catching the shows for a while but
this is my first time being able to
donate live oh thank you thank you we
appreciate that what doc do i put it in
the link um pretty sure pre-show okay
morpheus shows neo the matrix so is the
mate is the red pill the matrix
i don't know if we'll get to asmr this
stream
if y'all were your last stream 24 hours
i know it may it may get to that point
where we got to do some asmr
we got to eat i know
yeah really yes we are gonna go 24 hours
it started oh we didn't i didn't even
ask your questions
should we interview the intern on live
yeah
um we started at 12 like 12 15 12 10
and we're going to go
to 12 10 the next stage um i did the
pre-show doc if you go
um go you're it's the link above you
um under follow me on my other platforms
the second like banksies
do you guys remember banksy's he was a
guest um is it zed for you they're
they're going through hi banksies yes he
said for you
okay he says hi it was a guess he said
he said big ups to jess perlin ish it
was lovely meeting you guys last
saturday
uh that's from
thanks
i work out regularly so right now we're
uh
[Music]
what was the last one you wrote down i
think i accidentally exited it it was
like 33 33 31. yeah that's very good
okay so then we can plug it in
could we just put it up still the way it
is here but we just mute our headphones
until we tell you to stop it yeah okay
um
all right just thanks there's a buzzing
sound though
and it stopped
there's a buzzing sound yeah but it
stopped now
i don't know if it was anything you guys
changed
all right let's go yell at my dog
what videos like red pill videos should
be
okay
sorry guys we had to meet the bikes for
a second i just got through some
technical difficulties
we're back on now
i hope you guys like my macarena
okay
okay so we're at
33 31 okay okay
all right cool others and what they're
doing okay
okay
[Music]
i said someone said hashtag team ellie
if you don't know his name it's ish they
said what's the guy's name oh yeah are
you new here i go by the name of ish
just the producer that's all
i'm just the guy i'm going to get to 31.
we need to stop buying 31. all right
cool um so
um they talk about you oh i thought they
were talking about ellie
i don't know tell me okay you're
readyish
just give me one second
you should watch five hours
against women instead of just stopping
violence
that is feminist training
the mras
say that we live in a blue pill world
where women are victims men are
perpetrators and it's all a lie
and now we're brainwashed to believe
this
and that it's not true and that men are
slaves in this world and
women are
i don't think women are necessarily the
puppet masters but
i think they're saying that women
have the easy way out and
men are
they're given medals and statues and
written in the history books to justify
them
dying and being slaves to work or being
uh
being
used to progress that we live in a blue
technology so what is the people
domestic money for the men's
domestic violence we need to stop buying
sorry guys we are literally just sorting
out the video for you guys and then
we're gonna get started back again
um yeah
so
screen catcher
they call me big l.a
that's probably one of my favorite chats
low-key not low-key
[Music]
three two
one
go yeah
it's against women instead of just
stopping violence
that is
[Music]
say that we live in a blue pill world
where women are victims men are
perpetrators and it's all a lie
and now we're brainwashed to believe
this
and that it's not true and that men are
slaves in this world and
women are
i don't think women are necessarily the
puppet masters but
i think they're saying that women
have the easy way out and
men are
they're given
possibly
um
and now i can talk the knee surgery is
good i don't know what the need bbl
meant when i get it but it's going good
hey pearl you fan of the show i'd like
to know
if jess is single am i single pearl
what are you
you don't know if you're single
why are you asking me
she's a trick question trick question
okay i'm at 34 11 34 11 34 11.
let me get that yes there is it's in the
chat with discord server am i 3411 going
in three
two
[Music]
they're one medals and statues and
written in the history books
to justify them
dying and being slaves to work or being
being
used to progress societies
and i've just i've believed for
so long that
that i'm
at a disadvantage for being a woman and
that i have to work harder than everyone
else and i have more to overcome and i
have more to prove
just because of my gender
but the mris are saying that this is all
a lie and that the guys are actually the
ones that are
disadvantaged and discriminated against
and actually the more i learn from them
the more i think positive position thank
god it wasn't what'd you say
born a guy
and actually the more i learn from him
the more i think
thank god i wasn't born a guy
um because i i don't think that
the the expectations on men
[Music]
is good or healthy i mean they they have
so much pressure to succeed and to be
strong and to stand up and protect
others and to put their lives on the
line
i don't think i would want that
responsibility
but
you know
50 years ago no i wouldn't have wanted
to be a woman
but now i i mean maybe just it's right
now that the tides are changing and and
women are the
have the better deal
well no i don't know
and then sometimes i think the mras are
just
duping me
and
giving such a strong pitch about what
they believe in to
convince me of something that's actually
just
some out there theory that men are
discriminated against and women are have
the advantage
[Music]
so every time we talk just pause it yep
cool go ahead pretty good
all right um
it's great it's like interesting to see
her
verbally process all that she's like
yeah consuming and just digesting from
all of this
because
i was in her shade
and i would sit there i wouldn't
verbally process it but i would
internally process it
and when i tell you there would be days
where i would be exhausted kind of be
like
there's so much i'm like what
what's up
is it echoing again
i saw echo now yeah it should be okay um
no it was it's it's like you see the
world different and you can't see yeah
and i'm like is it my whole life is my
whole life a lie
now
or is it that i was living a lie and i'm
outside of the lie
it's just
it's interesting to see someone else
process the way i was processing and
like having the thoughts like well
is this real is it just trying to like
push an agenda
or this makes sense this doesn't make
sense why was i taught this as a woman
growing up why wasn't i taught this as a
woman growing up why is xyz
abc
so yeah
okay right 36-22
36-22 yes
so i realized okay i need to bring some
feminists into the mix to make sure that
we have that side good for i was
researching rape culture and so that's
how i stumbled across a website called
voiceformen.com so some of the people
that we've already interviewed on the
mra side is paul elam with a voice for
men yeah
are you familiar with them oh i'm
familiar with them i've never met him
yeah
obviously they've they spent a
significant amount of time and energy
denouncing me so i figured
[Music]
heaviest majority yeah hold on just one
second
so i realized okay i need to bring some
feminists into the mix make sure that we
have that side good
i was researching rape culture and so
that's how i stumbled across a website
called voiceformen.com so some of the
people that we've already interviewed on
the mra side is paul elim with a voice
for men yeah
are you familiar with that oh i'm
familiar with them i've never met him
yeah
obviously they've they spent a
significant amount of time and energy
denouncing me so i figured i might as
well have a look at what they say
yeah i really the men's rights movement
is part of the backlash
to backlash to feminism
the men's rights movement really got
going when as women began to make gains
and some men have felt threatened
by the opportunities that have been
opened up to women and i don't know if
it's because uh some of them feel
threatened that they now have to compete
with a lot more people for their jobs
they now can't get into the best schools
if a woman or a girl has better grades
think about it
grandfather's generation probably had it
pretty well right um all of his needs
his shirts were ironed just
all of that was always taken care of
well you know grow up realize the world
has changed
and as much as the
mras would like things to go back to the
way they were
and use the argument that women have an
advantage now
no person looking at the data can
possibly say women have an advantage
we're just beginning to get an even
a level playing field here
uh
it's not tilted in our favor i can tell
you that and they know it they know it
but it's the it's the constant
distortion of the data it's the
spinning of
sorry
it might it might start working
sorry no it says they're saying no mike
yes so there was no mics um because on
streamlabs it was muted okay
is that is it on now yes or no
it's only
okay and it's gonna stay on it's gonna
stay on as we were reacting okay okay um
so we're at thirty nine eleven yeah
okay
um
two thirty nine 11
going in three
a situation to make it look like women
are somehow
getting ahead getting an advantage they
don't deserve
it's uh it's part of the backlash
political organizing comes from a
feeling of victimization
which is why the men's rights movement
makes that claim that men are the
victims of discrimination but it doesn't
have much traction because you know you
look around and it's hard to see it we
don't have movements called you know
straight liberation
you know here's the men the question i
would pose rhetorically is is the men's
rights movement really
the gender version of the white
nationalist movement
of because there are plenty of white
people who say that they are the victims
of reverse discrimination so it's of
course it's not going to have very much
attraction you can't really organize the
people who are super ordinary
do you think that
yeah every time we talk just pause it
yeah yeah okay
um so
do you think that
do you think that it's similar yes or no
do you think do you think white people
can experience racism
no
not based on the
definition of racism
i think that the stuff that
white people face is from
a
hatred
standpoint from what has happened before
and not from a superiority
what's the definition of racism
isn't it just like hating another
another group
i don't actually know
i thought the definition of racism
discrimination or an antagonism by an
individual community or institution
against a person or community based on
the membership of their particular race
or group
or ethnic group
typically one that is a minority or
marginalized
okay so but what if um in south africa
when they were killing white farmers
wouldn't that be racism
i think when it comes to
because like it was based off the color
of their skin yeah so that sense in that
area i think it would be
like it could be racism because there's
a party but if we're yeah they're the
minority but in
america and and i would say here in the
uk the minority is flipped to where
that's where it's flying around yeah so
it's the other way around so
that's why i would say where we're from
and here essentially
what i can't even speak about here
because i don't
entirely know the history between
everything here but in the states
from what oh they're saying they changed
the definition
like it's kind of like when we said
essay you know like i think racism like
it used to just be if you experienced
like discrimination based on the color
of your skin but the woke people wanted
to like change it
where like
um like the same way sexual assault used
to be like you were actually sexually
assaulted
you yeah i'm sorry yeah yeah i know i
got you but sorry i cut you off no no i
was just saying that
i
can't just be like if i got killed by
someone because i was white like how
would you not say that's racism just
because i'm in england
if that happened like it to me that
wouldn't i'm not saying like that
happens left and right but like
you know to say that never happens would
be kind of silly yeah no i'm not saying
it never happens and
the reason why i say what i say is
because i was thinking about it yeah uh
a while not a while back a few weeks
back like why why can't they say they
say why can't black people be racist and
they usually say what i just said
and um
i'm not saying everybody but there are
people who are like i don't like white
people just because i don't like their
skin there's i just don't like them like
yeah and i would consider that
that racist because it's
it's it's complicated because
i
no it's okay it's okay yeah you could
like change your opinion if you think
yeah just like or you stand that way if
if we're not going based off the
oh i have a question
willow and a willow smith right because
she was born with power
can't like so would it switch because
she technically was born with power
i never thought of it like that from or
like jay-z's kids
is a person can a person be from a
marginalized
community and be the minority
i mean the majority because you could
say like how do i put it because would
they are they marginalized if they're
born into that family
stat like economically no
but i don't because even even like
certain groups like nigerian americans
like if you broke it down by that like
they you know like are they marginalized
even though they out earn
so then could not could like based on
that logic could nigerians
be racist to white people but like other
black people like would they have a
different standard because their
that group like stat wise isn't
marginalized
possibly
um
yeah
anxious
it's a lot that you could break down
within that
i don't condone i don't condone racism
or hate
like how that definition would like make
sense yeah because you could do subsets
and like if you break it down even
further it would be different based on
the group yeah i've never i never
thought about it like that because based
on that logic like the nigerian
americans could be racist but like other
black people couldn't
yeah i
i couldn't understand that i never
thought about it like that let me
sit and chew on it for a second okay
but going back to men
i know i think
you know we'll just keep going we'll
keep going three two one
i think that
men are being discriminated against in
any way
not under the law
men are not disadvantaged under our laws
um
or in the
business world as a class men are not
under-represented on corporate boards or
at the top of the fortune 1000 companies
in the corporate world in the in the
business world in a lot of parts of
academia
in the military in the sports world
still pretty much a male-dominated world
and where a lot of the privileges and
power and status accrue to men men are
advantaged over women no question no one
can no one can uh debate that not with a
series
i can debate that
she said that men you're telling me a
hot 18 year old
girl
a nine
it's not privileged
you could tell but she was hot back in
the day
maybe
[Laughter]
anything she looks like she might have
been cute
what
[Music]
100 yeah like back then not now but like
hmm the fact that she said that she
doesn't think that
men are
was there term
disadvantage that's the d where she's
the disadvantage she said no not in our
laws
i think
yeah that's not nuts she said not in our
laws when majority
of men
that are in
that just things happen to get in prison
xyz
are men
and they're homeless yeah suicides
they die in wars
yeah the law helps them out all the time
um
i'm gonna wave at you before i'm gonna
pause i think that'd make it better okay
um
i'm at 40 50. i mean i don't think maybe
you don't have to it's just going to be
a second or two yeah
i'm just gonna wave at you first and
then we're gonna pause okay
i don't think so because it's on the
screen now yeah it's on the screen now
yeah yeah they're pretty good okay
um okay three two
go
not in any seriousness
i was a math major as an undergraduate
and one of the fundamental things about
geometry is the distance from point a to
point b equals the distance from point b
to point a
and if women are so different from men
that men can't understand the female
experience we need to listen to women to
describe it then the male experience is
so different from the female experience
that you can't understand you need to
listen to us you can't really
compare how men and women have suffered
from sexism
that's sex
there's no way to quantify you know that
kind of suffering
so if a woman says well i miss 30
percent of my income
more than you miss
six years of life
there's no way to quantify that
or i've lost a job opportunity because
i'm a woman there's no way to say well
i've suffered more than you because
you've lost a kid because you're a man
you know we can't but it's here it is
serious
and um
and at least if you if if you're denied
a job because you're a woman
i never thought about how
men
like women live longer than men that's
crazy to think i'm saying you're
discriminated against why do we live
longer
if we're really so oppressed isn't the
world harder for us
yeah
man
we have a heart out here pearl
do we
yes
so hard aren't we moving into a
penthouse next week
allegedly maybe if they say yes
allegedly
but that is that's so so interesting
i'm just
like any of the videos you've shown me
i'm just sitting here just
just watching it that's so good about
you is you listen before you like talk
because you're like you you think about
the stuff first
think before you speak i don't want to
sound like a dummy out here in these
streets
i'm gonna gotta sound edumacated
i'm going to read some super chats
duhoul 101 pronounce
i can't read
pronounced duff fool i'm a six foot four
villain guy in australia i want to know
if pearl
is single um yeah
jess is really beautiful and feminine
wow that's the second compliment i've
gotten on being feminine me pulling in
these super chats i'm becoming a woman
i'm a woman
traditionally racism was described as
discriminating against someone due to
their race and ethnicity then the woke
warriors took suit to their political
needs changed the definition of the
power plus privilege that's what i
thought because i was like i feel like
it used to be different
okay because i was thinking like the
irish when they came to the us and they
put irish need not apply were they not
okay
you know what i mean like yeah
the
um
other super chat
how can you how can you differentiate
racism and present prejudice
see that's
that's what
i would like
being
hateful towards a majority i think
that's more so
prejudice
or that's like the definition of
prejudice someone correct me if i'm
wrong and then being hateful towards a
minority group that's racist okay so
what is the majority
because you could you could do the one
percent
they're the minority
that is true you know what i mean like
what is what is the majority is it
because you could say you could say
white people are the majority but if you
break it down by ethnicity then they're
the minority
like jews
they're definitely discriminated against
oh for sure they're white
they're jewish no i'm kidding you're a
musical yeah no i got you it's like
interesting when you like
i don't know so if you
if you hate someone because they make a
lot of money is that considered classism
oh
i mean i think so i think like can you
be racist in classes at the same time to
me to me racism is literally only hating
someone for the color of their skin like
yeah i think anyone can do it to anyone
and i think classism is the same way
like you know one of the most
discriminated groups is middleman
oh yes so that's like that before yeah
so it's like people that
made
it's it's like they're the they're the
people distributing products
and it's like they'll have the same race
of people or ethnicity of people but
when they're in different jobs one's
discriminated against and one isn't so
like bankers
landlords
um
like basically people that don't have a
physical product they're just in between
people hate tax collectors even in the
bible tax collectors
they hated tax collectors
that was jesus don't bring jesus into
this
i think in the bible there was like some
real reason like i think they they
overstepped like their power or
something but like
no i got you i guess yeah
my lord and savior jesus
christ okay three two
go
i mean at least you can go to another
company and apply for a job you know but
you can't when you lose your kid like
you can't say well okay i'll get custody
of that kid
i'll try for that one it's
it's it's a terrible thing that that wow
there was a case
the serpico case
you might be too young to know the movie
surfico with al pacino it's about a new
york city undercover cop he gets shot at
the end of the movie and retires from
the police force and he was a real man
frank serpico a woman after the movie
after this was made
decided she wanted to become a single
mother and tricked him into fathering a
child
and the court accepted that because she
told her friends she was going to trick
him and they testified and the court
said yes you were tricked into it
and still awarded her
over 90 percent of his police pension so
everything that he goes through in this
movie
to you know including getting shot to
earn his his pension she won by sleeping
with him one night
my son is
[Music]
said that she was going to sleep with
him
she got in the in her friend's head yeah
she's a [__] yeah
that's my friend go girl get his pension
what
i would have been if i was shapiro i
would have been in two movies i would
have been in this pro movie and
a time to kill or a time documentary
it would have been both of me i'm like
yeah that was me i got mine why are you
entitled to that just for sleeping with
a dude
essentially she trapped him
and that's glorified but if uh
if um
if it's the other way around
no
no she trap
anyways i'm i'm flabbergasted my brain
isn't that's like we're paying women to
make wrong decisions yeah it's like oh
we're paying women trap him girl
get the bag
go get that bag
i've said that before but i didn't mean
it for real for real
no but that's what i'm saying there's
like phrases in society that we like use
yeah and you don't think about it at the
time but
like because you're kidding or whatever
but yeah
like it's like we're in a gynocentric
social order yeah
look at the bag thank you
i'm at 43.29
there we go i almost said almost at 4
29.
but we are not four minutes
his mom wanted to have children with me
and i had to always refuse you know
saying you have oh my god wait pause it
pause the position
he's leaning in in the picture oh have
you seen the green light yes yeah yeah
he was leaning in he was leaning in
revello or whatever the frick that guy's
name is he's never wrong oh is it rello
revello it's like on twitter and it's
like if the guy's leaning into the girl
she has all the power yeah
never wrong
it's also what i think was spoken about
on the show about
frame
and that i think you said it best or
this is where i heard it from and you
explained that if a man
is like this is a [__] test for a girl
but if a man is insulted by a woman
if he takes offense to it
he's falling into her frame and vice
versa yeah yeah because if you're
you can't let a woman offend you we
don't even we don't even know what we
want 24 7. that's like letting a kid
offend you
i think women are children
because i feel like i'm a child
no to some level like
because i just think we get emotional
and act like kids sometimes like i i
talk about this stuff but i'm not saying
i'm better than other women you know
like i do
like i think men just have the power to
be more like logical in general
we're just so she's a good bathroom
we'll wait on jess believe so i'm gonna
read some of your super chats while
she's waiting or going to the bathroom
uh black people can be racist racism is
about hate not power discrimination is
about power and keeping minorities down
um
then someone else said racism is
attributing to the individual and
characteristics of their ethnic racing
group if that was
as if that was homogeneous genius
homogeneous
check out the self-made man later it is
a woman that goes undercover she works
and dares as a man and complained about
women
um
yeah
ellie's gotta chill
to a tribute to the individuals of a
community based on to a tribute to the
individuals of a community based in that
community on the basis of their racial
identity is called racism
yeah yeah fair enough
jess come back
yay
okay okay okay
um we're at uh 43-37
i'll read this last one and the feminine
mystique in the 60s betty friedman
friedman friedman i don't know friedman
i don't know who that is saw men as
fellow victims of societal pressures
placed on them by their wives who
depended on them for both their
livelihood and identity
oh that's interesting they never frame
it like that
men are the victims of societal
pressures placed on them by their wives
who depend on them for their livelihood
so it's like they have all the pressure
of the whole family depending on them
day
that's a lot of pressure
yeah
okay ready three two one go
children with you until that's dealt
with because she would lose her temper
almost every day and and just use any
weapon she could and like a child's the
perfect weapon so i was really definite
about that
but she also used to proofread my
articles for me
and i wrote an article for playboy about
serpico
and when she read that she told her
friend she's going to trick me into
fathering the child she doesn't need my
permission
and so that's how my son was conceived
then she said if you want to
see your son you have to stay in a
relationship with me but if you break up
with me i know all the things that a
woman can do to a man you know she's
read all my articles she saw my talk
shows said i know all the things a woman
can do to a man and i'll do them to you
so um
that's what i had to deal with like
everything that i had been raising
awareness about for the previous 17
years
then she combined and to one thing for
me to live through it's really ironic
for the first
[Music]
yo
that
that's
disgusting yo
bro
what
wow she's
wow she tricked him into fathering
his and some people would be like as his
kid he's supposed to do that he's
supposed to father his kid
but she she went about it in a malicious
way
like oh i'm gonna so so you can stay in
a relationship with me i'm gonna trick
you into having a kid oh i'm not on the
pill oh i'm not ovulating oh
you won't you won't get me pregnant
shoot up the club i think girls
i think girls do that on purpose
and even okay even that girl on the show
the other day she was like oh my
boyfriend or whatever husband whatever
it was he doesn't want any kids but like
that's not his choice
oh lady that was sitting right here
yeah
and i was like she like slipped up and
said it
i i'm like no no no no no no
okay if it's not his choice have that
kid and don't ask for no money from him
what have you done to me pearl bro no
that's like
because if you pay women to make bad
decisions more of them will do it that
is true so it's like why are we paying
women to make bad decisions like you
know
oh my gosh there was a guy on the show
that spent 25 thousand dollars trying to
get his kids back if you were in a
dude's position oh and you
like he had your kids
and
you just spent 25 000 just to have no
luck
in court would you keep fighting no
like that's why so many dudes just give
up
because they go broke yeah trying to get
their kids and they go broke and they go
to jail if they don't pay child support
like
how how do you expect someone to pay
child support
when they go broke trying to fight for
something that is theirs
and then you ask them to pay more money
and they can't pay it because they were
in this fight for x amount of years
trying to get something that is
rightfully theirs they pay money to not
see their kids exactly
and then you say well since you can't
pay you're going to go to jail since
you're not being a father
i was trying
i was trying and you didn't you didn't
give me a chance
you won a million dollars how much you
want
and and they lose their livelihood like
exactly average 45k a year what is he
gonna do
like and the thing is so jesse you don't
have one jesse williams that fine uh so
far what happened to my baby what
happened and he's so hot he's so he's a
gorgeous
gorgeous he um
he
quick question how old is jesse williams
his first wife he paid like over i think
it was like over 100k in child support a
year or something something stupid but
he wanted to switch careers so he went
from
grey's anatomy and now he wants to do
theater
okay just because that's what he wants
to do but he makes significantly less so
the court was saying he still had to pay
what he made at his old job oh no and
now he only pays her like it's still a
lot like four or five grand a month yeah
but that's it it's literally his whole
paycheck he doesn't care because he's
got millions you know he can do what he
wants but like
why why does he have to pay all of his
paycheck now and that's literally that
was seen as a win like it made news in
the manosphere wow and so it's like
why are we paying women to make bad
decisions
and the crazy thing is the language of
baby mamas sometimes is like oh well i
have to have the kids have to get to
get like these guys want their kids
exactly and they're they'll pay they'll
go broke trying to get their children
but you won't even you you want to be
so controlling and have your kids and
yeah essentially use it as like this
lady was saying as a pawn yeah even even
the girl that was here that one time
she's like i told them go to court why
why does he have to go to court why
can't you just
why can't you just
that's the father of your kids i don't
care if you hate him
the kids the kids ain't got nothing to
do with what's going on and she said and
she was like oh he was abusive but she
said she hit him back
how are you gonna say it is a stupid
does like
if you're not someone that hits people
you just don't
yeah you just don't do that
i understand self-defense but even even
me when i was whale attacked
yeah yeah like i i hit her back if you
was if you were violent pearl you would
knock that girl on her butt
as soon as she started bucking at you if
you were really if you if you were right
girl from chicago chicago oh
you wouldn't what do you mean i'm from
the hood
i'm from the
trenches you said i'm from the hood yeah
the turn from the trenches the trenches
i'm like even now we're in the trenches
of london okay this this is not the end
they say it is but this is not the end
at all
but not a view it
you
yeah look at me read some super chats
i have a physical dictionary printed out
in 2004. the word racism has truly been
altered since then
a belief that some races are superior to
others also discrimination on such
belief
and then in the 70s radical feminism
with the slogan the person is political
made justified female anger at men the
mission maryland french
deposited ordinary men at the
patriarchy's brutal foot soldiers is
maryland french
someone said someone
said congrats on 150k it's 250. 150.
250k
get right it's on the thumbnail
i don't know what kind of person you'd
have to be to literally and
oh deadbeat actually means women
probably beat the man half dead
huh
i'm like because that's the thing i'm
interested i hear about all these
deadbeat dads and i'm like i just don't
think there's that many i think like you
guys aren't letting them see the kids
i i agree with you i think that there's
such a stigma and there
it's been shown on
tv and reality tv so much about oh my
baby daddy don't do this my baby daddy
don't do that that when
a female gets a guy that wants to be
there wants to take care of the kids
they find every little thing to
discredit them when there's nothing
there just to fit that stigma to talk to
their their uh female friends about to
talk to their sisters about like oh he
doesn't do this he doesn't do that just
so they can be like yeah he is no good
he had debbie's daddy
it's like it's like you get social clout
for being a victim
why
okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna play
three
go
oh my knee
five to seven seven years i guess we
would see each other four times a day
for exchanges
on average every single day i had to
deal with some scene a scene meaning she
would just not show up you know and or
she would hold the kid out and then pull
him back and hold him out and pull him
and just kind of play with me or she'd
let me have the kid then she'd stand in
front of the car so i couldn't move you
stay in mommy town tomorrow in this day
mommy town for a couple of days
two days and then you come back to daddy
though another time i saw her hold him
by the shoulders and say daddy is a bad
man and he is a very bad man
that's look at that
that's um i think it is so selfish to
trash talk your kid's father like
publicly or privately you don't talk
like
i just think that is like the most
classic classless thing to do i don't
care if you hate that person you made a
kid with them
you and i think it's the same way with
men like you shouldn't trash like when
they're older you can have a
conversation with them you know but like
so many kids grow up with their mom
trashing the dad for years
years and they don't even know the real
story yeah that happened with like one
of my like her mom was crazy like
absolutely nuts and she would and her
dad was always on deployment oh okay so
he was gone so she could just say feed
whatever she wanted
and like and i could tell like growing
up i remember like i could tell her mom
was a nut and i remember when we hit
like 13 14 she was like yeah my mom's
crazy because the kids figure it out
eventually wow you can you can trick a
kid for for a little bit but at some
point even kanye
he loved his mom but he figured out that
she wasn't
she wasn't letting his dad see him
i don't know the kids i hear that about
that yeah they can't the kids they
figure it out at some point they're not
stupid
it makes a difference
and i wonder i wonder
what would kanye be
if
his dad was more in his life or if he
was allowed to be more in his life and i
wondered that about just people that are
close to me what would
where would their life be
if
stories weren't told to the kids about
their fathers if certain events would
have happened to where the kids were
separated from their fathers like what
would their
life be would it be the same would it be
different would be better like how would
it be
it's crazy and then they get all this
anger
and that's the thing like when i when i
talk to girls on the street i can tell
when they don't have a dad
because they're just so angry at men and
i'm like who taught you to be this angry
is probably their mom
that is don't don't trust a man he's
gonna leave you high and dry how many
girls have we had on the show that said
that you can't trust a man because this
happened to my mom
i was watching this a
youtube series uh called i think it's
called tough love
and the girl her boyfriend was like yeah
i i'm going to still be attracted to
these um
these women
but i love you and they're talking about
having a polyamorous relationship so she
calls her mom
and she's like oh why are you sounding
down like how are you and so and so and
she's like i'm okay
um she's like oh is he cheating
and she was like no like we're not gonna
talk about that mom she was like uh-uh
leave him she said i'm 30-something i'm
happy and you don't need no man she said
you know all these men out here do
nothing but cheat just like your daddy
did
don't be like me
you can do everything on your own be
independent and happy and i was like
ma'am you don't sound like it
when i i listened to that i said this is
what
it is this is like so in your face they
make their kids have the same problems
they have yeah
yeah yeah there's one thing like you can
like auntie she made every mistake that
like she said like she made every
mistake she could have made but she
didn't come back and say it's all men's
fault
she said that the dude the dad wasn't in
the picture but she didn't hate men for
it yeah
like you you picked him
you picked him so yeah
like it's your own fault
and
when you pick the things you do you
gotta suffer the consequences yeah and
that's the thing that's like women want
to pick the guys they pick and have no
consequence i'm not i'm not even hating
for on girls for going after guys that
are cheaters like i get it it's
pre-selection like we've always done
that why would i expect you to be
different than we've always been in all
of human history yeah like
that'd be stupid
but don't don't cry to me
you know cry to your close girlfriends
but don't come on the internet and say
how men are trash and you can't trust
men yeah you can't trust yourself to
pick good men
and that's something i feel like women
don't
even
think about
that's something i've had to think about
like
how's my selection okay let's not
all right let's keep watching the video
three two go
and the decisions that they would make
you would just go wow
there couldn't be any explanation you
know either they're absolute idiots or
it's biased there's just no other
explanation for it
one other thing his mom is obese and
wanted him to be obese for
various reasons
one thing is so he would identify more
with her side of the family than mine
position
you pause it
why why why
explain to me
why you would put your kid
in
a deficit in life for them to struggle
just to identify because you hate the
man you had a child with and you're
going to punish the child by making him
obese and letting him have
umpteen health implications and causing
his life to be shorter just because you
you
bro modern women are about me me me like
i swear to god girls from the 1950s
would think we were so weak
yeah
like that's
that's heartbreaking and you you trapped
him
you trapped him you trapped him you you
made the decision i'mma trap him just so
you can stay in a relationship with me
and now you're going to punish the child
because you do not like him if you don't
like him why why give him custody
exactly if you don't if you don't want a
child if you just want to take
get something else make a dog fat
not animal cruelty or anything i love i
love me some doggies love you ali
but that
yo that's so heartbreaking because i
don't know how this kid grew up where
he's at now what he's doing but to know
that a mother
your your best interest should be the
child once you once you have that child
even before you have the child once you
are pregnant and once you are carrying
that child your best interest is not you
anymore it is your child and once you
have that child you go out the window so
to know that a mother is
purposely
essentially killing her child slowly
just so
he can be furthest away from having any
resemblance of his father or any
connection to his father is disgusting
this is why you got to leave the whales
this is why i look at it no here hear me
out okay
if you if you marry a whale you're
suffering your kid to child abuse
i i think getting your kid fat that's
child abuse you 100 control of what your
child eats if you have an obese child
you are abusing that child
who she's the one giving him the food
child abuse you can't you can't marry a
whale because she's gonna abuse your
kids and it's suicide
now slowly she's slowly committing
suicide what if she was healthy there's
no such thing as a fat healthy no no no
no no i'm not saying that what if she
say
we okay
we're where we are now and when we do
get pregnant far in the future we're
married and when we're in situations
yeah to
take care of these children we we uh get
pregnant and we gain
we gain some weight and we
we don't become a beluga whale but we
become a mini whale like a mini whale
i mean if if i become a mini whale put
my ass on the treadmill i just hope to
god i swear to god you would want your
husband to be like yeah
wait you want a guy that's going to put
up with you being fat oh no no no i i
wouldn't put up with
hope my husband would threaten to leave
me if i get fat because i'm the most
driven person i know if i know you're
about to leave
about to become a marathon yeah yeah
that's what i did last time i got fat i
got i run a marathon did you really
that's what i did i hit i hit like 205
210 and i was like oh no oh no yeah i
ran a marathon i lost the weight in six
months wow that was so bad
determination
bruh
i mean look i've never had kids i'm sure
you gain weight i'm sure your body
doesn't look the same but i'm saying
like if you're wailing it out you know
when you're a whale
you're there's a difference you know a
little little pudge and a whale
300 pounds no excuse
none high 500 you can't you can't blame
that on you can't 250 you can't blame
that
i'm sorry you cannot blame that on your
kid you can't
yeah
look at pictures from the 1915 1920s the
moms were hot then they bounced back in
like six months and they're back in
business that is true
they also had crack back then so
i'm kidding
what does crack got to do with this jess
it helps you lose weight quick crack
yeah
you think all the moms were on crack
then
maybe not like super addictive but maybe
a little maybe a little here on that a
little bit a little bit
you can turn on the ac unit
if you want
is the door still open okay
it's just in here dying it's just
are you hot bro yeah
i'm kind of hungry you want food
yeah let's get some food go in the go in
what do you want off of deliveroo
oh okay i was actually about to thought
you're about to open it
thank you pearl and jess for your
consistency and effort positivity and
masculinity love to my gr two girls
thank you for everything you do you're
two girls you're welcome
hi we got a girl in the chat we never
get females there's one girl that is
subscribed her name is jessica
yes this is
i'm sorry i'm gonna butcher your name
it's okay guys if i butcher your names
it's not personal i butcher like regular
words often
so
your names are just part of the words
that i butcher hi jess and pearl it's
from oh yinda
oyinda
olenda okay hi justin pearl
linda i appreciate you both keep up the
wonderful work yay
now you understand why i said women are
too risky chad foreign wives can't do
this to you it's socially taboo and they
would be punished
that's true
let's keep going uh wait wait three
ish
three two two one go
hopefully fan
another was uh so that he would enjoy
being with her more because when he was
at my house he had to
get activity you know and eat
well-balanced meals and
brownie sounds
and so where would you if you're a
little kid you know where would you
enjoy being more
but he
self-reported to the mediator how upset
he was about being obese
that the worst thing in school was when
kids called him fatty and how he cried
and his physician
said that he's really concerned
medically and then when i did he was at
an age where he would um imitate things
that i would do you know i gave him a
broken shirt man like in vegas back in
the day
and what i did was i started weighing
myself every morning and and writing
down my weight the day and the weight
and i taught him how to scale so he kept
his own records
so i had six months worth of statistics
to show consistently that every time i
was with his mom for a few days he'd
come back weighing three or four pounds
more and then he'd lose it while he was
with me
so they had you should no longer be
allowed to wear that
yo
i'm over it
so
um ish wasn't in here also one second so
the um the guy was telling was talking
about how he taught his son how to read
the skill because the son was getting
upset that the kids were calling him fat
at school because when he was at his
mom's all they would do is eat brownies
and stay up late and then at his dad he
was more active xyz so he taught his son
how to read a scale and then he would
track it the son started tracking his
weight at his um dad's house and then he
would track his weight at his mom's
house and they saw the court saw that
every time he was at his mom's house he
would gain like three four pounds and
every time he was at his dad's house he
would lose the weight and so the court
ordered
that the father should not be able to
weigh their sons
anymore yeah
no way
yes that was the court's order that the
father should not weigh
their sons anymore
that's shocking
that's unreal that's
disgusting
i'm over it
over it
that would never happen to a woman that
would never happen to a woman oh no if
it was the other way around they'd be
like
give it to the mom give the child to the
mom
can you turn the video volume up a
little bit there's fans a little
video
i think if you just go to in stream labs
if you look at where the video thing is
you can turn up the volume
turn it up turn up
watch whole video
turning up turn it up we're gonna play
it in three
two one wait no
wait just give me one second i was
turning up the volume
yahweh ready to go in three
two
one
problem solved
after 14 years my body gave out i got
sicker than i've ever been i realized
i'm
going to die that's not going to do
anybody good i've got to give up the
[__] so i gave up custody so i i don't
see my son anymore he hasn't been in my
house since
um
and that's feminism
that is the saddest thing i've ever
heard that is and i bet she says your
dad's not in your life he's a deadbeat
i mean she said the stuff she said
before that like your dad's a bad man
your dad's a dangerous man
and it's like does that guy seem
dangerous to you
i'd like that guy wouldn't hurt a fly no
that's that's what that's what women do
to weak men
that they perceive as weak oh he was
leaning in
[Laughter]
that's so sad
and i like
mentally
what does not only for the kid but what
does that do to
the man
like to not to want
to be able to see
his son his offspring especially i'm not
saying there's any differentiate in a
different from a boy and a girl but
essentially the boy carries the
the
men's last name until
they don't anymore and so it's like
why
that's just so mentally like just
destroying to not to want something to
want to see
your child and
like literally nothing in this world
could
could change that nothing now can kids
when they get
older
do they have
the right to like want to go out and
find their father find their uh yeah and
that's what happens a lot like there was
a tic tac where the woman was like
tell your mom that you're going to have
a conversation with your dad about what
happened when you were a kid and see how
she reacts if she doesn't want you to
have the conversation she did something
day
because dudes like honestly i think
dudes own up to their mistakes more than
women do because you'll you'll hear guys
say about their ex breakups yeah i
treated her bad yeah like like guys will
say that women won't say that they'll
always say oh no he cheated on me he did
this this this and this
like i think guys own up to their
mistakes more than women do yeah but if
you're not letting dude see like him see
your kids what's your issue
like that's dang
oh my god okay three
two one go
just like a dream
[Music]
14 years fred claims that during his
14-year custody battle
he spent the equivalent of five years of
his gross income on legal fees mediators
and child support payments
i was really in his life a lot longer
than most fathers would have been
it's something most fathers can't afford
what time you uh 14
48 23 where are you at
i was at 14 or 17. oh wait keep keep
playing it played it for a little bit
[Music]
14 years
so beautiful
me
oh my god that makes me think of alfalfa
but
years
in a custody battle
bruh and five years of his gross income
on
nonsense
and he
wanted
that's the thing
he
wanted
to see his
son
and it's legal that's a crazy thing like
women are rewarded for bad behavior
i i think there should be
there should be a law if the woman is
physically
keeping their the child from
i'm doing your hand motions
it adds to the effect it adds to the
effects i think if women
are physically keeping their
child from the father and the father
wants
to
see the child wants to be in the
childhood there should be some
repercussions for the mother like why
jail time
literally if you want to put your kid at
every statistical disadvantage go to
jail
for your selfish reasons that's child
abuse go to jail
i literally think it is child abuse if
you are keeping your kids away from
their father for no reason but you don't
like the dad
if you're not being if you're not if
there's no abuse
if he's stable he's on drugs or nothing
yeah you should go to jail because that
is child abuse
you are letting your kid think their dad
doesn't want them that is the most
selfish thing i've ever heard in my life
and it's legal
and they reward when not only not only
is it legal they pay women to do it
that's the crazy thing
yeah that's
it's sad and to see something like this
so i think about
my my brother and my nephew and like if
uh my nephew's mother was like that
i
i'd probably
be on
uh the time document the uh
crime documents i would be on there
oh
me and my little brother
we would both be in there they'd be
doing a documentary because it's just
like why
why
uh
yeah
this one hits home
women
yay
[Music]
81.6 of custodial parents are women
18 are men
that was 10 years ago
let's see what let's see what it is
today i wonder if it's different
people don't do the census in the states
do you guys have census out here yeah oh
it's a worldwide thing
oh we have a census here it's a yearly
thing oh i thought since i didn't know
if it was the same thing this is the
yearly thing that they yeah
have you done your senses have you done
your senses exactly i don't know i could
be wrong about yearly but it's
16 in 1994 17 in 2014 20 in 2018. it's
only 20 every four years every election
year yeah they do it
wow that's insane
yeah i play it
three
two
one
literally know that fathers don't get as
good a deal in family court and we don't
really complain about it until it
happens to us and even then a lot of men
don't many men's rights activists come
into being men's rights activists as a
result of getting a divorce wanting to
be equally involved with the children
and realizing that women have the right
to children and men have to fight for
children
when your family courts run on the
supposition
that mothers are more fit
to be custodial parents
and
that fathers are more fit to provide a
check
every month
and to become
what we like to call uncle daddy where
they visit
visit their children
to me that's one of the greatest
obscenities in the world the idea of
visiting your own children where you get
to see them for two hours on wednesday
night and you get to have them for x
amount of hours every other weekend
and you have no say in how they're
brought up
so
why
why is it so
frowned upon
for
a woman to
like essentially have an income and be a
provider
not the sole provider but be a provider
as well to take some of that
pressure
off of a man
to
we're we're depending on you for your
income we're depending on you solely to
provide for this family
most women won't do it but is it i don't
think it's looked down upon most women i
think it's actually like women
empowerment it's like people are excited
when girls do it they're always like you
know how many ceos there are if it's a
woman ceo of a fortune 500 company i
guarantee she gets more attention
celebrated yeah celebrated where men
it's just like a
like i just women don't want to do it
i don't do you want
oh my god guys
i already have more people working here
than i like no fats
you guys nonsense it's just like i don't
i don't really enjoy hat like i i prefer
like but i'm like if i had 20 people
oh kill me kill me
20 people to like worry about like oh
god no like girls don't want to do that
[__]
they think they do they want to be boss
babes until they do it they're like [__]
this
you know law firms
in um canada jordan peterson talks about
this couldn't pay women to stay
they'd hit like 35 the girls were like
you can't pay me to be here anymore
because time's running out
and i've spent my most of my life in
this in this firm
wow
that's interesting
do you think
it's just a question for you
do you think that
if
say you were earning
top dollar yep
in that bracket saying you don't hear
hey hey
my income is
non-disclosed
i didn't sign the nda yet but
we're not disclosing things
just party things podcast
um
so
say that and then there was a woman she
came along yeah
she earned she had us
wow goodness
substantial
that
was
she has us
good you good yeah that stuttering was
jessie's
she'll be back in a second
okay
you met a woman that had a
substantial
living look here chad don't fire on me
that's upstairs
they're gonna and
she
she saw you as like okay you're a
provider i give that to you not down in
your manhood at all but i want to
relieve some of that pressure
off of you we can
essentially use the income that i have
and the income you have to be able to
provide for our family do you think that
would be
degrading on a man like oh you don't
think i can provide all
i can provide for the whole family that
i need your help do you think it would
be like a okay cool that's some of the
pressure off of me to solely have to
provide for the family and no matter
what circumstance
um i think your scenario is a perfect
world
scenario where
the woman is understanding or her role
she understands where she's at and i'm
not saying there aren't women out there
there i'm pretty sure there are women
that want to be submissive and it's all
dependent on how she views the man if
she's willing to give up that asset that
she's kind of created in herself
which
in some cases wouldn't be seen as the
most feminine thing to do
um
then
all props to her um
i see in most dynamics
it doesn't work
exactly like that because
you'll find that
if she's earning money and she's having
to put forth money she wouldn't she
wouldn't want you to decide what to
shoot what happens with it exactly yeah
and therefore what will then happen is
through time
decisions will be
made
without her
without her stamp of approval it's going
to be your stamp of approval as a guy
and
resentment will grow that's and that's
my theory behind it and also from what
i've seen
um and
it will end up in a divorce
in the latter stages of the marriage
that's interesting though i think
sometimes guys are paid less for harder
jobs
that is true but that's because most men
don't know how to they don't understand
the value yeah
well here at you want chipotle
oh yeah i want some people
coming through
but do you think that
if a woman did approach a man like that
and didn't didn't care about
stipulations and
didn't care that's just not the rule so
like kevin samuels would talk about
like the cio of like pepsi or some big
company comes home and submits to her
husband like oh you know who's a good
example that judge that supreme court
justice with the kids you know i'm
talking about i guarantee she goes home
and submits to her husband even though
how how the [__] are you more successful
than being a supreme court justice
you like i guarantee that lady goes home
and submits to her husband
i can understand that you guys were
ordering chipotle yeah but not
not saying that the woman earns more
than the man but she earns enough to be
able to
essentially set enough aside for her to
be able to do what
she wants and then
help out set another chunk aside for
aside for
to help out with um
with providing for the family so it's
not solely dependent on
the man
you have to put beans in and bryce that
was
i'm gonna go to the bathroom okay go
ahead
oh my god
because i
i would think that a man
would
would like that
to take off some pressure
i don't
i don't know i'm still trying to
understand i'm still trying to
understand the female species
would chat would you
would you essentially
like that for if a woman's earning x
amount of money and you are
the breadwinner of
the family if she came along she was
like you know what to take some pressure
off for you
i will
insert x amount to help out so where you
don't have all the pressure
of providing for the family no matter
what the circumstances
i think one thing i will add to what you
said is
in an ideal world
i wouldn't want that however
in the position that i'm in
where i'm not
earning the capability
of what i wish i could be in order to
provide for my family
like as a sole provider i would happily
concede to the idea like i understand
that
at this moment in time
i'm not
where i'd like to be and there's no
guarantee that i may ever get there so
concessions would be made
within the relationship dynamic to
understand all right this is where we
are at
i'm not making
for example 100k
a year so i can't provide the lifestyle
that i wish i could
give
so
if
the my partner
is
understanding and would like to
contribute to our lifestyle
then
more than happy to
say yeah let's let's do that let's build
something together if that's what it is
also
you know what i'm tempted to do
take everything off the walls
i thought about that but then
you would have to get white paint
if you if you plan on doing shows next
week if we get the call today
and we do shows next
have to reload we week could be here
till october yeah
okay i can i can understand that ish
um
assuming i saw some people in the chat
saying like oh if she was still
submissive assuming that she'll still be
submissive it'll be a perfect ideal
woman
[Music]
who me
you're the only man in here
never never um
no
do you know what it is
god forbid but yeah um but that's not
even the real issue i have an issue of i
can't sit still and do nothing
i need to have purpose i need to have
something i'm doing working towards
something and for me
the idea of being a stay-at-home husband
i i i'd see no purpose in what i'm doing
and i i get you could say oh there's
purpose in it like you could re-raising
your kid
but
it
a repetitive motion of the same daily
antics
yeah i i couldn't do it
yeah
i love kids yeah no no i love kids um i
before i started doing this i was a
coach
yeah i've coached all age groups um
basketball coach so
now i i go i do i'd love to have kids
one day um
i'm very interactive so
yeah but i just wouldn't
do you want drinks
um
it doesn't matter
i don't know i the reason why i didn't
order it because i don't know if you
guys wanted drinks or not yeah
i mean i'm just drinking water but yeah
if you want something you want you can
get it
have you had this lemonade before
i think you have i've got it there
you want one
is that alcoholic no
who's sure this is rose
it says rose
do you want what do you want to drink
ish
what do you do
what do i want to drink
i know um
if we can just get some ice from co-op
and then get some water
i'll be happy with that yeah
actually
what do you think
are we doing the intermission right now
yeah we can do an intermission yeah in a
mission or we could do when the food
gets here actually yeah yeah why don't
we keep going to all the food well we'll
order the food and then keep going until
the food gets here
cool this couch is like hotter yeah
it's the blinds
it's all sunny outside
you said it's not it's not sunny you
don't know what i was thinking
if you open the blinds you probably go i
was wondering could we
sit where you are can we flip the camera
and move the mics i almost feel like
it'd be hotter and we could all react
together off of that camera okay can we
walk is that possible
should we do it when the food gets here
yeah let's do it let's keep it because
then we could keep it on the screen too
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah and
then we could just all react to it and
then we wouldn't have to do the double
well how are we going to get these
chords over there yep the chords well
what we could do
how can we have chords over there
because you usually take the mic
yeah yeah well i was
so if we use your calls from over there
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah because i'm sorry
i'm not taking oh no no no you don't you
don't have to do that
um no well i i was thinking what do you
think so so you could just put it plug
it in and it'd be fine
i i i can take chords from over there
and plug it in and it'll be fine okay
yes and then we could what i can't do is
take chords from
and then we could get like a headphone
splitter on on that screen
like how you used because you have
i think
headphones bro okay i have one headphone
splitter here
and then you plug the other headphone
spinner out there and then it's three
do we have two headphone splitters yeah
we have that circle headphone splitter
too there's one over there you know
where it's at i don't
okay let's let's keep going until the
food gets did you order it
you click order
i don't know i've seen if you just
there's anything double checking yeah
yeah um how many sides i want um what um
number
i'm at 49.39
39.
girls trips girls night outs for women
that's an interesting question
someone said what are your thoughts on
girls trips slash girls night out for
women that have been married for 15
years
oh
um not too see okay
i know a lot of girls that don't do [__]
but i also know a lot of girls that do
do [__] i think on a balance of
probabilities you probably wouldn't want
your girl to do it but like
i put money that my mom's never like
cheated on my dad
and
like i mean she didn't run like girls
girls trips like that but like there's
probably things in the
that they'd be like oh no she's like
because she would go on like business
trips okay yeah yeah so it's like
i don't know
i feel like there's some girls that do
some girls that don't yeah i think it's
gone no go ahead i was gonna say i think
it's dependent on the friend group
oh yeah
the friend group depends like so if
you're going with
auntie mary
who
is
in church like she does her thing like
and i'm not saying like forget the
stigma that we have or most people have
uh but like
the certain type of group
won't allow for such behaviors to even
be condoned whereas does a friend group
shame her exactly would you shame me if
i was cheating
[Music]
shame you
would you like
yeah yeah would you be like what are you
doing
yeah if you
if i had like a good guy i was dating
yeah yeah yeah i'd be like reenact it
have the conversation right now yeah how
would it go okay
all right
just because i know how mine would go
i'll do it okay okay okay okay
jess you will not believe what happened
last night what what happened
um okay so do you know the bar pub 47
yeah so okay i went there
and i met this guy that looked just like
freaking michael b jordan like he was so
fine okay first of all
you went to this position
okay okay okay i met this guy
at pub47 that looked just like michael b
jordan i swear to god
okay if so yeah you went to a pub yeah
by yourself
um
could i go with oh i went with i went
with my friend theresa
okay
instantly teresa's a bad friend yeah
okay um
so you met this guy i could go yeah yeah
i'll keep going before i ask more
questions yeah and
okay i went i went home with him
because he and i know i know it's bad
because
are you in
[Laughter]
are you in um
tyrone still dating
interesting name choice hey that was
better than the other ones i was going
to choose
okay
i don't get it
look at me yeah we're still
yeah okay yeah i mean technically we're
still together
what do you mean technically
like if you had to put words into it
okay pearl so are you are you with him
or not like did you guys break up no no
we're still together it's just i mean
i just feel like he doesn't need to know
like because it was a one-sided thing i
just how was i supposed to know what a
michael b jordan look like
no
so
do it like
you you always talk to me about tyrone
about how he's a great guy he is he's
got xyz like
just
what you always dreamed of blah blah
blah
why would you go and
sleep
with someone i don't care if it was for
one night i don't care if it was for two
seconds why did you go
potentially mess something up that
you've wanted for so long
you're making me feel guilty i didn't
even do anything
um well it was
i just i don't think he'll ever find out
what he doesn't notice what if he does
not
so okay so you're telling me
if he went out and did the same thing
and he he was sitting right here having
the same conversation with me he's like
oh what what doesn't hurt her doesn't
get what she doesn't know won't hurt her
i'm just supposed to be like oh yeah
what's that go ahead
i mean i think if you loved love someone
you can lie to them
yo
all right bet so hey no you you didn't
do a dang thing wrong pearl
you did everything and you go girl get
that michael v jordan look alive
hopefully one day you'll actually get
the real one
yes
how did she do how'd she do she
she did one so she went to being
sarcastic and i i i i understand the
point i get it so i get it okay okay
let's sit down let's let's go see the
chat
what's chat saying chat how did jess do
talk to us yeah how did jess do let us
know
um
oh my god i totally forgot they're
acting out a possible scenario
someone's gonna clip that take out
context
who's tyrone okay
just pray thing cheats on tyrone
could you imagine
yo that people are gonna be searching
who was just playing things with they
said eight out of ten oh thanks
that's big
that's pretty good it's chad's fault
pearl got tricked
okay ish your turn okay okay talk to
me ash
sorry i'm an actress so
thanks
oh my god yes you will not believe what
happened last night like you will what
happened oh my god you will oh
okay so i want that that bar have you
heard of pub 47 yeah down the street
like i've been there yeah it's it's
popping you know what i mean and you
know how okay
i
you know i have a crush i'm michael b
jordan you know that's my celebrity
crush yeah you don't stop talking about
him yeah like i mean how can i not it's
michael yeah anyways i'm like leave
leave um what's her face steve harvey's
daughter for me please
yeah lord lori yeah shout out to laurie
okay okay so so um there's this guy that
walked in that looked exactly like him
elsewhere yeah like i i swear i went up
to him and i was like okay
are you i was i i literally asked him
i'm like are you michael b jordan like
is this he said no
oh okay i could imagine he said no my
name is mike yeah all right and i was
like okay hi i'm pearl and um
i i got
i know i don't drink right but i'm sorry
i'm just gonna cut you off here um
where's this where's the story going
like yeah let me finish the story
have you done something
i mean what are you doing he looks like
michael b jordan okay he looks like mike
will be door i was drunk i was drunk
yeah wait have you yeah i was driving i
started drinking again yeah
i mean just that time because okay i
mean if michael b jordan's there you're
going to have a couple shots you know
so i mean if
if i'm drunk does it mean if i punch
someone it didn't really happen
i mean does it take away the question
okay no no i
you know i didn't say it didn't happen i
just said yeah you asked what happened
so something happened
you could say that okay
have you told tyrone
um
i feel
uh like
i feel like tyrone needs to know
no does he now here's the thing
who'd you go with
who what do you mean who are you with
what is harrah on technically i don't
know who did you go with to the bar
sorry i went with theresa theresa so you
don't think theresa is about a
blabbermouth
and he'll tell someone i'll have a
conversation yeah but she's not she's
not really in tyrone's friend group like
that
like she doesn't she doesn't so would
you rather have it that tyrone heard it
from another person
or do you not care
i'd just rather take the risk of him
finding it like i'd rather you know not
tell him and hope he doesn't find out so
what i'm getting from this is you don't
respect him enough
to let him know that you messed up
um
well i think he'd leave so i don't i
don't wanna yeah okay
okay and you think you can keep this
under wraps
yeah i think it's like i mean it was
only theresa there like
you know like i'm probably never going
to see him again so how would he really
like who theresa could tell like you
know people at
you know the school but like tyron's not
friends with people at the school that's
fair so how would he find out
well um all i could say is good luck to
you um i don't really condone your
behavior uh i feel like you've moved a
bit mad
uh but
there's not much i can do here because
i'm not
here to die yeah you want to keep
working here you know what i'm saying
you pay me
you want to go tell tyrone do the right
thing
do i want to tell tyrone to do the right
thing doing the right thing is keeping
my job
how do you do in the chat how are you
doing the chat
let me know people let me know
tyrone homies with he telling tyrone
yo tyron the homie yo he's struggling
worse than jess yo
who's who's who's better is sure jess
who's who's better jessica get a dub
there look at
l ish 4.5 terrible shoes
i feel like i feel like you got to stop
smiling yeah i feel like in order to
really like like
because there's a difference between
saying like that's kind of [__] up or
like that is the most [__] up thing
i've ever heard like i don't know you're
dating him why would you do that i can't
lie to you i've been around a bunch of
savages so
do you think they're saying jazz because
she's a girl or do you think you're
doing so wait do you think they're
saying just because they're simping
what are you implying it i i didn't
apply anything i asked the question
i asked the question i said jessica
did you know that men's testosterone
lowers after the first child order in
order to be more empathetic to the
child's needs during pregnancy men's
oxytocin and dopamine mimics the wives
to bond to them closer oh that's so
interesting
so men do have a
bonding yeah i mean oh yeah do one yeah
100 just
savages and i don't
um
okay what who did the chat give it to
jess or me me yeah of course
issue too nice bro
hey hey hey
like i said i like working here
okay um
but i'll take the criticism someone said
my telltale sign siren i'm lying it's
when i say um i'm like i say i'm a lot
does that mean you lying a lot that i
just said um
then i just said um to turn this on and
i was like am i lying about turning on
the laptop
i say um when i'm trying to think of
something to say
the last word
okay
it's a fun exercise
oh okay
um do
do 49.39
49 that's where i'm at okay up amazing
wait wait let me put on my headphones oh
come in just put on your headphones
all right all right all right
three two
wait wait three two one go
you know i can't tell you how many
men have been in this office in that
chair
uh
in tears because they can't see their
kids
and some of this stuff ends up in
horrific consequences
like this gentleman here that's his
little son
they found him dead
not the son but the young man
in the desert with a bullet in his head
the day before the family court
where it became known
that he was going to get to see his
little guy even less
and of course he'd been falsely accused
one time after another after another
uh it had destroyed his life he had
bankrupt him driven him into debt it
caused him to miss work he was about
ready to lose his job he was in his rope
so he just decided to end it
the unfairness in
in in the family courts the unfairness
in the way child support is so often
structured it's commonplace and it's
everywhere and the more you start to
become conscious of it the more you
realize that it's there
i started to research some father's
rights issues
and came across some harrowing stories
like this man in south carolina who
found out his only daughter was adopted
away by the mother without his knowledge
or consent his daughter was with an
adoptive family in california so he
began his fight to get his daughter back
adoption is for children without
families not children with a willing and
capable family
and this man in colorado who lost his
daughter when the mother left the state
to give birth in utah where he wouldn't
have legal rights to his child
he fought for four years in court and
finally won visitation rights
only visitation
i can't explain the emotion to happiness
there's this hard fight and this
what this means to me and then there's
this heartbreaking story
the 20 year old father never left her
side until he was forced to give her to
adoptive parents this week after
kaylee's mother decided to put her up
for adoption in order to keep kaley
colby needed to file paternity action an
affidavit and a commencement notice with
utah's vital records a day before the
mother signed the adoption papers
relinquishing her rights but in colby's
case the mother only gave him a few
hours notice of what she was going to do
i would like her back
men in the men's movement are not upset
about having to be fathers
oh
my god
that that is the saddest thing so sad
and he has he has to do all of that
before she signs the papers and it's
like what if the
of the mother doesn't like she did a few
moments and it's like dang i had to do
all that before she signed the papers
what the like
that it doesn't give them any shot and
to
give a child up for adoption
when the father
wants it it's like if if you don't want
the child you don't have to have it you
don't have to give it to another family
give it to the person that
helped you make that child give it to
them to take care of it if you want to
opt out of being a mother give it to the
father that actually wants to be a
parent like the real the real issue is
women not letting men see their children
yeah it's not deadbeat dads that's not
the real issue and it's interesting
because even growing up i honestly
thought that was an epidemic
of
dads not wanting to be in their kids
lives and deadbeat dads but i
the older i get the more that's just not
what i see yeah like men
most men want
offspring like they want kids
like that they're biologically
predispositioned to want to spread their
seed yeah
and to to drive
to be that spiteful to drive to another
state
so you're
the father of your child
wouldn't have rights
to take care of your child
like what
when does it
when does the insanity come in
come in to where you're like actually
you know what i don't i don't wanna
i don't want this man to be around and
you're putting your kid at every
statistical disadvantage yeah
do you think there's a difference
between kids raised by single mothers
and single fathers
i think there is a difference between
both
i think gone no go ahead i was gonna say
i think
with
and this is a generalization with single
fathers you may find a little bit more
disciplined because you're in a
masculine household where
um a father will tell you to do one
thing and
in in most cases it's like this is how
it's going to be done this is the way
it's going to be done because i'm
leading by example whereas in a single
mother's
um household
not to say that there isn't discipline i
won't say that at all but it may be
sometimes the emotions
may overcome what is best for the child
at that moment and it's more so what was
bet whatever the decision is based on
how she felt
um may have an impact or a lasting
impact
long in the long form and so you'll find
that single father households breed kids
that
have a bit more discipline but have less
empathy
and then it's vice versa
single mother households might have less
discipline but they have a lot of
empathy but if a single mother's raising
a man or a child
a boy for example sorry
you might find that there's a lot more
feminine traits that the boy may have
because
let's just say
the mother is raising the boy he gets to
about 14 and the mom's talking about oh
it wouldn't it be funny to have like you
wearing heels and stuff
and like
the boy at fourth like a young age is
now pretending to have a handbag in
heels whereas a dad wouldn't have
allowed that yeah because he would have
seen
longevity
this is not conducive to how i want
this young man to
be raised
and so
um
yeah
it's a big epidemic and i think single
mothers are usually worse with money
so
like the kid usually grows up
not
like you inherit your parents but you
ever wake up one day and you're like i
am just like my mother
or i am just like my father oh god and
so it's like you inherit your parents
bad habits cheese sauce cheese sauce
yeah it's like deliver me okay three
two
one go
they're upset because they're not
allowed to be fathers
that guy
pulls his head out blows his brains out
there's a family
and people don't think there's something
wrong with that
we just open the doors tomorrow for
business as usual and that's okay
i've always thought of feminism as being
the fight for gender equality
and yet i've never heard about father's
rights and the injustice is going on in
family court
why is this
i decided to ask gender studies
professor michael messner
well
i'll just say i i don't think it's
i i don't think that that a lot of their
assumptions are correct to start with
there's no doubt that
there have been some men who get just
screwed by
court uh decisions and custody cases but
i think when you look at the broader
patterns
um
you know it's still the case that um
in intact heterosexual families with
with kids
women are still doing the vast majority
of the housework and child care and and
a lot of there's a lot of sort of father
absence lack of participation by fathers
some of whom i think then after divorce
happens
end up
suddenly wanting equality
you know
as fathers when they haven't really been
participating equally as fathers before
so to me it always kind of swings back
to the feminist perspective of of how we
need to push for full equality across
the board including before divorces
and
if we have that then we might expect
more symmetry after divorce is happening
the more i researched father's rights
the more i realized how deep this rabbit
hole goes
not only in the amount of issues
but also in the vast array of
perspectives on these issues
i decided to create a flow chart of what
i thought father's options might be
following a surprise pregnancy
i then put a green line for the paths
that i thought would be good turnouts
for the father and i put red lines for
the paths that seemed to not be good for
the father
then i created a flow chart for women's
options
and did the same with green and red
lines
and as i stepped back i saw all the red
lines for the women's options
if she does not want the child
but something dawned on me
of every path the biological father
could go down
he's at the mercy of the woman's soul
discretion
although women have very difficult
choices to make
she at least has the choice
but for biological fathers
they have no say
over their parental destiny
[Music]
this is my friend dara she's eight
months pregnant with her first child
and she's a lifelong feminist
it seems from mris from what i've read
that women seem to have more
reproductive
rights than men do
i don't know what to say like we carry
children they're never going to carry
children it's just a different thing so
i guess
as much as possible take the
steps
to prevent yourself being in that
situation
it's just like i don't know what to say
there's no
there's nothing like a woman
you know has been women have been blamed
for
and still are for
you know un unwanted pregnancies
choosing to have an abortion not
choosing to have an abortion choosing to
put their child up for adoption when you
know the the
burden lies on a single mother if the
man leaves there's real you know
societally she's she's lambasted so
there's a lot of things that women deal
with in that regard that men don't
actually deal with so i can have
compassion for their situation but i
don't know that it's going to change in
the way they want it to because it's
biology you know
so if you're going to be having sex uh
that could result in pregnancy and you
haven't had this conversation with the
woman that you're having sex with you
better have it better have it fast
that's when the man has the ability to
make decisions
either not to engage in sex or to use
condoms and to use other forms of
contraceptive
oh
my god
so just don't have sex with anyone if
you're a guy
it's impossible basically
i just have sex with people you can't
impregnate
or get a vasectomy
okay
vasectomy yeah so have a surgery that
could leave you sterile
um
[Music]
don't have sex be celibate
and then what does she say sex that
could result in pregnancy
is there sex that can't i guess [__] old
ladies maybe that's like a mating
strategy
she's like i can't she's i can't get
pregnant anymore
no she said
me i'm i'm that i'm at one point she
said i'm available she said me we're
gonna have no babies so you ain't gotta
worry about no child support yo did
y'all hear that the lady that was
sitting on the couch that one day that
was saying men don't have
a choice in
the babies yeah she was saying that her
grandmother had a
child at 80 years old
redhead
no no no
no not the redhead i'm trying to think
of what uh
she was here this past week
thursday
no no no she's here early in the week
she was sitting right here
and uh
it was the gray area agraria sarah
garvey and she was talking about yeah if
i can have
if i can have a baby a man doesn't have
a choice for that
what'd she look like
she was
african okay
we talked about her earlier
um
yeah
she was saying that her grandmother had
a child at 80. i'm like 80. i don't
believe you
i was like show me the carfax yeah yeah
i don't
show me the carfax okay yeah and um
maybe she doesn't know how to grandma
i'm the ceo of pepsi
like
oh yeah
damn
thank god right in the nick of time
because i'm over here
we are here dying it's human
bending
ishmael y'all if you can see ish it's
been over there
coast
i had to catch myself i'm like oh i'm on
camera
shake it off stick with it shake it up
have you ever has anyone ever told you
she got insane
i mean i've had a few people tell me
yeah no i um what's the verdict
what'd you say
yeah
pearl pearl has told me that i have a
nice speaking voice i had someone the
other day tell me that they were like oh
do you still perform and sing i was like
no i never did that they were like oh
your voice sounds like you would have
like a honeysuckle voice like for
singing do you reckon with training i
think anyone can okay because it's a
muscle
control yeah
if you
that's when you can look at like old
videos of singers singing like 10 years
later
yeah
mariah carey
okay please someone in the chat tell me
that you've seen
that video of the little white girl
singing i will always love you and she's
trying to sing it and she keeps messing
up she goes oh my gosh
if anyone's seen that
it's a pretty funny pretty funny video
you should put up on your phone-ish
check it out
you gotta send it to me
it's hilarious i don't think anyone's
seen that that's like old school youtube
days i'm aging myself
55 25
so what's that saying my voice can put
you to sleep
that that barrier white that
that luther man
it's like so hot in here like outside
paul
raise the race of blind to see if it
makes a difference yeah yeah
okay
pearl says it's nice outside people
we ain't been outside we in this heat 24
hours four hours done oh they said that
they've seen it yes
yeah it was ma'am
pro just knocked me out
did you say there's a key that can open
this door
yes it's in the drawer over there
a second one
on the left hand side has a black thing
with it yep
you want me to
that's it
[Music]
another one
unless you guys hit me up or not
can we put the mic back on in the middle
put on the table i think that would work
well
eating
asmr yeah so we can put in the middle
and i think it'll pick us up wouldn't it
let's try it
i don't know i saw kevin samuels do it
with the fans
oh it's right here
sorry
just open the door turn off the ac
look if it was that simple
we do have the door open and we turn off
the ac
it's hot
oh thanks baby
davey said
just looking beautiful as always dude
thanks evie i appreciate it
i appreciate it no
that's nice
i'm sorry oh
did you get a steak one um
wait speaking to the table oh that is
loud
in the middle
yes
yep just probably thinks asmr mukbang
if i tune in
[Music]
that's why it's because she's doing it
here no i think i've muted that oh well
yeah try now
oh are we doing are we just doing it on
that middle mic we're just gonna try it
test intestine once okay that's weird
[Music]
like just put it like hide it while
we're eating because
[Music]
yeah
just
is it loud chat
can you hear us chat
it's asmr time
it's asmr time are you guys excited
let's see if i can get this to sizzle
[Music]
if we could put that
and make sure that mike is still that
would be great this one yes please
[Music]
can we ask if the chat can hear us
we hear the crinkle please put the mic
down
[Laughter]
no we
here
[Laughter]
so anytime you slam anything on the
table
will
you said you're good just don't yell
table amplified everything is place of
honor no amplification
can you hear us chad
and my whisper can you hear me
i'm gonna do an asmr channel one day why
aren't you on
the screen
oh sir screen you're supposed to be in
the camera yes i'm in the camera
i was like it's so funny just just out
here while in people
what's up
it takes a second
maybe 20 seconds
oh
guys we're going to do a little rating
test
uh chipotle tortilla chips
super chat at work right now gonna catch
up later congrats to the whole team and
don't get ahead of yourself there's
plenty of time to grow yeah stay humble
team
let him know
who was it
davey jones davey jones mm-hmm what a
guy
why that jackfruit
[Music]
one of many thank you jess your content
is great does it work in a 24-hour
format it's unnecessary you get steady
viewership guys we're just doing it for
the it's like a party where we torture
ourselves
it's a celebration 250k quarter of a
milli
road to 500k starts now
no one know everyone everyone say what
they ordered
[Music]
i got steak and white rice
and hot sauce
i got steak
with red rice black beans mild tomatoes
or pico de gallo
um corn
vegetables
does it say it
oh that's ideal
i got chicken burrito
with white rice black beans mid tomatoes
and hot red chilli sauce
good stuff two girls
and guys
what up guys
[Music]
in that documentary crazy
mm-hmm
when i found out the adult i've seen it
before but when i found out the adoption
one
i'm like the audacity
brought to tomorrow hearing about some
of the men's stories and just thinking
like
that could be me
at any point in my life and
it's it would just be like yeah
devastating
to me in such a situation no chess was
not coming
you guys should go to her id and be like
jessica we really want you back on the
show we love you so much
i miss um
i never understood why rolo was so
against marriage but i kind of
understand it in 2022 like why men don't
want to get married that's such a big
risk
ian is a white knight
nice spanish jess
90 free to a pie
when are your birthdays everyone's your
birthday dropper food freestyle pearl
after i finished my burrito i was
starving
september 10th
we less than 30 days away you know what
it is
yes ma'am satisfied
i don't know what that means
see we're working on her
i'm um
i was born november 4th okay
june 16th
gemini
the only thing i know is gemini only
reason why i know virgos because my
nephew and one of my best friends is
virgo mm-hmm
so other than that
then i know cancer because my father
but
i'm a scorpio apparently we're like
crazy
two girls one guy and burritos
y'all give pearl some lyrics
someone write pearl or rap and she'll
wrap it
yeah give me
you thought what
we're gonna beat
look
give me a sec give me a sec
i'm getting a paper towel
it's um you might have to jump that's on
top of the camera
no one's jumping
i just had the job to get the max
[Music]
thank you
do you have to jump together mike's i
don't think so
i'm pretty long
you can read that one
what does it say
what did it say
okay
so
y'all need to give ish a stack of hats
to throw at these wacky broads when they
be capping other than that i ain't
subscribing you post too much
yeah bro i need to get some hats on the
level
i hear that i hear that
blue ones why
is that is it
the internet's up so you can't reach
this page you post too much so you're
not subscribing i do have the same
birthday as tupac that's my
favorite claim claim to fame
words hard today okay why is it just the
youtube it says you're not connected
we're still oh wi-fi is off that's why
hey you started scaring me i was like
hey that's true i was like i just
thought it was i saw on my phone
all right
i got y'all
okay
[Music]
just party things on the beach i can't i
can't rep that fast oh wait i got 90
free tour prizes became a member
okay
maybe this is too close to the mic
[Music]
make it lower yeah
someone said pearls burrito just had a
steak white rice a little bit of hot
sauce no flavor and cheese
[Music]
a burrito bust
that's the most important part
i know all this money and my cash cash
i don't got a dollar that's not stacked
hold up hold up
wait pearl nibbled
spit hot fire
hot fire trying to build another
[__] empire
i know the boy's desire
this youtube channel's on fire fire
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
i'm jessica nice to meet you
i'm glad you're his full name i'm here
with yourself
how are you uh i'm all right
[Music]
you see she got famous yeah
youtube
[Music]
oh she's still
yeah camera shy she goes back next week
so that's right
we're freestyling
oh this is the wrapping bit where you're
going to do wrapping oh my gosh
yeah i'm bad do you know how to wrap
auntie
i was like i can pass it out my nephew
my nephew
i've got a nephew in the business oh
you want to turn on her mic when you get
a sec yeah yeah
i just i just found that out
where is it
say hello to you right yeah yeah yeah
yeah we
will give her we'll give her the main my
meg
[Music]
hi everyone how's it going
[Laughter]
she's not [__] around with these kids
they make excuses for everything that's
what they do and she said
[__] the problem is you
[Laughter]
right that's my intro my auntie's in the
house
all right auntie i got questions oh wow
yeah
okay go ahead
okay okay they can they can hear me if i
go like this yeah they can hear you is
it better is it better to go here or
should i go here put any okay i'm done
i'm done eating so i'm asking like is it
better i sit here or here like which
might you owe me on audrey you have to
be like okay you wanna go to meet this
one though and then just turn justice on
yeah yeah
so how does it feel to have gone viral
wait oh
you are the most requested guests
that we have ever gotten on the channel
i've never had anyone request it oh then
you know what
she watches the tunnel oh yeah i should
say for the right reasons
how does it feel you get did you get a
bunch of like people reaching out after
last time
yeah
and funny because i've been auntie jenny
for years so you know i had a lot of my
i call my children so she's always like
that i had children saying especially
after the ola i had some
like female children like in their 20s
say why didn't you tell me that when i
was younger and i and i had to go back
and say do you remember this day when i
told you such and such well i've always
been here i was here before i was on
youtube i've always been auntie jenny so
you know but apparently it hit home
yeah yeah it hit home i was quite
surprised i think i think once you have
the experience
to like know what you know what like
what the kevin samuels always used to
say know what the [__] you're talking
about
well you see the thing is i never had a
problem with him
i i i watched him and i thought he gave
men a hard time in the beginning which
nobody seems to realize that he actually
done the same thing to women what he
done to men
and then
all of a sudden it's like he's you know
this person that's picking on women but
nobody made them far now like nobody
made ola come on the show yeah and
that's what people fail to realize that
you didn't say oh auntie ginny you know
i want you to come here i said oh i'm in
london i'll put that you said pop in
that's not popped in yeah
no that's true why do you think modern
women don't take accountability for
their actions because you were in a
position where you were a single mother
yeah and you didn't go to men and say
take me as i am like you didn't try to
change men you just took the cards you
were dealt
you know i was thinking about that and i
was thinking
the difference between single parents
now and then
there's no shame
i think when i had my son i brought
shame onto the family and as well as
myself
so it wasn't anything that you were with
pride you know i'm a single parent you
didn't wear a prime but now it seems to
be a thing of pride you know i'm a
single parent and i can raise a child on
my own whereas before
you know it was like you know there's
jennifer you know she's had a child
she's only young she's not married and
it was sort of like hung your head in
shame
but now it just seems to be
the norm
when did you notice that switch like was
there was there a year or like a maybe
like a decade i think my i had my son at
85 okay after that they were finished
okay i realized that that was a cut off
point i mean because i say after 85 like
my son can cook clean wash iron he's
quite self-sufficient but then because
he was an only child you get
people that are born that year
didn't know anything
i mean i remember his friends came and
they couldn't believe that you know
he could go into the cupboards and help
himself to food that's what you mean and
there were single parents out there who
had their food labelled
you know and
all that
happened i think i was just lucky that i
just missed it yeah do you think it was
because after after like the 70s
ballpark was when um no fault divorce
and birth control became rampant like
because what i think happened was like
when birth control became readily
available women got worse yeah do you
would you agree with that as someone who
was there i mean oh yeah because like i
said i got pregnant on the pill it just
come out he thought yeah i'm going to
try you know
yeah and then i got pregnant i can't
imagine that it was as effective back
then and then i thought yeah i know
because i had people saying oh you only
took it for a mom but i had to like
actually go into the nhs website and let
them see that you know the peel you can
take it from day one depending on which
pill it is you're covered from day one
so as far as i was concerned after that
you know if i wanted to have sex i'd use
everything
you know you know peel you know the
injection you know every single thing
but nowadays it's just like
i don't know it's just it's just so easy
to go out there and just have sex yeah
and i think after me
it all got worse
so i think you'll find that it's like
the 45 year olds
backwards
yeah that's true because it's like the
50s now and the 50s above i mean we're
quite surprised that there's this red
pill blue pill going on because i've
never seen the matrix i have a clue what
it was and even when you know pearl said
oh are you quite every notice in that
video when you said about the red pill i
didn't answer because i thought i
haven't got a clue what she's talking
about
because i don't know what red pill blue
pill is but it just seems like
bloody common sense
you know if something's not broken
and that's what they seem to try and you
see that nowadays the women are trying
to fix something that's not broken
and
when do you okay do you think modern
because you you've really seen modern
women like
from the beginning to now yeah do you
think that modern women are getting
worse or better
has there ever been a chef like you
cannot put it they're getting better at
being worse
[Laughter]
because before it's not it's not like
what you did it's how you did it but now
it's not like how you do it it's just
the fact that you're doing it so way
before you used to do things in secret
now
people don't care you're like you have
girls putting their body counts online
and they're like yeah and they're like
50 plus and they're like 25. i already
feel like after the other than me like
if you're over 50 plus and you're female
most women need to be banned and i've
had i've had that i said oh people
should not be on instagram and old
people shouldn't be on youtube and
look at my sister's face
i've been telling that all the time
because it's just not necessary because
they're getting all these ideas
or these modern women ideas which
are not necessary for people like me
mm-hmm you know it's really not
necessary i think what's necessary is
trying to tell the young people that
where where did all this come from
because whoever brought it up
i think there must be a plan behind it
just to emasculate all the men because
something's not right there's enough
balance somewhere and it's with the
women
so do you think the problems in the
dating market today are because of women
or do you think men have contributed too
i think men are contributing because
they listen to all the bs that women say
basically they listen i mean it's true
because you can get up and you can it's
like i hear the women it's like oh it's
so hard running a house how can i work
and look after your house you've got all
these mod cons out there
you know and is it a men believe it
remember if anything women say and they
need to get a backbone and stop
believing the rubbish that they say
you know all the women and their their
periods and you know their their mood
swings and that's rubbish
yeah like
how are you gonna have it for like 30
years and let the poor men suffer get it
sorted
you know you can go and get it sorted
you try one thing try something else but
i think the women just want to punish
them in you know they said oh you know
that every month moo's gonna swing well
leave home
go somewhere they should have a hospital
for all the women that when they're on
their period like an asylum they just
look them in there let them go crazy for
the three weeks and then let them out
again i believe it because it i can you
can control
you can control like your your mood you
know you know you act the same way
every month and you know it comes at
about the same time you can
cognitively be like okay i know i'm
going to be like this let me
not feed into it let me be accountable
for how i'm acting yeah i believe it
balance so you can go and get evening
primrose you know chamomile tea or yeah
something they just use it as an excuse
to be leave home
leave men in peace
because no because it's just
i hear women i look at the poor men and
i think and all this about men not
having sex when they're married once
you've got once you're married
if i was married don't expect sex on
demand
i didn't expect to hear no
you know because if you were sick for
work he wouldn't say oh no i'm not you
still struggle to go and so struggle to
have sex
you know especially if you're a woman
just lie down and take it and smile and
say thank you what are you
because at the end of the day if you was
going to work and you were sick and you
know that that's going to affect your
records you were struggling yeah you
said if you can struggle for your boss
struggle for your man struggle for your
woman
my man don't say no to me i don't say no
to him because if i want i want it she
said give it to me when i want it out
what do you think of the stat that 20
20 to 25 of men are in sexless marriages
i know i knew a few people like that and
it's sad and it's like having a dog and
barking yourself
you know i mean why would you have a dog
and bark i mean why get married mm-hmm
i mean
i couldn't imagine getting married and
not having sex oh i would be devastated
be like and i mean like ever every day
every day every day every day every day
every day and all this bad sex that men
are having it's the women's fault
because the women are so quick to open
their legs but not their mouth to say oh
i'm doing this you're doing this wrong
or this isn't right yeah so he goes on
to the next person thinking well this is
all right or he might find oh she's a
[__] because she's telling me oh i
shouldn't be doing this i should be
doing that if i'm having bad sex it's
the woman before me
and women never think about that they
always blame the men but they can so
easily take off their clothes but they
can't open their mouth and say excuse me
but what you're doing is wrong or this
is not what i like or i don't know who
taught you that but it's wrong but wow
do it yeah yeah you know if you can open
your mouth i'm a woman for everything i
refuse to put up with bad sex
it's just not on
so
so i have a question with um
do you think it's selfish when women
break up homes
yeah
um do you think it's selfish if a man
breaks up a home too i think it's
selfish whoever backs at the home and
it's not for viewers the reasons of like
life in danger so if it's not life in
danger then whoever breaks it up
is at fault what should the man of two
what should a man do if he's in a
sexless marriage but he wants the family
to stay together but she refuses to
cooperate with him
i'd explain to her like excuse me but i
need to get it somewhere so we have to
come to an agreement where i'll get it
outside okay so you say she she
yeah because i should have free up women
come on what would you say will smith
because like i know these are because a
lot of times i do think it's selfish to
break up a home
but like sometimes i see these women
that are like basically abusing their
husbands
and i'm like that can't be good for the
like i think honestly like jada and
willow are are so weird that like they
would be better like that you that the
his daughter was talking about open
relationships at like 16.
i think that she's got something against
him yeah
i mean at one point i thought he was gay
and she knew it and she was just holding
it against him and so like but nowadays
well if you're gay come out you know
everybody else is that might as well
come out don't hold it against you but i
just think to myself no
he should man up mm-hmm
and she's not even all that and you're
going to go and slap a man why couldn't
she go and slap her i mean
i've got alopecia you don't hear me
going on about it you know you see it
you see it that's why i park my hair
especially in the middle so you can see
it
but she's been out there talking about
it for the whole world to talk about and
all of a sudden she's going to get upset
because he cracks a joke not even really
about her alopecia about the way she
looks and then will smith's going to get
up there and just
he didn't want to slap him it's because
that look because he was laughing before
once she gave that look yeah he's under
the farm because if she didn't look at
him he would have carried on laughing oh
yeah
so now he's uh he's a and the thing is
that she's got him in a position where
he he thinks that she's the catch
and he's so stupid he doesn't realize
that he's the catch because if he left
her who's going to want her
no one's going to want her
she's like
she's gone past being leftovers
yeah she's just turned into compost
she's gone
so why we did that show right and we the
the term was leftover women yeah and it
was funny because you came in and i i
didn't like really talk to you much
before
and so i didn't know how you were going
to react because like clearly you're
over the age of 35 right and why are you
not offended by that
when you get to my hands not a lot
offends you
not because i didn't see anything wrong
it's like people got offended by you
know kevin samuels but he didn't do
anything wrong he didn't tell stupid
women to phone up and get you know get
told the truth
he's gonna say so why phone up mm-hmm
you phoned up and you say stupid things
you expect him to say oh it's okay
because you're a woman you're stupid no
he's going to put you straight and
sometimes you need to be put straight
and there's nobody
putting these young people straight
so
where do you think the accountability
should come from
i think that everybody's accountable for
their actions and every action has a
consequence so we're all accountable for
our own
selves why don't women want to face
consequences because they can't face the
consequences yeah they can't face the
consequences of anything
and that's why they will just bluff it
out or pass it on or make an excuse or
just
deviate they're very good at that mm-hmm
or what they call it now it's sliding
moving the goal post too moving the goal
is the same thing yeah yeah because well
because that's that happens all the time
whenever i get i this is something i've
learned from talking to women that you
have to get them to acknowledge like
their point because otherwise they try
to distract you and it's hard yeah
because they don't ever when you think
they're certain they've understood what
i've meant and you've agreed they say
yeah but
it's always yeah but oh i feel yeah but
and everything's butt and once once i
hear that butterfly
they've lost it yeah cause whatever they
said before the butt so that cancels
one of your questions yeah you asked
auntie um why she didn't feel
like um offended when you spoke about
leftover woman is that because you're in
a relationship
no no
because if i wasn't a nurse and [__] i
was just like yeah i'm left over and
what okay
but then would you say that you're not a
leftover woman because you are in a
relationship no i'll say that i'm a
leftover woman in a relationship because
i've got no ring
think about it okay okay okay yeah you
can be a leftover woman and still be in
a relationship because you can be
relationship for years but it doesn't
mean that you're not a leftover it just
means that you're lucky that you found
someone that don't want to go looking no
further yeah or vice versa because he
ain't gonna get no better than me and
i'm not gonna get no better than him
because thanks to you like we found out
what's out there and it's scary so we're
stuck with each other but i wouldn't say
that no i'm special or whatever i would
just say i'm a leftover woman in a
relationship
and
the win only comes when you get the ring
yeah okay
because that's the result
without the ring you're left off like
that's why i oftentimes girls come on
here and say they're traditional i'm
like i wouldn't say i'm not traditional
because if you're traditional you you
would have traditional results yeah
you'd have a ring yeah you'd be married
at 22. i have friends that are
absolutely traditional but it's like we
if you're pretending to be something
you're not men think you're like men can
feel that they can feel the
inauthenticity i can say i'm traditional
i do everything but i'm not married and
i'm having sex regularly but it doesn't
make me traditional doesn't really think
about it you can say it it doesn't make
it true
i'm traditional but
and that's what they'd say i'm
traditional but i have this no i'm a
leftover woman
and there's no qualms about it and i
just want them things in it yeah
so
the girl that was on the show
you um
she
had a lot of excuses for the way society
is
um and she she was talking about
how as a woman were discriminated
against and being black you're
discriminated against and you you said
no that's that's a load of horseshit why
did you say that you know something
right i
didn't really watch the show i didn't
realize how disrespectful she was being
and
it's not even disrespectful as a woman
it's culturally disrespectful
the role in the eyes the shaking the fee
and it's only afterwards when people
because i just i just read the comments
i didn't actually watch it when i looked
at it and i thought
that went right over my head you're
being rude you've been disrespectful
even you asked me what sectors i was
working and i'm telling you i'm working
oh it doesn't matter what sector i was
and i was in 42k a year
and and i thought she was she was just
being really really disrespectful
that that's so interesting you say that
because i thought you were just being so
composed because i i watched her like
any time you'd make a point like you'd
start to reiterate your point just to
justify what you were saying
she'd roll her eyes or she'd be like get
in a mood or she'd just give like some
sort of attitude and i thought you were
just composed and you just kept on like
i didn't realize you didn't see it
didn't see it i'm autistic went straight
over my head i was a foster carer and
i'm useless
brats
and
i didn't see it and not only that is
that
i remember saying to someone as an
african person and and a caribbean
person it's different
and she was being disrespectful she was
african and she was being disrespectful
because as an african person i used i'm
a west indian person i used to foster
african children
and i know that with african
children if i'm talking to you you lower
your gaze
as a west indian child if i'm talking to
you i want you to look at me when i'm
talking to you but she was doing neither
so she was being doubly disrespectful
and she just didn't want to know as far
as she concerned she knew what she knew
and she was i realized she was trying to
put me down
bit by bit by bit but it honestly went
over my head and when i get a night i
stutter
and i did stutter a couple of times but
i thought she's annoying me but all the
things that she was doing just went
straight over my head but you know when
you when you think to yourself oh i
[__] go there again i would have said
this i would have said that but that
would have made her cry in public and
that would have been nice so
so do you feel like as a woman you were
held back at all
i feel as a woman and as a black woman i
feel that people try to hold me back
because i know that people out there
saying oh she never had this back
i was discriminated against i had a year
off work i had um
work tribunals i've done it all
with work but i didn't let you hold me
back i didn't find it yes i had it hard
but
so did the people before me i didn't
have it as hard as my mother she didn't
have it as hard as her mother you know
so you can't keep on looking back and
saying oh it was all right for me yes it
was hard for me but you got it a lot
better than me i had it a lot better
than my mother so it always gets better
it doesn't get they're trying to make it
sound like it gets worse it doesn't get
worse it gets better but it's
interesting because i i think it gets
better and we complain more it's a crazy
thing because
i you don't hear our grandmas like
talking like this
like i always say women from the 1950s
would think we were weak
oh you're leaving your husband because
you're not happy my man had a family
across town and i stayed yeah
and it's like we have more rights than
ever but we complain more and more and
more
and they get more and more and more i
mean i remember saying to my sister
because everybody's like oh how did she
get around the house on this and i
remember walking to work walking miles
and nobody knew that i didn't have the
money to get to work i didn't tell
anyone i put my headphones on and at
that time every it was all trendy to put
your work shoes in your bag and wear
your trainers because everyone's walking
so i just pretended that was an exercise
you know and nobody knew and i walked to
work for mums
because i didn't want to spend that
money and i had better things to do with
it but nowadays they just think oh you
know she don't know what she's talking
about but
i'd like to see ola again now and you'd
like to see i'd like to see hola
and just do what i say
and see how she finds it that's a
challenge
no i actually that's something when we
i've been so busy trying to find a new
apartment but that's something i want to
i was thinking we should do with you
wife school where you teach uh modern
women to be wives so you teach me and
just how to cook
and then like you could and we could
even bring in other girls that have come
on the show and see if you could like
because even when you were talking about
the finish in school and i thought i
could be the start and finishing school
could be the finish
yeah i haven't found a finishing school
in the uk that wants to do it but i've
emailed a couple um so you know
hopefully we can find one what's your
specialty dish auntie
anything that's cheap filling and then
bargain hey i like it home cooking
nothing fancy
i'll call it booze in a bucket
and i don't do ugly food either
has to be cheap
it has to be nutritious
and it has to be easy
and it has to be something that you're
not slaving around
all day in because that's nonsense
because when women say that you can sit
at home and you can get the house fixed
now before your your man comes home and
make it look perfect then the cook do if
it's done
and it's that easy because we've got all
the mod cons now so it's about letting
the mod cons work for you mm-hmm and
it's
i've seen you cooking yes and it's
terrible
i've seen you oh you mean
pal sorry no you're fine
i've seen it you know when she sits
there with a knife it's like yes i've
done chicken what are you doing that
sushi and i thought she had all the was
it sushi
that's sushi bowl's fire
okay you get you could teach me how to
that was the most disgusting
she had like she had the seaweed on the
side she had all the ingredients there
on the plate uh-huh and i thought she's
gonna but you just didn't put it
together oh no you didn't you weren't
able to eat it with your eyes first
no but no oh yeah
that's right i like it okay the sushi
bowls i like apart because i like to
like make it like a sandwich like i take
the seaweed and then i put the rice on
okay that's why i do it like that but
now you can teach me how to fix it yeah
yeah yeah we can
take the take the modern woman out of me
auntie yes yes
after we move i was thinking we could do
it on like sundays or something that's
fine but we could just do like like
auntie teaches us a recipe a week or
something yeah i'm down for that and the
place
you know i haven't heard from them so
i'm sorry to think maybe we didn't get
this one we might have to find a new one
at the they have to hear back from home
boy he's probably living it up yeah yeah
we'll see overseas we'll see um so okay
i kind of want to know your life story
oh gosh
so you got pregnant you said when you
were 18. no
i got preg i had my son just before when
i was 17. oh seven couple of months
before my 18th birthday and were you
living at home with your parents when
you got pregnant i was living with my
mom did she kill you
or want to
i didn't actually tell her
it's really weird because you get these
old west indian women and my stepdad was
fantastic why is she laughing
because she knows what my mother's like
and i said i said to my stepdad you know
i'm pregnant
and i said i don't have to tell my mom
and he said
we sort something out
and then we sat there talking and my mom
came in and she said you just think i'm
stupid you're an idiot she's pregnant
and i don't know what you expect me to
say about it and she walked out the room
and i said actually no because i don't
know
and she just looked at me and thought
well she's pregnant and that was it but
my dad you know daddy's girl i didn't
have to tell my dad and i remember when
i had him my dad came to see the baby
and he said oh he's ugly i said yeah it
looks like his granddad
and that was it that's all he ever said
to me and had an auntie turn up and she
said oh
when i was pregnant she looked at me she
goes somebody's had a lot of dinners
i said yes but it wasn't something to be
celebrated
it wasn't now you know everybody's
having parties and it wasn't nothing to
be celebrated because
it was just like you brought shame on
the family same yeah oh that's
interesting yeah because now we have
babies baby showers for baby mamas
but i've never heard in those days it
wasn't it wasn't even like disposable
nappies so it wasn't they just started
to come out yeah so there wasn't even
disposable nappies i was there no they
hadn't watched it yeah and the bucket
was you know
milton in it but no they were it was it
was shameful so did your parents kick
you out of the house when they found out
or how long were you i actually um got
my own when my son was about
one or two
okay
yeah i i left because my my mom always
said two women can't share one kitchen
wow
and two men can't lead one household see
that's why
sons get kicked out at the age of 18
or go to uni what do you think of all
these people that are like because in
london i everyone lives at home with
their parents
like everyone i think sometimes it's
cultural mm-hmm like with the indians
the asians and the africans sometimes be
cultural or sometimes it's financial
mm-hmm
or sometimes the parents just love
having your children with them and i'm
not one of them people
get out
i gave him a deposit to go and find
somewhere when he was 21. i was like
that's it i've done my time yeah because
i was a foster carer yeah and i said
if he's going to be with me till 21
mm-hmm i've done more than most i've
done more and above because the law says
like 16 maybe 18 education 21. so i've
done my bit yeah and you gave them a
deposit too most parents won't even
help their kids get set up they always
had a key but i gave them the deposit to
say like you know you need to go and
find somewhere here's a deposit
you know there's always anything you
want in the house you can take but just
don't come back because i i hear two um
like responses from your generation
mostly about like our generation living
at home so much one is like when i was
your age i was out on the streets
working like why don't you like that
sort of thing and then it's rubbish
because a lot of people my age yeah
years ago they got pregnant just to
leave home because as a woman if you got
pregnant the government would give you
somewhere to live so
after my generation they stopped it but
that isn't why i've done it it's just
one of them things but i know a lot of
people that got pregnant just to leave
home wow a hell of a lot because if you
were pregnant the government gave you
somewhere
and they wanted to leave home so they
got pregnant oh wow so it wasn't that
they were being you know they were being
careless they actually went out
purposely to get pregnant to get their
own place and i would say about 50 of
single mothers that i knew done that
yeah at least and do you so
and do you think that
was where
do you think that
fifty percent that's why it went up
because everybody wanted to leave home
so everybody got pregnant to leave home
so you think that's when like the
breakdown of the family started was when
the government started paying people to
leave yeah and paying people to have
babies
so and then you have kids that were like
born for the wrong reason probably a lot
of them their their moms aren't good
mothers because like they wanted a kid
not to you know continue life but
for money yes that's a pretty shitty
i've seen i've seen all the the parents
that just go out there and they wanted
the property like i said you used to get
a flat if you got pregnant and so once
they get it they had no interest in a
child and then people like me look after
their children
wow
so
after you moved out what what happened
next
i just got on with it i went to college
took my son to college okay what'd you
study
car maintenance okay so you're kind of
you're kind of tomboy
yeah
i was i was because as a woman if you're
single i mean that you need a man and
always say if you're going to buy a car
take a man if you're going to get a car
fixed take a man and if there's no men
around you we'll know what you're
talking about because if i take my car
into the garage they're going to fix
exactly what i tell them to fix and
anything more it's on them i'm not going
to oh you know it's like the 300 pound
and it's going to 500 no
and i actually go to places now and they
will actually take the parts off
and keep them there or i'll mark them
especially if they're doing a service a
lot of people don't mark the air filter
and the oil filter you mark it a little
bit tip x and you can come back and
check whether they've changed it or not
so things like that i had to i studied
things that i needed to survive with
how was dating as a single mother
i think in those days people didn't
really care
they they didn't care that you're a
single mother he was a single mother
because
the children never got involved
so it wasn't that i was a single mother
i was a single woman with a child but
the two never
mixed really now people go out and they
they introduce their children but no
with us it was just you get the mother
to babysit or you get a babysit or
sometimes your own friends will babysit
your your children or you know you have
a group of them come round but you never
introduced
your children or your child to the
people that you're mixing with never
happened but now it does it's like a
handbag
so
was it did you have a did men
when you were dating was it harder for
men to take you seriously because you
had a kid
like in terms of because i mean yeah for
dating i'm sure maybe in those days
you see as in in those days as a single
mother you know how to wash cook clean
iron so you knew those things it wasn't
a problem but now you get single parents
and you're thinking
where the hell did you come from because
you know nothing no because like you
were still a wife yeah
and
the problem with single mothers today is
their kid is like a handbag and they
have no parenting skills parents don't
know how to shop they don't know how to
cook i mean people say about oh how
expensive food is you saw these people
crying at poverty but look around their
necks they're smoking you know they've
got their jewelry they've got a massive
wide screen tv they've got is it
playstation 5 or whatever their kids got
all the latest games but they're in
poverty why because they're eating you
know takeaway all the time they're not
actually cooking whereas in those days i
mean there's a footballer that i ain't
going to name because i don't like him
and he's like all these single parents
know in my day we had to go pound shop
everybody went pound shop your mother
done it you know and all of a sudden he
wants to give out all these free
vouchers you know forcing the government
to give out these free batches for these
children half of them don't need them
because what they need is lessons on how
to manage money and how to run a
household well that's what they need if
you pay people to make bad decisions
they're going to make more of them and
that's what they've been doing yeah yeah
that's what they've been doing because
that's all all the i mean you've got
people out in there now that i've got
like
two cars
big tv all the children got uh laptops
or you know tablets
and they're getting all these vouchers
in the school holidays and they're
unemployed
they're unemployed
and when you think about all the top-ups
that they're getting for being
unemployed why can't you give that to
people that are working really really
hard
i agree and they don't get it so there's
encouraging people to breed and have all
these freeness
because they're going to get it you
don't need it they need lessons in how
to manage money they need they need
parenting classes
you know one way they manipulate poverty
statistics
so i always say like people
like there are hustlers right there's
like race hustlers there's environment
hustlers like if there's a problem you
sell the solution and that's what the
politicians do is like they're selling a
solution
and one way they sell the problem that
poverty is so
widespread is that they raise the
poverty line where people with tvs and
air conditioning are counted as under
the poverty line
when i honestly say there's no poverty
in england
there's no poverty in england when you
look at it
because of the bills now you know the
the you know the electric and the gas
they might be but before you take that
all away there's no poverty there's only
people that don't know how to manage
money that have got more money than
sense
because
i know those religious people you know
there's a lot of religious people out
there but god always said well am i
going to give you more when you can't do
more with less you know if i'll give you
a little bit and you don't do a lot of
it why am i going to give you more but
the government's they're giving it a
little bit years ago they've given us a
little bit and we're doing a lot with it
but now it's like we're going to give
you more and people like we want more
than that because all they're getting is
more and more where's it coming from
it's coming from all the taxpayers
everybody's paying for everybody we're
basically paying for people to sit at
home and sit on their backsides and do
nothing yeah
i had someone
it was funny i had this guy come up to
me
um on the street like asking me to
donate money and i told him i'm like i
don't believe in giving money
and it was
and he looked at me like i was crazy i'm
like i hire people why would i give you
money for doing nothing that doesn't
make any sense and the older i get when
i see people on the street doing nothing
i'm like if i was in that situation i
would take a sign i would put my resume
on the sign and i would hold it up and
say these are the things i could do i
guarantee someone on social media will
take a picture you'll have a job in a
day but like one time one time for a
youtube video i just wanted to see right
i wanted to see what would happen if i
went door-to-door looking for work in a
rich neighborhood that's that's who
hires i i wound it up on knocking on the
door of a ceo i got a call from a
recruiter a week later i didn't want a
job i was pursuing media i just wanted
to see and then in the comments the
first thing was like yeah that wouldn't
have that wouldn't like if you were
black like you couldn't do that if you
were this you couldn't do that i'm like
try it
it won't try it like people people are
so willing to help people that want to
be helped i think there was a young boy
on somewhere on social media and he
actually went around trying to clean
windows
and you see when everybody turned him
down and he just happened to go to this
last house and say can i clean your
windows
and i think the guy was a businessman
somebody well known on the internet
mm-hmm
and he just couldn't believe it he said
keep on doing and he actually gave the
butt and the boy was there with his
little dog or whatever he was cleaning
the windows i think he was about 13. and
he said keep on doing it but i think he
knocked on lots and lots of doors and he
just the last door he knocked and just
happened to be this man
and he said don't give up but nobody has
to work anymore
no there is there's so like i just feel
like there's so much opportunity around
us and you can just create something out
of nothing like one time i lived in
milwaukee i i just decided i wanted to
know more successful people i literally
called up companies called up their
executives and just said i i got to meet
the cio of um freaking we energies you
know that's an american but it's a
billion dollar company i got to meet the
cio i got to meet the cio of
harley-davidson and the cfo of
there's one more i don't remember but it
was like billion dollar companies i got
to meet these executives just by asking
like there are so few people that want
to like try
and not only that there's a lot of dumb
educated people out there as well so
it's not saying that you can go knock on
doors and see ceo but what are you going
to do if you kind of hold the
conversation with them
you know because there's a lot of women
out there and there they've got all
these degrees but they can't store a
sentence together yeah but you have to
practice
i worked in sales for two years and like
you get so much better at communicating
with people because you learn fast if
you're communicating badly because
people are so blunt
they they hang up on you they slam the
door in your face like
and so you get it's like
you don't get good at stuff unless you
practice it you have to be you have to
be bad to get good at things i was so
bad at youtube when i started but like
people don't want to be like people
don't want to take the ego hit to be bad
and then like you get good i'm sure you
weren't you said you're a bus driver
yeah i'm sure it took you a little bit
to get good at it
no that was a loser oh no she's just
i'm a fantastic
yes yeah but when it comes to driving i
was on those boards are you drivers yeah
i'm dying to get my hands on an hgv
that's been my dream
but i've got a psv license a coach
licensed bus license when did you start
doing that
my dad was a driver and i've always i've
been driving since
i was daddy's goal it was one of those
things where they bet on the child you
know you park a car and you said whose
daughter can move that car
and i was the one that could i was
always the one that could
so it was like you said tom boy i always
used to hang with the guys and fix the
cars if i had to phone everybody phone
the man and say oh my car's broken then
he'd hang up on me
because i'm not allowed to say my car's
broken down i need to tell you what's
wrong with my car and it needs to be
something that i can't physically fix
myself otherwise any of my male friends
they wouldn't answer me because it's
ridiculous yeah i can't call someone to
say i've got a flat tire
change how how long were you a bus
driver for
11 months
i was a bus driver for 11 months
supervisor 11 months and and manager for
11 months
so and then after 11 months after i left
oh okay so what did you do for most of
your career
i was a foster carer okay i was a foster
carer
i worked in the market then i was a bus
driver then i was a foster carer i was
supposed to get there as a bus driver
but i haven't had that many jobs because
it's really workers actually when i
stopped being when i stopped working for
transport
i realized i've never done a rom
oh what you call it when you go for a
job and you mm-hmm like you're what'd
you call a resume in cv that's it i
didn't know what it was
and i realized that i'd been in that job
for so long
and people were really amazed there they
said which mean you've never heard of it
i said well i've never had a job where
i've had to do one
and
never had to do a cv before because once
you're in that job for so long
you never but yeah my two main jobs were
fostering and transport
but and then i mixed the two together i
was
transporting disabled children which is
my dream job that was oh now my dream
job was actually i've got i went from
42k to like nine
and the nine was
more i walled in in the 42k the 42k was
just
you know like
21 i was i held a second record for 21
night shifts in a row wow
oh you think you still hold that record
no
maybe second yeah because i know there
was a guy called steve i think he had
like 28 days and i had 21.
what do you think of all these women
that are doing hot girl summers
let's just ask her about different
things on the show i just think to
myself
why
i mean
it's not what you do it's how you do it
what do you mean by that can you explain
that more because
all right then i could i can oh for
instance i can look at you and i can
smile at you and from the outside people
think i'm smiling at you i can say pearl
i'm going to kill you
you know but from the outside people are
looking like she's smiling
so
you could be having a hot girl somewhere
in
all these people are coming nobody knows
what you're doing
but when you go out there and you're on
the internet and you're parading
yourself or doing this hot curl or
something i'm thinking have you got no
shame
you know that's what i mean it's not
what you do is how you do it it's not
that
this hot girl summons a new thing it's
not a new thing it was going on before
me
and it must really continue but it's the
way they're doing it now
they're proud of it before it was
something that people knew about but you
didn't talk about that's not gonna say
it's gonna it catches it's gonna catch
up to you eventually people talk
but it wasn't something to be ashamed
about
it wasn't how you did it oh okay okay
but now it's just you don't think you
don't think you should be ashamed if
you're sleeping with a bunch of people
that depends on the bunch of people
don't
no i mean i can only say you can you can
you can be ashamed of it but
i think that
there's a type of this type of women and
men
that if you sleep around
those men have got your back they won't
have anybody say anything bad about you
because they respect you as a woman and
they just respect you which sounds
really weird if you're having a hot girl
summer but then you've got the little
tramps that are going out there and
they've just got these hot girls summer
and everybody's knocking it and nobody
really cares about them so they met
you'll find that the men will have
nothing nice to say about them
whereas years ago
there's lots of women out there that had
hot girl summers and
you know they're upright living citizens
now you wouldn't even know because
nobody's got a bad word to say about
them but nowadays you know people have
got a lot to say about these girls
because of
how they're doing it so it's not what
they're doing it's how they're doing it
and there's no shame there's no remorse
there's no
some of the women there's not even
washing afterwards you know
yeah
who do you think cheats more men are
women
i think men get cool animal
you think women cheat more
yeah
i think when menshi it's just like one
of the things when women cheat it's like
they know it's over so they're either
going to lie about it or it's going to
be over so they more tend to lie about
it
do you um
do you think
that women
should accept being physically cheated
on not emotionally
but like if a guy's sleeping around do
you think girls should accept
that i feel like if you if you've worked
out from the beginning
i think it's something that needs to be
spoken about okay because years ago they
had open relationships and if you had an
open relationship it was fine you know
nobody got hurt was it open on both
sides or just like guys both sides okay
you gotta have it open on both sides and
then then it would be okay once you know
and i think that sometimes people start
off things and they change the rules and
i'm really against changing walls
halfway through
whether it's the women that say oh yeah
it's fine we're just going to have sex
and it's not going to matter and then
they as i said they catch feelings you
know and next thing you know they
they're stalking the man or they're
following him to wherever you're going
why are you changing the rules
that is not what you agreed to stick
with yeah
and so
but you think girls kind of try to do
that to trap the guy in a way like make
him feel because guys i think naturally
have such empathy towards women they
need to stop it
okay they need to stop don't have no
empathy for women having perfect for
yourself do you think men are straight
up with what they want or do you think
they lie in order to get sex
i think men are even lighter they don't
need to lie to have sex they could just
say i want to have sex and if it's the
right guy they just have it and if they
if they and the thing is every men are
lying to have sex women know they're
lying they just want to be easy and just
want the men to like you know just go
for this performance you know you're
going to give it to him in the end why
are you going to keep on saying no when
the end result is going to be yes just
say yes in the beginning
wait two for to sexy me yeah they make
men run all through these hoops for a
reason because they know they're gonna
say yes you watch every man let after
women let these men run all for their
hopes that their last hurdle the man
says now forget about it they'd be
crushed but that's what they do to the
men they let them run all through these
hoops
when there's no need because they're
gonna say yes otherwise why would you
let them go for these soups just say no
in the beginning so question you don't
think that
like to they should get to know the guy
though first like isn't that i just want
sex now oh if you just want sex okay
yeah and most of the time the men that
want to get to know the women they just
want to have sex they don't care what
your name is don't know you look like
you know i know but i'm saying like like
i would never advise girls to sleep with
a guy right away because you want to
like get to know him first see if he's a
good guy you don't think so then that
nobody'd be having sex then would they
nobody okay so how should how should
dating work how would you how would you
do it so if a girl likes a guy she
should just have sex with him
i personally think that
if i live my life again
i think i'll do the same thing all over
again
i think my i think most i must be the
oldest virgin going
i'll either be one way and i'll be
completely the same
or i'll be the oldest virgin going
because i think that being a virgin is
more powerful because everybody's after
you but you know you're not freeing it
up
and i think there's a power in your
virginity
and a lot of women don't don't realize
that yeah
because they think oh yeah you know
power's in between my legs here it is
until you're giving it away then you've
lost all your power mm-hmm
dang that's the opposite thing that
feminist feminism teaches that the power
is between your legs you hold the power
you hold the power they don't talk about
how my mother
that's why god hid it away hmm
put it outside on the men's and they
make them free up and with the women
they hid it away so somebody specialized
to find it wow
yeah that's not powerful you give it to
everybody
take me back so that's not powerful if
you give it to everybody yeah
it's not
but i just think personally i i would
just say like don't have sex
don't have sex at all
well tell your until you're married
yeah do you think there's a certain age
where virginity doesn't really matter
anymore
like like because okay
if i if i meet a girl that's a 30 year
old virgin i think the virginity
isn't as valuable because she's old and
virginity goes with youth
i just think all she needs is a 30 year
old virgin male 1
a 30 year old but virginity isn't the
same for men and for women i think i
think when you find somebody's 30
and they're a virgin religion most
really have something to do with it so
you vote
okay i understand it's very rare to find
somebody who's a virgin that's not
religious
yeah that's true that's there has to be
something to do with religion if it's
not what's wrong with you yeah no i
guess you know that's what you'd be
thinking everything's not for religious
reasons well i've never heard of anybody
being a virgin for unless it's for
religious reasons that's okay so
i've had this conversation with um
donovan and i said like what's up i keep
hearing that like virgins over the age
of 25 are crazy
and
and like something's off with them um he
he said that it's because they're lying
and i was like that's possible but some
of them i actually do believe
but something i could tell is off with
them it's just built up frustration
no that's what it is
i wouldn't say they're lying or
something i would just say
come on you've been out there and you
you want to stick to your morals and
there's all these sexy men out there and
all your lines are going and all your
juices are going but you're determined
to stick with it of course you're gonna
act off because you're sexually
frustrated
you're gonna have a cold shower that's
why sex ties are in such demand nowadays
because a lot of people say they're
virgins but they've got a whole
ammunition in their drawer in the
bedroom
so they might say they're versions but
virginia is the who
well they say this is the machinery yeah
they're celebrating um celibate yeah you
know that when people say they're
celibate another
part that comes with celibacy is
sustaining from marriage my brother told
told me that wait like in the in the
definition he
was watching a video and he was saying
when you say your celibate you're not
only sustaining from sex but you're also
sustaining from marriage and so people
don't realize when they say oh i'm
celibate i'm celibate if they desire to
get married they're abstaining from that
and it's
essentially
and not only that there was um a weird
trend going around some places still
going around where
can i say this women are virgins
by generally but not annually
so as far as they're concerned they're
still virgins
oh okay
just say nothing just says i'm sorry i
was
i was trying to because i i saw that
ish's face sort of went like i'll go get
him
oh this went
oh no we were because we were waiting
for a call for the apartment and so we
thought that that was the car we were
like
but yeah so when women say that
sometimes you have to ask yourself where
yeah exactly
i had a i had a friend who
was a virgin but
if
if she had a body count from the amount
of stuff other stuff she did and it
wasn't intercourse oh she'd have a full
graveyard yeah so you know
sometimes you need to find out what kind
of virgin is she yeah exactly because
version
i decided to go into church and he came
to church with me
and went for the whole you know he had
to do these classes or whatever and then
at the end of it we split up but he said
i can't argue with god and that was it
so it wasn't i went in there looking for
a man i had a man and i decided i just
need time out and and that was it
mad
but he understood
because he was kind of religious because
you know when you got religious he kind
of understood he just said i can't argue
with god mm-hmm
hey and then a few days later i realized
it was like a rubbish and i just come
out of it
hey you learned some things what would
advice would you give
women today if they desire to get
married
keep on desiring it and work your way to
it
but don't
have it in your mind 20 don't you know
live sleep eat drink marriage
don't do it live your life if it happens
it's going to happen
and if it don't happen it it doesn't
happen
but don't
i want to get married do this i want to
get married i want to get married i want
to get married some women go out there
and that's what they think about and
it's not putting men mostly men want to
go out there and see somebody having a
i would say that
my man doesn't make me happy because i
was happy before i met him he makes me
happy yeah
so without him i'll still be happy yeah
you know i'm content without him he
makes me more content yeah so i'm not
looking forward to somebody to make me
happy
good people hello
hello hello hello
oh hello
how are you guys doing yes
oh now
how was the driver
is she in i don't think she's in i said
she's in she goes how was the drive
okay
sit down take a seat take a seat yes
we have some new guests
we have some
you can where you guys travel from
whales talking to you did you come to
come on the show uh yes so oh shut up
me coming from coventry
yeah so uh yeah
uh philly do you guys know where cardiff
is oh yes just norfolk okay the second
biggest castle i think in the world
they're called philly castle
oh my gosh
i'm a cheese fan
philly cheese meant to be the best in
the world without obviously that's
subjective
cheesesteak
wow i can't believe you wow
how's that i'm so
oh excited
thank you yes
we bought a camera down fish
wow
[Music]
me and let's run our own charity and we
said in the first show some of this so
we can't really spend on supercharged i
said well we'll go down there
oh
[Laughter]
far was the drive for you guys three
hours oh freedom
and the blistering
yeah
and it was actually a really good
journey down until the m25 and there was
a crash on there so we had about 10
minutes 20 minutes oh my god it's 12
that for about 20 minutes oh goodness
we we homeschool so we have a
three-year-old with us he's in the park
at the moment
and everything with him
we were going to go to the town but then
i was like so hot because we came here
first to make sure we knew where we were
okay and we can get you on time
and then we just decided to just go back
to the asdas and just go to the parks
and everything around us yeah lovely
walking around yeah we'll take them to
cardiff during the week or something so
you'll be all right
that's so great why did you do this
today
it was when i hit 250k
it was uh yeah i did see your instagram
story
yeah it was
and also we have um two producers and
they were both free today last time ish
tried to go the full 24 hours it didn't
go well it didn't go well for any of us
to be fair
he's struggling right now we're gonna do
the full 24 hours now are you swapping
out me and jess are the soldiers of the
team yeah
but we don't watch the show
yes
i have a feeling jess is going to do
better than me um i think i do worse
sleep deprived
i think i'll be able to make it i think
i might fall asleep for an hour
it's okay yeah i think i can me in the
chat you should stay up a little bit
chat
i did i had a little karaoke moment at
the end oh fun we could definitely do
karaoke that's what we meant
i had to give the business up in the end
because it was just so it was so much
and getting people you'll know us like
having people work for you that just
know what they saw and i just kept
finding them for oh no
you know it's me i'm just finding all
these people it's just cute
and uh in the in the end i didn't bother
the business i said family and did other
things we wouldn't took took different
avenues which we talked about but uh
karaoke's
is there a big cultural difference
between england and wales um i i'd say
big in some areas but not so big another
so generally i'd say it wasn't much of a
difference but like when it comes to
things like sports rugby you know um of
course we have different cultures we
have stedford cheese and all the little
things england have their own songs so i
was thinking like more in terms of like
dating and relationships is it similar
to england
i'd say yeah it's pretty much exactly
the same most throughout the uk i've
seen i haven't seen a big difference but
then
i haven't been over this end that much
except for my military experience i was
in the army for like eight years so and
i did all my training from older shots
so
um so i just got around that area there
i don't know i find it slightly
different in scotland the ladies were
much easier in scotland when i was
younger that's all i'll tell you
nothing's changed
when i was younger scotland was a lot
easier than everywhere else
wow just uh just that just started i
haven't seen anything else no not really
how how old are you guys well i'm 41 42
this year
35. i'm a dinosaur so there's a eight
year difference
you don't look at day over 51 we're
talking about it
you look good auntie
wow
[Applause]
do you feel like uh relationships are
different from when you guys started
dating
i don't know it'd be hard for us to
really give an actual answer i don't
know about relationships
if we go by what we've learned from this
show yeah then yes
um i would definitely say 100
i am not
the general population i'm not the norm
i'm a vet i i think has something to the
fact i'm autistic so
yeah a lot different yeah
yeah so uh i have uh and i feel i wasn't
very well educated grown up and um
i would say that uh my entire school
life uh
you'd say bullied but i was the extreme
case of bullying in class so um don't
know if it had anything to do with the
fact i was different to the kids
and back in the 80s we weren't called
autistics we were called idiots so
that's just the way that's just the way
i grew up unfortunately and i mean there
are many people in my shoes they'll go i
know you're talking about
my wherever i had ticks growing up um my
parents didn't see us ticks they saw his
habits and when they grew up with those
with this kind of
well this kind of learning difficulty
they were bullied so my parents didn't
want that happen to me but it did anyway
because it was just one of them things
they were fighting something they didn't
understand they should have been
frightened of love as we know today but
back then it was fighting a bit more
fear so okay
but
you can see what they did was for love
they didn't want me to be bullied for
school they wanted me to you know
obviously go in with theme with this
show they wanted me to get a girl at
some point
[Laughter]
not much of a brag but this is number
three so yeah
uh on um wait what's number three isn't
she my third serious relationship
um in my in my oh i thought you meant
like you got three wives i was like oh
no
you decided to bring number three
i'm not saying something i'm against but
certainly something i couldn't keep up
with
no how do you know about that you want a
sister wife
oh maybe maybe
she's open i'm a lot more open
unless it's very open
how long have you guys been together i'm
11 years old together 11 years married
seven you're gone seven like over there
wow okay yeah
i would only wear wedding rings i mean i
told my wedding ring after six months i
can't wait
because i
wanted wow because at first there was a
little thing for her because all the
females in her family are like well he's
not gonna get his wedding ring on you
know that kind of thing and i was like
well i
has nothing to do with anything i
literally bought these rings i mean i
wouldn't have got married at all you
wouldn't have got a marriage from me at
all um it was something that she always
wanted to be married i don't see it um i
never
my parents got married but it wasn't i
wasn't raised a big thing you had to be
married to have children and everything
like that it was only when i started
going up and rowing
way before i watched the show that i
started seeing the other side of
marriage for a lot of women um which was
obviously that
um
we we say contract and we the contract
for the relationship but
i also see for another part of you you
look at it as a contract but then you've
got like uh
you talking about
stability things like that you know um
security that kind of thing so um i mean
okay then i'll marry you
i wasn't gonna let her get away anyway
she's a fox compared to all the other
girls
that's what we want we want yeah we want
to not
all the x's can't compare yeah
she's the
i'm very lucky as well because um from
what i've heard of her exes and scene of
her exes she can't they can't compare to
me this i'm very lucky
i mean i i don't know what let's accept
every individual but uh person i am to
the person
but we haven't got really high quality
men where we're from we come from the
valleys
anybody's high quality moves away from
the valleys
so that is the difference are the women
high quality
oh no
well i mean you get i don't know
how did people watch it
is a good uh 70 30 from a subjective
experience where i'm from 75 70 holes
30. oh okay okay so so if the guys want
to know where the hose is out they go to
wales kai filthy it's called kai filthy
foreign
so
philly is the name but kai filthy is
what we call it there you go just to add
a bit of context there's an actual tv
show called the valleys
and they are notoriously known
for
hooking up culture
wow it's very entertaining very exciting
um yeah
victor the welsh when you when you go to
culture culture
there's some differences like i said but
yeah i don't know i don't i don't see it
in a dating game it's just it's like
everything else in the the uk
they class themselves as uk only
only time i have you anybody go on about
whether the welsh english is rugby time
so during six nation season you know
rugby yes rugby match that's okay i'm
just asking because of the american
thing that's uh i know i know right now
oh i know the sport yeah the sport right
i don't watch it i mean yeah yeah why i
mean do you not watch american football
no
within the culture
so you said there wasn't much
differences but from what i kind of
gathered because
yeah yeah so what i from what i know um
when speaking to like people from wales
the mentality
of like the village mindset is a big
thing within the welsh culture so not
everyone but like predominantly a lot of
people that are still in wales
tend to have
the mentality that they want to stay
in wales they don't really want to meet
yeah i i guess it's like that it's
simply anyway but i'll explain it like
this in wales
the difference i'd see is that we have
like you said valleys
at the bottom of the valleys you can
have the city but as the mountains come
up and taller you can the values get
higher and higher so you go from use
which is where philly's a big new valley
a nice big town in there and filled up
the valleys
so you find the villages on the sides
and you're surrounded by beautiful
spirits and everywhere you go foreign
if you live in beauty in paradise you go
other places
like because if you're going to the
theme park or the zoo or something like
that you know you go to somewhere to see
the culture and everything like that so
you don't really want to go away from
there and i suppose that can be similar
with the dating game the closer you are
to the city
the more host you're going to get and
the more um the more opportunities
you're going to get but more up the
valley is more a little bit traditional
now and more cap because
there's only a small there's small
villages with not many compared to
cities but then again
like everywhere else you have the areas
which are built up on say council
estates which
gonna be less with discipline less with
um they're gonna have less
oh how should i say it
i know we talk about all the time so go
down there there's less parents showing
um guidance and showing you know this is
what it should be like so um
it gets a little different you know the
people it i said i see that everywhere i
go i've lived in a few different places
from canada to germany to england to
wales you know i've even done tours in
kosovo and things like that and i see
similarities and things now the
difference to me and most people is uh
my mind is more mathematical so i i see
patterns and things and i go
through
through different things like that
the text-wise as you'll notice on this
i've done very well so far
but i think i i i um i could stutter a
lot um i i can hold my breath on a word
you see that kind of thing just
significantly that's it
when i get anxious yeah i stutter yeah i
had a moment earlier
i was annoyed at the last yeah video and
i said no when you hear that i was
stuttering or forget my words or
say
stupid words and in in said the words i
want to say
i have those well actually was that
what do you think about this red pill
red pill well i never knew about it so
well in the last four weeks i've never
heard of this red pill blue pill well
for me i i've managed them the last
six years to go down many rabbit holes
and each of them have their own red pill
so i'm i'm awfully referring to the red
pill marriages and things that you have
their relationships yeah yeah and um
and can i just confirm this wouldn't
tell me red pill you want are you
talking about more the wife that's
submissive to their partner and things
like that and what we kind of have that
relationship i mean alyssa i mean alyssa
is very submissive to myself in other
words she lets me lead i don't always
like it because i can be very feminine
at times with the autism i just can't
yeah i'm mostly masculine but i've very
touched my feminine side due to
traumas growing up
so that was just one of the things you
you go through a traumatic life growing
up you'll be more there's more feminine
approach to you you know more teachers
coming because the other kids aren't
playing view your mum everybody is more
the females that were more he's been
bullied does help him but the males
don't leave him alone so i grew up with
a very feminine attachment did i join
the military and then they they they
beasted the the the masculine into me a
bit they brought it up a little bit yeah
and then when i came out of that i was
still making mistakes um didn't really
fully understand the difference in me
from my masculine feminine powers so i
watch the show and when i hear people
talk about men and women you see me at
home i'm like
you mean feminine-led people not men
a lot of the time i hear things about
and it's all and it's men of this amen
and women in both ways and i think why
to me there's just narcissistic women
and narcissistic men who are led by a
feminine power in them that make these
feminine choices there's no anything
else the difference between most people
is i don't understand good and evil i
don't think it exists i think you're all
being tricked by it
good and evil don't exist to me i don't
i don't know where they are i keep
asking people this i say what is evil
and they'll give me everything they can
give it and i say i tell you what evil
is evil is a fictional thing a stop gap
because you're too lazy to go back and
find out what the problem was you say
that's evil to solve a solution and good
and that's what everybody seems to do
and no matter what danny shine he's um
he's a free thinker going around london
doing um stuff you haven't seen any
great stuff he does and
i've asked him the same question and
he's been there for years doing it and
he's
no i don't know why evil is because i
said to him i said look anything you
class as evil
because it's such a subjective term
it's normally that you're seeing the
effects of illness
quick question then yes if i murder
someone out cold blood what does that
mean call blood
i have no thoughts yeah there was no
thought behind it i've decided to
stab someone
would you say if you did that you had
empathy
i think
anyone could have empathy not in that
moment did you have empathy for the
person you were stabbing
or i i i
i've never been no but i'm sorry
we think hypothetically yeah i mean in
the hypothetical in the happening are
you lacking empathy when you do this i'd
say yes i was lacking empathy i'd say
real then
you'd say evil not ill
you're lacking if you're lacking a
function that you you would normally
have to prevent you from doing it then
that's illness correct yes yeah i agree
so then i'd say you're ill no evil
what did he do
what did you do
okay so i'm saying i mad at someone
that's not confession um because i told
him that there's no such thing as evil
it doesn't exist
it literally does not exist because
these problems was that you feel like
grape women and kids ill
and that's evil
yeah i know you would see evil yeah but
what was the difference between our
answers
i say they're ill you say the evil
what's the difference what's the
difference because he's saying if
there's something missing
so someone who doesn't have their full
their full
if someone's out on the streets doing
something walking around shouting
screaming
because they didn't have everything
wrong
would you say they were evil or ill
you'd say they're ill or whatever you'd
say i'd say they know the right and the
wrong thing to do and they choose wrong
i think most people are like aware of
what they're doing they just like choose
to do the wrong thing again i think
there are times in my life where i've
wanted to kill somebody and i was like
you know what i should not like that
whale the other day
like
and i was like you know what i shouldn't
what allowed you to do that what did you
have that allowed you to do that
allowed me to do that um what i say to
people normally this is how i do it yeah
if my three-year-old was here and it was
okay for you to yeah you know i'm going
to exchange okay for you to stop this
three-year-old now no problem you won't
go to jail nothing you can just do it
would you do it
wait say it again if you allowed to
without any rep
repercussions repercussions just stab a
three-year-old in the throat right here
right now my little three-year-old would
you do if you was allowed to no
why
because that's gross why is it gross why
is it gross because i like kids they're
cute so that's it because if you didn't
think kids could you'd be okay to stab
him
no no it's wrong it's wrong why is it
wrong
because
why is it wrong
for me i would say it's mostly because i
have empathy which i wouldn't want
someone to stop me or anybody else and i
can think of that
but if i couldn't think like that
what would be stopping me what if i
think it's like a choice
i think you either look like the thing
that allows me to make a choice
missing i think i think you choose to
think like that or you choose not to
like i could think one way all right and
i have a question for you then if
someone has a mental breakdown in asda's
and really hurt somebody are they evil
are they ill
evil so an autistic person i know men
have a breakdown you would say that's an
evil child not an ill child an autistic
person i mean because i i have autistic
family members they don't do that it's
still like something it's still a choice
i have autistic okay so the question
then is do you say no autistics do that
no so the autistics that do do it are
they evil
yes
i wouldn't say that because i have um i
have a cousin
who
is autistic and
he's been severely autistic
his whole life
and when my family was being they were
telling me about a time where
he
um
he like almost severely
injured the person that's taking care of
him his aunt
and i wouldn't say that they're evil
because they don't
understand the concept of good and there
are some that understand the concept i
would say of good and evil or of good
decision and bad decisions there's some
autistic people that do understand
yes i would say yes there and i just
choose not to do it anyway i don't know
about choosing not to do it because i
know they understand and choose not like
not to hurt anybody
but it's the same as everything else as
far as i'm concerned anybody that can
hurt someone else in any way grape
any form
is missing something i would say that
was an unhealthy human being not a
healthy human being i just i just think
that by what you're saying you're taking
away accountability oh no no
accountability is i got something on
nominations i think that evil people are
extremely rare hurt people i'd say out
of all the people that
normal people classed as evil
according to him
which i agree with because we're we're
thinking logically now
i think
less than two percent are evil
he said no none are evil and i would say
of the hundred percent of people that
normal people class as evil
i'd say 98 have got something missing
like the missing link they don't
understand and i think it's very rare to
get genuine
evil people they're out there but i
think can that's a question why do we
even think they're there at all yeah
because i think that there's some
exceptions to the rule and i think
there's exceptions to every rule would
would we say those people
are there i agree with those exceptions
but in past we've used them for things
and we call them psychopaths
we call them psychopaths there's nothing
wrong they are generally born with
missing components yeah and we've used
them in the past for wars and things
like that you know
they've been a massive part of our
society for a long long long long time
in fact i think i watched something the
other day of so uh on
i was after your show actually uh it was
uh something we watched about somebody
who was saying about um
you know a doctor doing tests for
psychopaths he found one he was him
been living with his family and every
entire life didn't know he's a
psychopath because they can just fit
into society quite easily it's only when
something extreme happens
mostly to have narcissism
that's another question with a good and
evil okay okay i'll give you one okay so
there's that doctor that like was
graping those girls during childbirth
did you guys see that yeah i think
that's a guy who knew what he i think he
knew what he was doing but he wanted
something and didn't care i bet he knew
it was wrong but he knew they would be
hurt and he didn't care because he won't
he wanted he cared about himself more
than the other person oh yeah of course
but i still see that as illness so you
know i would say that's evil because i
would say you're putting yourself above
like that's selfish yeah but for me yeah
everything that there's something that's
happening for them to do that so you
don't think there's any case where
someone is not ill they're just evil
uh uh none no because they're not evil
hitler very very ill very very well and
the amount of drugs he took and and i
wouldn't say he was alone so when people
talk about hitler's like he was the one
man running all and he didn't have
generals and italians and i mean it's
like saying that biden's running the
whole show by himself right now i would
never say hitler did it all but i can
understand what people go to there
the way they want to go to the hitler
thing and i'm like
i don't know i could use ted bundy as
another
yeah i get him i've looked at ted bundy
and i would look at the man i'd say
completely ill i mean these actions were
not healthy unhealthy actions are only
performed by anything
healthy
as in what is healthy
yeah what is a healthy action oh healthy
action so um something that uh well
obviously it doesn't take away life away
from someone else um it's what do the
how do you definitely
so homosexuals is more
um health for me
so um just being in balance with
yourself so
i'm trying to think of in this
context healthy in this context so um
do you want to others as others who do
unto you would be a a very healthy
statement i would say um even though
that's a quit well i wouldn't say it's
christian it's uh one christian
statement yeah i just think if you're
going to argue that like you have to
have very precise definitions of like
what is healthy what is good and what is
evil oh yeah definitely i can put down
healthy but i wouldn't put one statement
done as healthy healthy is you know the
healthier questions the full statement i
would say healthy in this state is that
your mind has all the components needed
for you not to perform these acts so by
this um do you not do you believe in the
death penalty
i don't believe in crime at all i
believe in some sort of rehabilitation
and things like that but not the way
it's done today oh no i ain't living
next to them oh no no no no no no again
rehabilitation rehabilitation doesn't
mean you
it doesn't mean live next to him though
does it rehabilitation it means that
finding somebody who's in a bad
situation
if my kid if my child ended up ill yeah
like this ended up doing something to a
child and i knew the reason until but
somebody was guessing kill that kid i'm
like oh well i can understand i can i
can't i can sit there and i can
understand and sympathize and say no i
get it
i can understand you because when it
comes to um one situation that pops into
my head is um
mr robert
uh r kelly he's a artist in the states
and um
like i don't i don't condone anything
that he did with those girls but
when i was sitting there listening to
all of the stuff and him talk about what
he went through when he was a kid and
how
he
never was able to process through that
and then he comes up and he becomes this
big artist and he's sitting down with
his family
and he has a poster of him on the back
of his door and he tells his brothers
and his cousins like he points at it he
says that man is a dangerous man and
they're looking at him like that's you
he's like no i'm robert that's r kelly
and
i can understand if someone doesn't
have the chance to heal from something
that happened to them as a child because
what happened to him was very traumatic
and like i said i'm not condoning
anything he did no no that's just
success i it's just hard to
i just think sorry finish like no i just
ain't it's it's hard to
see someone hurting like that and just
see like
the steps that
it could have been fixed here it could
have been dealt with here he could have
healed here and
if stuff still have happened okay but
just
this area wasn't healed so it just
started it grow and different and
manifested but it does it doesn't mean
it's done in my life
use stories i don't normally tell people
now the one thing i'll say to the story
uh ladies
it can be a tearjerker it's not gonna be
long but once they say the story is is
from memory
now if i want to say this is hundred
percent i have to go back so i was three
years old and have a hundred percent
memory so i can't but still even to
today these memories come with emotions
and everything of like having you know
what a coat hanger is yeah so coat dang
it putting into my back of my t-shirt
and then hung up on the rim of the door
now obviously so it's this is
around there i'm being made to tell my
stepdad i loved him because i raised my
stepdad
um
now this happened to me it's free as
well as many other things and things i
think i remember from dreams memories
and things like that there's no point
saying it definitely did happen just in
case a little kid i made
i don't think i did
i've always had those memories my entire
life and there are others who
were privy to it at the time i said you
know we don't talk about those times
count on stuff like that so i've gone
through a lot
and then it was only in my later years
when i became mature
i saw a lot of other people talking
about stuff so no adult nobody in my
life even from a military career did not
help me see
the flaws that were going on in my life
the things i was doing that were
narcissistical the ill-minded and
everything only later on i seen him
because my parents highly narcissistical
they grew up narcissistic parents and
hers is exactly the same
and so we went through a life of just
not seeing it blind
you see narcissistic parents yes
so what do you mean by like nazis cause
then they use my emotions to control me
yeah okay
so as a child it was do what you say or
you know whatever anything like that
children should be you know they'll do
something and tell me i'm not allowed to
do that in the room and stuff like that
so real you know smoking and you don't
know that smoking in a room and said why
are you smoking around your child you've
got a child you shouldn't be doing that
if you've got a child you're gonna now
there's lots of things like that not
just my parents that was everyone grew
up to we grew up in a mining village so
you can probably imagine i wouldn't say
backwards but just a little bit behind
the rest of everybody they were only a
small amount caught up now
but that was it the other thing tone of
narcissism does everybody nothing is a
narcissistical thing to believe in good
and evil to believe that because if
someone is evil they're below you right
but if you believe someone is below you
then you've got no one you haven't got
unconditional love because that's a
condition you place on it and people
believe in unconditional love i do i do
um unconditional love is i just think it
frees you up do you believe in
appreciation he's a person you you
believe in unconditional yeah i love
everybody
do you know how to get unconditional
love you have to get rid of good and
evil from your mind i don't speak so i
love them from a distance can i ask you
questions
to keep away from me if you believe in
good and evil
can you have an answer i'm sorry like
yeah don't don't over talk me oh
respectively you know it's okay it's
okay
um but wait what why do you believe in
unconditional love because it's worked
for me so what do you mean by that like
what does that mean i love someone and
they hurt me it's not i don't let
anybody else's behavior affect mine
so if you're horrible towards me that's
not my problem i will still love you
that is your problem i'm not taking it
on
so i will go i i would like like for
instance
i believe everything people will tell me
if you lie
i won't believe anything you tell me
right and people think i'm stupid in the
wrong place for believing everything
people tell me but that's just the way i
am
because i don't lie and i don't expect
anybody else to die so if you lie to me
it's your it's your problem it's not
mine and if i love you and you're
horrible to me it's not my fault that
you can't appreciate love that's down to
you so yeah but the
i just feel like all love comes with
conditions not mine like like i feel
like if like you're not going to love a
homeless person on the street you don't
know them i do i don't sorry what does
love mean to you then i go out and i if
i got like if i've got dinner at home
and i've got too much i will pack it in
my car and i'll go and i'll find
homeless people to give it to mm-hmm
i'll actually go and find them because
we have it's not it's not my it's not my
fault
if i love you and you don't love me
you've got issues
i'm not the one with issues you're the
one with issues because you don't know
how to accept love you don't know how to
appreciate that but if i don't know
someone why would it like
oh that sounds like you're a problem
yeah but if i love you and you don't
love me you have to defense okay what do
you mean by love
not in love with you i care about you i
want to see you do well that's my view
of i want to make sure that you you know
make sure that you're healthy that
you're well fed and i'm like that with
everyone mm-hmm and if people if people
don't accept it they've got issues not
me but i'm saying like
if you if you pass homeless people on
the street you can't care and help every
single one i will
every single one of them
doesn't mean i have to give them stuff
yeah it's like because i'm a homeless
person and and i said [__] he was
begging i said um
you got some water
he looked in the car and he goes i'm
disabled i said there's my bed so am i
and because i've got like brightly
colored crutches
he said can i swap your crutch for mine
that's what you mean he said but mine's
a government one mine's you know the
police gave me my one yours is lovely
and blue can i have your one
you know what i love you enough to tell
you your crutch will work as good as my
one see you later
you know but i didn't have anything
against him if he wanted to drink i want
to give him i will love you enough to
give you food i would love you enough to
give you advice i would love you enough
to know that if i give you your money
you might go and take drugs with it i
would love you enough to give you my
money yeah i just like to be that
doesn't sound real like i don't think
you can love every single person on the
planet like that that sounds like like
it's just something you say
i actually do i actually do love i don't
even know how i would define it but like
i love is like what i have with my
family and my parents and maybe like
yeah for me love is treating you how i'd
like to be treated myself
i'd like to be feeling about myself if
that was you'd say love then i guess
like yeah yeah that's like that's how i
i was that's just not how i define like
treating someone how you want to be
treated i feel like that's just basic
decency you know for me this is crazy
you all got different subjective visions
of love to me love is just acceptance
and appreciation those two things
together makes love nothing else i don't
know anything else makes love anything
anybody adds to that i'm like
well you can mix a love potion any way
you want but the love potions have two
basic ingredients acceptance and
appreciation if you can accept everyone
you meet and appreciate everyone you
meet then you love everyone so would you
say you and it's just a question for the
men would you say that is something
that's just it for men it's just
acceptance and appreciation i don't know
what you have to ask issues opinions for
me love is just if you accept someone
and appreciate them that's love like for
someone to give you
to give
but again if you put a high bar
aren't isn't that your problem most of
the women today is they're setting these
high bars of love and they can't and
they won't lower it
it's unrealistic it's unrealistic to say
like that i love my mom the same way i
love the homeless person on the street
yeah that's what i'm saying if you've
you can build a cocktail of love so if
your unconditional love is these two
things appreciation and acceptance and
then you can add things to this cocktail
you can keep adding things it's like i
hear someone say about something
self-esteem isn't real i'm like ah but
to me self-esteem is real it's just like
love it's a potion not one thing love to
me isn't one thing to me it seems silly
otherwise what is it someone have to
tell me what it was but if you potion
things together like a love potion
that's what it is but to start for me
and might not be for everybody else but
i think anybody i've ever spoken to have
always said oh yeah this is involved in
love
and everybody's objective reality of
love that doesn't seem to differ is that
you have acceptance and appreciation
everybody else seems to have different
sort of like different because when you
said that
i think i'd love to homeless person just
like my mother my sister my sister would
tell you i want you and the only person
i'll cheat different is the person i am
in love with other than that everybody
gets treated the same no i go up hills
my mother my father i would treat a
homeless person
i wouldn't treat my mom any different
than i treat you mm-hmm i wouldn't might
treat my mom any different than i'll
treat my my family that's that's that's
my limit everybody gets treated the same
except for my man because i'm in love
with him but everybody else
i wouldn't cheat my i think if i saw
no i would treat my i would treat a
homeless person the same as i treat my
family yeah i can ask you a question
i just i just think it's unrealistic to
say you treat every single person the
same ever like i think based on how much
you like people you treat them
differently and maybe it's not like
conscious but if i took a survey of
everyone around you
like you really think every single
person would say you treat them exactly
the same yeah
yeah maybe i just now i'm just it just
doesn't sound like like because to me
i'm like i treat people like you don't
get special treatment
i can
it's just
a love you have for
people love you have for people so
it doesn't go on if you know them or if
you don't know them you're going to
approach them with the love that you
know you have in your heart because you
want them to experience what you have
and if they don't accept it you go about
your day but if they do accept it that's
something that they can take with them
that love they may not have had it that
day and they're like man that woman
touched me or man that man touched me
just from them interacting with me in
the
in that way that they have like wow that
was different and i can understand that
because that's how that's how my mom is
growing up
you might think it was that when i came
in i bought all the snacks and
everything like that no that was so
sweet yeah it's not sweet that's just
the way i am because wherever i go i
will have it you're the second drop-off
i've got more in my car
are you where are you going later that's
just what i am going to cook for i
already dropped off from my dad i got a
present in the car for you actually you
know someone you meet on the street
would would you give an organ to him
would i give an organ if he was in
hospital and somebody on the street
needed your organs don't give nobody my
organ son mother you wouldn't give a
family no one it's all mine would you
give blood
i can't but if i could i would but i
can't all right and i'll make this
simpler for yourself though because you
have different morals to the people
obviously not giving any parts with me
which is great i think i'm the same
actually
but if you
if it was life or death for your son you
wouldn't give a kidney you know no no
all right if
reason why
because it's not actually thinking that
because this is
i've only got one son yeah and i was
treating the same as anybody else you
know i mean you gotta die you gotta die
yeah yeah i will say but i will bury you
husband but you in love with him that's
different that's different
is that a different love to the homeless
man then no because i said i'm in love
with him
right into it i love everybody i got i
think i know he's saying it would still
be a different love for me
to save his life to save my life
everybody else can drop dead what if you
had one thing that you could give either
homeless person or your son
which one would you give it to
whoever needed it the most they both
needed the same or they'll die but they
both got a diet i can't choose oh my god
i'd be so insulted if my mom gave better
kidneys
you gave birth to me
you wouldn't expect any different
because like i said i raised a man not a
boy
okay um evil is allow someone to wait
actually i'm gonna pull up on my laptop
because i think i can pull up more that
way
after this have you guys heard of the
different types of love like the greek
words for
love
no no okay i'll explain it i don't know
i know a few of them but i'll explain it
after we read some soups also also guys
sign up for our memberships we're trying
to we're trying to get a thousand
members we're trying to get a thousand
members in here so make sure you sign up
for like the video too like the video
subscribe to the channel um i think
we're on subscribers only mode so you
only have to be subscribed for like five
minutes so you can
hit that subscribe button yeah i'm so
tired of y'all ninja watchers and i know
they said i shouldn't say ninja watchers
anymore right it's like a bad word on
tick tock they know what i'm saying on
youtube yeah on youtube i think it's
fine on tic tac it's just a thing they
put like the ninja when they're typing
out something for it to represent
something else but i think on youtube
they know what you mean she did she did
come in the room catch me watching pill
show and she pick up controller and
there's no light on it she's go
tell her she's my bee fishing
tell them let them know
you'll understand i'm the man and she's
lucky she's you're in the room to think
about um that's your problem you've got
mail watchers are like like buttons
what's she talking about
thumbs up thumbs up
babe
okay i'm gonna read these real quick
okay matt matt butcher i love auntie but
if you love everyone it has no worth hi
all evil is allowing someone with
illness to act in a way that you know it
will hurt themselves and other than
other than other when it is in your
control stop like the cop with the
grooming gangs lawrence bullock there's
nothing you can say that can convince me
that meghan markle isn't evil
[Laughter]
she's in the two percent
90 free to pay without god rules laws
are suggestions 90 free topi evils when
you choose to do something wrong
knowingly
that's a decent um peter sage can i join
you and discuss the uk family court my
support group 100k fathers now urges
fathers to avoid court what a disaster
for our children yeah if you're in the
uk um dm eddie um
hubert costellos um love the content i
keep it up with the amazing videos
therese kind men are taught to be men
women are taught to act like a lady
these women of today are ruining the
grace women used to have alistar horton
if you start a cooking show who will
judge ish
yes ma'am
get it we'll get a group of men yeah
we'll get we'll eat we'll get some men
and then every week it'll be like it'll
be like
whoever wins can go on the date
yes
carbon carbon mike hello from
fundamentalist society in new york city
you've built a great resource with your
channel oh a hundred dollars super chat
thank you um
you're challenging the received wisdom
on a lot of important issues give us a
shout we'd love to talk to you on our
podcast keep up the good work i'll i'll
i'll look at my inbox
um came out from phoenix can't afford to
super chat but thank you
oh from phoenix i was i was confused i'm
like how are you saying you can't afford
to super chat if you super chatted but
it's from okay from
from phoenix al can't afford to super
chat but thank you pearl on the pearl's
crew for helping me regain my
masculinity and helping me find peace
wow
yeah
we didn't do all that he did you did it
yourself a lot
you have some help i would say you had
some help all right all right all right
lowell gallon auntie jenny keeping it
realer than real auntie jenny is
securing herself because she's
completely in touch with reality love
her on the show you got so many
fans she's got so many fans thp network
pearl with another 24 hour live stream
and you got an og real woman spit in
facts no wonder why we rock with you
impressive very impressive 90 free toe
pay andy anti i've been asking everyone
why shouldn't men tell their girlfriends
and wives to
why i've been asking everyone why
shouldn't men tell their girlfriend and
wives not to come home on their period
all i've gotten is emotional responses
i should
have you ever heard of harry matt could
y'all do a reaction to harry max prom
night in dc gorilla bars 25 please sad
thank you for the super chat
p1553d cool auntie is the best glad
she's here for the stream great surprise
look at look at that you're getting you
got fans you got fans
um
calibre pearl wife days i'm a double d
bruh and she's talking a double scorpio
do you know what she's what the f she's
talking about no um
wd you all need to get ish a stack of
hats to throw out these wacky rods when
they be capping other than that i ain't
subscribing you post other you did that
one
okay i read the
i think i read most of them i don't miss
a couple today but what
the hats the hats okay so
we'll get you a little little plastic
cats from poundland
so i'm curious auntie
what outcomes do you think feminists
usually have
when you say feminist because
this is all new to me because i didn't
even know all this existed
because the feminist for my day we just
went to go speak to them we just went to
go to work pull the mic a little bit and
now
it's something else
so the feminists now it seems like they
want to be men
yeah and i would say back in the day i
would say yeah i was a feminist but i
didn't want to be a man mm-hmm i didn't
want to do men's things you know there
were pink jobs and blue jobs there's
still pink jobs on blue jobs and i don't
understand why
the feminists now want to be men why do
you want to be a man
and that's what it seems to be like you
know we're going to emasculate all these
men and we're going to show them that
we're better than them i just don't get
this new feminist do they ever so
with that i i imagine there's one of two
outcomes for them either they hold it
till they die or they drop it because
they want to get a guy so like around
30-ish they're like
you know what
i ain't a feminist no more which one do
you think happens more they become
lesbian
big big facts
but that's what i can say
they become butch lesbians
look at jessie's face too but the hatred
how many radical feminists do you see
that are going to be out there becoming
a housewife and cooking and cleaning
they're going to be there with their
butch woman i have a theory about
lesbians
it's that girls like they're not
actually lesbians they're bi they prefer
men but they get to a certain age where
they can't get the men they want so
they'd rather date a girl than be with a
beta
i think that
those movies are just women that can't
get men yeah yeah that's what i mean
they can't get but i mean anyone can get
someone
you know rather than get a feminine man
and i'm going to get a butch woman yeah
yes yes that's i see the same thing and
and the thing is like back in the day i
was a tomboy
but now the tomboys want to be men
they cast me as a tomboy i never saw
myself as a tomboy i just saw myself as
a girl hang around with a load of men
who like if you have men that fix cars
as a woman you learn to fix cars you
know it's just one of those things and
the clothes i wore because they were
easier to fix cars with you know to fix
motorbikes and to go underneath you're
not going to go near for money with a
mini skirt yeah you know but now it's
just like
everybody just wants
to be a [__] bloke i don't want to be a
man
i see something a little different
i mean i'm maybe it's because my mail
but i'm seeing more men want to be women
and the question i want to ask only
because obviously watching the show
lately was do you think there's a reason
for that and the reason in my head i got
and what i'm talking about is i'm seeing
more and more men feminine i'm not
talking about
more the um physical reasons why and
that would go into most of the estrogen
that's put into foods nowadays like
chickens and eggs and even cannabis
obviously that's how they get those
things to breed faster
think buddy
we all know how
you know most dairy farms will produce
extra cows they can't exactly do that
with chickens so they put chemicals in
them fake estrogen to make them make
more but that stays in the food and eggs
and more men are getting it into their
systems it even happens to women as well
so this fake estrogen is messing with
your biological whatever i won't go into
the biology of it but what i wanted to
say about that was i am noticing more
more men
across
knowing my subjective life but um
which moves on more of a subjective uh
virtual reality life from different
people in different countries telling me
the same things from what the things i'm
trying to research right now from our
show
and when it comes to media show the same
thing that you can men now more more men
turn in feminine turn really beta
um homosexual even to the point of
moment trans i've seen more men
transitioning than female to men i've
heard very little in my experience and
i'm wondering is it because of this
wonderful thing that females seem to
have that you guys talk about it is lack
of accountability and men going i want
lack of credibility so i'm going to be a
woman
wouldn't that be attractive it would to
me i know if i wanted lack of
accountability and you're saying that
all women have this lack accountability
and you go
i could be a woman and i can have this
like accountability too but i would that
would i asked my sons my teenage boys
and said if i put that are you and they
went
oh yeah i suppose and therefore like
that if they want lack of accountability
and they see these women all having this
lack of accountability men are getting
hold accountable and their lives are so
depressing why not transition to be a
woman what do you become gay what do you
think
the same foods that the men eat the same
things that are women otherwise
if that's the case they'll be the women
be extra feminine i think they are not
being extra feminine no i think extra
feminine on top is making a masculine i
think it's added too much now and then
the masculinity is becoming toxic within
them because the femininity is too much
within them it's like it's running away
and what they're doing is seeing men be
masculine they have less masculinity i
honestly just think i just think we live
in a society that's like a gynocentric
social order order and i just think men
are taught from a young age not to be
men and that they're trash and that
and i just think the world is harder for
men so why would you want to be a guy if
you could live on easy mode as a girl
because you're bailed out of every bad
decision you could ever make ever well
lack of accountability if you're saying
i never i never thought of it like that
so if you were given women lack of
accountability everywhere and men are
seeing this noted without even being
told it just knows on a subconscious
level
why wouldn't in their minds it be a
great future to be a female
i mean
it's wonderful you even say it on the
show all the time how wonderful being a
female is because i agree when it comes
to this lack of accountability so it's a
playground built for females so why
wouldn't men want that and then when you
see this rising
craze in trans women
and lesbians and things like that you're
going
look what you're creating the world
you're creating i wonder i think that
women create what person
i think that when it comes to
the men being emasculated i think it's i
think it's down to the women it's like i
raised my son
if a woman hits you
hit her back
if she slaps you once give her one [__]
slap back and give it to her so that she
knows equal rights
a woman is supposed to hit a man because
if it was a man hitting a woman they'd
have something to say about it so i grew
up when there was a girl and she used to
go around bullying all the boys
and i remember i came home with scott
from scotland and there was all this
fighting going on and everybody goes
what is it what's happening there goes
oh your son's hitting a girl and i
thought my son hit a girl he worked
raised like that to hit a girl
turned out the girl hit him and they
said oh aunt jen there's some i chased
that girl with him all in her house and
i said listen right i don't care whether
your mum's in or not but my son you hit
my son and my son's gonna hit you back
and i'll say to him when you hit her hit
her once
just one good slap and too many men
nowadays they've been brought up rubbish
oh if a woman hits you you're not
supposed to hit her back rubbish
everyone hit you [__] slap her hey
[__] actually if she can raise her hand
up to hit you slap her so that she knows
not to slap a man again auntie for
president
hate that woman an equal rights equal
laughs baby
who's coming out oh the women can do
this the women can't do that and men are
just laying down for all these stupid
rules that women are putting out women
are going oh you know i'm a female i
can't do this and the men are saying oh
she's a rubbish you're putting it on
whatever she can do to a man you can do
better as she slaps you knock her out
because you can't knock her up with one
slap and then she feels that she's man
enough or i'm big enough to like yeah
i'm going to hit this man
he hates her but the men don't want to
do that so that's where the men are
getting emasculated they're coming
they're turning into women not because
of all the homozygous because they're
letting the women get away with nonsense
you see a woman on a period and the
woman kicks off the man thinks oh i
can't tell us to shut up it's rubbish
i've got to sit there and take it
because no tell it's rubbish because
that's what it is it's rubbish go and
get yourself sorted if you had a broken
leg are you going to sit there moaning
about it for a moment oh got a broken
leg i've got cramping my leg about it
for years no you're going to go and get
it sorted but all this is making the men
more weak because they're not standing
up against these women and women who use
that or their feminine wiles against the
men and the men are falling for it the
men need to wake up wake up see your
woman for the animal that she is because
that's what they end the day they're all
animals see her for the animal that she
is and put her in her place because
that's what women love women love to be
put in their place and when amanda put a
woman in her place they turn around they
say oh no he's a wuss because but you
get a man that rough her up though she
will love it though so man what men need
to do is be the head whether you're
religious or not the men are supposed to
be the head of everything hated
relationships head of households head of
church no woman should be preaching in
church no one should be doing nothing
like that in church because the men are
the head and until men get the head
women are going to run it so the men
need to get back on top slap down the
women that'll be slapping them down and
just say to the women this one i'm above
you i'm a man
you can't emasculate me and stand up for
what you believe in don't listen to the
women because the women are leading the
men astray their families are leaving
the men and because the men are led with
their willies that's why they're getting
into where they're going because their
willies are following all these smelly
fannies and that's why they're getting
all totally out of it because that's
what they're led by you know when you
say to man where is your brain in your
pants we know what stop thinking with
your brain if that's the case because
you're being led by your brain and the
women know that you're being led by your
brain so the women are leading you do
you want some science to go with that
what you were saying about the light in
the pants did um
oh no if you
follow us maybe hype i'm going to use
the word hypothalamus you have to check
andrew hooverman will not
be good
now not be happy i haven't forgotten
this but it's part of the brain that
deals with two things one mating and the
other an aggression
now the hormone related to aggression
and hormone related to matin
testosterone is related to mating that's
why men will make a hole in the wall
and estrogen is made with aggression
so
what we're getting is the aggressional
side is coming from like i said
it's not coming from that exactly i
suppose this is subjective but it is a
theory of mind that more estrogen we've
taken on in our foods
the more this hormone is present in all
our bodies and even men and women and if
that's connecting with part of your
brain that's linking to aggression
lots of things this way you'll see you
know women need this i think i think
this is biologically put in for women to
to be that protective uh over your
family whereas men are going to need the
other part to be a little bit more have
that leadership to be able to be a
little bit more impactful in certain
areas you can take on the good and bad
as you see them and then be able to deal
a rule a ruling over there whereas a
woman needs to be i think
needs a little bit to be more on the
aggressive side to protect her young to
protect her family
when it comes down that you know mama
bear you know protecting her baby i
think that's why it's put in there but
this part that's related to these two
individual things has a feminine and
masculine part to it and the masculine
part of it is the the mating side it's
hence why you see like cats biting each
other there's a fine line between
aggression and mating for most species
but with us we can balance between uh
both now i'd say those with more
estrogen
are more likely to be more angry so
that's where you get better males more
angry and they can't think correctly now
i'm not a christian
but i can read the bible and i see
something different to other people read
like genesis for example explains all
this like um what he explains about you
know the adam neve attuned to me is not
they're not first individuals they're
first in you so adam is your intellect
eve is your intuition and the serpent
would be your instinct
and what it is is as a child you're
taught good and evil so your intellect
separates from this
so adam dies you kind of got a thinking
brain
and eve or the cardinal mind now suffers
as it says you suffer because you know
you have all you want your brain isn't
leading you properly so all of us most
people go wrong they can't think and
it's a very feminine thing to split
that's why they say eve is responsible
oh yeah well maybe he's responsible
because he let his woman lead
i would like to say the same thing well
the idea is the intellect is seen as a
masculine so they call it
you can't listen to women except me like
like i said that's why i've been most my
life in exception
um but it's been i've seen as a strength
for me my exception and i'm different to
most people so i can see
where they're different and i'm not and
they can't see it in me they see me as
freakish or strange i've never had a
problem with feminists i'm more logical
and they don't like me because i'm
autistic so i use my autistic cards
straight away because i know they're
going to use a feminine card and i say
by the way i'm autistic i don't see the
world like you do
please be respectful who i am and the
first thing they do because the feminist
is okay not a problem and i get a
wonderful conversation until i tell them
something they don't like
yeah i'm sure pill knows how that's the
story
and when you tell them something they
don't like
they do i have heard a couple get a
little upset but i remind them who i am
and why i'm asking them and they
normally calm down and normally say
something like
i can't i haven't been trained to speak
to someone like yourself so i'm going to
leave this here or something like that
it's just basically doing what paul does
on the street that putting facts in
front of them that you want them to at
least answer for you to at least accept
the answer the problem with the world
today is they think opinions matter to
me no opinion matters theory matters and
that's when you know like you've had
people on the show and they've and
you've said oh i feel i feel a feeling
like ish and the guys and people have
gone ah see they go you're feeling again
they go oh no well i think there's so
much to say the first thing i'd say them
is if you think show me a model
like what do you mean
what's your feeling thinking means
theory and they go oh no it's just
feelings say well don't say think just
to confuse us and you mean feeling a lot
of them say that to me they go i don't
feel then i think this and then i'll say
okay so what was what was the
mathematical process of your thought
i don't know what i mean what do you
mean
you said you think this so if you think
this it means you've used atum adam
you've put a logical
theory in place to say this is the
answer which is what we're all looking
for right logic but they can't do that
and they say well you haven't you're not
thinking this and you're just trying to
say that shut me up you're feeling this
because you can't give me people say to
me all the time i'm entitled to my
opinion i said yes but you're not
entitled to it just for me to justify
that paper
in my mind i don't feel nothing i don't
care how people feel
i don't care how you feel i'm not
interested in how you feel
i'm interested in logic i'm interested
how you think
so if you're telling me you feel i don't
care and for all the christian people
out there
remember adam listen to that woman and
look how the world's turned out stop
listening to the women all the women all
the men out there they're all religious
oh yeah i'm a christian well don't
listen to the women then if the women
are headed in your church
don't listen to them walk out i have
done if i go to a church and a woman's
leading the service i'm out at the door
because rubbish because women ain't
supposed to leave how can you be a
christian and you've got a woman there
preaching to people she is supposed to
do it and then and that's how you get
all the craziness in church where
they're letting like what happened to
the days where you used to deny people
for church
did that happen you can't you can't let
everyone in
i'm sorry but you know they say if
you're a christian right you gotta
believe that satan goes to church so not
everything you go in there you go into
church don't believe what they tell you
i write down stuff i argue i discuss
i get kicked out do you stop people
going church in this country why don't
they do that in this country i don't
know if they do it
no i mean i just mean like when i grew
up you could not live a certain
lifestyle and like go to our church
christianity in america it's a lot
different here
yeah like oh yeah you have to look at
this yeah like in italy they kick you
out if you're wearing certain clothes
like there are things you should be
ashamed of and how can you say like you
can't believe in that religion if you're
not because that's right that's why i
genuinely when andrew tate said the only
religion last left is muslim because
they're the only ones that'll stand for
anything yeah yeah that's the only ones
that like
changing churches with gay
pride
everybody else changes because people
like oh yeah i'm a christian and i'm gay
but christian being christian or muslim
is a choice and if you're gay why are
you going to choose to be that when you
know it doesn't accept you i've seen
individuals stand up for the christian
beliefs like that but not like i don't
know the right word as you're like like
a sec like i haven't seen like a
community do it the institutions won't
stand up yeah i haven't seen it being
paid i have never seen a community stand
up for it i mean they'll normally again
mob mentality like i don't believe any
group should have rights whatsoever no
groups of rights only individuals and
humans should have rights the moment
they give you rights you can mob
mentality and bullying look at lgbtq and
things like that what they do i mean i i
am for
you know that you know the the
protection of individuals and their
rights and things like that
i mean i do that thing and i say yeah i
got gay friends trans friends you know
we no problem there acceptance and
appreciation is unconditional love there
for me
but the a group that has rights over the
individual human and can like destroy
them i i don't like that in any group
not even in like the autism groups i
don't like it because and i see it in my
group happen especially oh yeah they go
with females especially mums
neurotypical moms of children autism
some of the most toxic women i've met in
the world is mainly because it's my
playground where i go into like the the
forums to talk see if i can help anybody
of issues that i've had and you'll see
and um all i find in there every day
it's a mum complaining about somebody
who looked at her kid wrong said
something the kid was staring and i'm
like
yeah yes
but these moms are victims for their
children yeah no i'm going to say i'm
not in victory
my granddaughter's autistic and you
wouldn't know because we just get on
with it yeah
and yeah i believe it i can't remember
what it's called but i was training in
it where you can train somebody to
act normal
to withhold their autism and their
behavior so they go home in their room
so my granddaughter will say
i'm not rocking grandma i'm not rocking
i'm dancing i said no no no no you're
walking she said okay then
i'm not rocking i'll go and i'll say to
her mom she spent the whole weekend not
rocking
but watch out for when she gets home
because she knows that when she gets
something she's allowed to rock so when
she gets something she goes oh from my
grandma
but she won't do it in my house
and it's the same thing i like people
they will go out there and they'll do
what they like because people allow them
to do it
so because people are allowing them
people to go with all these stupid
rights and these stupid rules and
everybody's thinking i can't say nothing
i can't speak up against it because
otherwise i'll be seen as being wrong
what a load of rubbish people need to
start speaking up for themselves if it's
wrong it's wrong i don't care
i don't care if you're a man you're a
man if you're a woman you're a woman if
you're in between your um of course
what's your name cause now um
that's the difference other than that
there's no other gender as far as i'm
concerned and even if you look at
hermaphrodites if they've got a woman
they're a woman if they ain't then you
can feel they're crazy like i don't know
how you can they're living in delusion
if i was walking around saying i was
black people would say i'm living in
delusion but someone can say they're
another gender
and then and they go as far as playing
in our sports oh no and get it in our
bathroom it's when they're telling me
what i am because i i've been here and
all the
sisters and the sister and i'm i'm a
female
i got a clue you're naming
i have some questions for you auntie in
the chat okay they love you
what percentage of mothers would you say
ruin their children out of selfishness
i'm gonna rapid fire ruin their children
yeah what percent of mothers eighty
percent you think eighty percent of
mothers were in their kids because of
selfishness yes
we need some housewives training down
here
um has your son ever brought home a 304
and what did you tell him after you met
her
i i about i able on before and and i
looked at him and he said mom please
don't say anything no 304 do you know
what that is yeah okay okay and he
looked at me and i looked at him you
know when the parents have that look
isn't it and he goes and he looked at me
anyway
so i didn't
but she didn't last long because he knew
you know
um
what you said you're autistic yes they
want to know how dating was for you
it was it was it was
it was right for me it was weird for
everybody else because i don't do
anything i haven't studied so i'm really
good at sex because i've studied it i
find it harder
easier for autistic ladies and autistic
men
yet i think everything's easier for
women i was going to add that but
i wouldn't say that people people
misunderstand when you're growing up
they just think you're you're weird but
i was happy in my weirdness because i
didn't see it as me i thought as
everybody else was weird i was normal
and i still think that
everybody else's wedding i'm the normal
that's my phone
what what do you think of women that
accept dates from men that they know
they're not attracted to is that theft
that's false advertising isn't it
false advertising would you call it
theft or no
yeah because they're stealing something
from them they're basically stealing the
man's body because you're going to sleep
with them you know you're not interested
so why do it mm-hmm
um let me see i think there's one the
they want to know if you have
the youtube channels coming soon guys
just wait we're gonna we're gonna speak
on that aunties
no we're gonna we're gonna get auntie
right when the new um when we move we're
gonna get auntie a little show yeah
she's she's gonna humble these hoes
um
what do you think of
women that expect men to pay for
everything
do you think that's good or bad like do
you think women should expect money to
pay whoever asks the person out if
you're going on a date if i ask you on a
date
i'm gonna pay
and there's a lady i wouldn't ask a man
in a day but if i did because you're one
of these you know these modern women
you're gonna ask your man and that you
pay so when you're ordering all that
lobster and stuff you pay i'm the
cheapest day ever because when men ask
me
on a date when i used to go on dates i
say if it was a drink what's another one
you know whatever's two for one buy one
and get one free whatever is a special
for the day i'm looking at it but some
women don't go they just think you know
what i'm going to bleed that man dry
and as far as i'm concerned if a woman
if you
if i say to a woman
if you're a man you're going to take a
woman out
art's going to choose the restaurant
and if it's
you can tell but if it's not five-star
restaurant don't go dump her don't
bother
don't bother if she chooses like you
know you can get i don't know like m s
you can get these meal deals where she
says it's okay i can get this meal deal
with the wine all the starters i will
cook for you then you can work with that
mm-hmm they're ever almost choosing a
five-star on the first date
and you know it's gonna cost you like
two three in japan don't go yeah cancel
go buy yourself fish and chips do you
think the world was a better place
before the internet
oh yeah why
it's because it didn't matter what
you've done on the other side of the
world you had no influence the only
influence i had is a person next door
in the same village in the same
community so whatever they did in
america
had no influence on me so when they're
dressing half naked the eyelashes the
injections in their bum the tit
replacements and all the sucking out of
everything it didn't matter because i
never saw that so now it's like the norm
was sky television the internet
because i saw that all on skype
television before the internet see all
that kind of thing so
that would have still affected me before
the internet i couldn't afford that
stuff growing up oh no i gotta admit
i couldn't really
if you did with the council flat they
came around with a little box once and
you're like yeah you can plug it in or
internet you just have to like press the
button
and you had to wait for everything so it
got worse from the internet you know
unless it's like you're gonna say how do
i fix the car or how am i gonna hang up
the shelf but other than that i think
for social life it's leading women
astray
if that question was social media
i would probably agree with her but
internet no
i think the world
is better than more places with the
internet in place because social media
is wrong
yeah yeah that doesn't mean that's more
my thought of it is
the whole point you're making definitely
with social media and or just at least
the way social media has been given to
us and and you know with
oh lack of accountability in some areas
like responsibility and others and then
with other areas and obviously
suppression shut them up but like the
way that has been run i can definitely
agree with what you were saying before
it was it was lb
g it was lb it was lbg
then it was lbgq
then it was all these other letters and
why because of the internet before the
internet we didn't know about this lbgdq
all we knew was that o and b and and
maybe g well it gives
it gives stupid people
people the ability to just say whatever
yeah and i just i don't like how the
internet has brought and brought up like
misandry against men
i think that's one of the biggest like
cons of the internet it's it's allowed
women to
make men feel like they're not needed
and they're not about like they're not
valued in society and that women don't
need men i was so shocked
it's only because of you that i realized
it was such a thing
because i i in my i'm i always say that
um
of the world but not in it
you know so i'm here functioning
everybody else but i'm not really in it
the way people are
and then when you came with all this
misogyny and manosphere
red pill
i just said to my man you know there's a
war going out there between men and
women that we never knew about because i
never knew about it
and it's really sad really because where
did it come from because i'm there
living a peaceful loving life about it
and then everybody out here fighting
it's like an unnecessary war
and i'm thinking
where did it come from if the women were
women men were men and it'd be so happy
the way it was before
but because of all this feminism and all
these rights it's just become weird and
it's really shocking because
everybody that i find that's 15 above
we're not aware of it
i agree like i i'll tell you i'm not
shocking i'll tell my parents some of
these concepts and they're like what are
you talking about it's crazy what world
are you living in
and
like when i'll explain just how the
girls move nowadays they're like what
they must be thinking i'm glad i had my
youth years ago before this all started
it's sad it's really sad because
there's no happiness in it
there's all fighting
there's all disharmony nobody's happy
doing it the women are not happy the
feminists are not happy the men are not
happy their children are not happy
so why do it
what do you think the solution is
we need to shut up and let men be in
charge
what do you think about women running
for office
what do you mean should women run for
office no
come on they're gonna start another war
that woman that's just gone to china
wherever she's gone
when i've gone they're gonna start
walking women are more likely to wage
war actually yeah because that one i
mean come on what is she doing going
there you know the one with the china or
wherever she's gone
that woman that just decided
you don't know
whoever she is the woman that's just
gone then open her mouth with taiwan and
whatever and started off stuff that she
shouldn't have started because women
have you know they say loose lips
women loose lips sing ships thank you
and that's that woman because everything
was fine until she decided to go over
there and now she's gone what girl
oh britney grinder what's that woman
that american woman that's gone britney
gregory yeah i was thinking it was anti
like she wasn't talking about no no
she's gone to thailand yeah and she's
supporting thailand against china and
now they're starting i don't know the
china started displaying their arms
she's an american politician
wow
the american politician has just gone
it's living in the last couple of weeks
yes i don't even know but because before
she done all of that
yeah china weren't displaying their arms
but she's gone somewhere and just like
women to open their mouth for no reason
all of a sudden
could be world war whatever's gonna be
on there come out you know the war you
said between men and women do you think
that war is still on or do you think
it's over and women have won
women are never going to win not as long
as there's a breath in my body then why
do they have so much accountability they
seem like they've won i agree i do i've
never thought about it that way but i
think women won because
we have all the
you're right because they'll be they'll
be 45 single and childless and that's
that's what's gonna they're they'll
listen
all right and should i
but change it comes to power like women
have all of it when it comes to
reproduction and what where is more who
is like that's the most powerful thing
you can do can i change it everybody
dies out then because they can't do it
on their own can they can i change their
family they're gonna end up charlie's
and they're going to end with all these
dogs that nobody who's going to have to
walk their dogs when they're old they're
going to be like china right but that's
that's like one of the ways that
civilizations collapse is like a
population decline
i think so
an increasingly old population
by
2025 it's going to change again
and then the women are going to realize
they've been fighting for nonsense that
they're what they want to be you're
going to see more women learning to cook
getting aprons and decided you know what
it's easier than men being charged other
than that the feminists lesbians and
lgbtq are going to run everywhere and
we're going to die out anyway because
they can't interbreed can they the
person you were looking for was nancy
pelosi okay
sorry
she always reminds me of something from
wallace and gromit that troublemaker
have you ever seen nancy pelosi yes look
at nancy pelosi and then watching
allison gromit and she looks like a
character from there i'm trying not to
be nasty here but that's that's the
person you're talking about that um is
she like the leader of the democrats or
something in america she's going to
start wars because she don't have to
shut her mouth and be a woman and know
her so you know how we've seen that we
think women have won and you say that
what if we change it to feminine what if
femininity has won the war against
masculinity because femininity doesn't
grow old
40 and childless no feminine feminine
exists within the women that will run in
the war so it also exists now they want
the men to have it oh yeah yeah
definitely existing with men
where's the war if it's not
women versus men that's why i said if
you take away women versus men yeah and
see the war is femininity versus
masculine and women and men who are
betas and that are just the soldiers of
that war yes so if that war
has been won by femininity because like
pearl said everything
is catered towards i'll become masculine
then and i'll join the i would join the
message what i would say is i would say
women have used femininity as a tool and
i wouldn't only women
they've used men and made men feminine
so okay in my my sense i'm saying women
have used feminist femininity as a tool
as opposed to femininity
and masculinity of two
pisa on the different side of a pod
against each other it's more so they
would work in conjunction you can be
feminine and masculine um at different
ranges of a spectrum oh yeah you can't
be a woman
you can only be a woman or a male oh
yeah within sex yeah that's why i tried
to take it out there and say they are
just the foot soldiers of it and the war
is between feminine as a whole and
masculinity as a whole and if you look
at just the whoever the souls are for
example more females um
let's just say uh homosexuals anybody
really it's high feminine within them i
said men can be feminine and like i said
i do see it as a as
maybe um feminine leadership and or
feminine pushed in areas but i i also
see that the other things like i've said
if you just do a little research you can
see the amount of fake estrogen that's
probably pumping through your body right
now i'm mine
what did you say the fake estrogen is
it's in the food it's mostly in foods
that they can't get to reproduce
anything so chickens they're not going
to be you know
masturbating chickens are they so
chickens eggs they also put in things
like plants or cannabis and things like
that is to help them breed are you like
vegan or something
i'm not necessarily vegan but i do
follow a a veganish diet and then i
cheat now and again
whenever i need it are you just organic
i just mostly organic yeah um it's it's
for me that's a similar argument like i
said to um like being whether if you're
disgusted over something like uh what
you talked about
um
um abortion and things like that if you
discussed it over things like that and
your point of abortion is you know you
shouldn't kill a child you know this is
cruel there's no need for it better
education things like that the almost
exact same arguments we use for veganism
as in you don't need to kill animals
we use much more grain but we kill them
we kill animals and we're killing a
child yeah
so that's why meanwhile this is similar
so for the same argument you can use
almost for children other than the fact
that it's your species but that's for me
it's the only point and then i look at
people and like i can ask a load of
questions in the same way it's not
prepared so i'm going to quiz anybody
but i've done before it's just similar
then what's your ethical value for you
and like meet or anything like that you
know if we was going to go down a debate
on our road with somebody and it always
comes up the same argument it's very
very very similar to abortion you get
the same answers from it's it's like i
can i'm arguing abortion with the same
person but just slightly different and
changed and their values and everything
and in the end they always end up
mending all right yeah there's no real
reason to meet i eat it because it
tastes good and i don't care how many
people die or what it causes the
environment or anything i don't care i
like meat i eat it and i say it and i go
okay fine it's true
but in the same case someone said i
don't care i don't care about my baby i
don't care i'm using it for this i just
want to kill it and have my way is that
okay and all right it's the same
argument it's the same thing you don't
care about that in you that makes you
bad i think it's what comes out of you
and i think to myself to use
you know child like you want to eat a
child i think if i was growing up in the
culture where cannibalism was rife then
yeah i'll be a child
so the same idea a child
if it was my culture i didn't meet
so to say that it's the same as abortion
if there was in the culture where we're
cannibalists then if he was in a culture
where abortion was legal and okay
no i'm not saying that but we are we do
live in the culture what about eating
that's your body i'm talking about food
why not you said if he was okay he's
different
what i choose to do my body is different
so
kidding kidding a child just because
it's different but if you're saying that
if i was had to kill a child to eat it
i'll eat it
because if that's in my culture i'll do
it it's not in my culture to be to be
having abortions it's not in my culture
to kill children it's in my culture to
kill animals to eat so i don't see
animals and children is the same because
if i was in the culture where i'm a
cannibal and it was okay to kill
people to eat then i'll be all right
with that yeah because
that would be my culture i just think a
cow is different than that because i
just i just think it's totally different
because
as far as yeah yeah of course if i was i
could if i was a cow and i was pushing
out a calf and you want me to eat it
it's different
but you want me to eat my own child no
you want me to eat somebody else's you
want me to eat animal yeah i would eat
an animal you know you said in your
culture if it's okay to kill your child
and eat it
[Music]
so if it's in someone else's culture to
kill a child and eat it you you don't
mind them if it's if they're cannibals
yes
if they're cannibals yes but if it's not
for the sake of job and money
or just for convenience you're going to
kill a child yet but if you're going to
tell me that i'm starving hungry and i'm
going to kill that child oh no no i
wouldn't i'm going to eat no i'm going
to eat it so that i can live i'd agree
with that yeah even if
if we are plane crashed on a remote
island and the only thing to do was to
kill a child and to eat it and we all
survive and we have to do it then fine
well if you didn't have to do it but
your culture was to do it
if you didn't have to kill the children
culture you could choose whether it's
your culture or not because culture is
not all right people say it's their
culture to be to be gay because they
grew up in a gay culture it's their
culture to have a and it's never going
to be in your culture to have an
abortion because that is not something
that culture's made out to be that is
just something that people have made out
that's like necessity oh we're going to
start having abortions because it's easy
but that's never going to be a culture
all right my understanding have a
culture of people continue to help me
can you help me with the word culture
for me culture was something that people
made up i didn't think it was something
that was real i thought people made up
culture
so people make up culture
and people make up their cultures and in
their cultures they state that
you know you can eat babies in our
culture
you don't need to eat bieber's you just
can't
you're saying yes you do something that
marrying five women you can marry in
some cultures you can marry four women
it doesn't mean that you have to it just
means that your culture is saying you
can't other cultures might not
so i've got a definition of culture so
the ideas customs and social behavior of
a particular people or society would you
say that in our society now in the time
it's been run in that it is culture for
people to have abortions because it's
allowed by law it's common everybody
does it i think i i think the culture
allows you to do it i don't think
everybody does it i don't think oh no no
yeah
even culture everybody doesn't do their
culture but if culture allows you to do
it yes so shouldn't your argument now
then be well if it's within the culture
it's okay for them to have abortions
within the culture it's their choice but
it's not mine of course yeah but you're
okay with others who do it because
obviously like you said if it's in your
culture and you can do it you're okay
with that so if it's in your culture you
say this is okay
it might oh then it might be in my
culture to eat people
right but at the end of the day does my
life depend on it is the same for that
abortion i don't believe in abortion
does your life depend on eating animals
depend on having
no that's why i don't eat a lot of meat
i can't go without eating
i i'm actually the one person that
actually eats like vegetarian and vegan
food like four or five five times a week
this is what i'm saying
it's not my it's not my culture the same
argument the people present for
you know killing babies i present the
same arguments for eating meat and then
the same people who tell me killing
babies disgusting you couldn't kill
babies i'm not for abortions by the way
but i'm just saying i like to look at
patterns and how people think
but when i talk to like like if i was
talking to someone like pill about
she would give me all the impactful
answers for killing babies
but in the exact same mathematics
empathy she can't give to a cow why is
that
because um i think maybe she's talking
from her own species oh no let's not
talk about pearl personally i just mean
something people like yeah
if i even say to myself if if i had that
point of view maybe i have a thing
against killing any one of my own
species i understand that
from a moral standpoint in the society
that we're in yeah in the environment
that we're in and the environment takes
a massive president because the
environment kind of dictates the social
order where we stand how we think and
that's what it is
i would say that's wrong
i understand from a moral standpoint
it's wrong i understand
from a
a societal standpoint it's wrong there's
punishments for it there's a holistic
approach of answers that would make me
come to the conclusion that i cannot eat
a baby oh yeah
and so
that would be my conclusion
sorry yeah uh that's why i should never
have mentioned it
yeah oh no no
that's right that's my thing that i mean
that's why i see the other people this
is moving out on
them it's some other redhead in there i
mean i'm not talking about cows and
babies in the same heck no i know for
abortions i mean i don't i'll eat a
little meat now and again i'm not saying
use them as your argument oh yeah of
course but then your point yeah but
that's like well i'm a hypocrite i'm a
100 hypocrite i i i know i but i i still
know the truth is does that not void
your argument oh god not for you
for me
of course for me
oh
um i just have some questions from so
the point of today is we want to talk
about red pill so like different red
pill concepts okay
so um
just some things that
are like pillars of red pill and i want
i just want to get you guys this like
take on it so first off
what do you guys think a high value man
is
uh it depends on the location sorry it
depends on location for me um
for example uh where i'm from you know
high volume man
i suppose is is uh
they would see someone as having having
a job it doesn't
necessarily have to have a certain
price tag price tag on it as i've heard
some people say um
i from where i am i haven't seen the
height thing but since you mentioned it
on here i started asking people and they
all said every woman so far said i want
a man follow me i never knew that that's
one thing i learned from the show
i said what i and everybody i've asked
now just to see if this is real in where
i'm from yeah they said it before but it
wasn't a known thing i i never knew
anyway from my subjective point of view
but um yeah whatever the high value man
from where i'm from is not the same as
if i go to cardiff there'd be a
different high volume man there and
certainly a different high value man in
london and at different areas so i'm not
going to say any specifics about you
know what how high how high they've got
to be anything but i've found out from
the show that taller is definitely one
of them
actually no
high value doesn't include height
it's desirable but that's not that's all
right so what do you mean by high volume
that's an attraction queue okay i can
tell you what my one is okay what what's
up why you value max uh speaking to the
mic sorry
my height so just when you so remember
you want to like talk like the the
circle you want that to be in your mouth
oh yeah you'll might
not not touch
just closer yeah the the the push up
push it down yeah that's better yeah
right and so when you when you look that
way like you're talking away from the
mic and people can't hear you yeah my
high value man
for me is a man that brings in a way
slip
a man that can
run the
household a man that can
do diy
and the man that can work together with
me as a team
i don't care about how much he ends
and he don't care how much i earn all he
knows is that he's the head of the
relationship
and he's got my back and i've got his
back
so the
the
idea of a high value man i don't think
kevin samuels came up with it that's
just where i heard it from and it's
basically um the most desired men
throughout history
and this is these are the requirements
that he said you have in modern day you
have to have 10k per month and you have
to have had it for three to five years
other men must accept you as high value
so if other guys don't cosign you're not
high value you have to have a network of
high value men you have to be visibility
linkedin level and you have to be useful
to others in the group
that's right for somebody under 40. i'll
say he's right yeah you'd say that's
right but under 40. actually he said no
he said that um typically they're not
under the age of 35
because there's like a
level of maturity that comes with like
age um i think that men age later for a
woman under 40. now we're talking about
men no sorry so when
from what i'm guessing auntie means i
mean as a woman what does she deem and
like no but i'm saying this isn't like
this is just over the course of history
okay like what people have valued so
this isn't like kevin samuels didn't
make this up this isn't like like this
is the most desired like the kings the
the politicians like the most desired
men throughout history it wasn't like
that this income is in today's terms but
this isn't like
it's like something he looked at i guess
throughout all of history
um
but so you're saying like under women
under 40 would look at that but over
over that that's not what they'd like i
think for me
is i've never what is somebody like you
know everybody goes about the six foot
something tall
i mean come on i'm going to get nick
hate trying to kiss you you know i want
somebody the same height as me i think
my mum must be about an inch taller than
me that's fine because i don't want any
higher
and when it comes to the money i've been
out with men that have earned lots of
money
but
i want consistent money i want a pay
slip every i don't care what it is once
i get that pay i can work with it
you know and some women they get all
this money and they can't work with it
so once he has a job and he has a i want
to see the waistline because there's
lots of people out there that has to
have jobs but you don't see the
waistline i want to see the waistline i
want to see where you're paying your
taxes
and as far as i'm concerned and
therefore there's a you know there's a
light fitting that needs doing and you
can fix it that will save me even more
money if there's a shelf that needs
putting up but that was all right for me
but now i find that now you gotta be six
foot five you gotta be earning a certain
amount of money you gotta be driving a
certain car you gotta be
it's ridiculous because
well i can't keep to that standard i can
i can aim for that standard but why are
they going to look at me well that's the
i think the issue today is average women
think they deserve that i don't think
that the issue is like in high value men
like that i think there's always been an
elite group of women in the league group
of men and they should be together right
like under the age i don't know 25 24
for women like
at a certain attractiveness like that
they don't really have high value women
they have to be like selected by a high
value guy but that's the closest
equivalent i could think of and but for
men it the whole point is it has to be a
small percentage of men but you have
girls that are normal and they expect
that and it's crazy right yeah because
everybody's expecting to get that but
how are you gonna win there's such a my
new
yeah there's not enough there's there's
not enough men out there yeah and then
why are you aiming for that when what
have you got to offer that high value
man because you might be aiming for that
however you man that man might be
looking at you thinking i'm not even
going that low so high value man is that
like
so what i'm trying to piece together is
it's basically someone's at the top of
every pyramid in like social stand-ins
and things like that from respect from
others
it's the man other men want to be in
other women and women want to [__]
so that's why they say like other men
have to accept him as high value because
like certain rappers may have like the
money or the stat but like other men
wouldn't consider him high value so like
jay-z would be a high volume and
poo-cheisty wouldn't be but the thing is
sometimes it all depends on your peers
because my my high-value man might not
be a high-value mentor like the jay-z's
of this world but compared to his peers
he's a high-value man
well
that's the way the income like he has to
have the income there's a whole point
it's it's like models there's such a
small percentage of the population but
they're in a way at the top of the food
chain for women right that's that's the
that's the girls that all the guys want
to [__] and wife if they're not hoes
right yeah and so like they're just at
the top of the food chain for men those
are the ones that the men want to be in
the women women have been
unrealistic in their expectations is
this like my wife wanted to say that she
may she may call it quits if jason mama
asked out so
she said you're like no man can do a
carl maybe if jason came along you you
you'd have her
and then when i found out uh something
about him living in a caravan or
something because he thought spit was
missing i started getting worried but
then i thought nah he's not covering the
wheels
so so another concept from the red pill
is that high value men get to cheat so
because or the high value men can cheat
and they've earned that right and the
reason being is because women are born
with value men have to like be calm so
if a man does all the work to get money
muscles game frame
he he becomes one of the top elite of
the world that he should have the right
to step out of his relationship any man
that cheats on the rights is cheap
because if he every was happy and
content he wouldn't be cheating in the
first place
so every man is gonna cheat well done to
you because that means that something's
lacking
do you think don't you think that men
can cheat in a different way than women
can like they can cheat and still love
their women
yes
yeah they can because it's just sex
isn't it women make love men have sex
yeah and so that's like most of those
guys will i mean i want to say most but
apparently a large percentage of those
guys have like side chicks they're kind
of like like bill clinton he had the
money she's been going on for years yeah
yeah i mean we've heard about you know
you see your grandma there's an uncle
you know so they've been they've been
going on for years but
that's what makes the the village run
yeah
yeah so do you agree with that do you
think men um should be able to exercise
their options
i think that
if you're not getting satisfied at home
and you spoke about it
and you're not getting satisfied at home
you're quite entitled to go out
and i think it's different for women
because
it's harder for men women can satisfy a
man any time yeah so i think if we women
go out this because you're lazy you want
to change there's nothing else but for
every man it's different so if you're
not getting it at home women free up
because if your mind's going out there
look at yourself look in the mirror what
are you not giving him i think there was
a saying where you're a chef in the
bedroom a [__]
was it you're a [__] in the bedroom a
cookie in the kitchen a child minder you
gotta wear all that i can't remember all
of it but you gotta do all these hats
and the women they say oh because i cook
i can't have sex because i look after
the children i kind of have sex because
oh come on just lie down and open your
legs and get on with it
is this that easy
i like all the extra stuff you do babe
don't do what she said
no i i i'm very very privileged not to
have that because now when you think
about it right you have to think about
think about i feel for men because
how hard is it for a man
you know but women you can just lie
there but you have to appreciate the
men's effort so when he's got it use it
help them
because you as a woman you can just lie
there and you know think of england you
know but with a man it takes so much
effort all that blood that he's taken
from his brain to go into that one part
and then you're gonna turn him down you
know high blood pressure he could have a
heart attack come on help our brother
it's almost like men's mating strategy
is to screw as many women as possible
and and they'll and they'll
they will be monogamous to one woman and
then the woman will turn him down it's
like he's trying not to cheat on you
but and then you're telling him now
what's he supposed to do
like if a girl hasn't had sex with their
husband in months what did you expect to
happen
if a man cheats on me i know that he's a
freak
he's got to be a freak because there's
nothing that i ain't doing for him that
no other one can do so he's got to be
doing something extra at the realm you
know for him to be cheating on me he's
like where you going extra right because
i'm giving it all i'm doing a hundred
percent i'm reading books i'm studying
i'm looking at a video i'm saying don't
watch the corn
i'll do that for you let's let's do it
oh no i'm doing it all
you don't think men crave variety though
i'll give you variety i will
i don't i will i'm not gonna say men
don't i don't so um
what are you talking about now many
varieties
hanging over the balcony hanging off the
bed do a handstand you know treat it
like exercise that's your personal gym
use the man's body
you know there's too many fat women
going out there and the men that they've
got they're not they're not having sex
at all and then women should be using
the man's but you can have a good
workout on the man
all the all the parts of you the arm
muscles you can you can do positions
with auntie jenny no but you know what i
mean you can do sit-ups you can do you
can have a total muscle is laughing
because she knows it's true because she
thinks i'm a freak she thinks that we're
all so embarrassing because me and my
manga we're like this all the time
uh-huh and she's really embarrassed
because she thinks that we had like
teenagers like when we first met uh-huh
i don't care i'm doing undercooked i'm
doing on the fridge i'm doing a balcony
i don't care i'll even park outside your
workplace in your lunch and give you one
quick one in the car because that's what
men want
i'm telling you i am telling you i would
do it anyway and as far as i'm concerned
if your man's cheating on you because
you're not freeing it up
i feel like you have thoughts you just
keep nodding
i think it's just green
auntie jenny man speaking mad facts like
where would your man have the time to
cheat on you if you were freeing it up
on a date like whenever or on tap
on tap on tap why have a dog embark
yourself i'm sorry no i'm going to say
it
yeah i'm going for it if i'm cooking and
he comes up behind me jimmy i'm i'm over
the sink i'm i'm going for it i'm over
the cooker hanging over the bed and i'm
disabled jeremy i will walk out of there
my crutches i don't care because i'm
walking straight i'm walking out of my
crutches i'm taking all my i'm taking
all my
my morphine i'm taking everything
afterwards because as far as i'm
concerned
wipe her up
i'm leaving him empty because they say
that if he's going to work right if he
gets about four o'clock i'm up at three
o'clock because you're not leaving to
work and you're going to think oh you
know what i should just hit it one more
time i know we're gonna do it before
work
we're gonna do it before and if you
follow me at lunch time and you fancy
i'm driving down there i'm going to give
it to you in the lunch time tell me oh i
will give it to your nighttime women
should we ask your mom and dad free up
free okay
how often should you have sex with your
mom whenever your man wants it
okay
my sister's loving because she knows
it's true
it's true she knows what i'm like she
said it's true people it's true she said
it's true because i'm a freak she she
you see the corner there you can't see
her but she she's there alyssa degrees
she gets embarrassed because you know
women will be there on their on their
social media and they're having all this
dirty people cry
and they're having dirty conversation
i'm having dirty conversation with my
man you know i'm getting freaked out
from my i'm letting you know what i'm
going to do to you and i'm going to do
this and i'm going to do that and she
just gets a totally embarrassed and she
walks out and i'm thinking do you do you
see these messages at times like she's
here i'll say it are you saying i'm
telling you what i'm going to do oh okay
okay
i'm telling you i'm i'm serious i didn't
ring the phone and rock this i'm telling
them exactly what i want how i want it
when i want it what i'm going to do when
i come down there as soon as i open the
door what you're going to do when i come
into the door drop me on my knees i
don't care i'm telling you as it is and
that's how it's going to happen and if
more women be like that they're going to
be happy then when weren't she and the
women just free up
you're not far we're not lying because i
have one right there it was it was
almost exactly the same
at all
there's a certain type of it's not as
frequent
otherwise
no it keeps you in shape it keeps you in
shape um so auntie has another question
so seventy to eighty percent of divorces
are initiated by women
auntie okay
you text and i know you're texting she's
letting the partner
[Laughter]
let me let me just take notes for like a
future
i was about to say paul i hope you're
taking notes of your future yeah yeah
i'm i'm taking
lots of notes jess you just missed some
great relationship advice
yeah it was sex advice no relationship
advice is
free up the [__] whenever your man
wants it
if you if you want to if you want it at
work drive to work
[Laughter]
um
i was gonna say okay so 70 to 80 of
divorces are initiated by women why do
you think that is like what have you
seen are the main reasons that women
leave because they're stupid they don't
realize what they've got
no because they're stupid you know when
they say the grass is always greener
women it's not no it's not it is not
always greener because you've got one
man you think you know what i need to
step up on that man but you don't
realize that that man's the highest
you're ever going to go
so you were thinking of you know what i
got him i can go higher no you can't
laugh you're lucky that you got him in
the first place so you might as well
hold on to him because you can't get any
higher and that's why they leave and
then they realize you know what i've
messed up i need that man again but he's
gone
or he'd be hitting it but not not
staying with him at what age do they
come crawling back
the women i won't even say that age once
their children leave primary school
once their children that's when they
divorce their husbands no when they come
back they've got children once their
children need primary school then that's
it they're finished
and that's when they start crawling back
that's when they start calling back
because
a man will have sex with any woman once
their children are in bed
but after primary school it's hard to
keep them in bed
raw
yo
that's yo that's game changing
it's true
goodbye
yo
um
and so when women leave do you think
most of them think they can do better
than their husband
but they can't thank you
because i actually said that if
hindsight was foresight and the first
person you have children with you think
about where you could be if you sat down
if there was no abuse and you sat down
and you thought about it and you think
to yourself
we could have worked at it we could have
had counselling we've had done something
and what you would have built together
nine times out of ten you would prefer
you'd realize that you should have been
with that person
damn that's
saying that again straight facts
straight facts yeah why don't you tell
jess the relationship advice that um
yeah
now you're gonna free up all the time
yeah a little more detail i just don't
think she's gonna give her an example
yeah give her an example
i would say that's jess's back whenever
whatever your man wants it you should
give it to him
even if you're in the middle of cooking
dinner
everything
i believe it if it's my husband
everything he says come to work
so 190 and 65.
in the car park wherever
hey someone said his auntie's single
is auntie
no
you didn't listen to her she got a man
okay don't scroll down
you know where the danger is
right that's right
don't scroll
yo and that was this day before
yesterday you know where the danger is
it's the emoji for me
okay that's us at 50.
hey i want to be like that 50.
makes sense that is i feel like that is
going to be me that was blushing
you know i was going to say right
i'm other than your mum it could be your
mom and dad done that
think about it they're happy
to find out when i think about that
seven days a week
i want a lady in the street with a
freaking bed
i've heard come close yourself before i
look
is it true that once upon a time we
didn't we didn't have little boys they
were all classed as little girls as in
even what we refer to as boys a day they
once upon time class them as
girls because the amount of estrogen
they have
um
and then that's one of my feelings when
i'm around it there's not many
high-class men and things like that for
people to cheat on but cheating is still
happening but it's generally for my for
when i'm like childish spite that's why
i've seen a lot of people who break up
um relationships a couple of friends
house in it um
use jamie as an example relationship
there without giving details here's the
same um a lot of women from our
experience around our idea they divorce
and split up on spite
because to them is there's a huge
childish playground game going on a lot
of men you know especially those who
obey that they're playing the same game
because they're very highly feminine and
it just seems like they don't grow up
this like there's no
there's no masculinity to get them to
grow up and stop that i think the women
have turned them highly feminine i think
because once you withdraw sex from a man
enough you just emasculate him and he
turns feminine anyway
so i just think if women free up more
give them more sex they'll be more
masculine they may oh you know they wake
up in the morning like
but now because they're not freeing it
up i think that's what's escalating to
men i don't really think that the men
are becoming more feminine i think that
lack of sex is making the men more
feminine
i think because men need that sex to get
that aggression out to make them more
manly because if you see a man when he's
just have sex come on he can lift a car
yeah you know what i mean
a man will come out like yeah that go to
work like you can tell a man when he
goes to work when he's had sex or when
he ate
and when a man have it has sex and he
goes to work he's just going like and
they will say he's a beta but he's not
he's just a man without sex that's his
balls full you know but if he's emptied
now he's going to work and he's like
come on
so do you think so do you think she's
playing
yeah yeah is that is that why there's so
many betas no they're not having sex
yeah
what what what what about
not even having sex not having good sex
because the women are fooling them the
women are given this hard-hearted sex
and they're making it bad if the man
leaves they're making it bad for all the
other women that follow you know you
need to give your man
good sex so that when you're knackered
that when you stand up your knees
collapse
you know it's like you're in the bed
he's like he's going to work
no because the women are just like all
right then it's like yeah you've had to
be like oh yeah go to work and they just
stay they get up and go shopping or
whatever but if a woman if you're having
papa
proper nobody is going anywhere because
your stool that is an earthquake
the men have gone to working
i'm inspired
i'm inspired same i want earthquake sex
yeah no more earthquakes you see the
difference is right is that
when you're going to bed of a man do not
make love don't even think women want
all that now men just want to have sex
there's times to make enough your
birthdays when you can go for dinner and
you can light a candle a man just wants
to bring you in take you as soon as he
comes in there drop you on the floor and
[__] you that's all he wants to do
he don't care about give men sex again
give me sex
and that's what women get mixed up with
get into all this romance
you know i mean come on what's your
marriage
[Laughter]
but foreign it's not about you it's
about the man let's give the man good
sex again
that's what they need the men i think
all the men would agree
only
any man they should do yeah
good sex that man is a true baiter
and i didn't even think there's such a
thing so as far as i'm concerned all
them baited men out there they're not
baiters they're just alphas with bad sex
hmm
yo i am inspired aren't you
what do you think what do you think of
the guys that go that
abstain from sex
for what are they monks
no they like they just decide they don't
want to have sex so like stop having it
after that often they sent to the women
they're what i think it's down to the
women they've had before them because
any man that stops having sex that means
he's had bad sex all of his life because
if he's having good sex you're going to
want to give it up mm-hmm so any man
that decides to give her that
women that he's had before him that
would have given him bad sex and that'll
put men off and that's what it is bad
sex books weren't meant off
and sometimes they wanted to stop having
sex because they had sex with a girl
that gave them bad sex yes and they
don't want to yeah what about the guys
that say they do it for like discipline
like that sort of thing
no they would they're weird
are they are they weird they either that
or they just they just meant that what
about men like me that are in between
then i have sex at least once a day but
i don't come yeah you don't come no
no no we have sex but then she's sorry
um
otherwise i'll be like what did you just
stop at some point
no no no
for me there's more testosterone than
not coming but having sex so it's like i
said um you can
have sex and come you get a nice big
boost of testosterone but you have sex
and you don't come it's like 10 times
more but if you're not on sex like you
said you're not going to get any of that
on it
if my man it's not coming i'm just going
to go on to become either that or i'm
dying on it
yeah
but for me i don't
when i release all that energy i i feel
like a woman on a period for a couple of
days i think so i really just want to
when you're tasting horrific you need to
shut your brain off yeah i think when
you're having sex you just shut your
brain off because if you shut your brain
off and then you let your body come and
then you start feeling all the tingling
what are you oh i said orgasms i just
don't know i believe that you could come
to me
what do you what do you think about
girls that abstain from sex
what do you think of girls that abstain
from sex after they after having it yeah
yeah
they got to blame the women that the men
have had oh okay because absolutely
blame the women
who is having bad sex it's a woman's
fault um
because the women are also free to open
their legs but not their mouth
and you will find that the men will just
be going on with what the women want and
it's down to the women to put the men
right
so if you are having bad sex it's not
your fault as a man it's the woman that
you've had
so if i'm having if i'm abstaining
from sex because it's bad i'm not even
blaming the man it's the woman he's
there before
it's always going to be the woman's i
don't i blame the masculine teachers you
had growing up who didn't teach you well
why is a man going to teach you a man to
have sex well man told me i'd have sex
do you think men should be shamed for
not getting laid
no once i don't tell anyone
no i saw i saw a post the other day that
was like
back in the day they used to bully men
that couldn't get laid and then they'd
go figure out how to get laid but now we
tell them it's okay we don't bully them
anymore no they need to be police some
more they need to be bullied to get
brilliant should we bring back bullying
aunties
i got bullied and it was it it was
character voted
yeah
he just made me oh oh yeah
i'm all for that
what do you think about women that
re-wait till they're married so they
they've had sex with like multiple guys
and then they say they're going to wait
have their husband wait until they're
married
that house was a fool
that's like buying a secondhand car
paying down on a second-hand car you
know everybody's driving it around but
you're like you know what i'm going to
pay down it because that car is special
to me everybody else has been around it
why is it going to be special to you
yeah but what
okay so but what about they they say
they're close with god now
like god god's saying that's a blaspheme
then
what i was about to blaspheme and say if
god's your man
god
do you know that almost happened to me
with her and it almost gone because when
we first got together she said um i want
to wait this time for a little bit
before
you know sleeping with you and i want to
have a proper culture
so at first i was okay but then part of
me almost for a week was thinking this
isn't right i don't like this but then i
found out from a separate source that
her ex partner got the same treatment
and didn't have sex with her at all and
she's only had four partners in total
including me so and i was like oh so
she's
so then i thought all right maybe she's
just had a rock i then checked and she
had the first couple of partners were
absolute
probably got it from another woman
but
because i know she made a previous part
of weight and she'd only had two
previous partners i decided that i was
okay for me to wait a little longer so i
caught i did a little courtship with her
i had fun doing as well
that right there is like acceptable
because it wasn't like she
had been doing all this stuff with other
men and then decided to make you with
what it
that x that she is sat with i
immediately i didn't i didn't even need
to think about it it was almost like a
feeling took over i was just immediately
relieved that this wasn't like you said
this wasn't happening to me i wasn't
thinking wait a minute now
is she running through all these guys
and then she's picked up me and i've got
to wait that ain't happening but when i
found out that she'd made the last guy
wait and she'd only had two previous
relationships from some friendship
little
young guy
was that if he didn't find that if he
wasn't
you didn't find out how she treated her
exes what would you have done i don't
know i probably wouldn't have be
we may not be sitting here now okay so
that's possible there because i would
have thought that was very unfair and i
didn't like that i thought you would
have been playing no i mean so it's good
really that you lived in such a small
place that you knew yeah yeah because in
london you'd never know
oh yeah of course yeah i mean you know
we're very lucky for those things and
like i said we all we reason we came
here we knew we wouldn't be like the the
people you know what pearl's talking
about but we're really interested in
seeing because we have sons my 17 year
old who just rang in now he's with our
child he loves pearl in the show yeah he
didn't know anything about it
he did want to cover the heat was
killing us
and then my little boy and i was like oh
will he do the right thing amanda i said
we really want to go down to see pearl
and all that you know we've been waiting
a long time to come and see the guys and
see how much we support the show and now
oh there you go you're going to know
what it is from the park
from the park and bring them up um well
i i would now come over
17 and he loves pearl um
he does say that sarah has a bigger
effect on him i don't know
for me but he's the sarah fan but i love
sarah oh sarah's great sounds amazing
what introduced me to you not obviously
personally but i watched in sarah for a
long time and then um i loved the stuff
he did on the street he does the
i first seen sarah when he did talk with
tommy robinson that was the first time
seeing sada and i really loved what he
was saying
i kind of fell in love with him on a you
know i feel a philosophical way
and then we when he introduced us this
show because we seen him on there and
then we fell in love with pearl uh
alyssa fell in love with head over heel
street which i love
we've got to go on our show we will we
will running out and then as soon as i
seen messages come out i was i was like
message eddie
and there's like five messages and i'm
like stop messaging eddie i'll message
eddie so i'm gonna say yo me and my
friend to come on shows okay bro yeah
i'll hit you up cheers
and i see the essays he's right now i
shouldn't have told it
but i was so busy in the studios doing
the things i was doing i just i thought
oh go on message her then i'll trust you
and i have to have she was like i've
written my my fifth paragraph now
give me the phone
i'll miss it
no and then come on the show but yeah he
my son is like
he didn't know half this stuff and his
friends don't even know what he's
talking about when he talks to them in
school because he's only he was 16. but
he's still 16 he's turning 70 now and
he's just finished school but when he
was talking about pearl and i'm sure
they didn't know who it was he's got a
lot of his friends to watch as well and
he didn't know after stuff you were
talking about afim would argue with him
he said no one in my school
no one male you can think of in his
school at the moment because that
thinks like you guys talk about wow so
that tells you the next generation is
coming even worse because they don't
even sound my friends have clearer
saying they think oh you talk about it
backwards and i'm like what are you
talking about this is his friends who
are 16 now
so our show i think is going to get more
relevant as time goes on if this is
what's coming out of school today i'd
agree to disagree because the first time
i ever heard about red pill content was
of an 18 year old
who is finishing college and he's come
and told me about our red pill
steph is cold
they talk about the world and how people
see it through a different lens uh also
interlinks into relationships and they
had like a group of them within that
like his friendship group
and at first i was just like i don't
know what you're talking about it
doesn't make any sense like i understand
the concept but while they're
why is it called red pill why is it
called blue pill yeah um and it was more
so that it was the younger generation
telling me about it don't get me wrong
they didn't really understand it too
well but they knew it was something of
importance yeah
i i i will still say yeah i'd agree with
it i think some young people like i said
even my boy now is understanding it and
some people do too
yeah maybe it's just a subjective point
and is where i'm from
the people in his school
he's just not understanding it my nieces
and nephews think i'm backwards for the
things i speak about like this they they
seriously do on if i go onto facebook
and write something because they've
written something that's like like
something pearl would jump over you guys
would jump over and go what you know
this is this is a lack of accountability
if i say something like that it's an
attack for my entire family and friends
who are all young the older generation
won't no when i ask them they go i see
your point on their point that's what
they say to me but the young generation
don't see my point at all and like when
when we ask them simple questions like
we get from the show or not
they think the answers we give them and
what we argue with them with or talk
them with are backwards they just think
that we're backwards and we see him from
a dinosaur world and i'm like are you cr
no this is logic
this is the logic of mathematics this is
the language you speak i said what
language do you speak for english they
look at me stupid and i'm like
mathematics of course that's how you
learn how to put one word and one letter
together this plus this equals this this
word plus this exists this emotion this
reaction equals this these are all
mathematics and this is how the world
works
they just they just they just don't look
at us like it's like it's silliness like
they don't understand like their
feelings should count more than their
thinking mind can tell them
it's it's
i don't know how to do it like they're
looking at a world through one eye that
i have but i look through two eyes and
they can't seem to see through the
logical eye to try and back up
everything their feelings tell them
all right i'm the same board as yourself
when you say like i don't care about
feelings all right i say yeah in a
certain arena feelings can walk out the
door
obviously i'm a human so that's part of
who we are so we all have feelings and
emotions cultures all them kind of
things linked into one
but i still hold
uh christians may say as christ but i
still hold
intellect
above and it should be leading
everything and a lot of intellect is
based on masculinity and being able to
bring two together within you to see
what the answers are you know rather
than going i'm just going to go with my
subjective answer here subjectively i
feel this but you give them a lot of
other subjective points
and they put them together to create an
objective answer more often than not
with highly masculine individuals so
that even in females
they'll look at them and go oh i see a
point there yeah i can see that now and
and they'll change their mind whereas
others may see that and where they're
more controlled by the estrogen side
they get angry about it instead and then
they just go
well again their subjective mind is says
and we've seen a few of pearl on the
road with some of the drunks and things
so we know what feminists and people who
are very one-track mind and b that's why
i feel a feminist is somebody who's one
track mind in their mission and their
mission goal can be again feminism
supremacy or what whatever you can i
think you can attach a bunch of labels
to it personally myself and they're not
all good so that's my opinion on
feminism but it's more of a
um
i've got to feel like i've been talking
forever and take nothing
um but yeah
um what's the point of feminine
supremacy in my head
do you think that um men will ever come
back it seems like men are walking away
from marriage do you think they'll ever
come back
i think it will
when i think we're we're playing
i think the tide is turning now
i think it's turning now i think thanks
to shows like you and
the late kevin samuels i think it's
turning when you see
when when do you think like legally
it'll switch like do you ever think men
will it'll ever be 50 50 when it comes
now i don't think legally it will when
the laws make women accountable
that's what i think too i think you
can't until there's consequences why
would they get better
yeah but the law ain't gonna change
because laws there for women not men and
it always will be
i think because they change to get this
way they can change to go back
definitely i just it's hard to see i
can't see it in my lifetime because of
how far we seem to go like i said i
truly think we lost the world i thought
about running for an office like not
that i really want to but i feel like
the only way you could get a law passed
for men is if a woman did it yeah like
that's like that's the only way i'd see
doing it
because i just don't think men can like
rally it's the right woman because all
the women
that are there nowadays they're not you
know
it's just a balanced woman it's a woman
working and doing whatever they're doing
would you say a balanced one can do it
someone who can see a man's point of
view as well
oh god no
[Laughter]
just cause like i have brothers and i
don't think it's like i don't think if
they get married that she's like they're
like my brother my one brother's
probably gonna get married the next two
years if they ever get divorced she why
does she get half his stuff
doesn't make sense like i work why can't
you get a job
make baby mamas get a job again
send them to work send them to work
because
look at it just because you have a kid
doesn't mean you can't work whatever you
got we move you should come out with if
you go in with ten percent you should
come out with ten percent
you know you asked it on what can we do
about this
can i just
say my answer to that and something i
might be doing is something you might
want to get involved with because uh
first time is getting on it yeah yeah
we still have time but um i want to say
is um
education of the youth
now one thing that me and melissa do at
the moment is uh
we we have a charity we're trying to
build at the moment we are building
we've we've published 10 well we're on a
10 published nine children's books
already for charity to raise money to
build schools in africa and things and
things for our communities aren't here
um and one of the ideas we i came up
with was to do something into all our
books educational books with children
and we thought we would be able to do a
really cool little um series called um
my pearly girl which is really to go on
is uh we did a cartoon of you a little
girl and the idea is you're in school
telling children about these kind of
things
um we did we did i did some practice
stories and they came out really well so
i'm just trying to get them rhyming now
because they go better with children
and i said as you did want a new studio
if we could talk afterwards about
putting these books together and for you
to sell i i don't like any money off my
boxes oh my books are charging but when
i've seen you looking for a new studio i
thought well if you've got a little
something to sell these books your fans
never gonna do it i do most of the work
anyway i do and making books i love
making books for children um we bought a
few down there not really for the
cameras for anybody wanted to look at
them one of them by the way is a really
controversial book it's called um little
white boy
and it's generally uh my very first book
was about racism because i i was in a
really bad place i i'd had a mental
break my
my grandson had been kidnapped by a
woman from london
so um i went on for months until we got
it all sorted
um and what that woman was getting away
with was incredible so i would love to
about another time but it's a really
touchy subject we haven't got all the
permissions from the individuals
involved
so you want to put like children's books
that like talk about this stuff
children's books talk about equality
between men and women the differences
and generally i haven't like i said
what i wanted to do is not put
everything into it because i wanted your
guy's input on it because there's a big
input and if there's a book that you
guys are going to be interested in
having as as a collection to do and now
there's a collection series
you don't have to go into every area you
can say like look at this area and talk
about it and it's put in a children's
way
and then you know they could do these
books once or twice a month and they
help
obviously get your studios we want to
try and help in a way because we love
shows i guess because since we was
helping my boy
i said oh my god i love this show so
what we did is the show we wanted called
the show we're doing is called virgo
what is really going on
but then once i've seen your show i said
oh we pause in because i'm taking some
tips
and we're gonna use some stuff from you
to enhance our show yeah and then we did
and uh we we're almost there with what
we need to say i'm going out more though
oh yeah yeah it's so hot
but i love the fact you go out so yes
we're moving soon to a place where we
got a few uh yeah we got a few
universities and things around already
and we have lovely woodlands and things
so i'm going to be able to get nice
areas which i can go out and do in and
it's going to be really interesting
i'm going to involve um it's going to be
very similar to the talks you do only
we're going to be sat down but we're
also going to have i'm very big on
fellas that she'll i scream at tv when
you're out i'm like
tell how fallacious he's been
a fallacy bill that's a red hair
but i want to be in a position because
i'm going to college people yeah just
have these fallacies on my table yeah so
when they come up my goal can you read
that please and tell me is that what
you've just done when i say i say well
here it is oh like the argumentative
fallacies yes so i can show that so what
i can do is when they go to an argument
that is fallacious that they can see
that they're just drawing away from the
point now yeah i can bring them back
with something but i can get them to
read and agree with beforehand so that
was greatness so um
the children's books would be
interesting it'd be interesting to see
like what you have in mind for that well
we definitely want to do alcohol i'll
guide these contacts now contact eddie
afterwards on them no because i know
you're busy with all this and i'll just
but this was a great opportunity no need
to come down and be guessing we've
always wanted to meet you yeah
you're coming yeah yeah yeah meeting all
you guys is great i haven't brilliantly
met andy because we love dante's shows
for me very radical and i love it i love
it i don't mean it in the way of like
your 80s radical for me as in like you
know
how do you man you know that kind of
thing you remind me of my nan and i mean
she passed away now so when you remind
me i don't mind telling you because i
love the woman to bits and uh
so there's that now i've seen it don't
agree with everything my nancy she said
she's still hyper narcissistical and
from
a military background so she can get
things a lot wrong but it's a love
anyway for grit and determination how
she says things and like yourself like
we've seen about christians and things
like that they don't say anything but
it's nice to see a person no matter what
to stand for what they believe in so
it's lovely seeing someone right now
well um the first time we've seen pearl
do uh i think one of the red pill
segments yeah jess so yeah so we've seen
jess and you doing it and i was like
yeah i like this we were just talking
about how that was like the series that
took the like that was the beginning of
this channel taking off was like the
videos we did together yeah oh you know
in those videos i want to ask you i have
two topics i was wondering if you would
ever look into for your redstone sir
yeah one of them um i don't know if
you're because he's from he's not from
states from canada which is tom mcdonald
is that the lion guy he's he's a rapper
from canada oh wait i've seen that yeah
and one of his latest tracks really but
like he is controversial he is funny as
well like he doesn't necessarily
necessarily just talk about the men and
women he talks about everything like
last one was the system and he was and a
lot of masculine feminine he talked
about the system what it does to you and
things like that he the songs um for the
talking about the lgbtq how how double
standards and all sorts of things like
this i'm talk about how i mean one of
the lines in these things so you can
imagine is you know that you you know
you say that there's life on mars or
whatever but a woman thing on earth
isn't life and all he's in he's very
controversial he actually probably won
the biggest selling
rapper billboard billboard purposely
because he's independent completely he
doesn't want anything with it completely
billboard leave him off their charts and
they fight for it every month together
their songs on charts and things like
that and some of their songs i think are
very red pill or at least very
controversial you can take people down
different roads but just thinking if you
wanted something extra because
everything on the show is great but if
it was like um i'm not saying this still
the show is still by any chance but um
it's extra content to look at and see
with me and some of it like i said um
buttholes is a really comical song and
yeah we can't do music reactions
yeah but maybe we could
weasel our way around it next next like
reaction section we'll we'll check it
out a lot of people do and the thing is
hog the hog gang is a massive massive i
mean he sells millions of albums all
sorts of things to his fans huge fan
base and anybody really does reactions
on him mention his name they just
skyrocketed
skyrocketed now he hasn't released a
song in a while and uh last one's pretty
controversial as well weren't they i
can't remember i system is stuck in my
head because i loved our song and the
other one was more of a british one he's
dead now unfortunately um his name was
john harris but john harris more talks
about the legality and how we as humans
policed and everything like that and the
laws and things and what they do and
stuff like that his is much more
controversial and he really just give
you an insight to how like um like
things like legalese like for example
legalese is a language of law but we're
not taught in school and yet everything
we do have to come out of law is to do
with legalese so why are they not
teaching us a language that does
everything that writes everything and he
talks john harris talks about all that
why it's done why it's damaging that so
they're really good things to look into
if you really want to find out john
harris she's
they killed him but that's the tinfoil
hat version
but he died the same as have you seen
the thing with rick mayo
before he passed away
um do you know rick mayers
we know him from bottom and things like
that if you if you practice and things
out but he was a comedian here
um oh do you ever watch the film drop
dead fred
the imaginary friend anybody ever seen
drop dead fred oh you've got to watch
some of his old movies he played
imaginary friend there but what what
happened is they sat down and shot a
short film i can't remember was early
2000s late 90s maybe it was weeks before
they
again he died
um and in there he actually said about
him dying but they talked about
everything everything has happened
between then and now it's happened and
they talked about it in a movie all
about there was about population control
and things like abortion rita and um
even talked about a virus being released
way before it released everything
um
someone shared it on on facebook when
they're showing it is the last movie him
and a gang people made this famous guy
in allah
see them happen to john harris and other
things like that i'm not saying going to
the rick mail thing is very short but
john harris he's released loads and
loads and loads maybe it's one of those
things you just look up and see what it
is
and and that was it really um we just uh
we just thought that those two topics
were great and the box thing um yeah we
can look into it
the box thing is definitely something i
would love to do because we've already
started working on it because we think
the material you do oh yeah great
material and if you can get them what
what happens is for for for yourself as
well in this country i don't know about
the us but in this country if you can
convince your fans to put your books
these books into libraries every year
you get a check
you'll get a check from the you get
anywhere between 600 and 6 000 per book
wow so over the course of like a couple
of years you've seen the show and we
managed to do 10 books like early girl
and and as long as it's in as long as
it's in libraries
and the idea is it's not to be it's not
to be too um
it's amazing just using colors and
things as backgrounds and stuff small
books but it's just generally this
little girl who gives different points
of view in school to what she's been
told and seeing where it ends up with
the children and everything yeah do
little things like that just to spark
ideas in people's heads yeah so like so
we do the book the the one book is very
confident i said a little white boy no
tom mcdonald does a song be the girl
that's getting less in the class
i get pearled
and every time you change someone's mind
you pearl them
but no we
didn't do any any topics we can talk
about i mean i i've we've done loads of
controversial topics and people read
them and go how did you make them this
innocent and it's like yeah because
basically at the core of it it is
innocent it's only when we put all the
subjective matter on top it becomes
really complicated so that's something i
thought would really be cool i said with
the books we'd create and and give to
yourself
it it would it we put it and obviously
um yourself and things like that you you
guys would have to sort out we know how
you'd want to do it all our books we do
is on amazon yeah we publish it on
amazon we can it's really easy to
publish on amazon really very easy and
once you've got it and like i said you
once it's on amazon as well your fans
can get into music museums libraries
they can go and order in libraries
because they've got this new thing now
amazon are doing um ibm numbers they've
they've got this new system over there
i s
their numbers you couldn't get them
really before if you were doing like
that but now they've got something
sorted so
the library's actually ordered from
amazon now all our libraries do not know
this and the the buyer said no we always
hold it from amazon now wow all our
books are we order from amazon so your
fans can get them in it doesn't create a
lot of money on purchase that way but
every year
you sign for all your books and then you
get massive checks in the mail soon yeah
well because they've been reading music
museums god libraries
libraries and schools and because
they're used there they see there's a
lot of earnings for you it's called the
plr scheme so if your name is on the
book and everything the ownership of the
book or the company whatever you want to
put it under that means if you've got 10
books in libraries all around per book
they can give you like almost
up to six grand per box if you're ten
bucks 60 grand a year oh jesus which
would pay for a lot of things so yeah
this is it's just an idea that i thought
you know i could because
we sit there and ever i see super chat
going up my hand i wish i could do this
because we love the show so much and
like
but like we we put all our money into
our charity and what we're trying to do
so we can't really give so like we say i
could i'd love to do that book with pill
i mean make up good friends are the guys
oh yeah i don't know if you've seen them
once we i i i yeah i quickly did youtube
holidays
were there women that submit get their
men to commit yeah
all sorts of things i
i love doing stuff like this yeah
yeah i know just seen it
yeah know if you don't put up there like
i said they would i chucked those
together the book idea is interesting
though yeah that'd be cool that'd be
interesting well what i'd do is like i
said i'll bug eddie about it so if he
mentions he would say oh no no i'm
interested
oh that's so cute the wall purple yeah
like i said i threw them together we can
make them much much better just get
their man to commit
simply don't want me
[Music]
that's great
like i said i thought you know if
there's anything i can do to help i'm
gonna yeah yeah i mean especially it's a
long way we can't exactly come down to
be on the shoulder
but like whatever i can i would love to
we'd love to yeah we're gonna be doing a
similar sort of thing in the future if
we ever reach out yeah definitely yeah
like i said not this but going out and
speaking alyssa won't you let me do it
i had to stick to the home school
yeah so that's our plans
we have a lot to do with uh oh and in
the background we we make bold games so
um we designed a couple now one we went
to a show with a bunch of board games i
spent years on and one game i put
together for the family quickly and at
the end of the day people were gathered
around the one i put quickly from my
family and all the ones at time i was
just there going well carl
you can try and be feminine and try and
make these work i understand the people
are telling you something you went over
looked at this ludo based game and we
turned into some respect outlets so
we're hoping for christmas at the moment
but uh we we're trying things like that
well thank you guys so much for coming
yeah yeah
so no no no it's absolutely fine i mean
we was hoping to come to the end now
anyway because it's getting really hot
in here
and we'll let you know everything about
that so uh yeah it's really great coming
down yeah thank you thanks everyone
does that mean we're going out for
airbrush
do you want to let them out yeah i can
no no i just want to show you the
quality of what this is the very first
book
this got published by um a publisher and
then we decided to publish all the other
books okay
read the end of that though because
you're not going to get through it all
right just go to the end right back
just ask already son for the important
the impatience began to show his parents
can see what else he needs to know he
said and then baby come aside before he
asked his very last time
if he was only a clueless camel and
being curious wasn't crying you told me
about the desert and all these gifts so
it's coming true can you answer me one
last thing it's both scream what why are
we in the zoo
so the entire time i get it so it's like
the point it's like why are these
animals ensues yeah yeah right so the
message at the end right and i do this
for all outside everything has a message
and says here we have creatures of
curiosity that's something we can't deny
that animals needed when we have such
advanced a.i
find the gifts within and they go it
goes on but every single thing it's the
same as this this was the first book we
did was about racism and it's about
beautiful people now i saw the problem
of racism that other people didn't see
so i wrote this whole book
just basically a teacher say there's a
new child coming to the class and all
these little herbals are trying to
wonder which creature the creature would
be like
and there's nice big tongue twisters but
at the end uh-huh um it just basically
says
you know
um
it's what the beauty of what people ask
there's a classroom to open and all the
children gasped yeah it says was he this
happened there he says
which one could he be like which
creature verbal but he was none of them
he was only purple
and said but that doesn't make him
different now this is where it comes at
the end
my master seemed so questioned and she
said so what did you learn today tell me
my little local i heard you had a
neutral start and his skin was kind of
purple he said mom
mommy made me think so i'll tell you the
great one today i learned not to judge
on the color of one's skin but then this
is the important part which we changed
in the other books but we put it as a
question so do you think the adults in
the store can we get any samples we're
fed pimping pups what's that can we get
any samples of the bug yeah
we're going to send everything to you
but i didn't want to flood you with it
without speaking first and you know what
about and it just generally says that
the adults in this book wouldn't be done
because the teacher said the child was
different and the mum said the child is
different and then the kids could see
the difference
i think there's a great children here um
we've got the show starting ahead hold
on
yeah thanks for coming yes thank you so
much
okay
okay thank you so much so much thank you
so much for the camera yes
thank you and driving all the way down
yeah my goodness
no problem
okay bye thank you thank you
wow
uh can i see the camera
what kind of camera is that i was just
curious
so it's basically is it the same one you
have it's the first g okay so this is
the gh5 so
that was the first version of it
what version is that so this is the gh5
mark ii mark ii okay this is the g
okay it's just yeah okay
okay
you kind of you need another lens for it
someone said someone said where's auntie
clapping cheeks
[Applause]
she's coming back
she's in the garden
i'm guessing
i thought he said 8 30
but no that's um
i might what are you
getting dressed up for this show i'm
gonna
change but just into like something
slightly nicer than this not
not super no no
i'll keep them entertained
yeah i can read the super chats
you can just zoom in on me
you can turn on the light a little bit
if you want to
give me some light baby
you didn't want to make a comment about
what auntie was talking about earlier
about uncommon
you don't want to make a comment
[Music]
um
hi guys
it's blurry unless you fixed it
what's good baby what's good shot what's
good
welcome back to the 24 hour podcast i
love it
with myself and jess uh pearl's just
going to get changed so she'll be back
soon
um
shout out to the chat
gotta love them
um
thank you once again guys um making this
happen 250k we're doing it again
out here killing ourselves the girls are
going until what
noon tomorrow yeah like 12 20
noon tomorrow i might show face you
never know
oh sorry thank you thank you um
someone said jess you need a short king
in your life funny thing is pearl and i
were talking about that earlier
about short kings
you know ish i'ma keep it 100 with you
yeah all throughout my life i was like
nah tall dudes only tall dude six foot
plus because i was like i'm close to six
foot
i can't have nobody my height because
that's what
i just always know and i'm like oh no i
can't
here lately
you know
the short king's been looking good i'm
like huh hey
there's been there's so many people to
change your life there's been a shift in
my brain changing your life and so you
never know i may pop up with a short
king one day like this that's my boo
thing right here makes sense not not
short short i'm not i'm not super tall
we're not trying to we're not trying to
cater to the to the masses but it's one
cent no jess you need a 6-4 king
he said
i'm trying to be there
i respect it
yeah you know how tall
am i drunk
are you asking am i drunk
hey shout out to brad davis new member
oh yeah we see you thanks brad
can i talk now yeah you can talk what do
you mean can you talk now
auntie
have a seat
to be
you educated the book
did you get one no no it's just you
just yeah no no no that's that's for you
oh he signed it um
oh you're the gang you're the guy
i'm kidding
i don't live near lewisham but
um
i've been there when i first moved here
funny story when i first moved here i
didn't
know
no guys okay
let me finish this story so i didn't
know where a hair like supply a beauty
supply shop was so lewisham was the only
one that popped up i took a bus all the
way to lewisham and i was like
i guess this is where i need to go
it was cool it was fun
but
no guys i just have a naturally low eyes
i don't run on sleep mode i'm just i'm
just on chill mode so i'm not drunk i'm
not high someone said that on the last
thing
but no
i'm just on chill mode all the time
y'all are funny
any questions any other questions you
would like to ask
from myself or auntie have you enjoyed
yourself auntie
yes it's been very
enlightening
it has been
i can say is the word yes ma'am where
are you sitting sexy clothes that you've
got all these people enticing huh i said
you're on these sexy clothes and
everyone's doing this
and everybody's talking about your legs
do you know what it is you know why you
you look like that because you're a
sports person
sports people are so used to wearing
short clothes
that it doesn't matter to them
it's nothing whereas people might think
oh my gosh
that's the same memphis like shorts that
she
and you find that with sports people
i think especially tall sports people
um
the
shortest i'll go
five seven
wow
i think five seven is the shortest i'll
go
depends of heights um i don't know what
that is in centimeters
oh thanks p4gy
i appreciate it i've been trying to
but
i
i have a dissertation all right
and
it's been
a lot of work so once that's all done
trust me i will be uploading more
so we'll get you right there
it's gonna be over with for everybody
one of my thoughts on muslims
i don't know much about them too
um
to comment on them the ones i've met
have been
great but
i don't know i don't have much of a say
on that
these aren't my windows to clean so
[Music]
popeye's is in stratford
who does my hair i do my hair oh made
you think posted us again
what are they saying i do my hair guys
so anytime you see my hair done in the
show
i've done it
besides straight back braids i don't do
those
that's not cool he's making a children's
book out of me that's awesome i was like
oh wow
would not have even
have a super chat span
good oh let's read them sorry i got
distracted
how do we go there
i'll be right back
um
what was the last one let's see
uh
hold on real quick
um we may have a guest downstairs could
you go grab them for me
hello
otay uh male or female
female okay thank you
all right bye
female
um
let's go
um one super chat says oh thank you guys
for the super chats as always you guys
are the best with giving super chats
really appreciate it
when i tell y'all this next studio
it's about to be
lit it's about to go up
you think you think the pregame and just
probably thinks it's blown up now oh
it's about to be
live
once we get to this new studio okay
so one super chat says product of
marriage as children
um
redeeming green sent these next three
super chats i think i said that name
right um in sister lenses in switzerland
it says it is law the product of
marriage belongs to the church it's how
we
the free humanity lose everything
the red pill should wake up
the red pill should wake you up to traps
like marriage or other cults like slave
trades
um
mg
mg toe by
logic
i think that's how you say it you know
um auntie says auntie says and does all
this but is she happy and does she feel
protected and content and loved or does
she feel oppressed because we all know
we know feminists would say she's
oppressed i'm depressed i'm happy i'm
content
i'm happy i'm happy i'm not oppressed
believe you me i'm not a friend she said
i'm not i was a feminist i'd be
oppressed i'm not oppressed no if you
saw those texts
she's not oppressed i am not a friend
not at all
on tv living her best life you're right
um same
same person sent the last super chat um
or
i'm dying on it
quote of the day aunty
hey i think everybody should have that
mentality
i feel like more women would
be pleased
at the same time as their men
uh the uk economist auntie spitting
facts
tim
newton
neuroth
uh there's a saying
get and get the angry man out men needs
the one thing women can give them auntie
speaking facts joe hello how are you
i'm jessica nice to meet you you can uh
take a seat it's going to be a little
bit
different today because we're doing a
20. yep you can sit anywhere
it's going to be a little bit different
because we're doing a 24-hour stream so
hopping right in the middle of it
is that what it is
okay the next one is from joe auntie's a
gangster with a hard r
um matt said pearl corner girl
wildflower is afraid to speak up why i
don't think she was afraid to speak up i
think
she just
wasn't the
talking type uh silly sausage time stamp
six hours 59 minutes and 59 seconds ish
is
ish is in love
oh
time stamps someone said time stamp oh
it must have been when answer was
talking
maybe it was go to the go to the stream
and go to time stamps six
hours 59 minutes and 59 seconds
um
i like cake forever mr cake imagine
auntie shopping while telling her man
stuff
i don't think men should go shopping
with me
i believe that i think women should go
shopping on their own and the men should
be outside either in the car waiting
to unpack the shopping or at home
waiting to unload it i don't believe
that men and women should go shopping
together that's facts that's facts
the uk economist the nation's favorite
auntie is back
i like cake forever mr cake at cool
auntie a woman holding a beer makes
makes them twice as attractive what are
you sipping on what were you suffering
guinness
uh silly sausage make trump say he is a
woman then woke people have to say with
no expectation that he was the first
female president of the usa if they
won't write that
if they won't write that themselves into
a history book you win you hear that
pearl
uh silly sausage says make trump say
he's a woman then won't then woke people
have to say with no expectation that he
was the first female president of the
united states
if they won't write that themselves into
a history book you win
i think that's a good thing to do lucas
why should a man date a western woman
versus going abroad 90 frito pie nancy
pelosi
he was a history book
um
he said make trump say he's a woman
there won't be people happy
with no expectation that he was the
first female president of the united
states
if they won't write that
into a history book you win imagine
hearing someone say i used to be a good
thing to do
a western woman versus
or today's delusion i used to be a woman
uh duran zin
darezin
gaming i wish i could have known that i
could hit women back
uh so back when i got essay as a child
his mom let him down yeah
somebody is you you hit them back yeah
male or female he said i wish i could i
wish i would have known i could have hit
a woman back when i got essayed as a
child women that i had been around but
lit
had been around but live and learn equal
rights equals left
equal rights equals equal left yep
matt going back to tick tock it's an
obvious chinese government tool to
subvert western culture please stop
using it people let themselves be
manipulated into many ways don't be
played and used gekko jesus i've
oh i've got i've the capacity to delete
still i have sorry i have the capacity
to delete still lie to anyone and
everyone to keep my family alive is evil
and i am willing to swallow that pill
silly sausage
silly sausage says rehab
uh
i love matt says
i love auntie but if you love
matt says i love auntie but if you love
everyone it has no
no worth
hi all says evil is allow
either
yeah that's why it's so hard to read
these because sometimes y'all don't type
them right i see the struggle
because you pause and you like
what's your giant what are you trying to
say
all right so
evil is allowing someone with illness to
act in a way that you know it will hurt
themselves and others when
it is
in your control to stop
the like the cop
stop the cop like
what
okay we're going to reread that i need
y'all to grammarly download it
evil is allowing someone with illness to
act in a way that you know it will hurt
themselves and others when it in when it
is your control to stop
the like the cop
with the
roaming guns
you know what y'all
my goodness i didn't even understand
that i literally am reading it word for
word
uh lawrence
lawrence says there's nothing you can
say that can convince me that mega mark
wasn't even okay you read that one
yeah
let's
refresh them one more time do you see
the struggle
yeah i'm like
oh we have two new ones uh
the fool says
oh 20 super chat thank you thank you
thank you uh the fool says
it's a cycle single woman raised a
single woman raised boys who don't know
how to be men those men then want to be
women
when a woman becomes a man she soon gets
shocked at the reality of how she is
treated as a man she was privileged and
lost it
uh md
toe by logic
mgtow by logic oh make a child
biological it's like men go their own
way oh okay mgtow by logic it's like
when men are like tired of women they're
like i'm not dating any i'm going my own
way okay cool mgtow by logic see i
didn't know and pearl helped me uh call
her show
auntie's cooking she can cook meals
and hoes at the same time
i like that
look
they're funny they say grammar grammar
yeah you all need to know grammar don't
come for us in the chat y'all need to
know grammar y'all here not putting
ings on the end of things e ds on the
end of things and just type it download
grammarly it helps you out
um it's wipes
um you can check in the bathroom
underneath the sink if we have here i'll
take the laptop you're welcome
appreciate you
i've got some muscle here you want some
um are you thirsty you want to drink
antibacterial stuff
okay okay i don't know if we have any
wipes
let's see
so you guys can see like what we do
pre-show so now that we're live 24 7. so
around this time jess goes and gets the
drinks out and the cups
you could if you want give them
play-by-play show the back camera the
kitchen oh yeah yeah yeah show them
all right jess show them what you do
before shows sean as you can see we have
jessica yeah
i sent her back to the kitchen
in her yes
doing the background stuff um
yeah look at she gets the drinks out for
the guests all the hard work that goes
on i don't know if you i don't know if
you heard it's a 24-hour live stream
yes we're live streaming for 24 hours
straight you guys won't stay for 24
hours don't worry just us
what day
we have a guest
yeah i'm going to set her mic up soon so
she'll be able to speak and bear with us
um okay
in the meantime you have jess
um yeah go buzz flat four i forgot we
ordered ice cream
[Music]
get galley house buzz flat four
four
yeah bye
i was hoping that was the apartment guy
i don't think i'm hearing from him today
me ellie
ellie excuse me
[Music]
we're hosting the most this
yesterday we're at 254 almost 5k hey 5k
yeah so this is just in the wild
yeah jess is in the wild yeah
yeah she's getting getting the
this yeah
yeah then ellie starts annoying
everybody
she's real cute though
[Music]
there's someone out there
yeah sorry i forgot we ordered this
no one sat here did they no
no here they did
[Music]
um
oh
again
on let's see i'm not thinking about
everyone's outfit
hold up
okay
hello naughty
is the camera mirror and jess
oh yeah
no no that's fine that's fine that was
it
i was just wondering
auntie can you rap
sorry guys i'm back no
um i'm gonna put you back on paul no i
shouldn't be able to because it messes
my family can but
oh here it is
look at it look at it
oh this is on 2x i think
oh no it's not it's just the beat
b is that
you just look at random beats on youtube
[Music]
what do you think of this one
too slow
i don't know
a booty popping still too slow
should i pick another
yeah yeah
look at it aunties auntie's a freak i
found out today oh yeah
and andrea
she's just down for her man
thank you
can i just say it below
but the thing is people do all of that
outside of a
relationship so why wouldn't you do it
in
[Music]
that's what the women do to catch the
man so why not do it to hold him
that's true i don't like this one
twerk music that's the type of music
twerk city girls twerk music
make sure it's not actual city girls
you might get copyrighted oh no you're
right this twerk music
beat what i put yeah
interesting
um
this one's got eight hundred thousand
[Music]
know the views
do you like this one
no it's weird isn't it that's all that
broken glass
two
beat
[Music]
let me try a different one
put the headphones on
this one's got spongebob on it
[Music]
it's decent
auntie and the gang she's going insane
all these hoes are telling her to let it
rain
pearl's been practicing
look at like it
would you give my wrapping skills wonder
if i give myself a six
i feel like i hold it down
but i get nervous okay
six you can hear a bit more as what you
can hear them thank you
you're not saying more than me
was that your earlier reference
we've been live all day
so we started live at noon today
because i got enough for half past nine
what's going on
wasn't it supposed to be a half nine
this morning
oh
was that the only one no no we we we we
we were late we were
oh yeah yeah
i'll pass nine that no it's half past
10.
yeah yeah look at it
season up my meat for tomorrow it makes
sense done on my washing change all the
bedding and enough for angles she's
still not on
there
i could go back and check my instagram
messages that she sent me to say oh yeah
we're doing tomorrow and i thought in a
minute but tomorrow's here
guys stop giving me a four i'm at least
a five okay
[Laughter]
rude
yeah okay fair she gets four her legs to
eight
i've seen the chats about your legs
i've seen them about your legs
you might be at four but your legs are
at eight
there was somebody out they even want to
date her because of her legs he even
said i want to take pearl like he said
i'll take her legs out
it's the it's the i'm tall we have so
much of them you know all i need is a
little dress now gucci
you know we should tell the guests we
shut out the rest of bring food to cook
that's what i said bring something out
to your cookie okay okay
because she's getting hungry none of it
[Laughter]
now when you see me you look kind of
taller
yeah when you're slimming he looks all
up i guess
i haven't been going gym
i i was on it for like a good two three
weeks but your eating has been up to par
you've been eating properly though
where's my teeth
i have been using them
they've lost them
congrats on 250k from beef let's go
250 now
you know well i'm actually already at
255. yeah
we almost we got 5k subs in like a day
look at you you got sunburn on your nose
so you need a bowl of ice cubes
[Music]
she has water it's in the back yeah she
knows where it's at i gave us some eyes
she loved it
she loves ice yeah yeah
i just give my dog frozen treats let's
go buy like
duck mixers and stuff like that and just
give them frozen
uh cameras on you paul just let him know
yeah i know
um
you're like
you're like the
you can be like the queen of the man of
sphere
[Applause]
okay everyone
you're like an honorary guest now
yeah they always say they always say you
spit facts they say auntie spitting
facts okay
it just seems like common sense to me
maybe it's not so common nowadays i
realize that yeah
see andrea we're officially freaks so
i'm not telling him that he's a freak
right you know he's officially a
freelancer she's laughing because she
knows she gets so embarrassed we were
talking i have to come out the room
because you just acting like when you
first met you're acting like teenagers
you're too old for that
i'm not which we are too old
why do you think why do you think
couples
um lose that like spark they had when
they were younger
just get caught up in life
when you have children
your mind comes before your children
your mind comes before your family
and if people especially single parents
if you got a good man and you put your
mind before your children the children
can't interfere with that it's that part
that spark still stays there
because i'm not gonna allow my child to
run my relationship
if you're used to it together as a
couple
then the child will know there's no
interference and then you can get your
sexy on
do you think do you think modern women
are lazy when it comes to relationships
yeah they don't want to put in the
effort
they don't put any effort for anything
and that's why you hear about
sexist marriages
i think that sexless marriages are
because the girls didn't actually want
to marry the guy
i think she wanted someone else and just
married him because he was there and she
was running out of time they marry them
because of what they can get what they
can do
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you
nice to meet you hi hi my name is nice
to meet you
alexandra
alessandra
but i think that's i think that's what
it is
that they just feel that oh you know
this is the best i can do
yeah yeah
what maybe they speak that that's the
best they can do so they just settle
do you think it's settling if that's the
best you can do
i think it's setting in when you don't
know that's the best you or you figure
out that's the best you can do i for
once you know it's not settling you
actually think you know what this is it
for me yeah but if you feel like
i can do better
but i'm settling yeah sometimes people
they make themselves seem better than
they actually are
because they think i can do better than
this so i'm going to settle them really
you're not settling because that's about
as good as you can get you know it's
interesting it's an insult to tell women
that they're not special
yeah but no
he told me all this week he's been
telling me you're the only woman i know
that can put on weight on her head look
how big your head is
and i didn't find it as an insult i said
i've had a big at all my life and then
he said no
your face has got big he goes when we're
talking on the phone he goes he said to
me can you put your head back a bit
because you're pulling up the screen
yeah i didn't find it as an insult yeah
because it had a big head there's
nothing i can do about that yeah but i
think that
maybe tell a woman about herself and
that should be i would rather hear the
truth from my man than hear
stomach from females because females
never tell you the truth
otherwise half of those women that go
out there with their friends dressed
like that they wouldn't dress like that
but you tell the truth right yeah so why
do you tell the truth but other people
don't
because i don't have any hang-ups i'm
not worried about anything yeah i'm not
worried about what people think about me
i'm not worried about being judged
because
i've been judged all my life and i've
had it all before and not only that i've
seen how women
women can lie to you i mean i remember
going out of a load of females and i
didn't realize that my my underwear was
fluorescent yeah so when i went out to
this nightclub and the ultraviolet
lights come on you
and i'm like why would you not tell me
because i thought you wanted to be like
that why would i want to be like yeah
you know and and that's what i don't get
but yeah if a man tells you oh no what
you're wearing is not suitable the women
have a problem do you think men should
be able to tell their girlfriends
they've gained weight
well if mine can tell i've got a big
head that i've gained weight on my face
why not yeah yeah
i just think that
if you meet someone and they're a
certain size
and you're happy with them a certain
size and then they put on weight and
then you try to help them they don't
want to help themselves i think you
should be able to step out of that
relationship yeah yeah because that is
not what you signed up for right some
and that i don't get how women they
don't know how do you not know when
you're buying clothes
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger you must know that if you're
a size 10 yeah and all of a sudden
you're buying size 16. you didn't
miraculously just get to a size 16. you
must have been buying clothes
no
true
you that's
i know that if i hit a size 12
if my size 10 are feeling a bit tight i
can't afford to come by size 12 yeah
because i've got a load of size 8 and
size 10. yeah so if i know that i'm
going to buy a size 12 then where is it
going to start am i going to fool myself
someone said oh it's different in this
right and then this different brand has
a different style and the thing is like
it's like there's healthier any size
but that's not true like you can't be
you can't be 300 pounds and healthy
i mean i always say to myself like i'm
i'm i'm fairly slim
i'm eight and a half stone
and i've got loads of illnesses but none
of them are because of my weight yeah
and i don't like when i see
fat people out there and adidas and nike
because she was seeing the gym she would
advertise him for i think his adidas
she was like a size 20.
and yeah she can roll a skate or she can
ice skate and she can do the thrills
yeah i eat myself
probably gonna be better
hold on one second
they're testing the mics hold on
[Music]
it's okay
okay uh yeah i can hear myself
i think yes it sounds good
yes
you remember jess
you're still gonna be married the way
you're carrying on the kitchen
keep it out
that's wifi material there
thanks you know
you're gonna you're gonna do you're
gonna teach us on sundays right we'll do
a new recipe every week yeah
yeah it'll be like
it'll be like from modern women to
housewives yes yeah yeah yeah bring us
back to the kitchen
i think that's where i i love cooking
and i think it's so easy nowadays
i mean you can knock up a free course
meal in an hour
yeah
yeah all right
i mean we've got all the tools in front
of them there look at everything there
once you've got the basics
you can do it
i mean i can cook i can cook a meal when
i'm drunk
you just go and you put it on you go
sleep and everything that switches
itself on or off yeah yeah do the basics
it's just there yeah
um i don't know but i think i know we're
gonna i think we're having people sub in
and out oh wow yes yeah it's gonna be
um
yeah i would get the the extra chairs
like bring something you could bring the
stool too from my room if we need it you
want me to put that
on the side try to clip them back up
no
no no
if they wouldn't hit them
we're moving it's we're moving it's not
um you could probably close the door
when it gets a little darker because the
mosquitoes are all gonna fly in
um
you can leave that one open but i think
that one we should close
i think i messed up tv
right
[Music]
i'll try it after the show we'll see
you think we're crazy for doing a
24-hour live stream
no food yeah i'm a foodie
somebody's supposed to be cooking all
the time now
just tell people this one when you come
in and bring you something to eat
i've got burgers in there you know
[Laughter]
why don't you drop us some game drop us
some game how do you how
so outside tell me the different ways
how do you keep a man
how'd you keep a man yeah open your legs
shut your mouth learn to cook
and clean that's it that's it but the
most two most important things for women
to keep a man open your legs and shut
your mouth
that's it open your legs and shut your
mouth because how'd you keep a man
yeah that's it
no it didn't even say nothing because i
know it's true
auntie how do you lose a man how'd you
lose in my hand yeah and doing the
opposite
no i mean once you get everything down i
mean that's the basis of it
auntie what does submission mean to you
submission means allowing somebody else
to take responsibility for all the
decisions that are being made
okay because me personally i'd rather
submit to a man
let's say you've got a problem you've
got a bill and you're saying women are
like i can do it myself i'd rather hand
over everything to the man
it's down to you
either it works it's down to you i'll
support you if it don't work it's down
to you are there jobs that women
shouldn't do
yes i think anything that they're gonna
ask for help with or anything that they
can't do a hundred percent
what about do you think women should
fight in wars
if they can why not men do it okay you
think it should be equal like on the
front lines if this women want equality
it goes all the way
and men can go out there and fight why
am i gonna go and send my son to go and
fight for a woman why can't she go and
fight for herself
do you think women only want equality
when it benefits us
yeah otherwise they'll be out there yeah
women are they're fine we just watched a
documentary today it's like 95 percent
of
it was like there's one war where 35 000
men died
and two women died oh [__]
that figures in there i just that sums
it up in it
but i just think it's all right women
call out for equality but i don't think
they actually know what it means reality
yeah because it's all right saying i
want to be equal i want to be equal
but if you have to say equal if you had
to wake up and say right from everything
you do with your man
you're going to split it down the middle
okay the women won't be happy yeah right
say hi
ellie all right
yeah yeah
yeah
fetish
do you think women should vote
i think if they're not feminists yeah
you think feminists shouldn't vote
but they they see the thing is is that
if you want to vote
then you gotta go for everything not
just for that
oh we're gonna vote for this we're not
gonna vote for that you have all the
rights so you have none yeah
she's the most requested guest
no it's true if you either vote or you
don't vote whether you're going to vote
vote for everything everything down the
middle i think women shouldn't vote
what's the point of voting because
because if we can't get drafted like men
get drafted then why do we get to vote
exactly if they don't do anything why
should they
it's like that's how that's how people
win elections
if i if i went to war i'd want to vote
[Music]
all right yeah my bad so guys um welcome
to 24 hour live stream um
my name is ish i'm the producer
uh we are gonna go through
some
bear with me
yeah uh so
this is our pre-game show routine of
what we do before we get the guest
started um i'm trying to get this on
camera so it's footage you know what i
mean
they are looking at me it's not it's not
a pleasant one
you look tall from the ankles hold it up
that's a taller
we're here but but we gotta get through
this come on hold it up even in the gym
keep it up there it's falling come on
now come on
no dennis
all right guys thank you for coming we
appreciate you um you want me to hold it
for you oh we still doing this
i'm good i'm all right i'm all right i'm
right no honestly um no guys thank you
for coming we do appreciate you uh we're
gonna go through some quick house rules
just to let you know what we do how
we're doing it um and as it's a little
different show we just want to make sure
you guys know what you're doing so
number one
how is our host we ask you guys please
do not interrupt her when she's speaking
she has a lot of content that she needs
to get through and more so than anything
we're trying to have a great show we
need to ensure that the content stays on
track and more so pearls here as a guide
to ensure we do that and
we want to hear what you guys have to
say so more so than anything we want to
hear you guys have your conversation get
your say in
but pearl needs to kind of direct the
conversation in the right manner in
order for us to get the content out
number two please don't interrupt each
other it is very frustrating on a
podcast for us to be speaking and no one
at home can hear us because we're all
shouting or even talking over one
another please allow each other to speak
make points i will try and interrupt
when needed to
you'll hear phrases like speaking to the
mic or guys one mic
or certain other phrases that will
prompt you to understand that we need to
ensure that we
keep podcast etiquette and speak one at
a time number three super chats will be
read super chats are chats that people
pay money to have read out loud on
stream
and when these chats are read
sometimes they can be mean sometimes
they're not
um don't take it personally it's the
internet is what it is
um yeah they'll roast the [__] out of
you yeah yeah
don't worry about it yes yeah number
four um
we have a few words we ask you guys not
to say on stream
for the purpose of this livestream i
cannot say these words but i will
give you an indication of what they are
so these words are grape
grape yep got it mm-hmm
get rid of the g
oh yeah yep sa or the
um
yep
yes wonderful these are words that we
cannot say on chat and the words that
i've used are words we can say instead
so please do not use these words on chat
or on the on the live stream uh once
again we are live
uh that goes without saying we are we're
here live right now um and
hey
hey is this heavy you know is happening
i offered
yo
okay that's done
and we'll be back in three two one with
the camera signal and we are back
yes uh we had a few technical
difficulties but we are back on track
anyway uh just to finish off
i know it looks a lot better yeah jess
you should be a videographer
yo
yo i don't know about shaking i don't
know about shaking but yeah just to
finish off guys let's have a great
conversation let's have a conversation
uh the topic is what pearl will say it
will be and more so just have fun say
your point agree to disagree we want to
have a great conversation we're trying
to learn something today and yeah let's
get into it yeah also um it's a 24-hour
live stream we mean we're streaming now
we'll be streaming so whenever you want
to leave you literally can
one last thing yeah we have
the way you guys need to speak into the
mic for anyone that hasn't been on the
podcast before is that we ask you guys
to use uh the ice cream technique so if
you're speaking to pearl like so you
twist your head while it's talking
directly into the mic
if you're speaking to my brother over
here speak directly into the mic what we
don't want is for you to be speaking
into the mic and i'm having now a
conversation with paul everyone in the
room can hear me
but nobody at home can hear me
so we must always be speaking into the
mic so that we can hear each other if
you can't hear yourself on the
headphones
nobody at home can hear you so you might
be making a great point but no one can
hear you
big importance thank you guys appreciate
you love
pro back to you
alright guys what up guys i'm gonna go
through our announcements i've done
these already on the stream because i've
been here since noon um but but i'm
gonna do them again so um
as you know we have eclipse channel um
we just launched that like i don't know
10 days ago and we're already at 18 000
subscribers our goal is to get to 50.
yeah yeah thank you
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
i don't want people to just clap for me
for things i do in my life
we've been clapping all day all right
we also have
ellie stop licking me
okay we also have four membership tiers
so the first tier you get to be a part
of the chat today we're on subscribers
only
if you guys start being rude i might
turn it on to members only so you be
nice in the chat okay
at the 10 tier you get to be a part of
our discord and you get to see our blogs
if you missed me rapping earlier on the
stream
which was amazing um i don't care what
the comments say um
you um you could see a vlog where me and
ish freestyle and ish was on some like
toxic
boy lyrics so i don't know what is she's
doing outside of the show
i don't know i don't know what you've
been up to
look look at look they're gonna see it
they're gonna see it in the vlog we were
reenacting some things yeah that one
sounded a little bit too real it sounded
like i was playing the pawn oh you were
playing i mean you didn't play the part
too well earlier yeah but this one that
one hit close to home we're playing the
part real well you just seem to know it
y'all are y'all are violin right now
anyway so if you want to know if you
want to know if you want to know what
we're talking about sign up for the 10
tier when do you think that vlog will be
out jess
hopefully within this next week in the
next season
also um follow my ig we're trying to get
to 30k i just got banned on tick tock
rip people keep asking me in the
comments update on the tick tock there's
a couple people that have a tick tock
rep that like shared theirs with me but
right now i don't have a tic tac account
it was really sad i was at 930k i was
almost going to hit my first mill on a
platform
but you know when you tell the truth
they shut you down i guess youtube's
next
yep
not too quick not too quick i'm just
saying youtube's next youtube's next oh
the next million i think meant to be
taken down oh no no no next meal next
time i was like i was like don't don't
no next meal that's what happened
youtube's next meal um also um thank you
guys for 250k
so that's that's what the 24-hour
livestream is in celebration of so we
don't just torture ourselves for fun we
do it for you um
they want to know when the next one you
know
we are not making promises just yet no
no promises on the next one because i'm
still scarred from the last one and i
think i'm going to get scarred again
tonight um
half a mil
why'd you say it what'd you say a
million a million
all right you said half a million a
million
she said half a million two million hey
you can't go back in your word you know
10 mil your word is your bond i never i
never shook on it
it's whatever the people want
260k
don't me don't make me fire you
[Music]
okay okay i'm like the meanest boss ever
the worst
horrible treatment worse the next studio
is oh
trash
living underneath the ground underneath
it's like horrible i'm making her live
in a box next year yeah yeah that's
gonna be homeless yeah basically
homeless uh you know it doesn't have a
pool which is rough yeah the squat rack
is like an assisted spot wreck how dare
they
yeah the the skyline um
it looks over london like
why not the whole uk
just london anyways hopefully hopefully
we get the place though the landlord i'd
email them to see if we got it what they
say they said they still haven't heard
from the the like i guess the dude's on
vacation okay you can be on holiday and
everything but i need to wrap it up you
got access to a phone what you doing
exactly yeah i don't understand like you
can be on a beach on your phone
we're trying to move here sir we're
trying to get out of this we're hot it's
it's hot in here right guys right yeah
yeah we're trying to move to a cooler
place
um anyway so that studio it's actually
really cool it it's um has a literal
whole like porch over the city of london
or what did you say a deck what would
you describe the terrace
terrace
so yeah over the whole city of london
and like a giant living room we plan on
doing um we're going to be doing aunt
jenny's channel when we move we're also
going to be doing um a cooking show with
aunt jenny on probably sundays where she
teaches me and jess how to cook
do i'm trying to get wifed up yeah we're
trying to get a wife um from the moment
we get we getting closer to 30 so we're
on discount you know what i mean i mean
you got some time i'm about to be
seventy-five percent off
no no it's like eighty percent off what
are you talking about
wow
how's your wall by the way my wall is
fine
far in the distance look at it no i
think you're in it aren't you i am not
what you're i'm 21 i'm 22. oh [__] [__]
and i'm the prime minister yeah of
course
um okay so so we're going to be doing a
lot of cool stuff we're really really
excited because it's so hot in here and
we need to move um also do you want to
tell them about the member of the week
tell them why you picked jess picks our
members of the week so tell them what
you picked up um i remember the week is
a zen tin so
um the way we pick it is everybody that
is a member gets generated into a
um
gets into a generator i guess names get
into a generator that's the way to say
it it's been a long day guys
um and
we will randomly select it or
if we see that there's one member that's
been just
off pumping it up off the chain
this week donating from the week before
and just been in the chat talking it up
with people and just commenting on polls
we have on the community um
chat and the member chat we will select
them out the bunch but if not if
everybody's on level playing fields then
we will put every name through the
generator so if you want if you want to
be the member of the week be extra
active in the chat
be you know doing the polls comments
we see him we especially just she reads
all your member comments she goes
through them i feel like you know them
personally i feel like they're all raw
yeah
um yeah our goal we want to get to a
thousand members so i think we're at
like what like 250 300 right now i think
we're about at 300 close to 300.
also if you want to come on the show um
our recruiter is named eddie um the way
you can find him is his link to his
instagram is in the description also on
my instagram bio has his ad in it so you
just click it dm him tell me want to
come on the show best way to come on um
honestly is if you're a guy to bring
girls because there's always a lot of
guys that want to come on um so we have
to be a little more selective with that
girls are a little harder to recruit
but either way um yeah dm him he'll get
to you eventually
so
today's topic is the red pill
we're just going through like red pill
[__]
i want to know who here knows what the
red pill is
auntie
still don't know yeah she doesn't know
i have no clue what it is josh
what is a red pill
really i haven't noticed she's just
kidding me you know what you hate me
okay
okay the red pill is based off well
loosely the concept of like the matrix
you know the red and blue pill yeah so
alternate reality and actual reality but
it's mainly based around male and female
interactions shall we say but mainly for
the men like the harsh reality truth
i don't know what it is
oh you don't know what it is either and
i've never seen the matrix
it's a classic
the idea is that like men are told one
thing their whole life
they're told to like court women treat
her nice
put her on a pedestal
and then she'll love you
and then it turns out like women like
the toxic men
okay and it's basically like the red
pill is when you you when you see the
world for how it really is and there's a
lot of different components to that like
that are part of
red pill
so um the question is the first question
i have is do you think women like nice
guys
no
i think they like them
at a certain time okay okay at a certain
time okay i'll say that
okay
yeah they definitely like it just
not every nice guy okay what do you mean
by that
um i think you can not like everyone so
just it's not like sufficient be nice
with me oh you know you just need to be
to match my vibes my energy so
say nice is not enough i can definitely
met a nice guy but it's not matching my
energy soon
do you think um women typically date the
nice guys
um yeah why not then why do they hate
men so much
i don't think they do
i don't think so i talk to girls all the
time and it's always like
they always talk about their ex as being
toxic
yeah i mean definitely i think everyone
at least had a toxic do you think
everybody's yeah definite
do you think that men are toxic
they could be or they can't be okay yeah
but it's not every man okay in the
underwear
do i think women like nice guys yeah um
short answer no
but long answer i think they like the
idea of nice guys okay so
you know someone paying them all their
attention you know all the things that
you know women naturally like anyway and
i think it also depends if they find a
guy attractive or if he's like a tyrant
or a chad because if he's a tyrant or a
chad or he's
her type he can be as nice as he wants
because
that's one of the you know he's got a
keepsake there so
overall no but i think it varies it
depends okay
yeah i was pretty much gonna say that
she likes a nice guy if he ticks every
other box okay right if he if he doesn't
then so it's like she likes a nice guy
if he's six seven yeah so she likes a
nice guy if he's rich exactly she likes
a nice guy
if
he's hot yeah exactly i understand
um i actually realized that i didn't
even let you guys introduce yourself how
rude of me um why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and where you are
from starting with auntie i'm auntie
jenny
50 free
in a really good relationship i'm real
good she was really good
real good be like that when
she's doing better than most of the 25
year olds in the world hey better than
me yeah
from that texas set audience
that one was a cool one that was nothing
i showed you
look at yeah we saw the rest of the ice
we saw the receipts don't scroll
she said don't scroll down i don't i i
wasn't about to i wasn't about to we
know the rules we know
what you got secrets in your phone
no it's just that people seem to really
think that when you get to a certain age
that you know you're just dead from the
waist down um
but i'm just hoping my man now was when
i met him 32 years ago
that's brilliant actually it is
she is hot for her man let me earthquake
sex
that's what i want
i aspire to have that my wedding night
earthquake sex
um you guys already know i'm jess for
who is new in the chat hi i'm jess i am
28 years old um
what else do you say
your name and where are you from i'm
from california and my relationship is
single
so my name is alessandra i'm italian
and
i'm 30. i just done
33 months ago
i'm single
i'm kb i'm 35 i'm from london and i'm in
a relationship
[Music]
i'm rolito i'm 35 i'm from london as
well
and i have girls that are friends
how are you guys close friends i have a
few clothes he said i have girls that
are friends
i have no girlfriend
okay i got you are they watching this
um i want to get the link so everybody
can watch it oh yeah you want to get it
for him uh yeah yeah
then yeah cool cool um
because she can send it to you guys okay
um
so going back to what i was talking
about earlier with the nice guys if
women like nice guys then why do felons
have 30 percent more kids than
non-felons
please say the question again if women
like nice guys
then why do felons have 30 percent more
kids over
non-felons felons
but wouldn't you say that women don't
actually like nice guys because they
like felons
i don't think that i didn't think
they're like nice guys anyway but if the
felons have got more kids they're doing
something right
would you consider a felon a bad person
yeah sorry convicted
why because you're breaking the law i
mean if if it's an unethical law that's
one thing but i think most laws are
pretty fair okay so just for argument's
sake
somebody
disrespects
you
for no reason uh-huh you hit them they
fall down good question i know where
you're going and they hit their head on
the floor uh-huh and you get charged
with gbh convicted do you think that's
the majority of felons
genuinely it's just like christian you
shouldn't have him
no the
yeah i mean i don't think you should
just hit people just because you feel
disrespected like i mean i the other day
i was attacked me man enough whale
attacked
and i'd like i didn't hit her she was
like coming at me and burning man
like i just i'm not trying to go i would
have it after you threw the mic i would
have it
is that the whale are you talking about
yeah the well she deserved to get [__]
she's not the mic out of your hand oh
this was here yeah this isn't i was in
shortage doing interviews this girl like
she she like didn't like the questions i
was asking and she wouldn't leave like
she kept following me and then she was
she was like come at me come at me i'm
like get away from me
and um she ends up like hitting the mic
out of my hand and like onto the ground
right
then went for the camera didn't she i
think there was something going for the
camera yeah yeah she did that too but i
mean like the reason i said that was
because i don't really believe in
like i try to stay away from the
exceptions and i'd say the rule is
felons
are
a bad people
yeah i mean
i mean bad and good is subjective but
they're more reckless they're more
dangerous
in general 30 is higher seriously 30
more kids yeah
i think honestly they just don't really
um
like
think about what having a child means so
just they have different point of view
like me personally
like i don't have any children like
because i think it's very art i mean i
give
the right
importance to be a parent so maybe they
don't that's just my
oh maybe there's nice guys just like to
hold it down in their pants
and the felons just go out there and
give it a free-fall
so maybe that's why because nice guys
ain't gonna sleep with everybody yeah
but bad boy is a bad boy's gonna take it
as he gets it so maybe that's what they
got more children
because the nice boys are just nice what
about you guys you guys are actually
dudes what do you what type of guys do
you think what kind of guys do you think
women go for well i like what she was
saying because
and i think part of this as well
especially with this specifically is
that it's there's still that notion that
women don't like sex as much as men i
think that's another thing as well yeah
and
you know a felon a bad boy whatever
because of certain traits
characteristics whatever
it's probably going to get women's
natural urges juices going yeah for
whatever reason and i think people tend
to dismiss that a lot as well like
there is that point as well and like
he's mentioning with a nice guy
albeit his treatment of you was nice
when it comes to
you know when it comes down to it
he's not going to flick that switch and
turn into that raw animal which
even the nicest of women the most meek
of women you know
you want men to handle it in the bedroom
right because you don't well you don't
feel like he can protect you if you see
if he can't even stand up to you as a
girl how the [__] is he supposed to
protect you exactly you can't even stand
up for himself to what a [__]
you're afraid of a [__]
a girl
you can't tell your girlfriend now who
are you
but just just imagine right
a nice guy
saying to a woman trying to get her into
bed
and she turns him down the night's gonna
be like all right
you turn them on their rough neck many
like what are you talking about
come on just free up and the women are
like well okay then yeah like yeah but
you know what i mean because a nice guy
be like all right then she don't want to
sleep with me so that don't sound too
consensual though
well let women just like confrontation
what do you mean sorry i say that again
well she said that um
a bad guy would be like would you mean
no
come and give it to me no i'm saying
that well you turn around as a as a
ignore a woman and see how she behaves
a nice guy would just take it yeah yeah
a fellow just like
i mean you think you're all that and
then the woman would turn around and be
chasing yeah well well the thing is that
the bad boy would walk away the nice guy
would take her out on another date in
hopes that she would say yeah
and also what you're saying is that
assertiveness as well it's again going
off the confidence and assertiveness
a nicer guy might as you said they're
kind of asking like yeah do you mind if
we can i have a case yeah like no just
kiss her yeah yeah so
it's kind of about confidence
so
but this doesn't mean that they know
nice guys
from my point of view like you can be
confident and a nice guy
so just about
how confident are you
um so another part of red pill i have a
question um do you guys think body count
matters
yes yes
hundred percent is this for both genders
yeah uh for women let's say for one and
then the firm i do women than men so
okay oh not for men no no matters for
god women yes men
not so much okay
no neither okay
i don't think it
i think it only matters
how it's put out there because somebody
a woman can have a high body count
nobody knows about it she carries
herself or even men will know about it
and she carries herself different member
treats are different
but you can have somebody without high
body cat not even as high as that
woman's body can and it's all out there
for everyone to see it's all over the
internet
then it matters because you must know
women that have got high body cats you
still respect them because of the way
they carry themselves and normally it's
the older woman not the younger woman
because there's lots of older women out
there with high body cats and people
still respect them they're the aunties
they're the grandmas
but then you get the young women now and
they got a high body can
and it's like a badge of honor
wouldn't you say it makes you less
valuable to men though the more men you
sleep
with yeah yeah the women don't know that
because they're always trying to get
that better man
what women don't know that women
definitely know that well no no it's
it's like a coke if they did why would
they be sleeping with somebody yeah
yeah i'll just um just a quick stat only
30 percent
of
wait um
when a woman gets married and she's a
virgin she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage if she slept with more than
five people it drops to 30 percent
wow
that means i'm at two percent
what did you know i mean
it's gonna be i've gotta be at two
percent or something like that
yeah it does it's not like the end all
it's not saying like every single girl
that's slept around like that's her fate
but
it's i think to say that like sleeping
around has a good
is good for women is kind of a lie that
feminism teaches go ahead i think it's
bad for women
i think it's bad for both but more so
for women because
with men there's a pride attached to it
with women there's a stigma attached to
it
so i think nowadays the women are trying
to turn that stigma into pride and it's
not working
that's where the modern women get lost
because that stigma of having a high
body count is no longer there they're
wearing it with pride i think it also
like from a male point of view it also
depends on the people she slept with to
a point as well because if for example
say you live in one of those areas and a
lot of people know each other
okay one of men's biggest i don't want
to say nightmares but hang ups is
bumping into another guy
like oh i know your girl like i know
her
sorry i think yeah you go actually the
point so
body con uh for men
so when you're approaching a girl
because it actually touching your
confidence so science you know that your
women actually slept with 10 20 other
men
you like losing confidence
and your like worry your first word is
like you know
get to know
yeah you don't exactly
left with
so it's about you not about us well but
if you give something away for free it's
not valuable
so if you if you feel free to
if you're given if you're giving it to a
lot of people it's not valuable so why
that doesn't like go
buff away right because because men and
women are different women are born with
value where men have men have to create
their values so for you to want to sleep
with a guy he's got to be tall he's got
to be good looking he's got to have a
job like he has to do things one out of
three men under 30 are virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year and
women are sleeping with five to 20
percent of guys so the reason like women
hate men is because we're all sleeping
with the same ones i'm not agreeing
about this honestly um because
the fact you as he said the fact you
slept with multiple men or whatever how
many they are doesn't really it depends
like was you actually in a relationship
with him
oh it was just occasional thing you know
and i also accept occasional stuff like
because
you know like if you match
someone and you you know you just want
to enjoy your day there's nothing wrong
with that and that's honestly no one
allow her men to tell me are less
vulnerable than someone else that had
sex just once
well it's not it's like it's not because
my body gonna be the same body
and myself gonna be the same person
after 10 20 men
it wouldn't change it's not it's not
anything about who you are as a person
but it's what men value so you can't so
so you can't go up to guys and say don't
value this because it's what they want
so that's like me selling a car and
going up to the people that want to buy
a car and say like this car and they say
no i don't want to buy that car because
it's got too many miles and you're
saying well you should like cars with
high miles
yeah
with the women honestly we're talking
about completely different
so women can't get no title like that
because when she's saying that nobody's
gonna know you have about 30 men you're
going to be as loose as hell men know
and like the thing is you know and at
the end of the day if a woman sleeps
with loads of men she's a she's a [__]
every man man sleeps with loads of women
he's a stud yeah so that goes to show
from the beginning and that's i'm sorry
you
we didn't make that rule as well no but
but that's the way it is yeah if that's
the way it is
and at the end of the day right men
can have loads of sex and it's always
going to be like women
yeah so
that's the only way i can put it you're
going to you're going to know
you can't say oh it's my body what's
going on because you tell cause you're
going to be no amount of lime and salt
can help you yeah because you get trauma
from everyone
like you can't you can't say like a very
okay that girl that came in earlier you
could tell she hadn't slept with a lot
of people because she was just so nice
and like like you can like feel it on a
girl because they're not they're not
like traumatized because if you sleep
with 20 30 40 guys the odds that one is
gonna have hurt you is like higher and
higher and higher like how do you go
through that many guys and none hurt you
come on
none you can't you kind of unscathed
i mean a man doesn't hurt you just
because you're having sex with him he
hurts you for a lot of other reasons and
doesn't matter this sex like it's not
about sex
he actually asks you when he does
something wrong i don't think it does
something wrong in bad it can do
something wrong you know in any other
occasion
actually probably they're gonna be
good in bed and then probably doing
but that's but that's like a masculine
trait is not being able to bond with men
through sex because women tend to bond
with men through sex unless they've
slept with a lot of people then they
don't why we don't just think about that
our women can enjoy sex as a man like
you different like you can imagine
catching feelings no matter what
guys in the room i'm just asking have
you ever slept with a girl that said it
was casual and then she caught feelings
yes yes um yes
have you ever slept with a girl that
casually and then she caught feelings
yeah
dude i don't know your name but yes yes
yeah give me yes or no yeah yeah okay
so four random guys are in this room all
saying this yeah what about the opposite
why do you ask me what do you mean if i
stop any kind of you know relationship
with me because we weren't talking
because we weren't talking about you we
were talking about the men yeah i mean
as a woman no me as alessandra like if
that can happen for a man it's tough to
see someone
because it was catching feeling that can
happen also with a man the only thing is
um that men usually they just don't say
when they catch him feeling because they
feel
like you know we
it's the study of people of men
so it's not allowed to say yeah i'm
falling in love just having sex with
with you so he wouldn't say that he
wouldn't say that no but like pearl said
we don't really there's always going to
be exceptions to the rule but the
reality is it doesn't work both ways and
listen if a man catches feelings for a
woman he's with that woman forever yes
he's going to stick with her
and that's the difference if a woman if
a woman catches his feelings she's going
to chase that man even though it's a
one-night stand but for mankind's
feelings then that's his woman
that is his woman simple as that because
men hold men hold access or women are in
control of sex men are in control of
relationships correct so again like it's
not it's not fun but it's just like how
the world is like there are double
standards for men and for women we're
different we don't operate the same way
and like guys are repulsed by girls that
have slept around women sleep with who
they want men sleep with who let them
yes point of view trucks
[Music]
so question for the guys how many bodies
is too many bodies
let's put a number to it depends on the
age
okay let's say so the average age the
average age of first marriage in the uk
is 31. okay what would you how many
bodies is too many bodies for a 31 year
old geez
i'm black you're first bro i'm over
double figures over double so 10 10 10
10 and up okay
20. i'll give a little yeah
now we've got to be released 20 22 years
nice man brother you're being nice you
you wouldn't want to hear 20 and yeah i
i agree with 20 i think 20. so you would
never lose you would marry a woman with
20 bodies
i marry a woman with 20 buddies
no
would you okay okay okay okay that was
too much what's the minimum
okay would you let me just ask the
question a different way would you marry
a girl with 10 bodies yes or no yes
would you marry 10 yeah yeah
well yeah what about you okay would you
marry a girl with 15 bodies yes or no
potentially potentially yeah yeah
i think 15 is the max for me okay 20. no
no it's just getting sticky
yeah
okay yes yes okay so
20 no no it's 15 is the max 15 is the
max
okay now what percent of women that are
31 do you think have less than 15 bodies
about five percent
about twenty percent twenty percent what
do you know i'm gonna ask the women this
too
go ahead 25 25 what do you think what
percent of women that are 31 have less
than 15 bodies have less than two yeah
uh just about yeah also say your name
your agent where you're from
i'm christina from hackney i'm 35. okay
welcome to the show
i don't know
wait come back to me it's okay what
percent of women do you think have less
than 15 bodies at 31
ten percent i say fifty
fifty i don't even i'm just totally
shocked when you think sixteen's a legal
age you're everybody's thinking like 40
and you're thinking 15 that's like
that's that's more than one a year
mm-hmm
wow so what are you
is that or you're shy like that's a lot
or a little that's a lot yeah
in like 14 years 15
yeah
wow and that's like going that's what's
going on now
yeah
yeah that's mostly one that's not
relationships that's just like shagging
didn't it well that's that's because
modern women are side checks because
because again it's a it's a
no no because remember it's a smaller
and smaller percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls so if you
look at dating app data like women only
swipe right like five percent of the
time up to you know 10 15 and that
that's high
so women are and the number one people
way that people meet is online dating
and so women are side chicks because
they're all sleeping with the same guys
because if you want a guy that's over
six foot that's 15 percent of men
you waving well i am
he's single if you want to be if you
want to be one of the girls
and so um
yeah so like modern women are side
chicks because that's disgusting it's a
small percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the girls
one out of three men under 30 are their
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year
so like so that indicates the trend
which is less and less and less and like
the big frustration that i hear from men
is basically that girls get ran through
by like the guys they actually want in
their 20s and then they hit like 30 and
then they're like please take me and
then they finally come around to the
like guys in their friend zone basically
at like 30.
sounds about right is that something
you've seen through the oldest one here
would you say that's a valid complaint
yeah i mean when they get older they
always try and look back at what they
could have had
but by then it's too late because
they've got loads of kids behind them
and
weird baby fathers and
i mean weird habits and
i'm just shocked about the 15. the 15.
what what did you think
okay okay at 30. how many how many what
do you think most women had from your
generation
i think you just slept with the same
person for a couple of years
but
so you would have said like five by the
end of thirty but fifty yeah because the
thing is like the girls are sleeping
with that small percentage of guys right
so those guys aren't going to stick with
a girl for a couple of years because so
but the girls because the thing is like
guys will sleep with anything so guy
that's an eight nine or ten will sleep
with a four or five or six even if he's
never seen it been seen in public with
her ever goes out there so having sex
close your legs don't do it it's not
good
and so and so it's like uh
that is disgusting
i'm thinking
15 partners in 14 years
yeah
do you think that's a lot
that's not a lot in today's generation
it's not a lot it's a i will say it's a
different time yeah it's a different
time yeah one a year no no no no we
ain't doing that no more they'll take
back my hot girl decade because that was
nothing because i could have had like
them 15 men in a whole decade let alone
oh yeah it's more like you know how you
guys slept together for a couple years
it's like a couple of months nowadays
men need to be preserving this verb and
this this
well why would they when when they have
like that small percentage of men if
they have women on a silver platter why
would they they have pride in who they
joke
why
listen because
you you wanna if you're gonna go there
sleep with a girl make sure you're not
number three number four you're gonna be
number nine number ten number eleven
number twelve number fifteen
because then you're you're fifteen
imagine if you're number fifteen
honestly
maybe honestly
honestly and you heard and you heard the
panel right the majority of my 31 have
probably slept with more
that's the question they were saying the
other day that women when the girls said
oh we can lie about it
if you have 15 by the end of by the age
of course you're going to want to lie
she was like oh what if they don't know
about the body count what if you lie
about it but guys know
oh my god do you think a man should feel
shame if he knows he's the 15th guy to
have had sex with
yeah you don't know who's been there
before you
vomit in that no man can i try and put
it into retrospect but and essentially
if a guy's the 15th guy here
he's going in knowing
i'm not staying
i'm leaving
straight after so
whoever's number 16 whoever's number 17
it is what it is yeah and then it will
get to someone who's like number 30 and
they're like
i'll wife it
and it's like that person is the one
that lost and everyone else got it for
well
i will say something on the other end
though a lot of guys do cap because
they'll come on these shows and they'll
say they wouldn't wipe a girl over a
certain account
and i know who they're dating
and i'm like
i'm just kidding
i've definitely liked girls who have had
high body counts i have but how did you
know they had did you ask them well they
they happen to be honest with me and i
take their word for it because it's not
a number that you would just openly want
to say
but
you know
it's always in my mind as much as i like
what they say what number
i just don't know what number it was a
ballpark figure
right
how do you lose count yeah it was a
ballpark figure so then so add add 20 on
to whatever she's saying
it was a ballpark figure of close to
three figures oh
shut up
wait sorry
okay
because wow
she's taking a chance having a hot girl
so much
decades
a whole decade crazy hot girl that
that's like a
that's a lot it's like a yeah but you
say you like her i did like her
before you found out the body count no
no i knew it i knew it you know what i
think i think my
i think you just thought right what
about if my friend they're gonna get to
know that that's the first line
you can't really control who you like or
who you fall for but you can control how
you deal with the situation or how you
operate or how you choose to move
forward
questions
when you found out about the body count
where you repulsed
um
i wouldn't say repulse no because i just
don't really get that surprised in this
day and age like you know three figures
yeah i know did you hit it
did you go there no why not
because it it never came about well ever
come about when you're still gone with
the three figures yeah yeah
yeah
i mean men can't undo their biology
they're biologically predispositioned to
want to spread their seed but they're
also biologically predispositioned to
want to want to ensure paternity so like
historically if a girl slept around they
don't know if the kid she's having is
his and that even still happens nowadays
like you see videos all the time where
this dude that's been raising a kid for
10 years finds out this kid is in heads
and girls can do that legally there's no
ramifications
where if guys don't play child support
they go to jail but a girl can trap a
guy and
crazy so mori made a whole career off
that real [__] yeah and so like guys
can't undo how they feel about it
i don't think like that automatically if
she
has a high body count and if she is in a
relationship she actually you know love
the men she's been with she's gonna
sleep automatically with someone else so
easily that doesn't honestly
we should like distinguish between when
you single are you free to do whatever
you wish and when you are in our
relationship so it doesn't mean you're
gonna be not loyal
do you know what i mean like
it's more likely your habits are who you
are
okay why you need to label someone just
because yeah it's based on your it's not
based on your actions so same for men so
i would say men can actually is actually
allowed to have high body count so what
i what i supposed to think if i'm
actually going to marry them they're
gonna cheat on me
like women but women don't women women
don't care because that's why i'm i'm a
woman and i can't as well no so women
women don't care you don't see girls
lining up to date drake and saying oh no
his body counts too high how will i get
like no no
but but the opposite of that brittany
grant grayner griner whatever her name
is like guys are like oh jesus christ oh
no no no no
yeah because brittany and she's
beautiful
your habits like make up who you are so
if you've been doing something for a
decade how like just like if a guy
cheated on every single girl before you
he's probably going to cheat on you too
duh
personally for me if the guy's body
count is like the three figures i'd be
just as disgusted don't matter if he's
drake chris but i don't care i'd be
repulsed to be honest with you
if it's 50 depending on how old he is
again i'd still feel a bit icky is it oh
yeah no you're gonna be icky would you
want to marry a virgin
i wouldn't mind you wouldn't mind
marrying a virgin you'd want to like
tell him what to do i wouldn't mind
because it's not
it's not an issue for me if he ticks
every single box and then it turns out
he's a virgin
to me i wouldn't i wouldn't be fast
could you name could you name five of
your boxes
name five of my boxes
so
ambitious
god fearing like prayerful
um
loyal as well
funny sort of sense of humor
and
i can't think of a fifth one when you
say ambitious is there a dollar amount
no ambitious like driven wanting
something for himself and not just so
he's making how old are you so you're 31
35 35 how old would you date
the oldest i would they yeah
probably 40. so if he's 40 and he still
makes 30
i don't know the conversion like thirty
thousand us dollars which would be like
twenty twenty like twenty thousand um
twenty thousand pounds would you be cool
with that he's forty he's had time to
get there
if he's if he's trying to get somewhere
and he's not just what if he gets what
if he gets nowhere
because i'd i'd sense that he's not
ambitious and it would put me off right
but i think like a lot of times it's
kind of disingenuous to guys because
girls will say there's no price but you
have one in your head
and there is a price he either has to be
working towards that like towards it or
there but if he doesn't get there within
a certain amount of time your ghost
you're gone no but
you can't really put a time frame on i'm
giving you a time to become successful
but no i'm saying and you might not know
everyone to want to get there and
actively trying to get there does that
make sense
you might not know it like like you
might not have thought about it but like
in some level you're not going to date a
bum forever so if he if he's
i wouldn't have
if he's a bum
and he's not ambitious i wouldn't be
attracted to him
yeah but i'm saying there's a there's a
doll there's a minimum dollar
so
okay would you date a guy that's
homeless with no job i wouldn't meet a
guy that's homeless in my job where
would i meet you you pass them every day
but why would i approach you you
probably couldn't even approach me or
how would that work right but i'm saying
you there's a minimum requirement you
have
not just related to like my mom
no it's not a bad thing i don't think i
don't think we should date bombs what
i'm saying like you're avoiding the
question what was the question
what's the minimum amount of money you
need a guy to make
i don't know more than me i don't know
it's the same as me or more okay what's
roughly you don't have to
i don't want to say my how much i make
but the same as me or more thus he can't
make less than you right basically yeah
okay why not well i'm not saying he
can't but i would prefer i'm saying what
i prefer is if he was the same level as
me or making more if he's making less a
bit less and actively trying to
progress within his career then there's
nothing wrong with that counters out
something he said about the boxes
what are your boxes and it was the
virgin
and you said you'd take on a virgin
virgin wasn't the book
no she said
she said
what are your boxes when he said about
yeah she no woman ever says sex
if it was a man wouldn't that be one of
your boxes
you know you said that if he was over
and you ticked your boxes yeah as a man
wouldn't sex be one of your top boxes
i'm just asking as in would i marry a
virgin
no are you getting sick
you know you said ever man every woman
takes all your boxes right is it sex one
of your boxes
um
do you think would you ever have could
you have a happy relationship
without having that box sticks without
having sex or without having good sex
good sex
yeah i could still have a
pretty successful relationship not me
yeah so youtube you have them
i don't believe you yeah i mean look i
know that's one of my main boxes no no
no because i'm saying everybody's
talking about oh i want to be nicer
compatible
but you won't know that until you have
sex with him that's why
that's why when women say they want to
have a virgin to me
i teach in a man
because i ain't got time if i'm a virgin
he's a virgin fine but i am not gonna go
and pick up a virgin
f
sex is one of my boxes and sex is one of
my boxes it should be a man's box too
because if you're not getting good sex
from your woman go elsewhere safely for
women i'm sorry but how could that's why
they've got sex marriages out there yes
how can you be having
like you be oh yeah i'm happy well sex
is not one of my boxes she knows that
sex take one of your boxes then when the
sex is gone what are you gonna do then
say oh but i like her personality
actually i have a question do you think
it's fair for women to expect monogamy
from men if they gave their best years
to another man
you want to start
he's a little nervous
no give your best to the one you got and
if you can't give him your best and he's
going elsewhere
then you can't blame him
i'm sorry but like i said before no man
no man no woman should put up with bad
sex
and if a man is having bad sex it's the
woman's fault
it's the woman's fault because if you
get a man a male virgin and a woman
he's gonna have bad sex anyway she's
gonna teach him rubbish just to keep him
down there but if you get a man who's
had lots of sex and a virgin he's gonna
teach everything he knows to make sure
that she can perform properly so as far
as i'm concerned if you are with
somebody and you're not getting good sex
from them
i'm not talking about making that
because we're an audience is making up
making up that's the lift of christmas
birthdays whatever minutes when i have
sex if the sex ain't good
get rid because i'm sorry but there's
too many men then having sexist
relationships and it's wrong
all these feelings about oh i want that
personality i want this and that why
doesn't that work the other way you said
that the man can teach the virgin
woman
how to have good sex but why can't the
woman who's had a lot of sex teach the
virgin how to have this why is it not
well i just i just think if women were
lined up for virgins then one out of
three men wouldn't be virgins
wait say again if women were lined up to
date virgins
if that was true then one out of three
men wouldn't be virgins
i don't get it
the male virgins
oh okay one out of three men under 30
haven't had sex in the past year or are
virgins one out of every three men
so like if women wanted virgins they're
there
but how would you know
i still think and that falls into that
how much confident she was sorry say
that she was talking about earlier with
a man approaching you nobody was talking
earlier and he mentioned confidence that
confidence comes from experience with
women over time so that same confident
guy you want to approach you he's not
going to get that confidence unless he's
had that previous experience including
sexual
so
you won this guy with this low body
count that's not the same sort of guy
confidence like i don't think it's like
just related to sex obviously yeah if
you had had you know multiple women like
you had a lot of experience you're
probably going to be a tiny bit more
confident but i think like you know how
do you acting by this kind of even you
know inside you or you have it or not
like it's not really about how
the men many
bring it at you a man can bring out a
woman but how often does a woman bring
it out of a man is that because you're
speaking from a woman's perspective so
you wouldn't know woman so i can only
speak from well i had around with men so
i i got male friends
most i say 99 of my friend a male
they're not getting enough sex
and they're not getting enough sex how
they want it where they want it whenever
they want it and it's the women that are
like holding this key to sex
like
that's why i can speak from a woman
because there's men out there you can as
a woman that's had ex-partners you can
look at your partners and see where the
women have done them wrong
you can know because the women at
teaching the women are so quick to open
their legs but not their mouth to say
excuse me but mate but what are you
doing down there that's wrong fix up or
this is how you're supposed to do it but
there's too many men there's too many
women out there now having bad sex
because of the men's previous partners
not teaching them properly
[Music]
interesting that's not well i guess i
guess as a girl but how do you know it's
bad
you must have a lot to complain like
nice pass yeah
right after that's not running and i'm
not shivering they might be saying about
the earthquake no i'm saying you have to
have a lot to compare it to to know it's
bad
no no you can just know how you feel
because if you go and you relax yourself
and you free up and you trust the man
that he knows what you're doing you're
gonna have good sex all the time
um okay what you want to answer the
question um i mean i personally so like
this might sound controversial but i
feel it's unrealistic to believe a man
should be with one woman
okay so i agree
that you know they shouldn't expect it
from a man but i feel like everything
comes down to control so as a man if you
decide you're going to go into a
relationship you have to decide to
control yourself and choose to be
faithful
what if your woman is a freak
what would that what would that do no
she's up for anything with you sexually
but you're still gonna go as well it
doesn't matter you're still gonna go out
swimming if you wanna go elsewhere
you're gonna go you can have the perfect
woman in the world
if you wanna cheat you cheat it doesn't
matter there's i do not believe there is
anything a woman can do to stop a man
from cheating if he wants to cheat
sorry do you agree that not all men
cheat
hold it down bro do you agree that not
all men should speak your truth
some men don't
no i'm saying not all men cheat yeah no
that's fine then
what one thing i can i i have yeah so
one thing i will say is i think men
exercise their options
right so most men
women don't find them attractive and
therefore they don't have options to
exercise
and therefore they cannot cheat whereas
the top percentile of men
have options to exercise therefore they
can cheat and if the woman that is with
them
feels a type of way wants to leave
he's like okay
i'll just add a new girl to the rotation
and he's able to get a plethora of girls
because he's got the option to exercise
his will to cheat
yeah that's fine i just i just don't
believe that all men cheat no there's a
minority that don't i agree i think yeah
but i think you'd agree most do if they
can yeah yeah if they could but but most
men can't
and that's mostly [__]
what most men in relationships can't
cheat
um
so what about you do you think it's fair
that women expect monogamy if they gave
their best ears to another man ah no um
definitely not definitely not what would
you define as a woman's best years go
ahead okay well i'll put that into the
same sort of especially with that
particular male or man
usually her child's dad her first love
is usually that type of person
you know he's usually he's usually got
everything else out of her by the time
you've come across her whatever the
scenario is
you are getting the after bits there's
going to be memories of him be it in a
relationship sexual whatever
you know there's going to be especially
if they've got a child there's an
imprint i've seen it loads of times you
know people have broken up they've got
with someone else as soon as the kid dad
come back in the picture gone they're
either sleeping together or they're back
together so
if a woman's had her best years with
another male
[Music]
to me she she's actually his to be
perfectly honest and i found a lot of
the time that there's that one
particular guy is there a certain age
that you would say
in and around 30 30 ish very midfield it
depends what she's kind of done up to
then okay um
but to be fair about sort of like the
mid-30s then by that point it's like
yeah
what do you think is it fair to expect
monogamy if you've given your best years
to another man
because because it's like if
men value purity and youth and we don't
have that to give to him how can we
expect like monogamy when they can't
fulfill their mating strategy
is this
are you speaking like from a new
relationship or they've been together
for years and now he can cheat because
she's given her best like so so what i'm
saying is relationships are an exchange
and men and women want different things
like we want resources we want together
tall and that can protect you we want
resources protection provisioning guys
want youth purity
peace
and so if they can't fulfill their
mating strategy which is to get a girl
with low mileage that's young
why would we expect them to give to
forsake their mating strategy which is
to spread their seed
but then so isn't that kind of an unfair
deal for men so then if if you
then why would you stay with that person
and cheat
if if the pers if the woman's not giving
you the youth and whatever whatever
why keep her there and cheat on her when
you can just
leave and be with the youth that you
want that's my thing like i don't
understand
but i'm saying well is it fair that
women expect it over a certain age
that's the question
because you give your best years to
someone else
she's talking about going into a new
relationship yeah i know but if you're
going to a new relationship and say this
is the car and the car has been used for
the last 15 years don't have a spy a
date honestly speaking like who said
that we gave our best to someone else i
don't even know my maximum or my best
probably i never done to to no one my
best because i don't know i give
honestly
someone before i don't know if i get the
maximum i can't i don't know maybe i'm
gonna find tomorrow man i'm gonna give
actually the best of myself who said
that i already gave to someone else it's
about what they think is the best it's
not about you because you're not the one
buying so the guy the guys think is the
best
yes what they think
men from the ages of 20 to 80 all think
that girls are the most attractive
around 22 to 24. okay but like this is a
man that cannot stand on his own like
honestly because
if you honestly think that he can't
stand on his own yeah because like they
actually mind about what other people
think because if you're telling me that
after like you're saving men for their
standards that's shame shame and soul
guilt need to be no that's just my point
of view i'm saying that i don't have an
inspiration doesn't mean that after
because i had six year uh relationship i
gave my best to someone
no
like if a man think this it means that
he's not that confident to like get my
best because if you are a proper man
you're going to get my best let's see
that's a shame if you're saying like if
you don't know no no no i just don't
want you i know i'll tell you why
because you're saying if you're a real
man if you're a proper man then you
would think like me but that's shaming
men for what they want it doesn't it
doesn't have to think like me i just
don't want to mend the thinking this way
just give me a loan do you know what i
mean i want to amend that it comes with
confidence say i'm going to get the best
of you
point like i'm not spying like just
because i'm 30 or
yeah do you think you determine what the
best years are do you think they
determine what the best years are i
think we pick each other we should we
should actually pick the best for us me
and the man also okay what do you think
i think it depends on the situation
it depends on your ages where you're
writing your life
obviously men prefer younger women so
what age ranges are we saying are their
best years
i mean
it's different for i didn't say an age
so you could say 40 you could say 45 you
could say 35 you could say 30. that's i
don't i don't tell the men what to do
they're 45 on average
men prefer younger women and women
prefer older yeah so i'm guessing the
man is older
so
so why wouldn't she expect monogamy like
is he going to go younger than the 40s
i'm saying okay i'm saying isn't that a
unfair deal for men because he's not
getting the things that men value
it depends on the age to say say you're
50 and you're going out with a 40 year
old
what would you want bro like
but the question okay so the reason i
ask this is because i think a lot of
women would have better results if they
took that off the table but they think
they're a higher value than they are
because they're they're selling the same
price they had at 22 that they that they
are asking for at 35 45 even though
they're on sale they're on discount
because you're you're not you're not
sorry
you're telling men what to think i'm not
telling i'm saying in this room i'm
talking about now she can't even say it
with a straight face no no i'm saying
that you're saying value me value me for
my experience but like they don't want
that they don't care you just said
that
your value is is dropping in the sexual
marketplace yes well sex isn't all that
you bring as a woman you bring more
things to them you bring more things
than just sex if it's just sex then
do you want to do you want to marry
someone you can't have sex with no do
you want to marry someone you can't have
something do you want to marry do you
want to marry me oh
for women for women not for men okay how
big is sex to you in a relationship well
it's
it will play
it will keep me in a
relationship no honestly like one
question
may i like do you had best sex with uh
like 18 20 years old girl or with a 30
35 40
women i i don't really tend to rate sex
like that when i go into sex no because
we're saying that we're dropping by age
so nobody's asking from your point of
view just you know i'm not saying to you
you know what she's saying is about men
as a collective yeah that's why what
she's saying is correct speaking to the
matter bro yeah and what she is saying
is correct because when women get to a
certain age men do see them as less
valuable yeah why i'm asking why because
she said youth purity you
you automatically see a younger girl she
looks younger she looks more attractive
you think that you hope that she's
has less mileage than an older woman
so naturally your first thought is i'm
dealing with someone who hasn't been run
through who doesn't have a higher
mileage her face moves there's no like
botox for hers right
so all of this now is it about going
into new relationships that's the point
i'm trying to get to yes is that what
you is that so so the point is okay if
you're coming to a guy
over a certain age is it fair to expect
monogamy when you gave your best years
to someone else is that a fair deal is
that no i'm saying is that a fair deal
for men to be monogamous to you when
some other guy got your best years it's
unfair to assume that a woman's given
all her best years to someone else
because but you're telling men what to
value now i'm not telling men i'm saying
it's unfair to assume that a woman has
given her best to someone else okay so
that's like going up to guys and say
they're saying hey you know i like 22
year olds maybe maybe 27 22 to 27.
that's that's what i think's the best
and then you're going up to guys and
saying well that that's not my best
years i think my best years are 30. when
they're like um
when you say best what do you mean the
most valuable the most valuable but
valuable in what way and
the market wants it the most okay so are
you talking about bearing children or
bearing children the way you the younger
bearing children the way you look um low
less bodies
everything but if everyone's ever if
someone is 40 and she's had less bodies
than a 20 year old and she looks younger
than the 20 year old who's more valuable
then
again because because you're looking
you're looking for an extreme excitement
show me show me one more time
show me one show me 140 show me one 40
year old that looks younger than a 20
year old i'm 35. i'm just younger
honestly speaking you don't want 20.
honestly i never said 20. yeah yeah
i'll give you 30. they're like 20. okay
that's from you one minute okay but i'm
i'm
in general
i people don't believe me when i say my
age so if a woman like myself who
doesn't look her age whose body count is
lower than a younger person who's been
run through as you're saying
would that mean that i'm less valuable
or more valuable than a younger girl who
looks older than me and has had more
bodies in in the marketplace you would
fall into an exception you would find
that men are extremely surprised
potentially to the point they probably
may not believe you but if we're talking
about a collective
most women will tell you that
from 18 to 25
they got the most attention from men and
after those years it dwindled and that
is the point she's making what she's
making is when you get to a certain age
you become less desirable
i can't believe it
because
and that's why it's blowing your mind
well but even at 30 but even at 35
exceptions ninety ninety percent of your
eggs are gone by thirty so guys
no i'm like what i'm not i don't
of your eggs are gone by 30. so if a
guy's looking for a wife he wants
someone that can give him kids so you're
less valuable because you are less
likely to give him kids and you are more
likely to lie about your body count so
you could say oh i have a low body count
but a guy's not going to believe you
he's like 35 you've been in the streets
for 15 years yeah okay
i don't see the sense in lying but i'm
speaking like i said i'm the exception
or whatever my eggs dwindling after 30.
i think that's really
awful to say that a woman's value is
less because her eggs i said in the
sexual marketplace okay well in the
sexual marketplace a woman's value is
less because their eggs whatever because
someone could be 18 or could be
diagnosed with an illness and they can't
have kids ever or there's probably women
that don't even want to have children
and they're living their best life but
when you're when you're arguing when
you're arguing the extremes that means
you are because you don't have a good
argument because that's not the rule and
you know i'm i'm just i'm just throwing
it out though i'm just saying it it's a
bit odd
go ahead can i just say that
i don't know why women just don't get it
because is it women or me could just say
me
agree with you you're not the only ever
want to say you ought to say you but i'm
just saying women as in general
because
it is because 35
right you can be looking good at 35 and
you can get with a man at 35 and say
you're gonna have
you're gonna get with this man you're
gonna have a five-year relationship with
him and then start having kids
think about your 35 you're gonna start
having kids at 40. it's not going to be
the same as somebody who is 20 being
with that man for five years and having
children it doesn't matter how good you
look it doesn't matter about your body
because you can't beat
biology
that's what's going to happen no but see
this again like what you're saying andy
is
is a is a great point it's like women
don't get it and
the facts are it's like
women can come out and say i want
someone who's
six foot plus two that drives a nice
german car that makes x amount of money
a year
and men have to accept that
men say
i want a woman who's got a low body
count
who doesn't go out
and
who looks good
and it will get challenged you can have
it both ways
instead of listening to what we want
you have to challenge it and then you
get confused about why men straight so
like when she's saying men will go for a
younger woman
the stats are there that men are more
attracted to younger women
instead of looking at it and saying okay
well that's that's the just the truth of
the matter the same way short men accept
women like taller men
women need to accept that men have
certain standards
and that is what the facts are and the
thing is why is it that
when
when a woman tells a man this is what i
want the men gotta listen
but when the man is saying this is what
i want the woman like no no no no no no
no no no no guys
i don't think we were saying that we
don't accept she just i just don't give
up i don't i don't care she's like
it's not like he is not the only man in
this
world like they think in this way cool
like he's gonna find his 20 years old
girl okay give free child and whatever
like we are setting that we are setting
that we just think in a different way
which is a completely different thing
but if the car we are certainly cool
like as i like a six-foot guy and you
are setting it i'm fine with you getting
taken out at 20 years old girl
i'm looking good i can get any man i
want you know why because i might have a
low body cam but i'm going to be what
all the men want you know what i mean
rubbish
and you can't get blood out of a stone i
don't care how good i look you can't
breed after a certain amount if you
gonna say oh yeah the upset she could
have a baby at 40. yeah you want to go
and be in the at the playground 65. that
all women want in school
but the women don't want children but
it's what they're doing one mic one mic
one minute it's what the men want and
the most women are not listening to when
the men talk but men somehow have to
shut up and listen to where women are
talking i'm not telling about what you
want when the man's telling you what i
want a man saying this is what i want
and the women like nah nah nah nah nah
you don't want it because i'm all this
or or
or no okay okay okay stop over talking
stop over talking
no no no that's rude you're being very
rude this is my show no no you're over
talking me you're over talking to me
trying to stop me stop stop stop wait
wait till i'm done you can wait till i'm
done or the other way is they say they
don't care but if you're selling a car
you have to study the people you're
selling to
and you don't go up to the people that
are buying and say oh you should want me
this is what you should want go ahead
the point i'm trying to make is you're
it's like you're assuming that you're
putting me in the box of people that are
saying oh no you can't want that because
i'm this way have me as i am i never
said that i said no i said people should
go for what they want if you want a 20
something year old woman go for that 20
sovereign woman that wants a 40 30 year
old man if there's a 30 year old woman
or whatever who can't have kids or
doesn't want to have kids or is too old
to have kids or whatever and she meets
someone that is happy to have her then
that's like it shouldn't be a combative
thing where it's like women don't listen
and and men listen and she should have
to settle and she'd have to listen to
what women want blah blah if there's a
man that is four for eight and he wants
a tall woman and the woman doesn't want
him he has to accept it if there's a
woman that's 37 38 and there's a guy
who's earning a lot of money ticks or
boxes he doesn't want her because she's
old just to accept it that's the point
that i was trying to say in the
beginning was would you blame a man for
stepping out
if you had given
somebody else your best years and this
is why the men were saying what the best
years are but the women
do not want to hear from the men what
the best years are and when it comes to
what the best the best years for the men
biology takes a main part of it so it
doesn't matter how old you guys matter
and you guys were arguing about what the
best years were because you said gave
your best years to someone else that's
where i was a bit what do you mean gave
my best yeah it's not just the success
experience it's the it's that whole
especially when you've had a child for
someone else especially
i will say majority of men legacy is
very important do not yes so but there's
a lot of baby mamas around okay okay
hold on hold on and then this falls in
with the age thing as well because as we
were saying the older you're getting the
more baron you're becoming so then
because you're older you should accept
that a man will cheat on you is that is
that what we're saying we're a dialogue
you could die alone too so yeah but we
don't that's the point guys like not
every woman need a man like it does want
to step out step out like when we are 30
that's my value when you say oh you know
20 anymore so you don't have any value
no i actually my value is that i can
stand by my own i can pay my bills i'm
independent and this is because i'm
party because when i was 20 i was
probably looking for a man to you know
help me out in you know just to in order
to you know are you going to be happy 60
without a family by yourself yeah
because in in the world i can do a lot
of things i can travel i can i can if i
cannot have my own baby i can adopt it i
can have a pet i can do whatever else
i'm not just a bloody baby machine
honestly
i'm not a baby machine so my value it
doesn't depend from how many eggs i uh
still have children
i don't know i still don't i've never
found a man that let me think okay let's
have a baby still so if
i don't
if you find the right man right at 35.
you get in the relationship at 35
when are you going to think about having
a child i don't know that can happen in
six months that can happen in two years
time that's not uh you know calendar and
we don't planify our life day by day
things just happens and i just don't
feel like i'm less valuable than 20
years old i'm just different did you
know one out of three women under 30
have fertility issues one out of
everything
our food is different today so so
i don't use a knife i want to tell you
so like so i i i know but i'm saying for
the right guy so if you found the guy
that that you would have a kid with like
that that's more of a risk when you're
older yeah you can he's free to go a 20
years old if he's just won't think about
me as a baby machine it's free to go
with a 20 years old one girl i'm fine
i'm just functioning about my age i'm
happy
yeah we're talking about baby right now
so i just answered the question your
value
my value i'll explain to you i explained
to you just now that my value is not
about how many when men i slept with
it's not about how many eggs i contain
still because i'm not a baby machine my
value is about how many money i can make
because i probably can make more money
than a man out there
is about how what i can deal with life
every day i don't need a man this is my
value okay i stand by my own this is my
value so the question is can you find a
man that can stand next to me and deal
with me yeah when you say that's your
value to him but who's that yeah for me
i don't i don't need
like when you're selling something she's
talking about cars when you're selling
something it's you you decide the value
of your
fire does yes the market the market does
so so okay that's like me saying okay
i'm envy like an nba why an nba player
would be stuffy that's like that's like
that's like okay stop stop interrupting
me that's that's like me saying that i
can get a top one percent guy so i would
say i deserve a guy that can that can
that makes half a million but none are
lining up to buy me then i'm not i'm not
worth that that's your value and so so
you can't just tell men oh i'm still
just as valuable you need to tell
nothing but you just did you just went
off on the right side so
you just thought
i'm going to repeat clearly so i know
very clearly what i want okay now as i
as you said probably i'm not available
so i don't want to get what i want cool
i stay by my home i don't need a man
like oh i get what i want i guess i can
just say buy my own i don't need a man i
don't ever child
i'm like a person i'm not a baby machine
i'm not do you know what i mean like
that's my
for what you're values you don't sound
very happy about that no i just don't
i'm not very happy about how another
other women can think about our body and
our essence
i'm telling you what men want
but you can you can think in your way
and that's that's perfect it's not no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no i've
talked about i've talked to thousands of
men yeah cool over there
men approach her and then she's saying
the value that she brings to the man
that is approaching her whether he
chooses to go to her or or wants a 20
whatever obviously he's approached her
so he likes her right so that's the
value that she brings that's that's the
point but i'm saying i've never talked
about you guys i don't know
the question is is that fair to expect
monogamy so i'm saying over a certain
age you're less valuable to men and then
as soon as i say as soon as i say that
you guys get triggered no no and you and
you and you guys you keep you keep
interrupting this
is this is this is this is my this is
she i don't know no i'm saying
stop when she stops
stop stopping
her mic
stop this is rude this is my show oh
it's very rude to interrupt the host
okay so sorry like this is disrespectful
sorry carry on and so i'm saying that if
you're going to men and telling them
what they should value and every time i
say this is what men value you guys you
keep arguing with it then you want to
say well what are my best years this
this this and this i get that but i'm
just saying she asked the question and
said that this girl said she's 30 and
then you said you're 30. so when you get
to 30 you made it personal about her but
i don't know why no no
i don't know
yeah she said once she gets to 35 and
then her eggs blah blah blah she asked
her something personal about her so
that's why it got personal because you
made it about honestly that's why she
was talking about herself and not saying
that you expect all men to accept this
value blah blah blah the point is if if
a certain man approaches her and this is
the value that she gives or she brings
and the guy doesn't want it then that's
fine
i can understand that you're saying that
this is men want xyz men want
um whatever you said from a certain age
or whatever as if to say
no man approaches a 30 or 35 year old
woman when there's two 30 year old women
sat here who men approach
well there's a difference between like
force that like like it doesn't count
unless you're getting a
none of it counts yeah it doesn't yeah
it doesn't it doesn't yeah
you can be approached your number can be
taken your instagram can be got but if
you're not being kept it doesn't matter
you can tell any man
i get moved to 10 times a day
cool all right do you have a man no
maybe we don't i remember because we
don't want men like the majority of the
men okay so it's not about you taking
women is about we like each other we
find genetic match so you cannot talk
about um as someone they've been taken
by again so
i learned something today yeah yeah
auntie
we me and auntie had a conversation rt
explained to me i said are you in a
relationship she said yeah i'm in a
relationship and i said does that so
does that mean you're not part of the 35
and over
leftover women which was a topic that we
were speaking about at the time and she
went
i'm still part of that category and i
said i don't get it like you're in a
relationship you've you've made it and
she went no
i have i've got i haven't got a ring
so i'm still a part of that category and
i didn't get it because i was like
why you're in a committed relationship
you where you well actually it's all
because i'm in a committing relationship
but i'm a leftover oh i'm a leftover in
a committed relationship that was it
that's what i actually said and even
when you was talking about the value
the difference with now is that yeah at
25 i was hot do you know me i was hot
slim hot you stink that's
nah you are just fooling myself
i don't know what i look hot for
somebody of 53.
yeah i mean but i'm fooling myself that
i look as hot as i am at 53 as i did at
25. no i'm just the obsession is that
the same man that i was with at 25 is
the same man that i was with now do you
i mean but other than that no
i don't see that and i'm not fooling
myself to say that you know i mean i was
lucky enough that he had my best years
and he's still got my best years and i
had his best years but at the end of the
day i can't turn around and say i'm
better off for anybody else at 53
because anybody else at 53 must have got
a wedding ring on they'd be married or
something like that by the end of the
day if it weren't for a fluke i'm just
like everybody else
i'm a leftover
in a committed relationship and that's
what women feel to realize that
yes before you think about
oh i'm gonna be single i'm gonna be this
and i'm gonna be that you gotta fix
yourself you know what
because before i started thinking like
that i was like you know i gotta get my
pension i gotta get my own house i gotta
get the house done in case i'm disabled
i gotta get my will gotta get my lpa
because
just in case you end up on your own
and you know something 32 years and i'm
still got that mindset you know what
because i'm still left over because i've
still got to think like that so i'm
going to think to myself yeah i've been
with the guy for like 30 something years
i got stuck i'll still think like that
you know what because i've
and say i've got the same worth to him
as i was years ago or i look you know i
mean oh yeah you're a hot come on 53
right now
the goal is marriage then is that the
goal should always be marriage because
that's when you know what guy is
committed to you and that's why i said
you can be a woman for today i was
talking the other week and i was saying
a man could be with you for 30 years 40
years 50 years whatever so there's a
ring on your fingers not committed to
you it can step out so you said you've
been with the same person that you've
been with since you were 25. no it's
before that yeah so since you were
before 25 and did you have kids or no we
got two separate children you've got two
so you've not had kids together now
since since you've no we haven't okay
that's interesting
and i can go around and say oh yes when
i was 35 i looked really good and we
could try and have children together
come on by the time you're 35 you picked
yourself yeah i could have better kid at
35 of him but then you gotta think to
yourself
how old am i going to be when i get the
kid goes nursery am i going to be with
i'm going to go and pick up my grandkids
now i don't want to be going picking up
my child and they're saying who's that
is that your grandma no it's my mommy
and then nowadays you're thinking about
secondary school or university i don't
want to be you know
70 years old and kind of picking up my
child and say oh yeah they graduate and
you're playing with fire because um the
average if you want to freeze your eggs
and go that route like that it costs
like 25 000 there's no guarantee it'll
work the average person can afford that
no i'm just thinking it's interesting
because you said you were together from
before you were 25 so what like 22 23
about that 22-23 and then
but you you were in the like you guys
said the best years of your life
whatever and still didn't have kids
still having them
sorry you're still i'm still having them
no no i'm just going by what these i'm
saying by the way by the worth from the
they said that i wouldn't have a child
from 35 onwards so according to a man if
a man wants to have a child and that
that would have been the time to get to
have a child then
not like 30 because by the time 30 comes
we like forget it and she's not i mean
forget it because i'm putting my body
through that by
according what um
say your name again kb kb
he said especially when a woman has a um
a child with uh before
that's the best year also because
there's a very strong and close
relationship between you know the your
your baby uh that and
yourself right
so but you are actually just showing
that that's not true so yeah because
the difference is you don't know my
story the difference is that i had an
abusive relationship that's why i've got
no hangouts
completely different if it was a happy
relationship and i had my son and we
left
that'd be different
but i number one i was on contraception
when i had my son so he wasn't planned
and because of that reason that's why i
decided to have one child because i
would say one is a mistake
two you can say is an accident three is
careless for and above your what list
so as far as i'm concerned i had one out
of wedlock and that is it yeah but
anyway you had a child and your partner
evaluate you anyways as a valuable
viable woman so he actually spent after
the best here with you in this scenario
i wouldn't judge you monogamy no i mean
this is just confidence he spent the
best today i agree with you that what
you guys saying it doesn't happen no
anything
is not good
all right yeah
what they're trying to say is that if
i'd met him at 30
why should he be faithful to me when
i've given my best years to some other
man if i stayed with my baby father yeah
until i was 30 and then said you know
what i'm gonna get back with
the first one the one i'm with now
why should he be monogamous why should
he stay with me because you have low
enough stuff no because i've already
given up my good life my good the best
of my life when i was young free
sexy agile fling my legs over my
shoulders was all between the ages of
20.
because because of this
no i don't know because
it's you're it's not valuable to match
yeah like because
you don't you don't you don't have the
youth and you don't have the purity at
30. it's gone so it's you don't have
what men value okay as i said
first of all right now uh 20 years old a
girl cannot have purity anymore because
they probably
lose their virginity when they 12. but
let's forget about it so if that the
point that means that every woman that
uh as child a child before or yes
relationship important relationship
before could not have a husband later
and i saw a lot of people that actually
had child
before and after they get married or
whatever so what do you mean that uh the
man they actually you know
wifey air is uh
i don't know it's a bum like
a bum well men don't i don't care about
your job like you could like you could
do nothing and like men do not give a
[__] like because you said earlier like
i make money and i'm like well not to
men that's like a shoe collection to
women like a guy if a guy says if a guy
says oh i have a cool shoe collection
we're like oh that's cool but then we
keep moving that's that's how men feel
about work
okay so they like
they'd prefer a girl that like does
nothing so she can like hang out with
them and like don't on them
good yeah i mean
one one person can get married
unemployed not two
yeah unless you know she looked like
michael
honestly speaking um me myself because
we're talking about what are men
expecting from our women but we're not
talking about what are women expecting
is expecting from a man and then because
we always hear it
because we always
no no did you did you in my point oh
like you think like what are we talking
about now is just a part of the you know
men in the world which is probably the
majority but doesn't mean that is the
totality guys
so
okay anyway it's fine yeah we can we can
keep saying that's the majority and i'm
i'm i'm fine with that cool all right
but again that's we said that but we
want a majority a man going out and
saying okay cool i want to go and find a
virgin yeah
and we're going to go and find this
virgin it's the same way you're saying
oh i'm going to be this exception and i
will find that guy who wants me no but
you're saying
no no no no no you didn't get my point i
don't give a [__] to find the men who
evaluate me because i know i know about
my value i don't need a man to recognize
my value i don't give a [__] if i gonna
find him cool
but you if i don't i can stand on my own
i'm paying my bills
i got a job what i do what do i need a
man for okay do you have sex but that's
fine i can still have sex
i have a question i have a question for
you how do you determine what your value
is right i told you i told you a woman
for me is an independent woman who can
stand by his own can pay air bills he
ask the maturity to understand even when
is the right time to have a children
because everyone can have a child any
time just you know and then those people
it's also about how we have our you know
what kind of pattern we are so it's not
just about having eggs because honestly
i prefer women that stay without
children instead that someone that who
doesn't deal with properly some question
who is that valuable to
what you just listed who is that
valuable to you mean who who yeah who is
that valuable to
what you just myself i don't care about
other people's opinion okay so i i need
to like that's just to people that i
should like
worry about god and myself
not
so i just want to clarify so you don't
care what men want
and and the way you determine your value
is what you say yeah isn't that a bit
narcissistic no he's not
because you're not only because you only
care about yourself and not what anyone
else wants no listen the point i don't i
didn't cite it just about myself just
about the people that actually is in in
my small circle
which is different because when someone
comes inside my circles they actually
understand my value i don't need to
explain to them
so that's the point the other point
obviously i don't i don't give a [__]
about any uh no offense but really about
people that is not in my small circle so
like okay i'm not vulnerable okay cool
like peace like i'm gonna come back to
my life i'm gonna go to work tomorrow
i'm gonna keep paying my bills and you
know what i mean like okay like you won
the man
so you you basically turn into that like
this is what girls do though like women
turn into the men they want to marry so
if you're looking for a guy like all the
things you i'm not looking for a guy no
no no i know you're not i'm saying but
like typically i'm saying in general i
don't know you personally but i'm saying
in general when women become the men
they want to marry so they become all
the things that like men want because
what she just described that's the mat
like that's a man i would date but it's
not women it's not what men want
like a guy that's independent that pays
his bills that goes like he gets the
back i'm like sign me up but to a man
that's like that's that's a red flag we
said men don't care what a woman about
her career yeah that's what i said so
then if she's making money getting her
bag whatever whatever a man wouldn't
care no no no i don't care so then her
value so then a man will approach her
then a man will want her a man because
he can walk into tesco and see an
attractive girl at the till i agree he
wants to change her life
a woman will not walk into tesco see an
attractive man that's what you think i i
i guess you agree
honestly that's fine that's not the
totality it's not the totality i had
i've been in relationship with men
they're honestly
less than me they add absolutely nothing
and where are they now
what does it mean that i like what about
other other men that are six foot and
they i don't know they billionaire they
anyway
go like you know if you if you meet a
billionaire and you're dating a
billionaire you fumble the bag
i actually i actually like com comparing
i probably had more relationship with
people that you know are
less rich than someone that i probably
didn't give a chance i didn't give a
chance to them right so it's not
absolutely you've dated like broke guys
is what you're saying i had some not
broken like bro
do you think you attract feminine guys
because you're more masculine uh
no i wouldn't say feminine honestly just
people with balls which is different
it's not about being yeah it's not about
being feminist it's about be very
confident because when you're standing
next to me because i think i'm tough i
got strong personality you need both
honestly
someone else who prefer a young lady who
doesn't work who can be manipulated and
can be general control because you are
the strong in the relationship i need a
man it doesn't really is a partnership
like we are together we strong in the
same way when a man is looking for a
younger lady which is virgin who doesn't
work he probably aren't less than me
it's because they need to feel like they
are the strongest one they control him
they taking the power in the
relationship
you're just deciding what you believe
men no that's my point of view yeah your
decision
i'm not assigning i'm expressing my
point of view as you no you will decide
you said i'm not deciding you are you
said men go for younger women because
they feel they're to control them and
manipulate them what if what if men said
that about women they look so stupid if
they're like like women like rich guys
because they want to manipulate and
control them people be like that's a
cope you just need to go make money and
it's the same thing when women say
things like that to men like you're
shaming them
shame guilt like this is like the common
tactics are shame guilt insult wait
shame guilt
shame insult guilt and need to be right
yeah no i'm not need to that's the point
guys you have like you work like you're
working like a horse you don't see like
on the left on the right yes because i
asserting your point of view by you
saying that i want to control your own
mentality
no wait wait wait wait wait wait and
are you telling the room
if more than one person in the room no
you guys are saying like how a man
should look at me no i never said your
name yeah i i don't i don't know what
you do no honestly when i say to me i'm
saying to women because i belong to the
actually i don't know if you guys
realize but yeah i'm a girl
so the category of women women now me
myself
you belong to women yes and we're
talking about what men want from women
you then take yourself out of belonging
to women to say what you are
no you you've been doing that no i just
i'm standing you just said yeah i belong
to women right and the discussions we're
having is what men want from women
when you represent the totality of men
in this world come out do you represent
the totality of man in this show
need to be right
no i'm the statistic
i don't need to be right like statistics
which statistic because like it's based
on what like honestly speaking
the statistic you're right and you come
out with the best number ever okay let's
let's say that okay cool so the majority
of men think like you right all right
cool i'm accepting that you prefer at 20
years old women i just don't give a [__]
is it clear like i don't give a [__] so
you can prefer go out with a 20 years
old girl have child married uh whatever
you wish i hope you do
i hope you do kids
go get that 20 year old you know i'm a
certainly right cool i just don't give a
[__] that's fine as you don't give a
[__] about what i think so why you
cannot just say okay this is just a
different point of view as am i setting
your point of view uh that's cool that's
cool for me like
you're you're quite you're quite angry
for being great no i'm not i'm not love
you
just get confused between have energy
and then i'm pretty energetic i know
that doesn't seem like i think
you know i just wanna like um commune
trying to communicate my point which is
different i'm not angry to you like to
anyone else just my point i want to make
it clear because i think i've been
invited for this reason
that's the point i'm not angry at all
like honestly speaking okay all right
cool good good it's passionate yeah
there we go i'm just italian guys
give me food and conversation i can
i love that okay
are men or women the prize
you ask
okay wait tell me why
because they're the ones that we're
going for well me personally i'm going
for the woman
and i want to go for the women that i
believe is the right woman and someone
who else
many people would want okay go ahead
no i made at the price um
we we run society we keep society going
i'm not saying women
i knew she's gonna go men of the prize
win at the prize okay what do you think
men are women who's surprised
the
the prize for like i'd
okay wait let me just
so
are men or women the prize in what sense
like in the world or in in the dating
game in the dating game
well women okay women are the prize what
do you think
that's 50 50 50. you think like half of
women half a man okay fair enough go
ahead
men men are the prize what do you think
auntie
i think men there's more women anyway so
i can remember the prizes so many of
them running out around that there's
gotta be men so second question all
right do women date up or down
they date up okay
um when they can help here okay do women
date up or down
are they up yeah i answered for me
personally up oh
i'm no longer
okay
they date down they sleep up
sit down
so if women if women date up wouldn't
that make men the prize
hmm that's a good point it makes sense
really
yeah
i get the point but i i don't i still
don't see men as the price
why not look
so let me get this right you've
acknowledged the point
yeah
i understand where i understand the
point allow me to finish so you've
acknowledged the point right but you
don't agree
can you explain why
no i you asked me who are the prize and
relation i could still i'm still i'm in
an iron about the question about the art
the question anyway like who's the prize
sort of
because then it's like the whole value
thing and all that sort of stuff so
that's why i just said women just to
give an answer that women are the prize
because
of
what they bring to a relationship or
whatever it is right i just said it just
whatever but then what was it you said
again that
why do women date up i said i said do
women date up or down i mean so if
majority of the the women here said they
up yeah why would and a man would be the
prize yes but then dating up
you're not dating down so
so if they're dating up then the men are
dating down
because
oh no but yeah but if women are dating
up
and men are dating down
you're saying that women are not the
prize that a man is the price yeah so
then men would just date men because men
are the prized why are men dating down
if a man is surprised when all men just
date all men
okay we're talking we're talking about
straight people okay yeah they wouldn't
date why would men date each other when
they're straight i like this isn't it
you just said men are the people would
make men the price yeah because men
could date up but they don't they date
down yeah so then men would be the prize
that means they don't have a choice
there's some there's some women there's
some women that would be up there are
some women that would be down there are
women that would be up like oprah is up
right so then a man has to be above her
to date down to her why are you saying
that oprah's not up no i'm just general
like i'm just saying like value money
whatever i can't think of a young rich
no no that's not up though so what's up
then got points
or a woman that is that margot robbie
so someone that's young someone who's
just yes
someone actually i think she hit 30. i
gotta find someone that's 22. but
so
young and pretty basically yes
with a lot of eggs so if she's young and
pretty and works in tesco yes exactly
yes that means he's dating up yes it
depends on her personality as well okay
a personality that she works in tesco
personality she's 20 she's young she's
her body count is zero whatever then
you're then then the man is dating up
yeah yeah do you know her there's some
guys that might want her
that's the point so she would be
considered high in the so she's high
value yeah yeah yeah
in the dating market yes so then
wait so
here's
yeah
and then
why would that woman want to date you
wouldn't she want to date someone high
value someone up yeah yeah yeah
yeah
right so then
wait i don't know
what i see
you know what i see where you're going
with this because you're saying high
value women go for high value men yes
you're saying they're correct that
there's an equality there yeah
the low value man who is trying to date
up she doesn't want you right now
that's why that's why one in three men
are virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year because nobody wants them so
so you're saying men are dating down
yeah so by dating down you're saying
he's dating someone
over 25 30 whose body count is up whose
eggs are cracked and yeah i mean guys
guys unless he's dating down guys will
put up with more than men do so they
will put up with more and date i'm sorry
yeah
the the guy will put up with more and
date down
yeah because he doesn't have a choice
but he'll still cheat on that woman he
still has a right to not be monogamous
to her
because her value is low it depends but
you don't have a choice because no the
high value woman doesn't want you so
you're dating down right but a lot of
high value women die alone because
that's what
i mean
so guys
wait wait wait what are we doing as a
hive sorry sorry i'll explain a lot of
it is
i'll explain a lot of eight to tens that
are very pretty die alone because they
can't leave the streets because they're
so used to the attention
like that
like
what sorry go ahead guys what do you
mean by that then you saw use the
attention
um this is like honestly i've just heard
this from guys this is just like
strictly this is just the experience
that i've had like talking to guys the
last like two years yeah and they just
say a lot of girls that are like very
pretty and they're given like that's the
most valuable thing you can be given is
extreme beauty like you come out you can
get a modeling contract and girls waste
it and they waste their best years that
doesn't make you high value
you're right sorry sorry
technically if we're going to go high
value woman the man i misused the term
like a high value woman technically has
to be chosen by a high value man i just
i just met like like very attractive
women that are like the most sought
after they wouldn't be you're right i
use their terms
yes and i'm saying like
a lot of like the most beautiful women
die alone because they're they're so
used to being like an eight to ten yeah
that's their whole personality they
can't they don't break they've never
been bullied like like if you tell a
girl she's not special they freak out
which is weird most people aren't
supposed to tell you well go ahead that
would make you low value
if you're if you're beautiful but you
don't have any other qualities you're
still in the streets you're still a
whole you're low value yeah yeah
equivalent would be a [__] i don't
know a cryptocurrency well you're not
you're not low value if you're in game
if you're if you're beautiful you like
oh like someone that's 300 pounds isn't
gonna get in the same like she could
have a no body count you're gonna get
the initial attention yeah but if you
have nothing else and you're a whole
yeah
like your background
correct correct
but that's that's why i say like girls
that are eight to tens often die alone
that's that's what i was saying because
because they're so used to that
attention that they it's like a drug
they can't they can't they can't wait
this is just this is just what i've
heard from men okay so like not sure but
it depends on no but honestly it depends
on your culture your background
like sorry generally speaking
if you look at
we can go to like
instagram chicks yeah
the majority of them are single your
bernie's
all of them and they may get gifts they
may get dated but
are they kept
how many of them do you see that are
kept
this is the point but you're referring
to looks only but that's what that's
what we're saying eight to tens yeah but
that's that's low value so no no so what
you're saying is that that's with life
when you start with looks like we as
much as people want to pretend that you
know this personality stuff matters the
initial attraction is looks yeah so when
you are
attractive and you have pretty privilege
yeah you're gonna get attention so what
she's saying is when you get that sort
of attention it's like a drug
you go out and you know that you're
gonna have the pick of men coming to
attract and move to and talk to you and
sell you dreams exactly right
but you're still not being kept at the
end of the day no one is going to turn
that attraction and those dreams into
marriage into a ring and they die alone
right i understand that but you could
you could say the same for some men
but
like a dude can be 50 and a girl that's
30 will still find him fine but like
it's not the same vice versa you could
be 50 and a [__]
and you're not attractive as a guy yeah
you could be a guy
you have all the money in the world but
you're just not well mostly you don't
turn women on correct most men have died
a lot like yeah i think for only 40 only
only 40 only 40 percent of men have
reproduced throughout history
so what 80 percent of women have so the
majority of men do die alone you're
right
it's just a new thing for women
because like they they get because they
don't listen to what men want anymore
so how do we fix that that's coming from
what what how do we how do we like level
the playing field there you're doing it
slowly well i mean to me it's like the
it's the
you you get rid of the consequence more
people do it so if you pay women to
leave marriages the more girls are going
to do it they're paid through child
support and through the government
like when you pay women to make bad
decisions every bad decision we make
we're bailed out of you could be
homeless there's a women's shelter to
take care of you
you could sleep around you can get an
abortion to build you out like whatever
bad decision women make there's a
bailout there's incentives yeah like
like so if you're paid to make bad
decisions more women make bad decisions
like they're not going to stop they're
not going to stop till the consequence
goes away yeah yeah that was a big thing
in this country
what'd you say earlier sorry there's uh
she didn't she didn't hear it and i said
in my day mm-hmm you know women were
just gonna they're getting pregnant
together
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's the first
time i've heard of it and i said yeah i
said but there was a stigma then mm-hmm
you know about it
hit reality hard because if a man makes
a bad decision or if he ain't [__] the
world will tell him yeah well they will
feed women lies and let her live in
delusion
like even even when i said you're less
valuable when you hit 30 like that
shouldn't be that's just life yeah i'm
less valuable than i was when i was 22
it is what it is it's not it's not a
personal attack on me
we're not talking about personal worth
but
honestly honestly honestly to everyone
like your looks are currency girls don't
even like we don't know how good they
have it
because you are given more attention and
opportunity because of the way you look
life is on easy mode as a young pretty
girl [__] like hit hit 50. let life
change everything
that's right but you you're like
auntie
we see it every day in the world but
people still choose to argue the fact
it is true as a 21 year old your life
was different to how it is now it is a
fact
it is a fact when you were younger you
were more attractive you went out you
you felt fresher no it's not about being
to me
honestly no honestly i'm gonna i'm gonna
ask you something then um it happened to
me to have many friends they actually
prefab like date older they're trying to
get they're trying to [__] you
men are trying to [__] you a 20 years
old girl as a 15 years old women that's
not different they are thinking just to
i don't want to be rude but like you
know what i mean they are thinking about
that from the principle
so
if uh
old women get you know less attractive
whatever it is
so anyway that's quite good looking 15
years old women that they actually
dating 20 or 30
years old man
do you even got money it's not even
not money no no it's not it's not it's
not even like honestly me personally i
had friends
very good look six foot guys very good
looking guys
they actually
dated
older women did they marry also child
did they marry them well what intended
what
it doesn't count unless you get a ring
for me like it doesn't know what i'm
saying it doesn't count unless he
commits to you for life so yeah
26 years old give him the time to get
married i could i could i could say okay
i dated a guy that was a millionaire
does that mean make me a millionaire
wife no no no yeah but that's not
actually if you don't have results the
results so first of all that's not the
result for myself because uh uh 20 years
old women who can get married when she's
22 so she's so valuable or whatever she
got a lot of eggs she can be left alone
when she is 25 and the husband is
sleeping around around and gonna left
her alone looking after the child so
what about the value we're talking about
she's still 25 she give you our best
life her best she's most valuable and
she is she is by herself now so what
about this
what about this go ahead and say why
don't you get married before she had the
kid no no i said
you getting uh 20 years old women with a
lot of eggs you know beautiful and
everything so very you know up upstairs
no childless okay so you get married
with her you get you got a pregnant so
let's say you've got one child or
whatever
now
how many cases we know about men leaving
the house with the child children or men
still cheating on them cheating
she was that vulnerable so why he went
outside to looking for actors because
because cheating is different for men
and for women no that men can have sex
with a whole and what about when they
leave the cheese
women leave 70 to 80 of the time 90 if
you have a college degree 90 percent of
the time you're leaving
men by and large are not leaving so
that's not who do you men and women
cheat at equal rates i'm not talking
about i'm talking about i know a lot of
a lot of lots of children left alone
from their dad
okay i know a lot of single mothers and
they've been left alone okay you can't
you can know it but you can look at who
files a divorce the difference that's
the that's they probably never even get
married but that's not good
but the difference from what she's
saying
is that the big difference is what you
said that he married her yeah that gives
her status who cares if he's sleeping
out she's covered
she goes
married that's what i was going to say
an ex-wife and a baby mama are two
different things
guys
the man
sorry auntie jenny just give me one
second guys i'm gonna reiterate the
rules because we're not getting there
one at a time people at home can't hear
you it's a great conversation i want you
guys to have this conversation but i
need to be able to hear you so please
allow each other to speak one at a time
thank you let's get into it
you got
a young girl you say 25 with a kid
and the man marries her leaves her goes
and sleeps out
you got
that's his 25
yeah yeah you got 25 year old woman
not married the man has a kid with vern
leaves her
who's at the better advantage the one
that got married
what's your point of view that's your
question because because she can take
everything because they're making
everything about status and what society
think about women no we're making a
reason no we're making sure
so she gonna be results
that's like me saying i'm an olympian
with no metal
like like women live like this is what i
mean like you like that's delusion like
women women go through life living in
delusions but everyone has different
pain like
focus in life
if i if i have a ring then i am
protected i if i i okay okay your mic is
off because you keep interrupting me if
i have a ring that i'm entitled like
then i am protected legally i'm
protected legally if you found wall
you can turn it on god oh i was on mute
this whole time okay but if if he if
he's cheated on you like a 20 year old
he's married her she's young she's got
eggs whatever whatever he's married her
they've had vows
they've had a child and he's cheated
she's okay because she's got a ring
he's basically broken
so you said that there was the 20 year
old who got married had a baby and he
cheated and then you got the 25 year old
who had a baby but didn't get married
and he cheated or let's just say they're
both the same age right right the one
that had a ring is more special because
she got a ring she's more protected
okay she's protected by law because his
husband wants okay
yeah exactly so like let's say so so
because sorry i hadn't finished so
because she's protected by the ring that
makes her more valuable because she got
the medal let's be real she's got
results
and then you say i haven't finished no
because you come in and didn't let me
finish okay go on so then sorry i've
just you just said the result was the
ring but the result was that he she got
cheated
okay allowed to finish a lot all right
cool
all right no it's just like they're both
they're they're both at a loss it's not
one is better than the other they're
both equal okay well it's not no no no
it's not
disagreeing i'm not saying it to make it
clear so if we're being clear about life
like you said we have two women in
identical positions but one is married
and one is not
if you're not married and it all goes
pear-shaped you're gone you're out
there's nothing you can't go nowhere and
say well he cheated on me i should get
half sorry love you're not married
forget about it if you're married
you're entitled yeah yeah in life let's
be real you're getting half okay cool
i've been cheated on emotionally you
might be sad for a bit um but again as
they say do you want to cry
in a bentley or in a fiat
and go and stay go back home to your mom
or stay in a room with your friend
or do you want to get the house
and men look at and men look at ex-wives
and ex-girlfriends different okay so
men look at ex-wives and ex-girlfriends
different because because one has
results and they can say oh that man
chose her she was worth being chosen
where a girl that's that's over a
certain age they're like why nobody
choose you because i know other guys
aren't stupid so why didn't anyone
choose you why aren't you so then the
two women that were both 20 years old
that got cheated on at 25 or whatever
and then one was married one wasn't if
now they're both 30 and in that 10 years
they were so heartbroken couldn't admit
date anyone else they're now 30 with a
child one was married one wasn't you
would go for the pudding they're left
over then put in left over
so no so you wouldn't go for either of
them like why are you getting divorced
for when you got married why are you
getting divorced because i just said
nothing women did no you're not
listening to what i just said i said
they were picking up
situations
no i said both were 20 one was married
one wasn't they both had a child each
one they both were cheated on and then
after 10 5 10 years or whatever now
they're ready to date again because they
couldn't date when they had a young baby
or whatever now the child is five six
seven eight years old too young today
and they're sorry that's too young
what's too young have you got a child
five years old and you've been mad you
guys are adding extra stuff like just
i'm trying to get to your reality she's
been from reality
now that the the two women that one was
20 both were 20 one was married one
wasn't whatever they've now come to 26
27 8 whatever years old you're saying
that the one that was married that
divorced she's more valuable than the
one that wasn't i'm just trying to man
yeah yeah so then you would date the one
that so you would still go for that one
with a child who was divorced
can we stop acting like like men are out
here cheating all the time the majority
i'm saying
i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying the
majority of men aren't even having sex
okay
guys wait and the weight wait and the
number one reason for divorce is
financial reasons okay so i'm just going
off the conversation that was happening
before you gave a scenario of two women
one both twenty one one divorced one did
it who gave i didn't give that to you
yeah exactly guys but i was trying to
make another point like if the man got
the most valuable women ever because she
was young pretty whatever
why they still
leave
those women if they are
we don't do they do because i know quite
a lot of single mother
so they've been left alone so single for
those single mothers
being left alone
being left alone did the man leave or
did they choose the men the men the men
married
i like honestly speaking like i have
very close
very close relationship also like people
that i know very closely that
like they coming from
divorced parents and she was the first
she was the virgin we're talking about
he had two children and then after he
left for
honestly speaking so
like what we're talking about man anyway
can get even the best women ever the
most vulnerable that we're talking about
whatever in at best she can give him her
best
but
i'd say that's insignificant by and
large it's not true the women are
leaving it's not men
okay
honestly i came next time i gonna come
with number two so probably i'm gonna
improve my the stories that you have are
probably the exception the two that's
quite a lot there's quite a lot of
single part and single mapping single
quite a lot yeah quite low it's probably
like 15
15 or more
yeah and that's a
a new amount to the whole thing and so
what
they're saying is i see more divorced
divorced couples than moderate buyers so
in your in your circle would you say men
left more than women yeah definitely
from people that you know yeah men of
more than women yeah
yep and the thing is that a lot of what
women don't fail to realize is
how hard it is for a man to get married
in the first place ben don't take that
lightly
men don't take it lightly and i don't
think they realize the importance that
every man decides to put a ring on your
finger
he can have 15 women out there he
decided to put a ring on your finger
that means something because marriage
does not come easy to make it every man
decides that's who i'm gonna marry
that puts you up there wherever you
think whether he's got 15 women or not
that puts you out there because they're
married men are men are risking losing
everything like men
men are risky
men no men are risking ruin they're
ruining their entire life if they marry
you because you can leave take half
their [__] and take the kids with you
and then they have to pay you to take
their kids yeah because they don't even
mind probably about their children
sometimes
is that is that what you think of men
some of them yes
because if you want to build a real
relationship you
gonna
very
you're going to look for someone that
actually can deal with everything and
when i'm saying everything i don't mean
cheating because loyalty is actually on
the basement of every relationship so if
you know men have lost their entire life
savings trying to get custody of their
kids from mother's day i know because
like me personally
i know about i had two brothers and
they've been they coming from first my
my dad first married so i know quite
well so i'm talking about something that
actually be involved during my life so i
know what i'm talking about but i'm
saying that's that's such a high risk
for a guy
so if a guy is putting a rail willing to
put a ring on your finger that means
something like you just took actually
the right uh example because like my dad
had two children from a woman who was
the virgin we're talking about
she was 18 years old when she met my dad
and they had two two children
and the marriage end up all right and my
dad actually fight to you know see the
children all right
so
you see even though she was the
most like i mean obviously considering
your standard so your standard guys
she was a very valuable girl but anyway
the marriage end up and who win i will
say no one definitely my brothers they
suffer quite a lot
but
she didn't win because she had the ring
because after my dad married another my
mother yeah and then then she kept
thinking actually
actually yeah that's that's horrible
yeah this is horrible win so
she won because she had the ring who won
in this story where did she where did
she win it just means she won more than
the girl who never got the ring it
doesn't mean she won in life the one who
wins is the one now
the one who wins is the one who gets
married and stays married that's who
wins no i i think she had a very very
sad life
because
you know when you get that angry to take
your children from your ex-husband you
having a very hard time you having a
very sad life even though you got the
ring you got [__] and you got [__] okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna so i'm
gonna get married so um i do you wanna
get married but i'm gonna read the super
chats real quick so i'm gonna take a
second to do that and then you can ask
that question you can be the first one
to ask a question if you guys have to go
to the bathroom feel free to go now
also they're probably going to be mean
i'm just warning you okay sepa saying
sketch lady in the middle doesn't know
what the best number one woman in her
eyes not is not in men's eyes ask the
men in the middle how many friends she
has mgtow by logic italia you think that
all men cheat because you only sleep
with men in the top 20 percent of men
yeah we in the top 20 of men don't know
what we want
do no do what we want not what you want
but that doesn't mean the other 80
percent of men behave as badly as you do
you're delusional um drazy and gaming
god please come back to me when you talk
to please don't come back talking to you
middle one
uh actually okay guys i'm gonna do over
over ten dollar super chats just because
there's so many i don't think i can get
through them
maybe over ten dollars okay alter void
stop the lies you know single women that
lie about being left the truth they they
just know now they've [__] up and they
need to be the victim and you're lying
to and your friends are lying to you
um
to be fair i don't know any married men
that cheat on a wife that makes his
sexual needs a priority if that's
accurate and accurate generalization
then when a man cheats who who really
broke the vow first oh that's a good
point um vuduki to
my ideal woman attractive fit
affectionate part-time job at most
homemaker while i work 70 hours a week
making good money is that chauvinistic
sounds like pretty laid back life for a
woman to me
uh let's go to the next ten dollar one
okay um matt butcher women need to hear
some anti-jenny wisdom at 14. it would
solve
extant this existential world problems
silly sausage they don't get it did
anyone actually ask her to start stating
everything that has about that they
don't get it did anyone actually ask her
to start stating everything that is
valuable about herself no one asks you
to put up your personal trauma walls
don't move the goal post with emotion
light cake for mr ever the woman in the
middle is going to die alone with no
family all men don't care about how much
money you make have fun with that and
ask yourself when you're all alone
having your fun matt butcher this is
great we get to see the effects of
feminism on full to display real time
what to watch out for mgtow by logic can
a man stand by you no man wants to stand
by you that's the point of everyone is
telling you wake up your value to a man
is plummeting hourly listen to auntie or
die alone um bane split cheers cheers
pearl keep it in line um ten dollars
from the blackest panther are we
surprised that thirty-year-old women are
disagreeable and annoying men do not
care about your experience the more
experience a woman has the more baggage
she has and the lower her value is to
other men mgtow by lodge at 50.00
the buyer determines the value always
men are the buyer just like you
determine what you value in men you
don't date bums do you know stop shaming
men you are 30 and alone you better
listen to anthony you've already wasted
12 years
um tg love love love auntie also pearl
if you want to experience the ultimate
red pill look up yuri ben's something
and
our call is going to be allowed i'll be
down from the chicago area
black is panther it's not hard to tell a
woman with a high body count combination
of these frequently wants to go on girls
trips bars and clubs or has high alcohol
areas constantly on social media for
attention
um
the next is ten dollar mr mt lavadair
hello from colorado usa i live in the
mountain ski town all the girls here are
ran through please help i i literally
can't help you um
condor mayanda you all be really putting
in the red hill park red pill work for
eight hours straight and then i'm gonna
refresh it real quick
um
okay so you you said you had a question
you wanted to ask yeah but they've left
they left
oh actually there's one there's one more
super chat um cv boy god my girl really
hated that i started watching you yeah
don't don't tell your girlfriends
um go ahead now my question was
um like who actually wants to get
married and why
um yeah that was my main question
two minutes um i i wanted to the guy oh
to the guys okay very good question he
wants to get married and why yeah and
what in what regard like what are you
referring to i was asking the men do you
want to get married if not says yes then
why if it's no then why
i personally still believe that marriage
is quite beautiful
i know it's a risk
because like as we've covered with the
statistics most women end up leaving but
i still think it probably plays back to
my
my upbringing i just feel like marriage
is just a natural next step
um in in the progression of a
relationship so you you want to get i
would love to your idea so
but i also think to add on to that
marriage is more beneficial for society
because even throughout history if you
look at that polygamous societies one of
the things that they see that's
prevalent is there's a lot of like grape
there's a lot of crime because
um in polygamous societies the strongest
men take all the women which leaves the
other men to revolt and cause problems
so monogamy's actually beneficial to
society it keeps women safe it makes a
city by enlarge more better nuclear
family homes lead to less um
traumatic experiences for children so
you can see there's a lot of benefits
through marriage so yeah there's
all right but you actually didn't really
answer the question like why you want to
get mad you why you want to again it's a
beautiful thing
okay you already said that beautiful yes
it puts your kid in every single
advantage over that being in a situation
where you're not married yes so why like
what so it's more beneficial for kids
don't have children now right it will be
beneficial uh it will be yeah yeah yeah
so now the point i was trying to get is
if like if you have a reason for why you
want to get married
and you believe in
marriage and the vows that you've made
whether it's to god or wherever then why
would you then
go against those vows and cheat and then
it's for some reason it's okay first of
all i haven't cheated no no i'm just
because the guys have left and they were
here before i'm gonna ask them no i hear
what you're saying but
i hear what you're trying to do i hate
what you're trying to say but you have
to remember and we've mentioned this
before that
although marriage is what's sought after
and it's more beneficial for our
offspring one the reason i seek marriage
is because
it's better for my kids to be raised in
a nuclear family
but even though it's still
marriage is still not my biological
imperative
i have to sacrifice elements of my
biological being
to conform to the female standard if i
had my way i'd have my woman that i love
and this woman that i just chopped down
again if i had my way but to conform to
the social standards of society
i try to be in a monogamous situation i
don't aspire to be a man that cheats
however anything that hasn't happened
it's just a prediction of the future
what i'm saying yeah and i think most
people put it that way so i'm just
saying this look if you've got a good
man
and he steps out once in like once or
twice in 40 years
listen the grass isn't green until you
water it the grass isn't green on the
other side so i think that's the thing
that women have to recognize does that
work both ways of course not
because men can love multiple women at
the same time where women can only love
my man and if she's cheated if she's
cheating on you you don't love him no
but you you use an example yeah could
you just walk out now
see a guy do you attracted to you and
say listen go [__] me in the corner
right now could you do that so that's
could you could you do that for me
personally i couldn't most women most
women couldn't that's not that yeah so
most people don't want to behave like
that you see a man if he sees a girl
he's attracted to you i will bang you in
the bush
i'll bang in a street corner i'll bang
in the yard it don't matter it is what
it is but that's the that's the
fundamental difference so so why it
can't be flipped around is because it
takes more for you to allow someone in
whereas for a man it's like taking a
piss so that's why it's different but
why is it except no i don't think you
get one trying to say why is he accepted
no because if if a woman cheats yeah
there's a reason behind why she's
cheating of course so then why is it
that if she cheats you can't just accept
it it's because it goes beyond sex
there's the emotions involved that for a
woman to let a guy in there's a process
it's premeditated it's never just a slip
up for a man it's literally like i
wasn't using my head and i had a nut to
bust and that's that's all it is but for
you it goes further than that okay but
what if it was a slip-up if it was a
girl
you should just have a one-night stand
that's not a slip-up i'm not bending you
over and blasting your back yeah she's
on holiday that's premeditated you've
got that holiday i want wanting to [__]
her brother
if you love a man if you love a man
you're not looking
if you really love a man you're not
you're not looking at anyone else you
only see him listen to what i'm saying i
said if you are in a situation where
you're married and your woman slipped up
and just one time she slept to someone
just on holiday you know what once do
you know why you take her i see you're
doing here and
you're you're trying to use the
exception to that it's not to me no
there is because most women wouldn't
behave most women aren't slipping up
later giving a scenario in that scenario
i'd like to think but it can never
happen i will just fall and die if i
hear that
my immune system will shut down i'll
just get covered and i'll pass away okay
so would you take her back i could not i
couldn't because you know what by look
by by by holistically that's not how
women behave so how am i supposed to
assume that this is just a slip up and
not something more how how can i make
that i'm telling i'm telling you it's
not
giving you a situation no and i hear
what your situation is saying but i'm
saying as a man
i can't assume that that is the case
after the assumption that the answer is
no you wouldn't take her no
100 percent because you know
because you should know that me slipping
up is literally just slipping up
you letting a man in
it's not it's not because you said it
yourself you couldn't just let a man
slip into your tongue like that i said
me personally i'm most women dating you
i'm always giving you a situation but if
you was dating me you can't slip up like
that i'm sorry
i'm saying i'm giving you an actual
scenario where she slipped up she went
on holiday she had a hot girl oh yeah
and then she just had a bit too much to
drink one thing led to another she just
one night stand oh i didn't it meant
nothing it was just a slipper but i
don't care
and then would you take her back
can i just say that women can i just say
that when men she right when men she
it got no it's just it got nothing to do
with like i understand that when women
oh then when men cheat it's a one-off
when women she the relationship is
finished
everything that you've i agree and 100
what i'm trying to say is that how many
women
are there if a woman cheats
she knows that the relationship is
finished
nine times out of ten if the woman
cheats that's the end of it that's the
end of her relationship that's true but
if a man cheats
it's not the end or to put it as my mum
will say it
men have all their bits on the outside
so they can fling it around everywhere
god hid the women's away because it's
hard to find internals so if you're
gonna go and give it away like that
there's a lot to go through for a man to
get to you internally rather just on the
outside because women are the
gatekeepers of sex but even more but
even more than that you have to think
but the point guys is like it's not
about the man which is coming back and
every time we know that he probably
gonna sleep around and come back home
the point is what about us like how do
we do you think that no actually you
know
has an impact on your marriage do you
think she's gonna be fine
no knowing that you actually eat other
okay
and you're
[Applause]
everything about you like we talked
about when i told you i explained you
stopped over talking me
stop over talking me again again stop
over talking me stop over talking me no
no no stop stop you can go after i'm
done okay
it men and women aren't the same and so
a man can have sex with a hole in the
wall they don't care a woman a woman if
she sleeps with some a man he has to be
someone we are not sleeping with bums
out there unless she looks like michael
b jordan that is it i get that but again
i'm like i asked everyone individually
would you get married and why i've asked
him individually would you take a woman
back if she slipped up and it was just a
one-and-done thing and it was michael b
jordan and it was like she had a chance
to would you take her back no
no no but but if you did it and you
slept with a random whatever she can
take you back
to sleep with a random american
woman i'm saying you as yourself i'm
asking as an individual not generalizing
okay so
should a woman take a man back if he
cheats no she shouldn't does she yes
that is not our choice
as we are saying men and women are
different if you speak to women i've
spoken to a lot of women yeah and when
they say to me oh um my relationship
ended because my man was cheating yeah
the first thing i say to them is what
did he cheat once and then you left and
they said no he was cheating is never he
cheated it's always he was cheating
which meant this dude has decided he is
going to continue
sleeping with other women but when did
she find out it was women
and then it was oh
no no no my point is you are not going
to go out and find a woman who says
i went i was going out with this dude he
cheated on me once and i left
you don't it doesn't happen if women if
women don't like being treated why do
they pick the guys that cheat
exactly but even so yeah even so
on your point yeah
if i was to take this woman back do you
think she'll ever respect me
so she's gonna go she's gonna go sit in
the next man's face for banter
one was a look it was a man no no no no
no if if you because you have to
remember a lot of relationships are
predicated on on respect yeah
if you've lost that respect for me
enough to step out
it's gone because you have to think
about in relationships the only time the
relationship's really done is when the
woman says it's done
the man can say he's done and come back
uh a week later babes listen i'm sorry
he's dick's heart he wants to do
something you see when a woman says
she's done there's no return
end of end of so for a woman to do that
you might it's done
you're saying and for a man the most
egregious crime you can commit is is
disloyalty there's no there's no bigger
crime may i come back to your point you
said uh i never about you know our women
say uh he cheated once
yeah you're right because man doesn't
cheat one if it's if it's cheat one
they're gonna come back to again again
again so man doesn't cheat once in a
while or once in his life it just if it
is going down it gonna come back
do you ever ask why he cheated
yeah
a lot of times like girls don't give
their guys sex and are confused when no
trust me trust me i've been there that
way
okay okay 25 percent of marriages are
six
months
do you think sex for your husband is an
obligation so when he wants sex you can
give it to him
wait say again is sex in marriage or
relationship an obligation
no you should enjoy it obligation
every time he wants to bend you over are
you letting him put it inside you is
what i'm saying oh if you're married or
a relationship
honestly guys about feelings about what
i'm saying
elsewhere
is that a problem
you're going to say yes but see but
that's that's that's messed up so then
because you're because you know what i'm
saying i'm saying because you're just
thinking about what you want
because
because you're kidding if you want
because a lot of times they have kids
with the girl i'm not and so you're
adding stuff to the stuff okay
in the context of marriage yes that's
correct
context of a relationship act cool just
bounce so when you're married it's a
difference what are your what are your
obligations from a man
for you
in a relationship
what do you what do you want from a man
like what is he obligated to for you in
a relationship well i'm saying loyalties
up there trust loyalties up there that's
that's a must but then if you guys are
saying that no no for you just
obligation from a man yeah just for you
yeah just those two things well that's
one of them i can't think and list them
all up but yeah the main one is loyalty
and
to respect me love me all of that stuff
that's that's
up there that's well what if he says
i'm only doing that for someone that's
my wife i'll respect you then i'm out
you can't be loyal or respect me but you
want to be with me you only be
respectful and loyal to your wife
so then either you put a ring on this or
i'm gone that's it what if he said i'm
gone unless you give me sex on demand
i'm going as well then you're gone
what the hell what did you what if you
don't you don't think sex is a duty in
marriage but she just are we talking
about marriage you're dating i'm
confused like you keep changing it
usually talking in the context of
marriage but i don't know i'm not
married
i'm not married and i still can't speak
on marriage i've never been married i'm
not married i mean i i even think in a
relationship honestly if he's not
sleeping with anyone else yeah you
should give him sex whenever he wants
whatever he wants yeah
because like otherwise why should he go
because guys guys
guys want to [__] all the time so if i'm
saying like please don't [__] other
girls just [__] me like then i should i
should
okay wait yeah understand that but then
if there's just a one day where it's
like i'm not on it right now or i'm on
my p or whatever you're not using
obviously
does that mean that he now has a right
to go and have sex with someone
obviously it's not one day come let's be
let's be real about it like that's
that's what i'm saying but you guys are
making it sound i'll give you one day
i'll give you one day in that deal
if you miss work one day they might give
you a pass two days in a row
you might you might be getting a pink
slip
show us the scenario that you gave us
earlier about um you're you're messed
with your man yeah and work
i was about to say that yeah women
aren't feeling well
but they got all cold
they will still go to work
but if their man wants some sex they got
excuses for it they've got a headache
but they've never got a headache to go
to work
we saying that a man actually is going
to cheat or he's cheating because you
didn't give it enough
yes that happens
one scenario i don't think it's always
like that
okay
that's like you're not showing up to
work and you're mad they gotta temp
while you're gone
yeah at least your job's still there for
when you get back
at least i didn't fire you just to tell
them
i just think that it's a duty to have
sex with your man whenever he wants it
however he wants yeah
guys guys before we go again and let's
just reiterate some rules i know we've
got some new people on the panel but
guys one at a time i cannot hear you
they can't hear you please let's do this
all right
say that again free up give them in the
station
statement as far as i'm concerned we
need to free up all the time andy what
if he wanted what if he's at work
what should i do to your workplace
what if we're at the grocery store they
got taught in grocery stores
[Laughter]
what if we're at the library i don't
care that make no noise
[Laughter]
only fans i'm getting paid for it yeah
i'll have a go
but i just think you need to do it all
the time i have a question for you two
ladies because when auntie's talking
about that earlier she was talking about
it we were like yeah if that's my man if
that's my husband why wouldn't i youtube
right now your facial expression your
body language is
when she's talking about it it's like
no i wouldn't do that if he wants it i
wouldn't do that all the time no no
if no but if if you want sex all the
time and that's your man or whatever
then fair enough have sex but the point
i'm trying to get is
you could be giving him you could be
throwing it back do like you could be
giving it to him all day every day he
will still go somewhere else see someone
has the choice to cheat she's there and
i'll still have sex with her even though
my girl is giving it to me every day
okay live but life's nice
life's about trade-offs real life's
about trade-offs
no no but i'm saying so like i just i'll
i'll explain so life is about trade-offs
so you can either pick a guy that other
women want and know he might cheat on
you or you can pick a guy that no other
women want and he won't cheat on you but
the thing is girls pick the guys that
other women want to bang he might cheat
but how would how would you know you you
you know and the thing is like girls act
stupid like no that no i'm not i'm not
i'm not talking about you i'm not
talking about you girls will act stupid
like they don't know this guy might
cheat
like but they know they know what like
you you can feel it on a guy if he gets
a lot of girls
honestly if i can express my point of
view i wasn't like about
uh the fact if i love that man i will
definitely uh sex with him whenever he
wants because i want it i want it
but
if you're actually talking about like
i have two
that's another point i don't have to i
want it it's different like in a
marriage it's supposed to be like that i
have desire i want you because i love
you because there's something between us
not because you ask me that's one of my
duty which is different i don't have
duty for one day i'm sick and like i
just had that baby let's say men like
you know i agree with you i agree with
you do you know the problem is i think a
lot of women are quite idealistic about
future so a lot of women think about as
i am now in a relationship when you've
been there for 30 years your feelings
and emotions remember
woman having good sex and she gets 20
years older 30 years older she said no
i'm too old she's talking rubbish banger
right she's talking about rubbish
she's talking about i'm telling you
[Applause]
wherever especially you know that you
know what makes me sick about some women
especially like western women when they
get a house they will get the priest to
come around and bless it but they don't
want to go around and bless every room
with their man
there is not a room in my house that i
haven't performed in oh every house that
i've been outperformed because you know
what i'm blessing the house i can't sit
down in that yard
i don't care sweaty cheeks everywhere
the whole house from the time when you
move in because it's true they always
get the priest round how come you don't
do say to man you know let's chris in
this room and this girl's in that room
and let's go in the other room let's
explore yeah go for it and women did
this get to the point oh i'm getting too
old rubbish if your woman is getting too
old god then find somebody else that's
young enough for you i'm telling you go
out there because as far as i'm
concerned leave her out
move around right or leave the world
just lie down and as far as i'm
concerned if you've got the right man
and you're not in the mood
right you've got to he'll get you in the
mood
he will get you
[Laughter]
but you understand what i'm saying some
people are saying that oh no i'm not in
the mood
a right man will get you in the mood
yeah i don't know about i've either been
definitely actually yeah
as far as i'm concerned
the women are out there performing like
i say kali longus when they're not
pregnant and then when there's whatever
it is and whenever they decide that oh
yeah i'm pregnant open your mouth
open your mouth because you was opening
your mouth before opening your mouth
they will give their best to all the men
out there and then when they come home
when they get home later on in like late
in life it's like oh i don't do that you
know you were doing it when you're yeah
we want to we want the free father with
the twist
now that before they even say they're
dropping on their knees as far as i'm
concerned if you can do that when you're
young do it when you're older
well it's almost like girls don't want
to earn a guy anymore
out there but oh no i'll go ahead you
know what i'll get rid of the headache
for you
i will get rid of it i've got that
natural paracetamol
[Music]
as far as i'm concerned some of them
women got big mouth stories and feel it
and they're gonna sit down oh no i don't
do that and then you can hear from jack
and harry down the road oh yeah oh yeah
she gives good hugs you know you can do
it give it to your man give it to your
man that's what when the men are talking
about you giving your good years to
somebody else because you go there you
free up for everybody else and then you
want to come back and go like oh no i
don't do that yeah you do yeah you do
you know i don't want to hear them i got
a headache i got a period i got this i
got that what are the men gonna stop
with it how long do you have a period
for 40 years do men want to pop that for
four years
no not they don't they don't exactly and
then there's a problem they're always on
their period no she's on their period
the week before what she did
what should what should she do what
should he do if she says she got a
stomachache
i was helping a rubber star come on
any headache
any headache the right sex can get rid
of how
women who want to make love they want
the rose petals they want the bubble
bath they want the mask out come on
please the one man's got time for that
no matter what's going to be in and out
you know i mean before he goes to work
if a man's like me i've got 10 minutes
now you got 10 minutes i've got you
course i've got 10 minutes for you
because what i'm gonna let you go to
work frustrating i'm gonna give you five
boys listen right i'm gonna empty you
before you leave the house i mean men
need to be empty before the house fool
their belly empty their sacks
actually such a kind of way i agree with
that i like when are women actually
saying like constantly obviously can
happen some i mean we human being like
we get sick too but like when i'm even
actually saying constantly i got a day
canada man forgot about it because she
doesn't want you anymore like me
personally like when i actually end up
actually a very long relationship it was
for that reason like there was no way i
didn't like it anymore like i wasn't in
love anymore so there was
also sex was missing so she actually
right if you actually such a you know
one you want your men
so if women stop having sex with men
you're saying the man should just leave
you because at that point you know it's
done yeah
yeah it can happen once in a while
because you you know there's real reason
like you just had the baby you know
whatever but like when it becomes
something constantly they are going
gonna say no no
man just leave yeah this is the time she
says no once go somewhere else
i'm not even waiting yeah because
i'm sorry about that i can't take
rejection
you know i mean i ain't rejecting nobody
else so as far as i'm cause if your
man's coming to you and you're his woman
and you're gonna say no leave
don't give a chance to say no to you
again because there's lots of women out
there they're not forgetting how many to
one yeah he doesn't want how many to one
there's there'll be lots of women out
there gonna say yes to you so don't let
a woman come to you no no no i've fallen
out in love with you so then leave us in
leave the relationship leave the
relationship who wants to have a sexist
relationship we leave the relationship
don't you
keep her there and cheat leave that's
the point i'm trying to make auntie i
got a question for you what should a
dude do if his wife gets fat
leave her
no seriously no no no no no because come
on
you meet a woman
you me lisa if you can't help her
right and she won't help herself leave
her yeah because that's changing the
contract because you never married her
like that i'm the same size now as i was
36 years ago
and as far as i'm concerned my man
thinks i'm fat now because i put on four
pounds so i've got to lose that four
pounds yeah i mean because i would i was
four pound heavier but as far as i'm
concerned
if the women there and they're eating
they're eating they're eating they're
eating the eating they don't want to
help themselves leave them
right oh if not and you're married keep
on feeding them and just insure her buy
all the fattening foods going just kill
her off and just let me die natural
causes and claim the money back
so okay so do he should leave his wife
if she's not sleeping with him
what else what other reasons what what
you think if she can't cook and she
can't clean
up
it's the right a woman needs to do all
of them things before you put a ring or
nothing and if the woman can't cook take
it home to mummy unless your mother
can't cook but no she needs to learn how
to cook i had to clean
and money
she needs to know how to sort out her
finances
not like oh i've got a bill i'm going to
go to daddy they need to sort of because
too many women
waste money and the women the men let
them waste the money and then they waste
all their money and then they want to go
and spend the men's well yeah women
women own 70 to 80 percent of consumer
debt even though they um they make less
money i bet nine out of 10 women got
clothes in their in their in their
closet that still got tags on yeah yeah
that's what they are yeah yeah you see
men don't do that
and women buy stuff that's fashionable
every time they win this we knew the
fashion member classic clothes that they
can wear this year next year the year
after but women just we may just waste
money you want a woman that's good with
money good in bed good children can cook
was it a chef in the kitchen
a [__] in the bedroom a nanny
and a cleaner that woman's got to be i
think there's about five different
things that you want in one woman guys
how did that how does that sound to you
let's just
get some feedback on what she said no no
it sounds good and and like look to be
honest yeah i don't think it's asking
much
you know it's not it's not over and
beyond for those things
you know the basic things like you said
cooking cleaning just to
like and if you've been raised a certain
way you would have been you would have
known that naturally anyway you know
what i mean and then you bring that into
a relationship to be honest the best
sort of raised women no matter what
country they're from are those that are
raised to be
traditional yeah exactly
so when they come into the relationship
oh
can you cook is this standard to work
can you roll a dumpling can you do
fulfill of course you gotta take off
your fingernails for do you wear gloves
to season me come on there you go even
even on a black level even little things
like can you plat do you know what i
mean little things like that it's like
if they come with no it's like who
raised you type thing so by the time
you've got there you've got two three
four of the things naturally
already
because women seem to think it's like oh
because i you know men want me because i
look good because i earn a lot of money
because i got a job i got a car i got
men don't want that they just want
someone can i say something as a man
sorry to cut you off we do like women
that look good we like attractive women
yeah
but if i'm gonna be honest
most of us don't want a baddie i know it
looks that way i know things like social
media are ig and even some of the things
men say even
you know the whole sort of uh urban
hip-hop and even just hip-hop black
culture
it's like we want baddies and all that
but realistically we don't want we don't
need to have a 10. most men will tell
you we'll take if you want to rate a six
seven on the looks scale
but all the other like the boxes you
said as long as they've got those
we can go with that like we were saying
earlier
it it's not great to say but men do
date marry relationship if you want to
say the word settle in not the worst
context we do so if she looks good on
top bonus and the sex should be you know
a standard thing yeah good good good sex
and to be honest as a woman don't you
know
it's uh there's this whole notion that
only men like sex and i'm one of those
people but any any person i've had sex
with in my whole life whether it be
relationship or even a one-night stand
as far as i'm concerned she wants me as
well it's not just i want to just smash
her and she just let me i love it
do what i wanted to do you were the
footba yeah it's like an equal value
exchange but women treat it like it's
not exactly and and you know what's
interesting like some of the language we
have in society always takes
accountability off of the women like for
example he knocked her up
mm-hmm
or even almost or even even in the
church like the girls will always be
like oh i was so broken i was so lucky
no you're a horny shut up
shut up
and now you found god it's convenient at
29.
matt
so um question people in the chat want
everyone to rate them on a scale of one
to ten rate themselves
wow
yeah
on a good day like i feel like i'm a
strong seven seven
i give myself a six six
seven eight seven eight what are we
writing one to ten yeah what looks
like are we luke okay
six seven six seven
six
i'm a four
no
auntie
okay i'm going to read super chats
i'm a phone
i would have said i was a knight i'm a
fool oh night in your handbag yeah let
me you got pecks let me see
you see the pictures i think they're on
them
youtube oh we got a hundred dollar super
chat we're in class
y'all y'all okay
i'm trying to i'm trying to move into a
new apartment it's gonna be big it's
gonna be beautiful it
is tell them about the apartment how
nice is it tom
you're talking to the mic
skyline
top floor
views
from the six
now from the one the e1 yo
special
special oh it's beautiful and the color
scheme the furniture
yo we gonna do a little mtv cribs kind
of thing yeah yeah
it's actually special but we're only
doing the apartment tour
on memberships so if you want to see it
you got to be in our second tier of
memberships which is the 10 tier i know
i'd share it with all of you
but i'm trying to get more members i'm
going to be honest
i'm just i'm just you know if you if you
want to see the full yeah you got it you
got it ten dollars it's not that much
okay
anyways so thank you to darvey jones for
the 100 super chat thank you auntie for
top shelf content you're getting so many
supers today they love you blowing up
top shelf ain't good
right
top shelf and that would like no that's
good that's good it's good that's good
that's good yeah i'm thinking nowadays
you know when you put things on the top
shelf oh no top notch think talk guys
we're going to work
we're going to work with annie and
auntie after we move and we're going to
like get her a little channel set up so
we're going to
you're going to get more content from
her um so mgtow by logic
ladies on the couch are laughing but
auntie is trying to save your life your
pee is worthless if you don't share it
with a man who loves you get off your
horse you're not special
darkened flame auntie you are fire
preach keep telling these secrets we
need more females with your commitment
to honesty ry morgan in the video
yesterday you talked about how men
mature later so how do you recommend
they pursue women when they are 20 to 21
because the women that want to settle
down are looking for older men focus on
purpose um
yeah i mean
yeah i would just say as a guy like the
more you build yourself up the more
girls want you so if you get in the gym
and you make more money girls will come
mgtow by logic he might cheat on me even
but he might cheat on me even if i bang
him so i won't bang him just in case
chick logic is stupid
mr travolta dating and financial advice
for men anytime a woman rejects you or
flakes out on you you should pay into
your savings account or pay off a part
of your mortgage or make a financial
investment you'd be surprised how
quickly it adds up
maury he's not giving me money lol
females are more loyal to their bosses
than their man sad darzian gaming i
understand why the italians x cheated on
her sigma i'm sorry i'm sorry i didn't
say it he did um
um
what i'm hearing from the two women is
that in the middle is that they're
living in fear their whole argument
against marriage is the fear of being
cheated on matt butcher italia is the
perfect example of how ladies attitude
can take her from a seven to a zero
silly sausage wow ish did work at the
alton towers loads of experience
explaining rules to children please keep
arms and legs inside the podcast at all
times please avoid speaking logic as
there are feminists nearby
cv boy gold21 my girl hated that oh then
we're back to that one okay let me
um
let me
see what question i want to ask next
do you guys think you can turn a hoe
into a housewife
neo thought you could
oh
who is neo40 neo
what is singing
what happened oh he married a former
porn star corn corn
in which situation we are now allegedly
he cheated yeah yeah
but he thought he could
yeah he thought but he couldn't but like
in a way you ever think about how like
all girls kind of cheat on their husband
because you're supposed to be a virgin
for him so you kind of cheat him by like
[__] gross cheat on him by [__]
guys before we met yeah just bang out
but um to answer the question
i don't think
i don't think a man can
turn
a hoe into a housewife but
she can change so if she makes a
decision it can happen
okay
all right um let me say this as a
prefix as well
in the very few cases because it is a
few but it does exist
if there's
like extenuating circumstances why she
is now a 304
i.e
maybe there was essay
in her childhood because sometimes is
the case because of that and it comes in
those sort of ways and by the time
you've met her you just know as this 304
if those those sort of circumstances
possibly depend
but but she's got to deal with her
trauma
already because it will affect their
relationship if she's just a general 304
then i don't think so and it's not just
because of the people she slept with
she's used to being
or what you find is that she used to be
intrigued by guys a certain type of way
she's used to being talked to a certain
type of way doesn't that say something
about the man she picks
exactly yeah like doesn't that say
something about her because you pick
them
no it does yeah it does it does and it
was like what we were saying earlier
it's not just
the amount of uh men women sleep with
it's the men who they sleep with because
sometimes as men it's it's not even that
say
say you're my girl and you sleep with
someone i know it might not just be that
it's someone i know i know that guy i
know who he slept with
and that translates through to us so
that's part of it you know you know he's
a lame yeah
you know i mean you can you can like a
girl and you just just from the person
that she slept with
you know that
she doesn't think yes logically
you slept with him yeah
so is it better that you're because okay
i think in two ways right is it better
that the girls slept with a lame or
slept with a guy that's better than you
someone that's better better
really i would respect like
there's certain that like i i'll say for
me personally
if a girl goes out she can go and tell
people she slept with me and there's
nobody who can turn around and be like
what you slept with ro
because i know me personally there's no
one out there that's gonna be like oh
he's a lame or he's done this or he's
this type of person
whereas there are certain dudes out
there when you hear that a girl slept
with them you just think that this
girl's
not got her head screwed up so so it's
interesting though because i think that
in order for a girl to truly love you
she has to look at you as the best she
can do
and so if her ex is better than you like
she doesn't want you she wants him he
just probably like rejected her and so
it's like like she's gonna view you as
she's settled exactly
if my girl cheats on me with someone
that's less than in whatever respect
then
then it comes down to
but i think partly at least what i've
done i've i've done i've messed up in
some way because if she's gone below me
she's dropped her standard below me then
yeah something's gone wrong here if
she's going to go and do that as you
said go above
i'm not going to like it but i
understand so what do you guys think can
you turn a hoe into a housewife
oh wait so sorry so you're saying if she
slept with someone that is better than
you
that's more accept that's no no i'm not
going to like it but i i get it at least
at least if you're going to do that at
least you leveled up so then so a hoe is
someone that's slept with lots of people
is that what that's what we're saying
a hoe is a woman that slips with a lot
of men like her body count is up she's
she's slept with a lot
yeah very very quickly as well without
much
situation or or circumstance around it
just they've had there's a lot of things
around it so yeah all of the above so if
all the men that she was sleeping with
were better than you
does that still make her a hoe or yeah i
mean a hoe is a hope you sleep with a
lot of men you're a hoe like but then
all the men were of like more valued
like it doesn't matter so you're still a
hoe like the term hoe is pretty simple
you know you sleep with a lot of men you
are considered a hoe
but that i'm just saying if this hoe has
let them lots of men that were better
than you can she be turned to a
housewife or
like i said i believe
it is her choice i don't believe a man
can turn her into a housewife she
chooses she has to choose she has to
choose whether she wants to turn
that lifestyle
she wants to give that lifestyle up
i don't i don't believe girls i don't
believe them like because they always
conveniently stop being a hose at like
30.
and it's like that's kind of convenient
you found god this year right when
time's running out 28. it's like 27 to
30. now you joined the church where were
you at 20.
yeah that's what i'm saying like they
they conveniently learn their lesson
when like time's running out so i just
don't like if she does it at 21 you know
maybe like
okay yeah okay i could yeah well a 20
year old hoe can be turned to a
housewife but no not really
[Laughter]
not
occasionally but not
not really no
i just think housewife is top 20 of
women most girls don't get to be
housewives and so it's like if you're a
hoe you you get the outcome of like the
best women i doubt it
you gotta remember being a hoe is also a
mentality as well it's everything based
on i can use my sexuality my looks how i
you know everything based around that
it's nothing else about her character as
a woman
or being a woman that she can use to bag
or snag or impress on a man it's
literally all on her looks as well so
that goes into it as well and which is
what you two said earlier was unfair
and what what did i say
you guys were talking about you know men
just focusing on looks a lot of 304s
do use that the sexuality the sexuality
there's the deduction
the looks
so
yeah but what we what did we say you
said us two said no no you was earlier
when we was talking and we was talking
about things that like
yeah exactly
yeah you you guys were kind of offended
when we were mentioning that so i'm just
saying
certain 304s they literally only bring
that that's another thing in it as well
they literally only just bring their
looks and sensuality there's nothing
else to them that they can bring
of value to a man or relationship so i'm
just saying i think that is possible i
think that
the cut off point is like 20.
i think if he was a [__] before you is
20 i think it's still possible because
i've seen some young girls that
they've done a lot of things they were
young for one reason they have a bad
upbringing or whatever and they've just
turned their life around fantastic
highest wife cool again
they chose to yeah but nobody turned
them into it they decided you know what
this ain't for me
but
i i personally said the cutoff point i'd
say is about 20.
i think the older you get and the more
horrors you get the harder it is
i think we potentially everyone can be a
whole or as i was wife
potentially just
about choice yes i i think it depends on
your mind well i was
i was good he's like fat chicks don't
get to be honest
that's not i want to be
like i wasn't talking about you
you go ahead what did you say no i was
saying i think it depends on the man
because if the heart if the man is high
value enough the woman is not going to
stray or continue being a whole nother
that's not she's going to keep in mind
that's what i think if you if you love
and admire respect this man you do not
want to leave you don't want to [__] up
this relationship you don't think
there's tendencies that she's gained
over time
that is not the right man
see if she if she has the right man in
front of her she's going nowhere you're
playing you're playing a dangerous game
yeah right
you're gambling on an investment not me
personally i'm not taking that risk i'm
saying it's possible not probable he's
betting on the injured horses
i'm saying
and the question was is it possible
that's why and i'm saying yes it's
possible is it probably not but not
probably what i'm saying is what i'm
saying i'm saying it's impossible you're
saying impossible yes because i believe
a woman will have gained certain tricks
things that she's learned over time
habits that she will have
going into whatever relationship a
woman's a hypergamy so she's been living
a certain lifestyle exactly
yeah
how is she going to come down
to a man she wants to settle with
why she why is she
that's how i'm saying if she's come
across a high value man yes she does not
want to leave like you said women are
hypergames yes why would she why would
she [__] up that relationship because
she's had variety she's had all but
she's met the one have you you know that
song that she's not doing what she's
been doing
she's met the six foot guys she's met
the guy who's got money she's met the
guy who's finding his job
why would you cheat i'm saying
everything i'm saying it's possible
she's better than 50.
women in the world
you're saying it's impossible i'll
explain there's always going to be
someone that's bigger or better than you
in some way shape or form this is just
life you will never be top dog someone
will overpass you in some way shape or
form and she as a hypergamist
will jump we also
we all saw the
clip of um jeff bezos and leonardo
dicaprio
we all saw that clip the richest man in
the world so and yeah but you say that's
what i said earlier just because you've
got money don't make what
she's going nowhere yeah but you yeah
exactly but
this is the dude richard bezos is a
[__] man yeah
richest man in the world so but it's not
a soap bro it's not a soul bro that just
proves that having money alone doesn't
make you that guy that's all it proves
against leonardo dicaprio maybe yeah
he's a gay he's
the majority of men yeah you're losing
to jeff it doesn't matter
what you think you look like you are
losing to him the same way you are
losing to jay-z yeah you might look in
the mirror and say to yourself i look
better than jay-z
but you are losing to him again we can
do the exception of rules however much
we want the reality is when we saw that
clip
everybody said the same thing wow the
richest man in this world look at his
wife she can't control her all you're
talking about is finances one question
that's what you're talking about one
question i've got for you yeah you've
just said
it could never be you you wouldn't do it
do you not think it's disingenuous to
give
advice to say yeah like i think it's
it's probable i'm not giving advice
obviously i was asked a question ask the
question and i'm saying it's possible
yeah but it's not probable okay well i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna take my chances
and i wouldn't advise anyone else to
take the chances but it is possible
that's what i'm saying
anyone else got any ideas on this no i
just to come back to the
this point and um actually agree with
him because
i don't know why which insane idea you
guys have about women because you're
teaching us about men
but like
i don't know if you agree with me
um
we don't really mind that much about
money obviously we have
hey hey karen karen
um
i mean obviously we trying to don't you
know get the broken one but um
we don't really mind
our ticks are different ones so we do
you remember you when we asked you a
question um
how much money would you like your
person to earn and you said
no i'm just saying i'll say the same
yeah i think
but i'm actually agree with that but i'm
gonna give you an explanation um i'm
agree with that because i think i mean
it must be kind of
in the same you know pretty much the
same amount of tiny bit more probably
but why no because i need is money
for the reason is
if a man is earning less than me he's
gonna feel
probably insecure next to me so you're
gonna struggle to stay next to me so in
order to do
you know to be a partnership i mean when
i say partnership i mean we need to be
equal
such a kind of way so also financially
it's just better for both if we are in
the same situation so you wouldn't feel
like you know you are you know
you know that's not a gap what if he
doesn't know what if he doesn't feel
insecure i fell in love with a man who
had less than me and he actually fine it
can deal with that it doesn't have any
issue with that
cool life fine so you're okay with that
do you think majority of women are okay
no they they know they're not exactly
but yeah we're coming back now listen
we're coming back to the
i did not say most it's like before when
we said
uh about men men care about virginity
and you know be pure young and beautiful
the majority of men probably they do but
you know the point is i don't really
want a man who care about that because i
think a man should look at something
else so is actually true probably i
don't know up to eighty percent of men
they looking at the beauty how young are
you you know [__]
but i
i accept that but it doesn't bother me
because that's not the man that i would
like to next to me because i don't like
to have data guy that is going to come
out asking me oh
uh how is your body count
do you know what i mean oh you 30 so you
are [__] so you just threw yourself in a
bin you know what i mean so you said but
enough you said that most women don't
care about
how much money a man makes that's i
didn't say must so i said that's steel
that's still some people like me okay i
think i'm not the only one that they
don't really put that as a as a top top
requirement so some so some don't almost
don't some some don't some more than do
would you say more women care about how
women they publicly in today's society
yes
i think it's also about culture not
offense but like me being italian i saw
quite a lot of differences between when
i moved like
in the british like
in uk i've this stuff it come up like
for me something it was something new
because
back home i grew in like you know for us
relationships kind of we built in
something together from scratch
so you met your you know a man it
doesn't have probably nothing as you
don't and in together
we built together so
that's the way in which i
see relationships so i don't i can
obviously pretend from a guy to you know
okay be a billionaire right
do you think girls only care they only
don't care if they can't get the guys
that are rich
they don't care like i feel like girls
only don't care about money if they
can't get the guys that are successful
i've always been like that even you know
my 20s and i actually was as you said
them you know my best i actually been
for long with in a relationship on my
20s and i decided to leave the guy
so and that guy wasn't that he was rich
rich no he wasn't oh he wasn't but
that's not going to say i'm sorry
i'm saying like if you have guys i
actually didn't date a rich person to
stay with a broken one
yeah that's probably why i didn't
why if you dated a rich person no i said
i had like
honestly speaking at the beginning when
i met my ex-boyfriend i
date once a guy who was richer than him
six foot
tall
footballer oh anyway good looking
and i actually prefer
my the one day after became my boyfriend
that wasn't six foot he wasn't rich i
was a footballer you know i mean i
actually pick him as if you ask me why
there's always a reason
why don't you stay
uh
with the this guy because growing up i
was
25 when i left him i had a different
plan from him
so i decided to leave the country to you
know develop my career study
he actually followed me but at some
point for me i just decided he wasn't
the guy yeah but
so it's kind of like you picked him but
you didn't you picked him for a little
bit but then you didn't pick him six
years not a little bit probably is
more than some marriage he's with him
for six years yes
that's like scarier to guys though
because it's like you stayed with him
for six years and then left
i'm just like no i think i just i think
it's scary if a woman is the same woman
science i mean from her 20s sis six of
signs she gets 40. you cannot be the
same person when you're 20 and when
you're 40. if that is the case
you know growing up like you cannot be
the same person at 20 and in your 40s so
i think i actually
you know i had a development
and and this is could happen that you
know the development didn't match my guy
development so you know we just end up
in different do you feel your values the
same when you're 20 and then when you
hit to 40. again we i think i already
asked this question like i already
answered
if i mean from my side the value is not
about
be young be pretty and be virgin
the value is about the topics that you
can come out with is about your
knowledge is about what you can do by
your own
uh is about what have you done like
in those 30 years what have you done if
you study have you worked what have you
actually built
in your life what do you have that's
like that's that's men though that's
like what women want from them i don't
know
yeah no no that's what girls do is they
become the men they want to marry
so like all because
whenever i was being like that even on
my 20s yeah i'm not yeah i mean a lot of
girls are cause feminism feeds women a
lie
because i mean the least happy
demographic of women is 45 single and
childless
and and it's like what is your career
matter if you don't have someone to
share it with like i could be a
multi-billionaire and if i came home to
an empty house my life means nothing
that is like the set like and then it's
like like what you need to focus on
yourself all the time you run into your
big house and hug your dogs and you're
over the moon no because like life is
not about just about i i'm not at the
opposite way i'm kind of scared about
those women that they focus everything
in
their
marriage and their children because at
the end yeah why because at the end like
at some point you're just a human being
you need to be focused also on your
on yourself not when you have a family
you have some needs no because when
you're when you're a mother when you're
when you're
when you're a mother it's not about you
anymore it's like your kid's happiness
comes first but it's like if you're it's
if you can't put your kids before
yourself like yeah you probably
shouldn't have kids yeah but many people
like i think we are agreeing i think
that many people actually ask
they decide to have
i think girls decide not to have kids
because they can't get a guy that they
want to have kids with
i think because most girls if i talk to
them if they said if this if you found a
guy that checked all your boxes would
you have kids with them the answer is
generally yes yeah so to me it's that
they can't acquire the men that they
want and the men that they want don't
want them
but you said that already yeah you said
that earlier
i've heard that i've heard that from
women
i've heard that from women and they'd
rather die alone or like just be alone
yeah right
when you start talking about
oh yeah when you start talking about
being an independent woman and what you
bring to the table and if he can't match
that i'm fine to be alone what you're
saying is
okay
i can't find a man i want so i'm going
to be alone yes
exactly
like that because i don't see like the
need for a women right now in 2022 to
add other men next to you like i don't
because i'm i'm not looking for a man
who can provide me
financially i don't look for a man who
can protect me
so like my man must be my friend
what if he was a bum he could protect
you be a bum like he doesn't work
you're not looking for him to provide
yeah yeah but no i i
i made the point very clear like i want
someone that is like i
still like yeah it must be like my
friend it must have focus like like me
like exactly like kind of me but
obviously you know the the yeah but
like
so in a way you do you did become the
man you wanted to marry yeah you you can
actually say that yeah and it's it's
like almost sad to me because i feel
like you actually think like that's what
men want in terms of like a career woman
and they just don't care
like would you date a girl without a job
yeah
did you marry a girl without a job yeah
yeah but we
coming back to the same point he's free
to do whatever as i i'm free to stay by
my own
because i'm not sad as you think i got i
go anyway family i got niece and nephew
you're right i got a job and i'm taking
actually a lot of a lot of um
i'm happy i mean you're also you're also
beautiful
and so so like but beauty runs out at
some point and when beauty runs out the
attention stuff
when beauty runs out the attention stops
because nobody's knocking on your door
at 60. no one's knocking on your door at
50. i wouldn't and like life is lonely
after 45 if you don't have a family i
wouldn't at low my standard and i
wouldn't accept a man who thinks i
should just be in the kitchen washing
the dishes i'm not saying you don't be
lonely i honestly prefer being lonely
for the rest of my life then keep myself
my ass in the kitchen washing dishes
most men don't care if you have a job
like most men if you want if you want to
have kids
i'm saying most men can't even afford to
have you washing dishes in the kitchen
yeah so most men aren't going to require
that of you but what i'm saying is like
if you don't prioritize family it's
going to be lonely and i think a lot of
times like you think it'll be fine but
you don't know how different people
treat you because you're pretty and when
that goes like you're going to have a
completely different experience in life
and one day the party runs out
just to add to your point
um i i learned this quite a few years
ago that a greatest achievement someone
could ever have is to see their
grandchildren
so when people talk about their parent
like you having kids and how is it going
to affect your kids it's like
the byproduct of you having kids will be
your grandkids and that's when you'll
see the and reap the rewards of
everything you'll see everything come
full
for what's it called force full circle
full circle you'll see everything come
you'll see everything come full circle
and it's more so that you need to have
kids in order to have grandkids and if
you leave it too late you'll be in a
position where you'll be 60 and you may
see other family members with grandkids
but you have nothing to show
for your life through
your lines they will you know like come
out with that travel picture or whatever
you know
but nobody's going to look at it because
no one's going to care yeah i don't care
he said i probably wouldn't care about
the grandchildren or whatever
do you think that a life that's only
about you is worth living where it's
just me me me selfish all the time it's
everything's about me and my feelings
but if you if you if you're alone
forever that's what life's about it's
you like to me life's about people and
if i don't if i don't have a family to
share it with like i am no but they'll
die in fact i don't i don't know i have
a sister i have brothers
and nephews
so like they won't die before they may
absolutely
you know what i mean
yeah there's no one that will be at your
funeral talking about how hard you
worked in your great career yeah okay
and like honestly like my channel is
pretty big like by and large most people
would say i'm very successful at my age
it means nothing if i don't get married
like every
like i think a girl don't get married or
nothing you don't have children and if i
don't get married like honestly a girl
that can't get married is a loser
so just like just like that just like
yeah just like just like mighty cutie
could you lose her loser i mean look at
lolo
because we're still studying where's she
discovered
grandchildren
but you're not out of marriage
i'd be a loser yeah i think that you
have you have grandchildren and you have
that the memories that you was talking
about you still have that but you won't
have to be okay so i raised my kids at
every statistical disadvantage that's
selfish on me no but let's see
you have children they're grown they've
had grandchildren and then now you're
divorcing for whatever reason have you
not still had that life that you've been
talking about you still have the
grandchildren you still have it there
you still have that full circle okay i
would say i grew up in a family i have
nine siblings i have two parents i've
been married for like 30 years
it is not the same when there's two
christmases
it's not the same like the
i i talk to people from like split
family homes and tell them about like
the traditions that me and my family
have like we go as adults take pictures
with santa every year we all go to the
fourth of july the whole family comes
like we do these events all year it's
actually stressful because my mom
expects us to be at so much [__] but you
don't get that in a single parent home
and when i talk to people from single
parent homes they're jealous
like they wish they had that and it's
like why would i put my kids at every
statistical disadvantage because it's
not about me anymore once i have
children who [__] my happiness no but
the children the point i made is the
children are grown up now they're not
kids like you've had your marriage you
they lived in a two-parent household
they've grown up they've gone to college
uni wherever they're older they've had
children you have grandchildren but now
the only the only difference is you
weren't married yeah that's just what
i'm trying to say oh am i still with the
husband i just get divorced later like
you weren't married but you had oh i i'm
okay with like like i committed yeah
like i i know the laws are kind of [__]
for men so if it if it was something
similar but you don't get the government
involved fine
but so then the ring
no i would say you still need a ring
it's just like there's people that do it
outside of the government like that you
know they do it in their church or
whatever so you need the ring for that
whole grandchildren
i mean yeah you should you should be
married before you have kids whether
it's with the government or not so
you're saying you should is it because
of god or because of government because
that it
that gives the kids the best outcomes
that you've got married yes but you can
still be in a household where you're
together and not married and the
children have both mom and dad in the
house it's possible they have a happy
home it's possible but not probable okay
they have a happy home and then you have
grandchildren and all that stuff
is that that's still the goal no that's
still happiness no the gossip
you just said the goal was having
grandchildren and having your future and
your loins and all that sort of stuff
which you can still have without a ring
that's what i'm trying to say so you can
have all of those things without a ring
my point was that is one thing
one aspect that not having kids or
looking to have kids with the person you
want to find
that you come across in your later ages
as a woman
your goal is the ring
that's that from what i've learned is it
the ring or is it the children it's
commitment oh it's both the ring it's
the legacy it's the man that you respect
it's the man that you look up to and
you've got him and you've got him to
commit so you got him to commit but you
didn't have kids
what i don't even know what these
hypothetical situations you guys have
been through
i'm sorry okay this is this is the goal
i want to get married and then have kids
i don't if it's outside of the
government fine but i still want to be
married and some level so you want
marriage first and then children yeah i
think i think it's quite selfish to do
the other first and a lot of girls trap
guys in order to do it
and like i think it's it's selfish
because you're thinking of yourself
before the kids
put the kids first so no matter what age
you're at you're you're waiting for the
ring before the kids
yeah i mean oh are you sorry i'm 25. 25.
so then if you meet the guy this are you
dating married now engaged like what's
your i don't have a boyfriend now so
then if you met someone and then you're
dating it's going well but then he
doesn't propose until
i don't know you're 28 29
and then you don't have kids until your
eggs are like you said after 30 your
eggs are now like would is is that
is that that's you're okay with that
then after two years cut it off
yeah cut it off
earlier
no no no i'm telling you if you're
dating so if you're dating someone for
more than two years yeah where's the
commitment why hasn't he done it no he's
proposed but you're not you're not
married yet
you can have a ring but you can get you
can get married and go to a courthouse i
don't need a wedding so you're happy too
25 and then he proposes at the 27 you
get married the next day
yeah i mean honestly i'm uh i'm like
i've never cared about a wedding because
i don't think it's about the wedding
it's about a marriage yeah so who who
can like i mean if i got married i could
do it at a courthouse just make sure my
parents and my siblings could come so if
he doesn't propose after 27
are you you're back out there looking
for someone else
yeah who probably
yeah then i'd be on discount yeah be on
sale so you just pick whoever will take
you
i'd pick the best bet i could that's
that's like
that's the saying like pick the best bit
yeah the one that ticks some of your
boxes you won't just pick anyone because
oh i'm 27 i need to just quickly get
married because that's actually what
well i don't know
for someone that that is where are we
going here
you're only as valuable as your options
i remember i remember a girl saying to
me yeah i remember a girl saying to me
that
there were certain
type of man that
constantly moved to her
so she had to look at it and say well
if these are the type of guys that move
to me
then
i need to readjust and find a way
to see what these guys are about
so if you're a girl and you go out and
every single man that moves to you is
five foot seven and white
right
right no no no because this is so yeah
that's a good point
how is it settling
interesting okay
if every black six foot three dude moved
to you picked the one no it just made it
just threw me off and you said
something's going on
the girl that i'm talking about was
white
and she said that every guy that moved
to her was a black guy
so it wasn't that black guys weren't her
type
but it's like well the only guys that
move to me are black
and i want a man i like guys
so
okay let me see what they're about
so you're only really as valuable as
your options so if you're a guy and
the only girls that
show you attention are
big girls from a certain place
you have to say to yourself well okay no
i'm not going to go with them because i
still feel like i can get no bro that's
kind of very
that's your level that's your level yeah
your level is who approaches you no no
for girls that's who commits to you
right because a dude a dude that's a
nine i'll sleep with the four but he he
ain't taking you to meet his family
right so
it's used to us to approach you yeah but
i'm saying like like girls think that
they're as hot as the guys that approach
them but you're not you're as hot as the
guys that'll commit you're the one that
commits he still has to approach that's
right yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
but actually i got dependent it's
actually interesting for me because i
noticed this
like big difference like
since i'm moving here like that's
definitely like a type that i can
describe yeah try to come yeah
come across and definitely i'm here
three years
the same
same type of food i started to wonder
myself like what like why why yeah you
know also because when i was back home
it wasn't completely different type of
guy right they used to approach me i've
been in a relationship with completely
different guys i still i don't know i
can answer the ques this question to be
honest with you i wonder myself quite a
lot of time like there's something that
i'm doing
and i'm not conscious about that you
know make them come across yeah
and i i don't know honestly i think they
just go for everyone and so just more
probable they gonna you know come across
me also do you know women i mean the
variables are there but as i said
that's how you have to look at things
you know so your own like if you're
attracting this certain type of girl and
that is your type happy days
if you're attracting certain people that
are not your type and time is moving but
it's not about it's my type or not okay
it's about why it's just
that that kind of guy like why you can't
answer back into there
oh you can't you you have no control
over that you can't yeah just trying to
answer yeah guys we are having a super
productive chat but gonna get you to
read some super chats and then we're
gonna restart the stream we're doing a
24 hour live stream right now and we're
we're halfway through
we're about to be anyway it youtube
youtube ends the stream at 12 hours so
after he's super duper then we just
restart a new one because we're going
for 25. we're at 11 52 right now yeah
yeah yeah so we got a we got a 11 58 no
11 52 we got eleven now we start a
little after 12. like you you see like
we oh well mostly we're not perfect
um okay so i'm gonna refresh this real
quick
guys thank you so much for
thank you for watching the video like
the video subscribe to the channel okay
i'm so tired of you all
watching and not subs i see my analytics
okay i see you guys i know you're here
and you're thinking oh she's not talking
to me i'm talking to you like the video
it's free it's free okay
90 um free top women want symbolism but
not in substance tracy roberts
robinson
italia must understand that as she ages
she becomes a liability to the rest of
her family who has an established clan
medical bills companionship living
expenses life gets really expensive um
cold soul dragon middle women needs
guidance and strength on mindfulness not
attacks they seem to express desire for
love god bless you auntie dragon
stellium1001 hate to break it to the
woman in the middle on the couch no man
that is like you is going to stay with
you the genders are opposite like
magnets you will repel any man you want
mgtow by logic she followed her
hypergamy left him and now she's alone
at 30. that's how hypergamy ruins not
benefits women most of the time
mgtow by logic you decided to leave
shocking and now you're 30 you'll never
get a better man than you had but you're
you're mad about it you're an alpha
widow seek help save yourself listen to
auntie matt butcher the equal and
opposite reaction to feminism is coming
but slowly men are learning marriage
rates and red pill type popularity are
showing this david through marriage a
man financially pays for exclusive
exclusive intimate access in the same
time women pay intimately for financial
security if a man can keep many women
financially secure them what's the
problem tracy robinson robinson
it's a shame that what she's saying
sounds cro crass it's
sounds crass to girls that want to show
that want to throw communist kitty to
every tom dick harry and pookie listen
to auntie she comes from a time that you
brought into existence davey jones um
thank you auntie for the top shelf
content okay
um all right guys we are going to end
the stream don't you worry don't you
worry we're going to start it right back
up after this after these messages yeah
right back
youtube ends the stream at 12 hours and
we're killing it 12 hours
i like this one better than the last one
yeah the last one was hell yeah
we're not done yet yeah this is no but
we're only halfway but remember we
started at this time yeah we started
like this was
there's hope yeah this wasn't this
wasn't a good plague it was better to
start earlier yeah
um but anyways um appreciate y'all um
don't forget subscribe to the channel
and tune in in like five minutes when we
restart the stream and go until 12
o'clock tomorrow i hate myself about 30
tomorrow 12th
i thought it was like 12 10. i was like
okay i was factoring in this time oh
this time like the break and whatnot
i mean if the chat don't care i should
sure don't care okay um like the video
subscribe and i'll see you in like five
minutes bye
all right
we go again five minutes five minutes oh
my god
got you
got you baby boy
i love you guys done 12 hours already